ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY ALLEN
ARAMBULA.
BAKER.
BERMAN BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA BROUGH.
BURKE CABALLERO CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU.
CHAVEZ CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM DALLEY DAILY.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER.
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
[inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON HARPER HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN.
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
REYES REVISE RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO STEINORTH STONE
[inaudible]
THURMOND [inaudible]
TING VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WOOD.
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
THE DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND OSHITA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
AS WE WIND DOWN THE MOST ACTIVE
WEEKS OF FLOOR SESSIONS FOR THIS
YEAR.
I LIKE TO HEAR PROMISED MY WIFE
PATTY NINE MEET TOWARDS SELF
TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO.
AFTER A SENIOR MINISTER RETIRED.
THEN BISHOP YAMAOKA LEFT A
SERVING A CONGREGATION OF TWELVE
HUNDRED FAMILIES WITHOUT
REPLACEMENT ASSISTANCE.
WE SERVE TWO AND A HALF YEARS
WITHOUT TAKING A DAY OFF FOR
VACATION.
THE PROMISE THAT WE MADE TO ONE
ANOTHER WITH THIS.
NO MATTER HOW HECTIC OUR LIFE
MAY BECOME.
WE WOULD NEVER UTTERED THE
PHRASE I'M SO BUSY.
WHEN I MEMBERS WOULD ASK HOW ARE
YOU DOING WHATEVER AND? FOR US
TO SE I'M SO BUSY WAS AN INSTANT
CONVERSATION ENDER.
THEY WOULD FEEL HELPLESS AND OUR
SCHEDULE FELT NO LIGHTER.
AND IF WE COMPLAIN THAT WE WERE
BUSY.
WE WHO ARE MORE PRONE TO
BECOMING TIRED AND WEARY.
PEOPLE AROUND US KNEW OUR LIVES
ARE EXTREMELY WELL SCHEDULED.
AND DURING THAT TIME WHEN FOLKS
WOULD ASK BECAUSE YOU'RE SO BUSY
REVEREND HOW ARE YOU DOING.
WITH THE SMILE WE WOULD REPLY I
GOT NOTHING BUT FREE TIME.
WE WOULD LAUGH TOGETHER ENJOY A
MOMENT OF FRIENDSHIP.
IN THE DAY FELT IMMEDIATELY
LIGHTER.
THAT PROMISE WE MADE TO EACH
OTHER TWENTY FIVE YEARS AGO WE
CONTINUE TO KEEP TODAY.
THAT HECTIC TIMES WE LIVED.
TO GIVE US AN UNEXPECTED GIFT.
THE GIFT THIS THIS.
WE ARE NEVER TOO BUSY TO HAVE
TIME FOR EACH OTHER.
OR FOR THE PEOPLE WE HAVE IN OUR
LIVES.
SO.
AS WE WIND DOWN THESE LONG
WEEKS.
I HEAR OUR SECRET TO LIVE TOO
HECTIC MOMENTS.
WITH THE PROMISE NEVER TO SAY
I'M BUSY.
AND ALSO A BIT OF HUMOR THAT
LIGHTENED OUR DAYS.
AND NURTURED A SURPRISINGLY
PATIENT DEPRECIATION. FOR EVEN
OUR MOST WELL SCHEDULED OF TIME.
NUMBER ONE WE WITH GRATITUDE AND
KINDNESS BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER.
A SALUTE PLEDGE I PLEDGE
[inaudible]
CASE [inaudible]
VISIBLE [inaudible]
GAINES I THANK YOU MAY BE
SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY AUGUST NINTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE ASSEMBLY MET
AT NINE AM ON WILL KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF QUICKIE DOTSON
WILSON AT THE DESK READING CLICK
KATHLEEN I'M LUIS READING.
THE ROLL WAS CALLED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LAWYER MOVED A
PLACEHOLDER.
BONTA MOVES AND DOCTOR CHEN
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE OF BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
WHO DO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS?
THERE ARE NO ABSENCES FOR
TODAY'S SESSION
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM EXCUSE ME MISTER
SPEAKER.
THAT'S OKAY I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BROWN THURMAN
TO SPEAK ON IT IS GERMANY
MEMORIES TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE MOVE THE FOLLOWING BILL
TO THE INACTIVE FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SIX SHALL.
CLERK WILL NOTE.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX
TO WITHDRAW AS WE TWELVE FORTY
NINE GALGIANI FOR THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND ORDER THE BILL THE
SECOND READING.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I AM REFERRING.
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE.
ITEM ONE FORTY AB NINE THIRTY
NINE LOW TO COMMUNICATIONS AND
CONVEYANCE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SEVENTY AB.
THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ON PARMI THAT'S AUTHORED BY THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY TO THAT
* JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
I DON'T.
ONE SEVENTY THREE AB FIVE
pITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE AB SEVEN
FORTY EIGHT TING TO PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION.
I DON'T ONE SEVENTY SEVEN AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR RUBIO. TO THE
LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SEVENTY NINE A.
B. NINETEEN FOURTEEN FLORA TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
AND FINALLY I'D HIM ONE NINETY
TWO AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY TWO
CARILLO. TO THE JOBS ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THE ECONOMY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BE
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE [inaudible]
SECOND READING [inaudible]
CORKERY.
SENATE BILL SIX OR 710-124-6013
395-391-52790 SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
ONE TWENTY AND ONE SIXTY EIGHT
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE.
A HOST OF ITEMS THAT WE WILL BE
TAKING UP TODAY.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE RATHER
QUICKLY.
STRAP YOURSELF IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWO EIGHTY THIS IS ON THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE WE'RE GOING
TO BE A BEGIN ON THE SENATE
THERE READING FILE.
FILE ITEM.
TO EIGHTY WHICH IS S. B..
THREE FORTY NINE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY NINE BY
SENATOR LARA AND ACTUALLY THE
COURTHOUSES.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER.
S. B. THREE FORTY NINE CLARIFIES
THE POWER OF JUDICIAL OFFICE.
SERVES TO PREVENT ACTIVITIES
THAT THREATEN ACCESS TO COURT
HOUSES INCLUDING BY PROTECTING
THE PRIVILEGE FROM CIVIL ARREST.
IT DECLARES THAT NO ONE SHOULD
BE SUBJECT TO CIVIL REST OF ANY
TYPE WHILE ATTENDING A
COURTHOUSE OR COURT PROCEEDING
FOR LEGAL BUSINESS.
IN STATES OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL MAY BRING FORD A CIVIL
ACTION IF THERE IS REASONABLE
CAUSE TO BELIEVE A VIOLATION THE
BILL'S PROVISION HAS OCCURRED.
PROTECTING PERSONS FROM CIVIL
RIGHTS WHILE CALIFORNIA'S
COURTHOUSES IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THE LITIGANTS AND
WITNESSES AND OTHERS ARE NOT
DETERRED FROM PARTICIPATING SUCH
PROCEEDINGS WHICH ARE OFTEN
NECESSARY TO PROTECT IN
VINDICATE.
GUARANTEED RIGHTS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S IMPORTANT NO THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS WOULD
STILL BE ABLE TO MAKE A CRIMINAL
ARREST IF THERE'S PROBABLE BOWL
CAUSE OR A CRIME IS WITNESSED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THAT A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VETERANS ARE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER TIED A AYE AYES
[inaudible]
FORTY FIVE NOS.
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO ANYONE IS S. B. TO
SEE HE WON COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY ONE BY
SENATOR ROBB IN ATLANTA COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS.
MISTER BONTA S..
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PRESENTING
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY ONE ON
BEHALF OF MY FRIEND SENATOR
RICHARD ROTH.
SENATE BILL TWO SIXTY ONE IS A
NON CONTROVERSIAL BILL THAT DOES
TWO SIMPLE THINGS FIRST IT WILL
ALLOW RESIDENTS OF COMMUNITY
INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS ARE
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION SHOULD
OPT IN. TO RECEIVE EMAIL
COMMUNICATION ELECTRONICALLY
UNDER CURRENT LAW THIS OFTEN
MUST BE IN WRITING SECOND IT
SHORTENS THE NOTICE REQUIREMENT
FOR BOARD MEETINGS TO BE TWENTY
EIGHT DAYS RATHER THAN THIRTY
DAYS IN ORDER TO OFFER MORE
FISHING CALENDAR IN.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR AYE VOTE VOTE
ON SENATE BILL. TWO SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CERVANTES SAYING
NO DISCUSSION
.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CLERK LBERAL.
ON MEMBERS.
IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALENT OUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO EIGHTY TWO IS SB.
ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR MISTER DALY
WE'LL JOCKEY CORKERY.
SENATE ELEVEN SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
MR I'M DALY.
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS BILL MAKES NECESSARY
CHANGES AND CLARIFICATIONS TO
THE CRAFT DISTILLERS ACT. TO
BETTER ALIGN THE RULES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CRAFT DISTILLERS
[inaudible]
WITH THOSE.
CURRENTLY APPLY TO WINERIES AND
BREWERIES.
THE BILL ELIMINATES AN EXISTING
REQUIREMENT TO CONSUMERS MUST
PARTICIPATE IN A TASTING PRIOR
TO PURCHASING A BOTTLE AT A
DISTILLERY.
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL INCREASES
THE MAXIMUM VOLUME THE
DISTILLERS CAN PRODUCE.
STILL BE CONSIDERED A CRAFT
THE INCREASES FROM ONE HUNDRED
HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS TO ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS.
SENATOR SKINER IN I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS DALY.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
RAW.
NUMBERS LETTERS THERE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS AND OF ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TOWN ABOUT AYE
SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WERE
GOING TO PASS A RETAIN ON FILE
ITEM.
TO EIGHTY THREE THAT TAKES US TO
FILE ITEM TO EIGHTY FOUR S. B.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR BERRYHILL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION.
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SP.
NINE SIXTY SEVEN OF SEEKS TO
WAIVE THAT YOU SEE AND SEE IF
YOU TUITIONS AND FEES FOR FOSTER
KIDS WHO HAVE BEEN IN FOSTER
CARE FOR AT LEAST TWELVE MONTHS
--
TWENTY EIGHT STATES ALREADY HAVE
TUITION WAIVER PROGRAMS IN PLACE
--
REMOVING THE SPIRIT EDUCATION
HAS THE POTENTIAL BE A TRUE GAME
CHANGER FOR OUR Y. TO SO MANY
FOSTER NOT CHILDREN IN OUR
STATE.
I S. B. NINE SIXTY SEVEN
RECENTLY PASSED OFF THE FLOOR ON
CONSENT HOWEVER THE BET BILLS
BACK WITH AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHICH ARE
ALREADY.
MOST INCLUDED EYES WELL AS OTHER
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS.
I REQUESTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL-ON AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO EIGHTY FIVE THIS S. B..
NINE SEVENTY CORKERY SEVERAL
NINE SEVENTY BY SENATOR ATKINS
AND OTHERS ACTUALLY TO
EMPLOYMENT MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT S. B. NINE
SEVENTY WHICH REQUIRE CALIFORNIA
HOTELS AND MOTELS TO TRAIN THEIR
EMPLOYEES.
ON HOW TO RECOGNIZE SIGNS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND REPORT
THESE.
I TO LAW ENFORCEMENT.
TRAINING EMPLOYEES IN THE
LODGING INDUSTRY IS ESSENTIAL TO
RADICALLY IN THIS FORM OF MODERN
SLAVERY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
NAME SANTIAGO SEEING THEIR
DISCLOSURE BEAT ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IS THERE A LITTLE MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TYPE ON I
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE ARE
AT FILE ITEM.
TWO EIGHTY SIX WE'RE GOING.
TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
MEMBERS WE ARE ONE TAKE A FILE
ITEM TWO EIGHTY SIX S. B..
TWENTY FIVE CORKERY.
CYNICAL TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS THIS RUBIO
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PRESENTING
SB.
TWENTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
PORTANTINO WHICH WILL CREATE A
THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THAT WILL REVISE
THE BALLOT ORDER.
THE PROPOSED BALLOT ORDER WILL
PUT LOCAL CITY SCHOOL OFFICES
AND PROPOSITIONS FIRST ON THE
BALLOT.
FOLLOWED BY DISTRICT COUNTY
OFFICES AND PROPOSITIONS STATE
OFFICES AND PROPOSITIONS AND
THEN FINALLY FEDERAL OFFICES.
IN ADDITION THE BILL REQUIRED
WILL REQUIRE A REPORT TO BE
SUBMITTED BY THE LA COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON THE FACT THAT THE NEW BALLOT
LAYOUT HAS ON VOTER TURNOUT FOR
LOCAL CONTESTS AND ITS EFFECT ON
DROP OFF RATES.
THE REPORT MUST BE SUBMITTED
THREE YEARS AFTER THE PILOT
PROGRAM HAS BEEN OPERATIONAL.
FINALLY THE BILL WOULD NOT TAKE
EFFECT UNTIL THE NEW VOTING
SYSTEM MODERNIZATION PROJECT IS
COMPLETED AND THE COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL.
DECLARES IT OPERATIVE AND NOTIFY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE PROPOSED LAW IS AN EFFORT TO
BOOST TURNOUT IN LOCAL ELECTIONS
AND IT IS AN ATTEMPT TO LEVEL
THE PLAYING FIELD FOR LOCAL
CANDIDATES WHO ARE FIGHTING FOR
VISIBILITY.
IN INCREASINGLY CROWDED ELECTION
CYCLES.
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
NUMEROUS CITIES IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGION AND RECENT
AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES. FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REVEAL [inaudible]
STIR [inaudible]
HARPER.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS VOTER
FATIGUE IS A REAL PROBLEM.
THERE ARE TOO MANY MEASURES ARE
RACES IN A SINGLE ACTIONS. FOR
MANY PEOPLE TO FOLLOW.
CHANGING THE ORDER OF THE
OFFICES WILL NOT SOLVE THE
PROBLEM.
THE REAL SOLUTION MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS.
IS THAT WE SHOULD NO LONGER
REQUIRE CITIES [inaudible]
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS [inaudible]
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND OTHER LOCAL
BODIES TO HAVE THEIR RACES
CONSOLIDATED TO THE STATEWIDE
PRIMARY AND GENERAL ELECTIONS.
IF WE JUST SIMPLY HAD
FREESTANDING ELECTIONS ALLOWED
FOR FREE STANDING ELECTIONS THEN
THESE LONG BALLOTS WOULDN'T BE
AN ISSUE AND WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO
HAVE THE STATE CRAM DOWN.
THINGS LIKE TRYING TO FLIP
AROUND TO MANIPULATE THE BALLOT
ORDER JUST TO TRY TO CHANGE
WHO'S VOTING FOR WHAT.
WE SHOULD ALLOW CITIZENS TO
FOCUS ON THEIR LOCAL CANDIDATES
AND ISSUES BY GIVING.
CITIES AND OTHER LOCALITIES THE
RIGHT TO HOLD THEIR OWN
ELECTIONS LIKE THEY DID JUST
ONLY A FEW MONTHS AGO.
NOT CHALLENGING THE BALLOT
ORDER.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR NO VOTE ON
THIS BILL.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE WAS RUBIO YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER JUST ON
RESPONSE I WE'VE TRIED THAT IT'S
BEEN HAPPENING FOR THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND IT HASN'T WORKED THE
TURNOUT IS STILL LOW FOR LOCAL
ELECTIONS AND SOME OF OUR
CANDIDATES.
I DON'T HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STAND OUT IN THESE ELECTIONS AND
FOR THOSE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO WITHOUT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL THE VERSE
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
LIKE WELL.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALIBAN ICE.
FORTY SIX KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES WERE TO PASS
TEMPORARILY [inaudible]
ON WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
AND TWO EIGHTY SEVEN THAT IS S.
B. SIXTY FOUR CORKERY.
SENATE BILL SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR WIECKOWSKI ACTUALLY THE
NOT VEHICULAR AIR POLLUTION
[inaudible]
DOCTOR RECOMMEND.
THINK IT WAS A SPEAKER MEMBER
TODAY ARE RISE TO PRESENT S. B.
SIXTY FOUR BY CENTER WIECKOWSKI.
THAT MEMBERS THERE WAS A TIME
WHEN OUR BAR GRID OPERATE IN A
MUCH DIFFERENT WAY --
IN MY OWN DISTRICT I HAVE A
PICTURE PLAN AND WE HAD BIGGER
PLANS TO USE WHEN WHEN WE REALLY
NEEDED THEM I'M AS WE HAVE
EXPANDED OUR RENEWABLE RESOURCES
AS WE HAVE.
A TAKEN AT A DIFFERENT TECHNIQUE
ON HOW WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE
OUR GREAT REMAINS RELIABLE.
WE NOW CYCLE IN AND OUT OF USING
OUR PETER PLANTS --
SOMETIMES ARE APPROPRIATE NOT
QUITE ALL THE WAY POWER AND
SOMETIMES RUN A COUPLE TIMES A
DAY SOMETIMES ARE NOT ND WE
HAVE NOT HAD ANY WAY OF
MEASURING THAT --
AND AS YOU KNOW THEY ARE MOST
OFTEN IN THE COMMUNITIES WITH
THE WORST AIR QUALITY --
I DID NOT VOTE FOR THIS BILL THE
FIRST TIME I SAW IT.
I ASK FOR MANY AMENDMENTS AND WE
GOT ANOTHER ONE AS OF LAST WEEK
--
TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE JUST
LOOKING AT THEIR AROUND GAS
FIRED PLANTS AND MAKING SURE
THAT WE UNDERSTAND HOW THEY ARE
BEING USED NOW WHAT IS GOING
INTO THE AIR --
WORK TO ALLEVIATE ALL THE
CONCERNS FROM AIR DISTRICT
BOARDS AND SO IN ORDER AGAIN AS
WE COLLECT DATA TO PLAN FOR OUR
FUTURE LET'S REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OUR GAS FIRED
PLANTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
IT IS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
DOCTOR RAYMOND.
DOCTOR EGGMAN MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER
[inaudible]
THIS IS.
FILE ITEM TO EIGHTY EIGHT SP TWO
SEVENTY FIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY FIVE BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTH CARE.
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY PRESENTING SP TWO
SEVENTY FIVE ON PRINT BEHALF OF
SENATOR PORTANTINO WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE CHILDREN
ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG.
ADULTS SUBSTANCE ABUSE ACT
DISORDER TREATMENT TREAT
DISORDER TREATMENT EXCUSE ME.
S. B. TWO SEVENTY FIVE REQUIRES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO CONVENE AN EXPERT
PANEL TO ADVISE DEPARTMENT
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ON THE
DEVELOPMENT.
OF YOU SUBSTANCE ORDER DISORDER
TREATMENT AS YOU DE STANDARDS.
COLLEAGUES CALIFORNIA HAS MADE
NUMEROUS ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS THE
COMPLEX NOT OF ISSUES RELATED TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE AND YET OUR SYSTEMS AND
PROGRAMS.
DON'T SEEM TO CARRY OUT OUR
INTENTIONS WE SEE THE RESULTS
AROUND US ON THE STREETS IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
MULTIPLE STUDIES OF ESTABLISH
THAT ADOLESCENTS ARE MORE
VULNERABLE THAN ADULTS TO
ALCOHOL CANNABIS TOBACCO AND
OTHER DRUG RELATED PROBLEMS.
THE BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS ALL OF
THESE ISSUES TO DEVELOPMENT OF
YOUTH TREATMENT STATUS FOR
CHILDREN ADOLESCENTS AND YOUNG
ADULTS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED UNIT
UNIFIED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH
COMMITTEE. FOR THIS WEEK FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINK ELECT WOOD ST NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
IT IS SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS HAD A VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM.
WORK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TELL YOU VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE MEMBERS WHO WANT TO
TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
TO EIGHTY NINE S. B..
THREE TWENTY CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY A PUBLIC HEALTH MAKING
A PREPARATION THEREFORE
[inaudible]
MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SB THREE TWENTY WOULD
REQUIRE ALL CAMPUS STUDENT
HEALTH CENTERS THAT PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES TO PROVIDE
MEDICATION ABORTION FOR THEIR
STUDENTS BY JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ACCORDING TO
THEY'RE GOOD MARKER INSTITUTE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION WOMEN IN THE
UNITED STATES HAVE TERMINATED
EARLY PREGNANCY THROUGH THE USE
OF MEDICAL.
MEDICATION ABORTION.
ACCORDING TO THE U. TO A U. S.
SAN FRANCISCO STUDY ABORTION
MEDICATION HAS SERIOUS ADVERSE
EFFECTS IN ONLY POINT 5% OF
CASES.
WHICH IS LESS THAN TYLENOL OR
*.
THE SAME STUDY ALSO FOUND THAT
EVERY MONTH UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
AND NINETEEN STUDENTS.
AT THE THIRTY FOUR UC AND CSU
CAMPUSES SEEK MEDICATION
ABORTIONS AT OFF SITE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES.
MANY CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES ALREADY OFFER
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SUCH AS PREGNANCY
OPTION COUNSELING AND
CONTRACEPTIVES.
AND I'LL AND ALL CONSIDER THE
SERVICES TO BE COMPONENTS OF
BASIC HEALTHCARE.
MEDICATION ABORTION IS A SAFE
PROCEDURE AND WITH CLINICALLY
SIMPLER THAN MUCH THAT MUCH OF
THE CARE ALREADY OFFERED AT
COLLEGE.
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER SUCH AS
DIABETES MANAGEMENT MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND DIAGNOSIS
TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED.
INFECTIONS CURRENTLY 51% OF
STUDENTS ACROSS THE YOU SEE AND
THE CSU SYSTEM OUR LOW INCOME IN
TWO THIRDS OF THE UC STUDENTS
AND ONE THIRD.
OF THE CSU STUDENTS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION.
IF A STUDENT HAS TO GO TO AN OFF
CAMPUS PROVIDER THAT DOES NOT
ACCEPT THEIR STUDENT OR OTHER
PRIVATE HEALTH CARE INSURANCE
PAIN FOR MEDICATION ABORTION MAY
BE A SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL.
BURDEN ACCESS TO MEDICATION
ABORTION ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES IS
CRITICAL SINCE WOMEN MUST
RECEIVE THIS CARE WITHIN THE
FIRST AT TEN WEEKS.
OF PREGNANCY AND MOST WOMEN
DON'T FIND OUT THAT THEY ARE
EVEN PREGNANT UNTIL THE FIFTH OR
SIXTH WEEK OF THEIR PREGNANCY.
DENYING COMPREHENSIVE AND
ACCESSIBLE REPRODUCTIVE CARE ON
CAMPUS INTERFERES WITH THE WELL
BEING ACADEMIC SUCCESS OF WOMEN
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND LOW INCOME
STUDENTS.
S. B. THREE TWENTY INSURES THAT
COLLEGE STUDENTS HEARING
CALIFORNIA HAVE ACCESS TO THE TH
TO THIS CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
IN CLOSING WE KNOW THAT
TERMINATING A PREGNANCY IS A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED RIGHT
BUT THERE IS A DISTINCT
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HAVING A
LEGAL RIGHT AND HAVING ACCESS.
TO THAT RIGHTS AND ON BEHALF OF
THE SENATOR --
FROM THE SAN BERNARDINO AREA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU IS CARILLO.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
USER TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FORTY
SIX KNOWS.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE FILE ITEM TO NINETY
S. B..
THREE FORTY THREE A CORPORATION
SENATE BILL THREE FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ATLANTA
TAXATION DECLARE THE URGENCY
THERE OF MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT I'M SENATE BILL THREE
FOUR THREE BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
A SENATE BILL THREE FOUR THREE
IS A DISTRICTS SPECIFIC BO THAT
WILL PROVIDE THE STATE INCOME
TAX EXCLUSION. FOR PAYMENTS
RECEIVED BY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE HOUSEHOLDS IN CARSON.
THESE HOMES WERE WRONGFULLY
BUILT ABOVE THE WALK OF THE
ABOVE A FULL RESERVOIRS.
ARE MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS AGO.
I WAS ON THE CARSON CITY COUNCIL
WHEN ACTION WAS TAKEN ON AS A
RESULT OF THIS INDIVIDUALS LOST
THEIR HOMES OR HOMES OR DEVALUE.
INDIVIDUALS LA PASSED AWAY AS A
RESULT OF IT.
CALIFORNIA TAX CODE MUST BE FIX
THESE RESIDENTS DON'T HAVE TO
PAY TAXES ALSO CALL INCOME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK AYE VOTE THIS
MEASURE HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES.
TAKING HIS GIPSON.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
I'M.
THE SAD ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I SIXTY
SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PARMI SIXTY SIX ZERO ON THE
URGENCY AND SIXTY SIX ZERO ON
THE MEASURE.
WE'RE FILE ITEM TO ANYONE S. B.
[inaudible]
THREE FIFTY FOUR CORKERY.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION [inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
S. B. THREE FIFTY FOUR THIS IS A
BILL THAT CREATES BETTER SUPPORT
FOR FAMILIES WHO ARE BEING
SERVED.
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL ENSURES
THAT LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
WILL PROVIDE PARENTS WITH A
COPY.
OF A STUDENT'S INDIVIDUAL
EDUCATION PLAN OR THEIR I. P..
TO BE TRANSLATED INTO THEIR
NATIVE LANGUAGE BY REQUIRING
THIS TRANSLATION WE EMPOWER
PARENTS TO PLAY A MORE ACTIVE
ROLE IN THEIR CHILD'S EDUCATION
AND ADVOCATE. FOR THEIR CHILD'S
NEEDS THE BILL ALSO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
UPDATE SAFEGUARDS TO MAKE SURE
THAT PARENTS ARE INFORMED OF
THEIR RIGHTS TO REQUEST
TRANSLATION SOMETIMES.
EVEN THOUGH THEIR TRANSLATORS
PRESIDENT I WITHOUT HAVING THE
MATERIALS IN YOUR NATIVE
LANGUAGE IN YOUR HANDS THIRTY
DAYS IN ADVANCE OF THE MEETING
SOMETIMES TRANSLATION.
CAN BE LOST IN THIS BILL WILL
MAKE SURE THAT WE PROVIDE THAT
SUPPORT TO OUR FAMILIES AND OUR
STUDENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY MUST THURMOND SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORPORAL OF
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DECIDED TO GO.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHEN
I FIFTY THREE NO.
SIX THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING OF PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY TWO AS WELL AS TO
NINETY THREE WE ARE GOING TO
TAKE UP.
FALLEN.
TO NINETY FOUR S. B.
[inaudible]
FIVE OH ONE CORKERY.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH ONE BY
SENATOR GLAZIER ACTUALLY TO
DENTISTRY.
MR LOW YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
S. B. FIVE OH ONE BY CENTER
GLAZER IS THAT BILL DEALING WITH
THAT UNTIL.
ANESTHESIA THIS HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND SUPPORTED BY THAT
THAT SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER LOVE SCENE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
TELL YOU I SIXTY TWO KNOWS.
ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS MOVING BRIEFLY BACK TO
GUESS INTRODUCTIONS ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
PLEASE WELCOME HIS DAUGHTER
DESIREE RODRIGUEZ WHO WILL BE
JOINING HIM AT HIS DESK FOR
TODAY'S SESSION WALKING TO THE
ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK ON THE FILE.
WE ARE IN SENATE THIRD READING
FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY FIVE S. B. FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND I
PLAYED A PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU MAY OPEN.
THEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HONORED TO PRESENT S.
B. FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
DODD WHICH ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
TEACHER CREDENTIALING
PARTNERSHIP PILOT PROGRAM.
CURRENTLY 75% OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DISTRICTS REPORT TEACHER
SHORTAGES.
MANY COMMUNITIES ARE NOT CLOSE
TO AN INSTITUTION THAT OFFERS A
TEACHER CREDENTIALING PROGRAM.
IT PUTS THEM AT A DISADVANTAGE
WHEN SEEKING TO ATTRACT AND
RETRAIN AND RETAIN HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATORS.
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES CAN HELP
IN MEET THE GROWING NEED FOR
TEACHER TRAINING A CREDENTIALING
ESPECIALLY AND UNDERSERVED RURAL
AND URBAN.
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL AWARDS UP
TO THREE GRANTS TO
COLLABORATIVE'S THERE WOULD BE
COMPRISED OF AN ACCREDITED
TEACHER CREDENTIALING HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTION.
AND A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
TO OFFER TEACHER CREDENTIAL
DEGREE PROGRAM ON THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
S. B. FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN
ADDRESSES SIGNIFICANT WORKFORCE
NEEDS BY REMOVING A CRITICAL
BARRIER.
PROSPECTIVE TEACHERS IN RURAL
AREAS ARE OFTEN UNABLE TO TRAVEL
OR RELOCATE. TO ATTEND A
CREDENTIALING PROGRAM THIS
MEASURES LOW COST EFFICIENT.
A AND A POSITIVE SOLUTION TO THE
CRITICAL TEACHER.
SHORTAGE OUR STATE IS CURRENTLY
FACING ASPIRO ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE ITEM.
CARP LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTED
IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TOWN ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE AND TO
NINETY SIX S. B..
SIX NINETY FIVE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL SIX NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS AND ACT
ON PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS.
MISS CARILLO SHE ALREADY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION IS
CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
I PROUDLY PRESENT S. B. SIX
NINETY FIVE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
LOTT A WHICH REMOVES BARRIERS TO
LIFE INSURANCE FOR TEACHER THAN
HEALTHCARE PRACTITIONERS.
BY ALONG THE USE OF INDIVIDUAL
TAX IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS ALSO
KNOWN AS I TENS WHEN APPLYING
FOR A PROFESSIONAL LICENSE
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING A MASSIVE TEACHER
SHORTAGE ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN
AREAS AREAS.
SUCH AS BILINGUAL EDUCATION THIS
BILL ENSURES THAT EXPERIENCE
IMMIGRANT TEACHERS INCLUDING THE
ESTIMATED FIVE THOUSAND TEACHERS
WITH DOCTOR STATUS.
CAN CONTINUE TO TEACH IN OUR
STATE.
THIS BILL ALSO EXPANDS
OPPORTUNITIES TO MANY
PROFESSIONS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING SHORTAGES INCLUDING
THE CERTIFIED NURSE ASSISTANTS.
AND HOME HEALTHCARE AIDS THE USE
OF AN AYE TEN WHEN APPLYING FOR
A LICENSE PROVIDES THE SAME
STANDARD OF INFORMATION. TO
LICENSING ENTITIES A QUALIFIED
PERSON WITH CAREER ASPIRATIONS
OF BECOMING A TEACHER A NURSE
ASSISTANT OR A PARAMEDIC.
SHOULD NOT BE BARRED FROM BEING
CREDENTIALED SIMPLY DUE TO THEIR
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
CALIFORNIA IS A STATE OF
ACCEPTANCE AND IMMIGRATION
INTEGRATION.
S. B. SIX NINETY FIVE OPENS UP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES TO WORK IN HIGH
SKILLED IN DEMAND PROFESSIONS.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS CREEL.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RIGHT ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE TOWN ABOUT ICE FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS.
NINE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHAT A PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM?
TO NINETY SEVEN WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK TO MS CARILLO.
THIS IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TO NINETY EIGHT S. B.. SEVEN
TWENTY SIX INCORPORATE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR WIENER AND ACTUALLY TO
CAL WORKS.
THIS CARILLO YOU MAY AGAIN OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AT SENATE BILL SEVENTY SIX
AUTHORED BY SENATOR WIENER SIX
TO MODERNIZE OUTDATED LAWS AND
CODIFY EXISTING PRACTICES
RELATING TO PROCEDURES. FOR
COLLECTING CALIFORNIA WORK
OPPORTUNITIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR KIDS ALSO
KNOWN AS CAL WORKS OVER PAYMENT.
BY INCREASING THE OVERPAYMENT
COLLECTION THRESHOLD FROM THIRTY
FIVE TO TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
AND ALLOWING FOR THE DEPARTMENT
TO INCREASE THAT THRESHOLD.
IF THEY DISCOVER THAT A HIGHER
ONE WILL BE MORE COST EFFECTIVE
WE PROVIDE RELIEF TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AND TWO PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATORS.
THIS ALSO ENSURES THAT COUNTIES
NO LONGER PAY MORE MONEY TO
RECOVER OVER PAYMENTS THAN THEY
ACTUALLY RECOVER.
FINALLY S. B. SEVEN TWO SIX WILL
CLARIFY THAT COUNTIES MUST
ADMINISTRATIVELY WAVE OR EXPUNGE
A CALL WORKS OVER PAYMENT IF IT
DECIDES AT AN OVER PAYMENT HAS
BEEN MADE.
AS A RESULT OF A THEATER COUNTY
SYSTEMIC ERROR OR NEGLIGENCE IF
PASSED THIS BILL WILL RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS TO THE
STATE AND COUNTIES.
AND ALSO CREATE A MORE FAIR AND
MORE JUST PROTOCOL FOR
COLLECTING OVERPAYMENTS THIS
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
ENJOYED NEARLY ANONYMOUS SUPPORT
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL I'M.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER TO SARAJEVO.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
ICE [inaudible]
FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY NINE S. B.
[inaudible]
SEVEN FORTY SIX CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AND EXPLAIN
FIREARMS [inaudible]
DR QUIRK [inaudible]
WE MAY.
AFTER QUIRK.
EMAIL BUT THANK YOU SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS S. B. SEVEN FOUR SIX
WILL AUTHORIZED PERSON NEW
SUBJECT.
ANY TEMPORARY PROHIBITION TO
TRANSFER THEIR FIREARMS OR
AMMUNITION. TO A LICENSED ARE
FIREARMS DEALER FOR THE JR
DURATION OF THE PROHIBITION.
THIS MEASURE CLARIFIES THE
SURRENDER PROCEDURES FOR
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION.
APPLY TO ALL TEMPORARY
PROHIBITIONS S. B. SEVEN FORTY
SIX ALSO CLARIFIES THE
INTERACTION OF TWO EXISTING
LAWS.
IN TERMS OF HOW THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE IMPLEMENTED
REGISTRATION PROCEDURES ON
HOMEMADE GUNS SO THAT GUN
REGISTRANTS DO NOT HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
I THINK IT AT QUIRK WHO SEEM NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO IS OUR VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE NO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TALLY THOSE.
I FIFTY NO SEVEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
WANNA PASS AND RETAIN A FILE
ITEM.
THREE HUNDRED THIS IS FILE ITEM
THREE A ONE S. B.. EIGHT TWENTY
SIX COOPERATE SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR JACKSON
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
CORPORATIONS ISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SENATE
BILL EIGHT TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR
JACKSON WOULD PROVIDE GREATER
GENDER DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE
BOARDS BY REQUIRING PUBLICLY
HELD CORPORATIONS BASED IN
CALIFORNIA. TO ADD MORE WOMEN
DIRECTORS TO THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
CALIFORNIA WOMEN MAKE UP 52% OF
OUR STATE'S POPULATION YET ONLY
15% OF THE DIRECTORS OF OUR
PUBLIC CORPORATIONS.
THAT MEANS MANY THE STATE'S
CORPORATIONS ARE OPERATE WITHOUT
THE BENEFIT.
EXPERIENCE PERSPECTIVE AND TOOLS
THAT WOMEN BRING TO THEM IN THE
CORPORATE SETTING.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY SIX
TAKES A BIG STEP TOWARDS CLOSING
THIS GENDER GAP.
RECIPROCALLY THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE EACH PUBLICLY HELD
CORPORATION HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA TO HAVE AT LEAST ONE
WOMAN ON ITS BOARD OF DIRECTORS
BY THE END OF TWENTY NINETEEN
BEGINNING IN JULY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE NEARLY THREE YEARS
FROM NOW.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE MINIMUM
TO WOMEN DIRECTORS ON THE BOARDS
WITH FIVE DIRECTORS IN AT LEAST
THREE WOMEN ON THE BOARDS WITH
SIX DIRECTORS OR MORE.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY THE WORLD IN A SUCH SETS
AN EXAMPLE FOR RESPONSIBLE
BUSINESSES GLOBALLY.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THAT WOMEN ARE INCLUDED
IN THE DISCUSSIONS AND DECISIONS
THAT BUSINESSES MAKE EVERY DAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
COR CLUB THERE ALL ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THEM
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
IS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER MOVES A CALL
.
MEMBERS AND FILE ORDER THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
THREE OH TO S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
EIGHT CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR WIENER AND ACTUALLY
DELAYING USE.
MISTER BLOOM EMAIL BUT MISTER
SPEAKER THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT AND ALLOCATION ARENA.
IS A POWERFUL TOOL FOR THE STATE
TO ENFORCE HOUSING LAW AND FAIR
SHARE PRINCIPLES.
BUT IT NEEDS TO BE MODERNIZED
AND STRENGTHENED IN ORDER TO
PROPERLY ADDRESS THE DEPTH OF
OUR HOUSING CRISIS.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR WIENER STRENGTHENS THE
STATE'S RINA PROCESS BY ENSURING
THAT HOUSING SHORTAGES.
ARE NOT USED TO JUSTIFY LOW
HOUSING ALLOCATIONS BY REQUIRING
HOUSING COSTS TO BE CONSIDERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT AS AN
INDICATOR OF ON IT OF AN
UNHEALTHY HOUSING MARKET.
BY STANDARDIZING HDDS PROCESS
FOR CALCULATING REGIONAL HOUSING
OBLIGATIONS AND BY REQUIRING
REGIONAL GOVERNMENTS TO SEND
DETAILED DATA TO THE STATE ABOUT
HOUSING MARKETS RELATIVE TO
OTHER.
COMPARABLE REGIONS THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY MORE OFTEN THAN NOT
RINA ALLOCATIONS ARE HEAVILY
POLITICIZED AND DIVORCED FROM
DATA.
ABOUT TRUE HOUSING DEMAND AND
FAIR SHARE PRINCIPLES THIS BILL
COMPLIMENTS COMPLIMENTS MY OWN
BILL AB. SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE
TO ENSURE THAT THE REVIEW
PROCESS IS BOTH FAIR AND ROBUST.
SB EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT FOCUSES
PRIMARILY ON THE INTERACTION
BETWEEN THE STATE AND COUNCIL
THE GOVERNMENT'S.
WELL MY AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE
FOCUSES PRIMARILY ON THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE COUNCIL
THE GOVERNMENT AND CITIES AND
THAT'S HOW THEY DIFFER.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
NAMES BLOW.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CARP WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TYPE OF ICE FORTY
FIVE KNOWS SEVENTEENTH THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE. TO FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY SEVEN THAT IS S. B.
[inaudible]
SEVEN HUNDRED CORKERY.
SENATE BILL SEVEN HUNDRED BY
SENATOR WIENER AND ACTUALLY TO
ENERGY.
MR HOLDING YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
HUNDRED BY SENATOR WIENER WHICH
PASSED MY COMMITTEE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AFTER EXTENSIVE NEGOTIATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR.
SENATE BILL SEVEN HUNDRED WILL
HELP CALIFORNIA ACHIEVE MARKET
TRANSFORMATION AND ENERGY
STORAGE INDUSTRY BY EXTENDING
THE EXISTING INCENTIVE PROGRAM
FOR THESE TECHNOLOGIES.
DISTRIBUTED STORAGE RESOURCES
REMAIN CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING
THE MID DAY SURPLUS OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY OR TUCKER.
THEY CAN ALSO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RESILIENCY DURING TIMES
AWHILE FIRE OR OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS.
WHEN TRADITIONAL DISTRIBUTION
SYSTEMS MAY BE SIR SEPARATE
SERB?
OR POWERED DOWN.
UNFORTUNATELY THE SO GENERATION
CENTER PROGRAM MORRIS CHIP.
A CROOK A CRUCIAL DRIVER OF
GROWTH IN THE STORAGE MARKET
WILL SOON EXPIRE.
UNDER FIVE YEAR EXTENSION
ESTIVER COULD GENERATE AS MANY
AS TWO THOUSAND TOTAL MEGAWATTS
OF STORAGE WHILE DRIVING PRICE
REDUCTIONS IN BOTH TECHNOLOGY
AND HARDWARE COSTS.
AS WELL AS SOFT BECAUSE SUCH IS
INSTALLATION PERMITTING AND
CUSTOMER ENGAGEMENT.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN AND
APPROPRIATIONS WOULD STRENGTHEN
THE PROGRAM'S ABILITY TO
GUARANTEE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
UNDER SB SEVEN HUNDRED THE S.
TIP WILL CONTINUE TO LOWER
ENERGY DEMAND IMPROVE GRID
RELIABILITY.
AND FOSTER THE GROWTH OF
RENEWABLE RESOURCES AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT.
OF SB.
SEVEN HUNDRED THANK YOU MUST
HOLD.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTE
WAS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TALK ABOUT EYES.
FORTY FIVE KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS BACK IN THE PREVIOUS
FILE ORDER THIS IS S. PARMI THIS
IS FILE ITEM.
THREE OH THREE S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY NINE COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY CANNABIS DECLARING
THEIR NC THERE OUGHT TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
DOCTOR WOULD THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE HAS
PRINCIPLE COAUTHORED PRESENT S.
B. EIGHT TWENTY NINE BY SENATOR
WIENER.
SP TWENTY NOT EIGHT TWENTY NINE
ALLOWS DONATION BASED
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS.
A PARDON WHAT PARTNER WITH
EXISTING RETAILERS TO FACILITATE
THE DONATIONS OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS.
IN CANNABIS PRODUCTS TO VETERANS
AND LOW INCOME PATIENTS WITH THE
BALLOT POSITIONS RECOMMENDATION
OR STATE IDENTIFICATION CARD.
THE BILL ALSO EXEMPTS THESE
MEDICAL DONATIONS FROM THE USE
AND AND AND CULTIVATION TAXES.
COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS
OPENED AFTER PROP TWO FIFTEEN
LEGALIZE USE OF MEDICAL CANNABIS
IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX PROGRAM'S
EMERGE TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
DISADVANTAGED INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAD A PHYSICIAN'S RECOMMENDATION
FOR CANNABIS BUT WERE UNABLE TO
ACCESS AND AFFORD THE MEDICINE
THEY NEEDED.
WITH THE ENACTMENT OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR THIS YEAR NEW TAXES WERE
PUT IN PLACE FOR ALL CANNABIS
AND CANNABIS PRODUCTS.
WELL COMPASSIONATE CARE PROGRAMS
DO NOT SELL OR PURCHASE ANY
PRODUCTS AMBIGUOUS DRAFTING DOES
NOT EXPLICITLY EXCLUDED
DONATIONS FROM THESE NEW TAXES.
THE DONATION BASED PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN FORCED TO CLOSE IN THE FACE
OF THESE EXORBITANT TAXES AND
NEW LICENSING FEES AND
SUBSEQUENTLY THE VETERANS AND
LOW INCOME PATIENTS WHO
CERTAINLY SERVED ARE CHOOSING
BETWEEN THE BLACK MARKET.
OR GOING WITHOUT THE MEDICINE
THEY NEED IN LIGHT OF THE HIGH
PRICES.
DONATIONS A MEDICAL CANNABIS AND
CANVAS PRODUCTS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
THE SURVIVAL OF CHRONICALLY ILL
PATIENTS LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
WITH CANCER HIV.
AND VETERANS WITH.
PTSD.
WHO OTHERWISE CANNOT AFFORD TO
ACCESS THEIR MEDICINE EIGHT
EIGHT TWENTY NINE SALSA CRISIS
BY ALLOWING THESE TERRIBLE
PROGRAMS TO PARTNER WITH
EXISTING RETAILERS TO FACILITATE
THE DONATIONS OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS? FOR CANNABIS PRODUCTS
ON THEIR LICENSE PREMISE AND BY
EXEMPTING THESE DONATIONS TO
BALLOT PATIENTS FROM USE AND
CULTIVATION TAXES.
THE BILL HAS HAD NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINKING BACK WOULD MISTER
BONTA.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE TODAY AS A CO AUTHOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. EIGHT
TWENTY NINE THERE'S A LONG
HISTORY IN OAKLAND IN MY
DISTRICT.
OF REGULATING THE MEDICAL
CANNABIS INDUSTRY WE HAVE DONE
THIS TO PROTECT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF PATIENTS WHO USE
CANNABIS.
AND TO ENSURE THE QUALITY AND
THE RELIABILITY.
OF MEDICAL CANNABIS PRODUCTS
SIMILARLY.
THERE'S A RICH HISTORY OF
COMPASSION AND SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN WHICH THE
INDUSTRY HASDONATED THEIR
MEDICINE.
YOU PATIENTS IN NEED SO I URGE
YOU COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT SB
TWENTY NINE SO WE DON'T ALLOW
ADULT.
LEGALIZATION TO ERASE THE
ORIGINALINTENT OF LEGALIZING
CANNABIS WHICH WAS TO ALLOW
PATIENTS TO SAFELY ACCESS THE
MEDICINE THEY NEED WITHOUT
TURNING TO THE UNREGULATED BLACK
MARKET [inaudible]
COULD JEOPARDIZE.
THEIR HEALTH RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA MR
MATHIS.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES ARE RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT.
OF S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY NINE WE KNOW THAT
ARE VETERANS ARE TWICE AS LIKELY
AS NON VETERANS TO DIE FROM
OPIOID RELATED OVERDOSES.
INSTEAD OF USING HIGHLY
ADDICTIVE OPIOIDS.
MANY VETERANS IN CALIFORNIA
MANAGE THEIR CHRONIC PAIN AND
PTS THE WITH CANNABIS.
HOWEVER VETERANS AND OTHER
VULNERABLE INDIVIDUALS CAN NO
LONGER ACCESS THEIR MEDICAL
CANNABIS DUE TO HIGH TAXES.
IN ACTED BY ADULT LEGALIZATION.
HER MORE COMMERCIAL TAXES
SHOULDN'T BE ATTACHED TO
DONATIONS.
ESPECIALLY IN LIGHT THAT THESE
DONATIONS ARE MADE TO OUR
VETERANS AND OTHER VERY ILL
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE ON FIXED INCOMES?
MEMBERS WE HAVE AN OPIOID
EPIDEMIC WE HAVE PEOPLE
STRUGGLING AND THE LAST THING WE
NEED TO DO.
IS TAX [inaudible]
A MEDICATION.
THAT IS BENEFITING THEM AND
GETTING THEM OFF OF YOURS.
YOU GUYS THINK ABOUT OUR
VETERANS THINK ABOUT THOSE ON
FIXED INCOMES AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MATHIS MR COOLEY.
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THIS IS NOT SOME BILL CARRIES
FOR THE POLICY ENACTED BY VOTERS
IN NINETY SIX FOR THE
COMPASSIONATE USE ACT.
WHICH JAMES SPECIFICALLY TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS FOR THOSE WHO NEED IT
VERY GOOD POLICY IN VERY
IMPORTANT UPDATE GIVEN RECENT
CHANGE IN THE LAW.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED
DOCTOR WOULD YOU MAKE CLOTHES IF
YOU WISH.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
HARTWELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE KNOWS TO ON THE
URGENCY.
I SIXTY FIVE NOSE TWO ON THE
MEASURE.
THAT BILL PASSES.
REYES WHERE FILE ITEM THREE OH
FOR S. B.. EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY FIVE BY
SENATOR GLAZIER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO PARKS.
MISS YOUR LEVINE.
I THINK VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE SENATOR GLAZER THIS
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE OF
SMOKING PRODUCTS.
OF ANY KIND AT A UNIT OF THE
STATE PARK SYSTEM AND MAKE IT AN
INFRACTION PUNISHABLE BY A FINE
UP TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
THE SMOKING PROHIBITION
CONTAINED IN THIS BILL CAN ONLY
BE ENFORCED AFTER SIGNS HAVE
BEEN POSTED THIS BILL ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE DIRECTOR OF
PARKS.
YOU DESIGNATE AREAS WITH IN
UNITS OF THE STATE PARK SYSTEM
AS EXEMPT FROM THE SMOKING
PROHIBITION WHILE THE ADVERSE.
HEALTH EFFECTS OF SMOKING AND
HEALTH CARE COSTS TO THIS DAY
ARE WELL KNOWN THE ADVERSE
IMPACT THAT SMOKING HAS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
TO THE STATE IS NOT CONTAINING
MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TOXIC CHEMICALS CIGARETTE*
THOUGH SMALL IN SIZE.
HAVE A HUGE NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
THE ENVIRONMENT AND ECOSYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE
SEASON WAS THE MOST.
DESTRUCTIVE ONE ON RECORD AND
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SEASON IS
NOT OFF TO A GREAT START.
MOREOVER CAL FIRE REPORTS THAT
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS 10% OF
THE FIRES IN CALIFORNIA WERE
STARTED BY CARELESSLY DISCARDED
CIGARETTES.
IMPROPERLY DISCARDED CIGARETTE
* IN CIGARETTE RELATED WASTE
DON'T JUST CAUSE FIRES THEY ALSO
POLLUTE THE ENVIRONMENT THIS
BILL IS A COMMON SENSE APPROACH
TO LOWER THE RISKS OF FOREST
FIRES.
AND WILL HELP CURB POLLITT
POLLUTION PLEASE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON S. B..
THREE NINETY EIGHT THIRTY FIVE
IF YOU MISTER LEVIN.
MISTER HARPER HERE RECOMMENDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
PERMISSION TO READ FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IF THE PEOPLE CAN'T EVEN SMOKE
ON A DESERTED BEACH WHERE CAN
THEY THERE MUST BE SOME LIMIT TO
THE COURSE OF POWER OF THE
GOVERNMENT.
THESE WERE THE WORDS OF GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN WHEN HE VETOED A
VERY SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR.
WE SHOULD NOT RESTRICT THE
FREEDOMS THAT SOME CALIFORNIANS
CAN STILL ENJOY.
WHEN EXISTING LAW CAN MAKE A
DECISION ON STATE BEACHES?
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION CURRENTLY HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO PROHIBIT SMOKING IN
CERTAIN PLACES.
AND LET ME ED THE PUT THE
PROPONENTS MAIN ARGUMENT ABOUT
FORCED IS NOT APPLY TO BEACH IS
BECAUSE WE KNOW.
BEACHES THEMSELVES ARE NOT
FLAMMABLE.
ADDITIONALLY IT IS AGAINST THE
LAW TO LITTER ON PUBLIC
PROPERTY.
THIS THEY CAN ALREADY WORKED TO
CLEAN UP OUR STATE BEACHES FROM
CIGARETTES WITHOUT BANNING THE
SIMPLE ACTIVITY OF SMOKING WHICH
MANY CALIFORNIANS DO INDEED
ENJOY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL [inaudible]
SHERBRO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER --
I'M GONNA RISE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS TODAY BUT I WANT TO COMMIT
TO MY FRIEND FROM.
CENTER FELL --
THIS IS A HUGE PROBLEM --
WE DO BANDS I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF
BANDS I'D RATHER FIND SOMEBODY.
FOR DROPPING A CIGARETTE*
DOWN OR A PLASTIC BAG IN THE
OCEAN.
BUT THE FACT IS THAT HALF TO
DEBRIS ON THE BEACHES FROM.
THREE DECADES OF COASTAL
COMMISSION BEACH CLEAN UP
CIGARETTE* ARE NEARLY HALF
THE DEBRIS ON THE BEACHES SO I
WANT TO COMMIT TO MY COLLEAGUE
ALTHOUGH WON'T BE SUPPORTING
THIS BAND TODAY.
LET'S WORK TOGETHER NEXT SESSION
WHILE VOTERS WILLING IF THEY
RETURN US ALL OUT TO FIND A WAY
TO CLEAN UP.
CIGARETTE* ON CALIFORNIA
BEACHES.
THING WAS BROKE MISS BAKER.
YOUR RANKING MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND I RISE AS A CO
AUTHOR AND URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE.
A KILLER BILL IS DIFFERENT FROM
LAST YEAR'S BILLS WERE VETOED BY
THE GOVERNOR DO ALLOW THE STATE
PARKS TO DESIGNATE AREAS FOR
SMOKING SO THAT WE CAN THIS TIME
ACCOMPLISH A BETTER BALANCE
WHICH IS.
ATTACK CLEAN WHAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF POLLUTION
ON OUR STATE BEACHES AT THE SAME
TIME ALLOWING THOSE WHO.
STILL SMOKE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO THAT --
WITH GREAT RESPECT FORGET
COLLEAGUES TO REPRESENT WELL
THEIR BEATS BEACH AND COASTAL
REGIONS OF I'VE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FREE AYE VOTE.
THEY WAS BIGGER MISTER THURMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT THIRTY FIVE YOU KNOW.
JUST TO CLARIFY THERE BEEN SOME
STATEMENTS MADE USING EXAMPLES
ABOUT WHY SO MUCH OF THEIR SMOKE
ON A BEACH.
AND THIS BILL EXCLUDE SPEECH IS
IN THE PLACES THAT CANNOT BE OUR
PERSON CANNOT SMOKE SO LET'S AT
LEAST GET THE FACTS RIGHT --
IN JUST A FOCUS ON THE MERITS OF
THIS BILL WHICH SEEKS TO
PRESERVE OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
PREVENT ADVERSE HEALTH EFFECTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WHICH THURMOND MISTER
BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JUST
WANT TO RESPOND TO THE NOTION
THAT -- WE
SHOULD WORK TOGETHER TO PASS
SOMETHING NOW SESSION.
ON I FIRST BROUGHT THIS
LEGISLATION IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
IT WAS ONE OF THE FIRST BILLS --
THAT I BROUGHT AFTER HAVING
WORKED VERY VERY HARD AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO ENACT SMOKING
BANS -- TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM SECONDHAND
SMOKE TO PROTECT FROM THE LETTER
THAT CIGARETTES CAUSE AND THAT
MANY MANY.
THAT NEGATIVE HEALTH EFFECTS ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH SECOND HAND
SMOKE [inaudible]
I THE TIME IS NOW TO PASS THIS
BILL WE NEED TO GET ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK YES HE VETOED IT
BEFORE BUT HOPEFULLY WON'T THIS
TIME.
DOCTOR CHOI.
YOUR RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU SPEAKER ARE.
RISE IN SUPPORT OF OUR THIS
MANAGER BECAUSE I STRONGLY
BELIEVE FIVE OUT DIAL.
A SMOKING IS INDIVIDUAL FREEDOM
OF WHAT ABOUT YOU OR THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE NEARBY AND A NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED.
I'VE DONE ALL I EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH ON WHEN I WAS SO --
WITH YOU IRVINE THE CITY COUNCIL
OR ON THEIR IMPACTS ARE OF THE
SECOND THERE YEAH.
I HEALTH IMPACT OF SECONDARY
SMOKING ARE.
IMPACT UPON THE OR THE PEOPLE AS
THE HOUSE.
AND THE THOSE OLD WAR WHEN MEAN
EVERYTHING'S THAT THE SECONDARY
SMOKING AUTHOR SOMEBODY ELSE'S A
SMOKING IS A VERY VERY HARMFUL.
ARE AS A RESULT OF I'M PRO PRO
THAT UPON MY INITIATION.
CITY OF IRVINE ADOPTED THE MOST
MOCKING POLICY ON PUBLIC PARKS
OF IT WORKS BEAUTIFULLY AND
EVERYBODY CAN ENJOY WE ARE AWARE
PARKS.
AT THE SAME TOKEN AT THE STATE
PARK SAW.
OR THE VISITORS SO. TEN ENJOY
WITHOUT.
WORRYING ABOUT THE SECONDARY
SMOKE OUR BY SOMEBODY ELSE'S
SMOKING AND THE SECOND ALREADY
AS A SOMEBODY ELSE ALREADY HAS
MENTIONED THE CIGARETTE*.
OUR MAJOR BECAUSE OF OF ALL THE
SMOKES.
MANY MANY DIFFERENT PLACES.
IF YOU DO WELL A SOME ARE A
STUDY ON THE OUR OUR COSTS OF
THE FIVE YEARS A CIGARETTE*
ARE ALL.
THE CLOSEST SO FOR HOME FAR
YEARS SO AS TO ANNOUNCED SO WHY
FIVE YEARS SO THEREFORE AND
THERE ALSO ALTHOUGH IT HELPS AND
THE BEAUTY OF OUR PARTS A MAN
THE UC'S SO MANY.
A CIGARETTE* ARE.
ALL ON THE PLEASE STREET DOT
THEY THOUGHT JUST OF THE WAY SO
I THINK THAT THIS IS A RIGHT WAY
TO GO.
I JUST SHOWN YOU URGED YOU YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THEY GET AYE CHOI MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU'RE RIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
WASN'T GONNA GET UP AND TALK ON
THIS BILL BUT I'D THERE'S A VERY
URGENT MESSAGE THAT CAME TO ME
FROM A VERY CONCERNED INDIVIDUAL
THAT WE ALL KNOW --
FORMER SPEAKER PEREZ --
SAYS IS THIS GOING TO BAN THE
ABILITY TO SMOKE CIGARS ON HIS
MEMORIAL PORTICO --
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT --
SO MAYBE MAYBE THE AUTHOR --
OR THE THE BILL JOCKEY COULD
SPEAK TO THAT IN HIS CLOTHES
THANK YOU.
SOUNDS LIKE FAKE NEWS TO ME.
YEAH.
SEEING KNOW ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MR LEVINE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DEBATE THAT WE JUST SAT ON THE
FLOOR AND DIE IN IN APPRECIATE
COMMENTS FROM SUPPORTERS --
PARTICULARLY OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
DUBLIN WHO TALKS ABOUT HOW WE'RE
ATTEMPTING TO STRIKE A BALANCE
HERE.
OR OUR COLLEAGUE FROM IRVINE HE
TALKS ABOUT THE IMPACTS TO THE
OTHER PEOPLE WHO AREN'T SMOKING
THOSE CIGARETTES AND I THINK
ABOUT JUST THIS PAST YEAR WHEN I
TOOK MY CHILDREN TO THE BEACH.
AND MY DAUGHTER WHO IS NINE AT
THE TIME SHE JUST TURNED TEN
LAST WEEK I ASKED ME DAD WHY ARE
THERE SO MANY CIGARETTES ALL
AROUND US.
AND DIE AND SO THIS BILL IS
ACTUALLY ABOUT PARKS THE NEXT
BILL I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE WILL
BE ABOUT BEACHES BUT HOPEFULLY
WE'VE EXHAUSTED.
ALL OF THESE ARGUMENTS ARE ON
AND I I WOULD INVITE.
AYE GOVERNOR BROWN TO TAKE A
DRAG ON A CIGARETTE ON HIS RANCH
IN COLUSA I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE.
WITHOUT CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AN ICE FIFTY
KNOWS TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
THREE OH FIVE S. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT THIRTY SIX KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL EIGHT THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR GLAZIER AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA STATE BEACHES.
MR LEVINE IF YOU MAKE AN OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD OF THIS BILL S. B..
EIGHT THIRTY SIX I THIS BILL
WOULD BAN SMOKING AT INLAND AT
STATE PARKS UPBEAT BOSS BUILT
DID INLAND STATE PARKS OF THIS
BILL.
WOULD BAN SMOKING AT STATE
BEACHES THE MAXIMUM FINE MIRRORS
THAT OF THE PREVIOUS BILLING CAN
ONLY BE ENFORCED AFTER SIGNS
HAVE BEEN POSTED.
VARIOUS NONPROFITS IN STUDIES
HAVE CONSISTENTLY FOUND THAT
DISCARDED* ARE THE NUMBER
ONE WASTE ITEM ON BEACHES.
ACCORDING TO THE STUDY BY THE
CALIFORNIA OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL ABOUT 40% OF DEBRIS
COLLECTED ON COASTAL CLEANUP DAY
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN WAS FROM
SMOKING RELATED.
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS DISGUSTING
IMPROPERLY DISCARDED CIGARETTE
RELATED WASTE CREATE SERIOUS
HEALTH HAZARDS. FOR LAND AND
MARINE ANIMALS WHEN INGESTED.
MOREOVER RECENT STUDY BY
STANFORD UNIVERSITY SHOWED THAT
A NON SMOKER STANDING DOWNWIND
FROM A SMOKER.
OUTDOORS CAN BE EXPOSED TO
SUBSTANTIAL LEVELS OF TOXIC
SECOND HAND CIGARETTE SMOKE THIS
CAUSES CANCER.
BY THE WAY.
BANNING SMOKE IT STATE BEACHES
IS THE NEXT STEP IN ADDRESSING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
CONCERNS ASSOCIATED WITH
SMOKING.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE THOUGH.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVIN MISTER
HARPER YOU'RE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THERE SO MANY NANNY
STATE BILLS ON THE FLOOR IT'S
HARD TO KEEP TRACK OF THEM.
I MEAN IS ONE AFTER THE OTHER
AFTER THE OTHER AFTER THE OTHERS
LIKE THE BAND THE MONTH CLUB
HERE ON THE FLOOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLY.
BUT IN TERMS OF THIS ISSUE IN
SPECIFICS MY DISTRICT INCLUDES
THREE STATE BEACHES INCLUDES
PARTS OF BALCHIK A STATE BEACH
HUNTINGTON STATE BEACH AS WELL
AS CRYSTAL COVE STATE BEACH.
AND IF THERE'S NOT ENOUGH IF YOU
IF THERE'S NOT SPACE WHERE YOU
ARE THE SMOKE FREE THERE'S
PLENTY OF BEACH TO GO AROUND
IT'S AS SIMPLE AS THAT THE
BEACHES ARE HUGE.
THE BEACHES ARE PLENTY OF SPACE.
IN TERMS A LITTLE QUESTION.
SOME FOLKS HAVE A PROBLEM
HANDLING THE LETTER AND WE
SHOULD GO AFTER THE LABORERS
[inaudible]
BUT THIS ISSUE IS REALLY SIMPLE
ON ONE HAND YOU MAY HAVE ON
SMOKING --
THE PEOPLE WITH PROBLEMS --
WITH THAT GETTING THE LETTER
WITH THE WITH WITH WITH YOUR
FILTERS BUT CIGARS DON'T HAVE A
FILTER PROBLEM.
YOU'RE SIMPLY ENJOYING A CIGAR
NEXT TO A BEACH BONFIRE WHAT'S
THE HARM IN THAT.
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I ASK YOU
ALL TO RESPECT PEOPLE'S FREEDOM
DOES GET A LITTLE ELBOW ROOM.
MOVE ALONG ENJOY THE BEACH
ENJOYED THE TREASURES OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT DON'T IMPOSE YOUR WILL YOUR
IDEOLOGY ON PEOPLE WHEN THEY
SIMPLY WANT TO ENJOY THEIR
BEACHES.
I OR SEC WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE
ON THIS BILL.
MISTER LACKEY YOUR RECOGNIZE
YOUR QUESTION THE AUTHOR PLEASE
[inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
IS YOUR GOAL TO HELP YOUR*
ON THE BEACH [inaudible]
THANK [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SIR LACKEY [inaudible]
ALL DISCUSSION.
HAVING BEEN EXTINGUISHED
[inaudible]
THIS.
MISTER LEVINE YOU MAY CLOSE.
IT'S NOT THAT FUNNY I I OR
SOMETHING ASTRONAUT.
CLICK BELOW FOR THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
BUT IS THERE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL INTO THE
BUT ICE FIFTY KNOWS.
TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE. TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM.
TO NINETY THREE IS FILE ITEM TO
NINETY THREE SB [inaudible]
FOUR FIFTY TWO COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL FOR FIFTY TWO BY
SENATOR GLAZER IN ATLANTA
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS MAKING
PREPARATION THE FOR THE CLAIM
THAT HURTS THEIR UP TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MISTER GLORIA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM OR THE BOTTLE
BILL PROGRAM HAS DIVERTED TONS
OF BEVERAGE CONTAINERS SOME
CALIFORNIA LANDFILLS.
AND FOR MOST OF THE PAST THREE
DECADES HAS BEEN A MODEL
RECYCLING PROGRAM AS MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES MAY KNOW THE PROGRAM
SUFFERED A SIGNIFICANT SETBACK.
LED JANUARY TWENTY SIXTEEN
STEMMING FROM A REDUCTION IN THE
FEES PAID BY THE STATE TO
RECYCLERS INC RESULTING FROM A
PRECIPITOUS DECLINE IN GLOBAL
COMMODITY PRICES.
SUBSEQUENTLY RECYCLING RATES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE DROPPED MY HIGH
OF 85% FOUR YEARS AGO TO JUST
75% LAST YEAR. TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES THIS BILL WILL IMPLEMENT
THREE KEY ELEMENTS TO STABILIZE
THE BOTTLE BILL PROGRAM.
FIRST THE BILL WILL RESTORE
RECYCLING INCENTIVES TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN LEVELS SECOND THE BILL
REFOCUS CAO RECYCLE RESOURCES ON
BRINGING RECYCLING
OPPORTUNITIES.
HUNDREDS OF UNDERSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WHILE
PROVIDING LIMIT TEMPORARY RELIEF
TO DEALERS SPACE WE TAKE BACK
REQUIREMENTS AT NO FAULT OF
THEIR OWN AND LASTLY THIS BILL
WILL ACQUIRE CAO RECYCLE TO
DEVELOP RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE
LEGISLATURE.
BY JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TO ENSURE THE HANDLING FEE
CALCULATIONS ARE ADEQUATE TO
MAINTAIN OUR STATES RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS.
RETAILERS GROCERS RECYCLERS AND
OTHERS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA.
THIS BAKER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AYE ARISES A CO AUTHOR AND
STRONGLY URGE SUPPORT FOR THIS
RESOLUTION THIS MEASURE.
I THIS IS A LONG TIME PROBLEM
THAT WE'VE HAD THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA NCA JUST WHEN I VISIT
IN NEIGHBORHOODS MY DISTRICT FOR
FOLKS ARE SAYING WHAT AM I GOING
TO BE ABLE TO DO WITH
RECYCLABLES I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING WITH IT IN THE OPTION
TO BECOMING NARROWER AND
NARROWER.
IT IS TAKING YEARS TO GET TO
THIS POINT THIS IS A VERY
BALANCED AN APPROPRIATE
RESOLUTION RESPECTFULLY URGE
DRIVE THE THANK YOU MS BAKER
MISTER BLOWN.
YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ARE ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR FIFTY TWO AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR OUT WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE AS I HAVE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS NOW I THINK MOST --
FOLKS BELIEVE THAT --
WHEN THEY HAVE A RECYCLABLE
PRODUCTS AND THEY PUT IT IN THE
RECYCLE CANDIDATES NECESSARILY
BEING RECYCLED AND WOULD BE
SHOCKED? TO FIND OUT IN JUST HOW
MANY CASES THAT IS NOT HAPPENING
IT SO THIS IS MEANINGFUL REFORM
IT'S NECESSARY AND DIE AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM MISSED
CUNNINGHAM THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER ALSO RISE IS A CO AUTHOR
AT LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING HARD ON WHAT IS TRULY A
STATEWIDE PROBLEM.
I THINK THAT THIS BILL IS GOING
TO MOVE THIS FORWARD IN A
POSITIVE WAY AND IN PARTICULAR
IT WAS AMENDED RECENTLY TO MAKE
SOME EXCEPTIONS TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESS FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND SMALL GROCERS. TO
MAKE THIS MORE ACCOMMODATING TO
THEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CUNNINGHAM.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
MISS GLORIA MIKLOS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU I'VE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOU ROLL AND TALLY THE
VOTES EYES.
FIFTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE ON THE
URGENCY AYE AYES FIFTY SEVEN
KNOWS.
ONE ON THE MEASURE THAT BILL
PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN REGULAR FILE
ORDER [inaudible]
THIS IS FILE ITEM THREE OF SIX
S. B..
NINE OH FIVE CLERK WILL READ
SENATE BILL NINE OH FIVE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL IS ABOUT PURE LOCAL CONTROL
AND WHAT IT DOES IS ALLOWS NINE
CITIES.
THAT WANTED TO VOLUNTARILY
PARTICIPATE IN A PILOT PROGRAM
THAT IS REVIEWED BY THE
LEGISLATURE EVERY YEAR.
PILOT PROGRAM WILL GO FOR FIVE
YEARS AND ALL I WOULD SAY IS.
IF A LOCAL MUNICIPALITY.
HOW DO A COMMUNITY PLAN?
IF A. B. C. APPROVED IT IF LAW
ENFORCEMENT INPUT --
DE IS TAKEN AND THEY APPROVED
AND IF COMMUNITY INPUT IF TAKEN
AND THEY APPROVED.
THEN A LOCAL MUNICIPALITY AND
MEANS THE GOVERNING BODY WOULD
STILL HAVE TO VOTE ON IT AND
MAKE IN RESTRICTED.
THEY GET UP THEY CAN MANEUVER IT
IN ANY POSSIBLE WAY THEY WANT.
WHEN ALL THOSE THINGS HAPPEN
THEN [inaudible]
ONLY THEN.
WOULD THEY WOULD THEY ALLOW THIS
A CERTAIN.
OF RESTAURANTS.
AREAS OR CITIES THESE NINE THAT
VETERAN A MENTION IN THE BILL.
INCREASE THE TIME. FOR ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES TO BE SERVED FROM TWO
TO FOUR MORNING.
IT IS A RESPONSIBLE BILL.
I IT'S GOT ALL THE PROTECTIONS
THAT ARE NEEDED.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO IS
CARILLO.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND I
RISE IN PROUD SUPPORT OF SB NINE
OH FIVE AS A CO AUTHOR WHICH
PROVIDES LOCAL COMMUNITIES WITH
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DETERMINE FOR
THEMSELVES WHEN HOW AND IF.
THEY WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND HOURS
OF SERVICE IT IS CRITICAL THAT
OUR COMMUNITY OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE INCLUDED AND DECISION MAKING
PROCESS HE'S WITH.
CONFRONTED WITH ISSUES THAT
GREATLY IMPACTS OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY EXTENDING HOURS OF
SERVICE WILL EXPAND TOURISM
OFFERINGS INCREASED TAX REVENUE
AND OFFER.
FOSTER ACTIVE AND VIBRANT
NIGHTLIFE TO OUR COMMUNITIES
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA DESTINATION
CITIES ARE AT A DISADVANTAGE.
WHEN COMPETING WITH CITIES OF
BOTH NATIONALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY FOR TOURISM
CONVENTIONS AND CONFERENCES?
THIS BILL WILL ALIGN CALIFORNIA
WITH THE LISTS AT LEAST FIFTEEN
OTHER STATES WHERE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DECIDE ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
SERVICE HOURS.
THIS BENNETT THIS BILL WILL
BENEFIT BUSINESSES ACROSS OUR
STATE AND FOR THE FIFTY FIRST
THIS BILL WILL HELP THE
REVITALIZATION OF QUARTERS OF
SUNSET BOULEVARD SILVERLAKE ECHO
PARK YOU'LL YORK BOULEVARD
HIGHLAND PARK.
CHINA TOWNS IN DOWNTOWN LOS
ANGELES WHICH I KNOW MANY OF OUR
MEMBERS FREQUENTLY COME AND
VISIT AND HAVE A GOOD TIME AND
SO WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR IS --
OUR EXTENDED AND THAT YOU CAN
ALL ENJOY THE BEAUTY THAT OUR
OUR STATE HAS TO OFFER.
I FEEL CONFIDENT THAT S. B. NINE
OH FIVE IS A MEASURED APPROACH
THAT WILL BRING NUMBER OF BRING
NUMEROUS BENEFITS TO THE
COMMUNITIES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS CARILLO.
MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE AS A CO AUTHOR OF
S. B. NINE OH FIVE I REALIZED
THAT MIGHT RAISE A FEW EYEBROWS.
I'M PROBABLY THE LAST PERSON
YOU'D EXPECT TO FIND IN A BAR AT
TWO O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING BUT
I'M A BIG PROPONENT.
OF LOCAL CONTROL AND I BELIEVE
IN THE ABILITY OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO MAKE THE THEIR OWN
DECISIONS ABOUT WHAT'S BEST. FOR
WHERE THEY LIVE IF I WAS STILL
ON A CITY COUNCIL I MIGHT WELL
VOTE NOT TO ALLOW THIS TO OCCUR
BUT I DO SUPPORT THE RIGHT FOR
THEM TO MAKE THEIR OWN DECISIONS
AND I DON'T SUPPORT. ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACHES BY THE STATE
TO REGULATE THAT KIND OF
ACTIVITY AND FOR THAT REASON I
URGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
MISTER HARPER HERE RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I ALSO AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIG BEAR LAKE I THINK ONE
THING THAT'S REALLY.
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO CLARIFY
HERE IS THAT IS AN OPT IN BILL.
ANY CITY CAN SHOES THE OFTEN.
BUT IT DOESN'T REQUIRE CITIES
THE OPTIC.
I RECOGNIZE THAT SOME CITIES ARE
GOING TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
CLIENTELE DIFFERENT FOLKS THAT
ENJOY GOING OUT AT NIGHT.
AND ESPECIALLY THEY'RE GOING TO
BE SOME CITIES THAT MAY HAVE A
TOURISM BASED THAT DRAWS
INTERNATIONALLY AND THOSE FOLKS
MAY OR MAY NOT BE ON THE SAME
TIMELINE.
OR TIME ZONE AS YOU OR I IN
TERMS OF HOW OTHERS BEING ASLEEP
AND HOW THEY'RE BEING AWAKE.
AND SO WITH THAT I URGE THIS BY
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER MISTER
BLOOM YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
MEMBERS IF YOU ARE PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE MEMBERS WHO ARE
GET UP AND SPEAK ON THIS BILL
THIS MUST BE THE COUP BY A BILL
OF THE YEAR --
I ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB
NINE OH FIVE I REPRESENT. TO THE
CITY'S LOS ANGELES AND WEST
HOLLYWOOD THAT WANT TO
RESPONSIBLY ENACT ORDINANCE SAYS
TO SHOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT CAN WORK AT THE PILOT
PROJECT I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
SEEN NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OUR DEBATE ON THE ITEM MISTER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MISTER SANTIAGO FOR YOUR CLOSE.
I THINK MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A
GOOD BILL IT'S ABOUT LOW PURE
LOCAL CONTROL IT WILL HELP US
BECOME A COMPETITIVE.
A THE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
ALREADY INCREASED --
THE THE CONSUMPTION TIME OR GO
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
WHAT'S ALSO IMPORTANT THIS IS A
HISTORIC MOMENT.
THE GENTLEMAN FROM HUNTINGTON
BEACH AND I FINALLY AGREE ON A
BILL.
AND MANY DEMOCRATS MANY MANY
FRIENDS ON THE ON THE SIDE OF
THE AISLE THAT I'M ON WILL
NOTICE.
THAT THE TENEMENT HUNTIN BEAT
FINALLY AGREES ON SOMETHING.
I EXPECT THAT TONIGHT.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO WITH
THAT CLERK WILL OPEN ROAD ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
FOURTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SEVENTY
SEVEN THE ONE DAY WAITING PERIOD
FOR CONCURRENCE IS ITEM ONE
THIRTY NINE THROUGH ONE NINETY
NINE INCLUSIVE TO ALLOW AUTHORS
TO TAKE UP THEIR BILLS TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST.
IS GRANTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
PARDEE WHERE WERE TO PASS
TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM THREE OF SEVEN
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
THREE OH EIGHT S. B. NINE FIFTY
FIVE THE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL NINE FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR NIELSEN OTHERS IN
ATLANTA WATER.
MISTER GALLAGHER EMAIL.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE RISE TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR S. B. NINE FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR NIELSEN --
I AM ALSO A CO AUTHOR ON THIS
LEGISLATION --
IN FEBRUARY TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
STATE AVOID A NEAR DISASTER.
AT THE WORD BILL DAM WITH THE
COLLAPSE OF THE FLOOD CONTROL
SPILLWAY.
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
RESIDENTS MY CONSTITUENTS WERE
EVACUATED FROM THEIR HOMES AND
FLED FOR SAFER GROUND.
WHAT ALL THE PARTIES RECOGNIZES
THERE IS A PRESSING NEED FOR
GREATER COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
THE COMMUNITY?
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES.
THE FORENSIC REPORT THAT MANY OF
YOU SAW AND COMMITTEE IN AND
HEARD ABOUT.
CALL DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND INSULAR
ORGANIZATION.
THAT THEY HAVE NOT DONE A GOOD
JOB OF GETTING OUTSIDE
INFORMATION AND ESPECIALLY FROM
INFORMATION FROM THE PUBLIC.
S. B. NINE FIFTY FIVE WOULD TAKE
A TREMENDOUS STEP FORWARD IN
RELATIONS BETWEEN THE ORVILLE
REGIONAL COMMITTEE COMMUNITY.
AND THE DEPARTMENT BY CREATING
THE CITIZENS ADVISORY COMMISSION
FOR ORVILLE DAN.
THIS COMMITTEE REFLECTS A
SELECTION OF LOCAL AND STATE
GOVERNMENTS PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS.
MAKING UP A WIDE SELECTION OF
THE CAN WITH VARYING
BACKGROUNDS.
THE UNIFYING FACTOR WILL BE
THEIR COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING
THE ONGOING.
AND I REPEAT ONGOING SAFETY AND
SOUNDNESS OF THE FACILITIES
WITHIN THE SITE AND ALONG THE
FEATHER RIVER.
ASSEMBLY MEHMET'S REMOVE THE
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND CLARIFIED
LEGISLATIVE FINDINGS.
AND DECLARATIONS RECORDING THE
FAILURE OF THE SPILLWAY AT AT
THE DAM.
AFTER FIFTY YEARS OF HISTORICAL
GRUDGES AND MISTRUST I BELIEVE
THAT S. B..
NINE FIFTY FIVE CAN IT WILL
SERVE TO BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER
TO GREATLY IMPROVE.
THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THE ORVILLE COMMUNITY
DOWNSTREAM COMMUNITY.
AND PROVIDE A FORMER IDEAS CAN
BE DISCUSSED AND WE CAN ENSURE
THAT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IS
OPERATED AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
SAFETY THE WAY IT SHOULD BE --
FOR THOSE OF US WHO LIVE --
DOWNSTREAM OF THE DAM.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO
OPPOSITION AND HAS UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I SINCERELY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER SEEN
NO DISCUSSION.
OUR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
USER TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL AND TALLY THE VOTE
EYES FIFTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSED
.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM THREE A ONE
THAT'S S. B..
EIGHT TWENTY SIX THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ON MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WISH TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WISH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL ABOUT AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY ONE THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING.
TO RECESS UNDER CALL OF THE
ONE PM THE MEMBERS OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
YOU WILL BE MEETING AND ROOM
[inaudible]
ONE TWENTY SIX EVERYBODY ELSE.
THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL OF THE
SPEAKER.
LUNCH IS BEING SERVED.
DAMS IN THE DEMOCRATS THAT IS IN
THE LOUNGE REPUBLICANS IN THE
RULES COMMITTEE ROOM WILL BE
RETURNING AND TAKING UP.
BILLS AT ONE P..
THIS IS RECESS UNDER CALL
.
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK IN SESSION
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
SOME
WOMEN WHO HAVE CHEN.
VOTE CHANGE S. B. EIGHT TWO
EIGHT FILE ITEM THREE OR TO
CHANGE FROM A NO TO AND I THOUGH
CHANGE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN CYNICAL
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT NOTES I
MISTER DALLI. FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DO YOU RISE.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN OF THE
FLOOR.
PLEASE RETURN THE FLOOR WE HAVE
LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE THE BODY
FIRST PLEASE TURN OF THE FLOOR
IMMEDIATELY.
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP
ITEMS
[inaudible]
BOB
OKAY MEMBERS.
WE ARE GOING TO RETURN TO THE
FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. THREE OH NINE
S. B..
NINE FIFTY SEVEN CORKERY.
SAMPLE NINE FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA VEHICLES.
MR MONDAY S..
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT SENATE BILL NINE
FIVE SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
LARA.
ACCORDING TO UC DAVIS STUDY MORE
THAN HALF OF CONSUMERS WHO
BOUGHT IS OUTSIDE AT THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A CLEAN CAR
STICKER AS THE TOP REASON FOR
THEIR PURCHASE.
HOWEVER UNDER EXISTING LAW IS
THAT CANNOT RECEIVE A CLEAN CAR
STICKER IF UNDER THE PREVIOUS
OWNER THIS I'VE HAD PREVIOUSLY
RECEIVED ONE THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A PATHWAY FOR
HOUSEHOLDS WITH AN ANNUAL
INCOME.
OF FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND OR LESS
TO APPLY FOR A CLEAN CAR STICKER
WHEN THEY PURCHASE A USED ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE.
THIS WILL HELP MAKE CLEAN CAR
STICKERS MORE ACCESSIBLE TO LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND HELP
INCENTIVIZE THE PURCHASE OF THE
USE OUT.
S. B. NINE FIVE SEVEN WILL
SUNSET AND TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TO
ALLOW THIS LEGISLATURE.
TO ASSESS THE IMPACT OF THIS
PROGRAM ON THE ZEV MARKET AS
WELL AS THE USE OF HOV LANES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
MS MELENDEZ HERE RECOMMENDS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
WHILE I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF THE AUTHOR IN HELPING
PEOPLE OUT WHO MAY BE
FINANCIALLY --
STRAPPED I DON'T REALLY THINK
IT'S FAIR TO OFFERED THIS
INCENTIVE TO A CERTAIN.
CATEGORY OF PEOPLE AND NOT
EVERYONE ELSE EITHER YOU WANT
THESE VEHICLES ON THE ROAD IN
AND BEING USED IN THE HIV LANES
OR YOU DON'T YOU'RE PICKING
WINNERS AND LOSERS HERE THERE A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
WHO WANT TO GO BACK AND FORTH TO
WORK AND A FASTER WAY THAN THAN
USING THE REGULAR LANES WHO
WOULD LOVE AN EXTENSION ON THEIR
EACH OF THE STICKER BUT THEY'RE
NOT GETTING IT?
SO WE'RE SUBSIDIZING THESE CARS
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES THAT NOW
I MEAN YOU CAN GIVE THEM AWAY.
SO WE'RE SUBSIDIZING THEM AND
NOW WE'RE GOING TO ADD ON TO
THAT BECAUSE YOU CAN'T SELL
ENOUGH OF THEM.
YOU'RE GONNA ADD ON TO THAT AN
EXTENSION OF BEING ABLE TO USE
THE H. O. V. LANES CUTTING OUT.
AND A WHOLE OTHER SEGMENT OF THE
POPULATION IS WHICH IS GROSSLY
UNFAIR I URGE YOU KNOW ABOUT.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOUR RECOGNIZE --
MY CONCERN AND THE FLOOR MANAGER
CAN MANAGE CAN DISCUSS THIS IN
OUR CLOTHES IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
TO IS THAT RIGHT NOW IN THE BAY
AREA WHERE I LIVE.
THE HOV LANES BASICALLY ARE NOT
ANY FASTER.
THEN THE REGULAR LANES.
AND I THINK WE JUST HAVE TOO
MANY PEOPLE IN THOSE LANES RIGHT
NOW.
AND SO I REALLY CAN'T SUPPORT --
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE GETTING IN
THOSE LANES WE NEED FEWER PEOPLE
IN THEM SERVE THEY'LL START
WORKING AGAIN.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
[inaudible]
DISCUSSION.
OR DEBATE.
MS CERVANTES YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS IN CLEAN
TECHNOLOGIES IS NOT BEEN ENJOYED
EQUALLY BY ALL THEREFORE SP
FIFTY SEVEN HOPES.
BY THE TRANSFORMATION OF THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TO APPLY
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING
THOSE IN OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE ABOUT.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
MISTER BONTA S. MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS PLEASE RETURN TO THE
FLOOR.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR FROM
THE LOUNGE.
WE HAVE LOTS OF BUSINESS BEFORE
THE ASSEMBLY TODAY.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE TEN S. B..
NINE SIXTY CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY TO
CORRECTIONS.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU MEHLMAN YES
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS SOMEBODY AROUND LAST
YEAR THAT THE STATE AUDITOR
RELEASED AN AUDIT AFTER
INVESTIGATING GROWING IN
INMATE'S SUICIDE RATES IN OUR
STATE PRISONS.
THOUGHT REPORT DETAILS SEVERAL
DEFICIENCIES WITH C. VCRS
PROTOCOL FOR RESPONDING TO AND
PREVENTING SUICIDES.
THOUGHT AUDIT NOTED THAT SEVERAL
STATE PRISONS FAILED TO COMPLETE
REQUIRED SUICIDE RECEIVE
VALUATIONS AND TREATMENT PLANS.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT STAFF
DID NOT ADEQUATELY MONITOR
ADDRESS INMATES OR COMPLETE
REQUIRED TRAINING RELATED TO
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND RESPONSE.
FOCUSING ON THE AUDITOR'S REPORT
RECOMMENDATION RECOMMENDATIONS
S. B. NINE SIXTY REQUIRES A CB
SI ARE TO REPORT ANNUALLY TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON ITS PLANS AND
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS IDENTIFIED
DEFICIENCIES.
THIS BILL IS VITALLY IMPORTANT
TO ASSURE THAT INMATES HAVE
TREATED HUMANELY AND IF THEY
RECEIVE THE SUPPORTING CARE THEY
NEED ON BEHALF OF SENATOR LEYVA
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER SAYING
NO.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON.
ROSARIO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROME TELL ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THREE ELEVEN IS S. B..
NINE SIXTY SIX CORKERY SENATE
BILL NINE SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR
WIENER AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE WATER QUALITY [inaudible]
MISTER LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT S. B. NINE SIX
SIX BY SENATOR WIENER --
NON POTABLE WATER.
SYSTEMS ARE SYSTEMS THAT ARE
CONTAINED WITHIN A SINGLE
BUILDING AS OPPOSED TO
CENTRALIZED UTILITY SCALE WATER
RECYCLING.
SUCH SYSTEMS PROVIDE IMPORTANT
COMPLEMENT TO UTILITY SCALE
CENTRALIZED WATER RECYCLING
FACILITIES IN AREAS WHERE
EXISTING OR PLANNED
INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROVES INADEQUATE FOR ACHIEVING
CONSERVATION GOALS IN A COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER YOU COULD TELL
I DIDN'T WRITE THIS.
KIRK CURRENT LAW GOVERNING ON
SIDE.
RE USE REMAINS A PATCHWORK.
IT DOES NOT ALWAYS.
APPLY PROPER RISK BASED ANALYSIS
TO GUARD AGAINST EXPOSURE TO
PATHOGENS.
S. B. NINE SIXTY SIX NEED YOUR
SUPPORT I HOPE YOU'LL VOTE I
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
SCENE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THEY'RE ALL OUR
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS THERE TO VOTE [inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW THE VOTE I
SIXTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE TWELVE S. B. [inaudible]
NINE SIXTY EIGHT CORKERY.
SENATE BILL NINE SIXTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PAN AND OTHERS AND I
PLAN TO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
[inaudible]
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB NINE SIXTY EIGHT
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND REQUEST THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
ONE FULL TIME MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELOR.
PER FIFTEEN HUNDRED STUDENTS
ENROLLED AT EACH OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE CAMPUSES THE BILL
ALSO HOPES TO REMEDY THE LACK OF
DATA ON MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
BY REQUIRING THE CSU EVERY THREE
YEARS TO REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH
COUNSELORS EMPLOYED ON EACH OF
ITS CAMPUSES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ADDRESS THAT
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS FACING
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND DEVELOP A
CONSISTENT SYSTEM WIDE.
REPORTING REQUIREMENT THE BILL
HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND A
COALITION OF SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BONTA SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
PURPLE OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
I'M VOTE.
HIS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF IT I SIXTY
THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
FILE ITEM [inaudible] THREE
THIRTEEN IS S. B. NINE SEVENTY
THREE CLOVER WREATH.
CYNICAL NINE SEVENTY THREE BY
SENATOR DODD AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
MISTER LUCKY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SB NINE SEVENTY THREE TAKES A
TWO PRONGED APPROACH TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF DRUG DRIVERS.
A CALIFORNIA ROADS.
FIRST THIS BILL INCREASES
FUNDING FOR THE SIEGE PRE.
A THEIR DESIGNATED DRIVER
PROGRAM BY INCREASING THE ANNUAL
SURCHARGE THAT A. B. C. COLLECT
FROM ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE LICENSES
FROM FIVE DOLLARS. TO TEN
DOLLARS.
THE SIEGE PRE DESIGNATED DRIVER
PROGRAM EDUCATES THE PUBLIC
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF DRINKIN
AND DRIVING.
ENCOURAGES AND REWARDS THOSE WHO
CHOOSE NOT TO DRINK IN ORDER TO
SAFELY DRIVE OTHERS HOME.
SECOND THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
DISTILLED SPIRITS MANUFACTURERS
TO PROVIDE CONSUMERS FREE OR
DISCOUNTED RIDES TO FURTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY.
THIS AN EXPANSION OF A PROGRAM
STARTED LAST YEAR'S AB SEVEN
ELEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW
WHICH WE APPRECIATED.
AND THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
COOPER SHIP IN OPPOSITION AND IT
DESERVES YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS LACKEY SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CAR CLUB IN THE ROLE.
DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
S. TAKES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. TWO THIRDS VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL
.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES FIFTY
SIX NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM.
THREE FOURTEEN IS SB ONE
THOUSAND CORPORAL READ SENATE
BILL ONE THOUSAND BY SENATOR
LARA AND ACTUALLY TO
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION.
MS BURKE EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RIGHTS
RISEN SP ONE THOUSAND WHICH
PROMOTES THE ADOPTION OF
ELECTRIC VEHICLES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE BY ENSURING MORE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO CHARGING STATIONS.
STATE HAS SET THE MOST AMBITIOUS
GOALS IN THE NATION FOR EVEY
ADOPTION HOWEVER A LACK OF
AVAILABLE CHARGING STATION
REMAINS ONE OF THE MOST CITED
CONCERNS FOR PURCHASING AND AS
AN E. V..
S. B. ONE THOUSAND MAKES CLEAR
THE PUBLIC INVESTMENT IN
CHARGING STATIONS ARE MEANT FOR
USE BY ALL TYPES OF ATVS
INCLUDING PLUG IN HYBRIDS IN
ADDITION AS PER THE STATE'S
CONSIDERATION FOR PUBLIC
INVESTMENT.
IN CHARGING STATIONS THE ENERGY
COMMISSION SHALL CONSIDER THE
PROPORTION EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FAST CHARGING
STATIONS.
FINALLY THE BILL DIRECTS THE CPC
TO PRIORITIZE THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HEAVY DUTY EVEY PLEATS AS THE
ONE THOUSAND IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT IN REACHING OUR STATE
SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT HELPS MAKE
SURE CAL POINTS FROM ALL WALKS
OF LIFE CAN COMFORTABLY USE ANY
VIA ARE.
ACTIVELY REQUEST ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE SARAH BUT
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
THREE FIFTEEN THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
THREE SIXTEEN S. B. TEN THIRTEEN
CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TEN THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE GREENHOUSE GASES.
DOCTOR RECOMMEND BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
TEN THIRTEEN OH IS.
DEALS WITH HYDRO [inaudible]
FLORO CARBONS.
MORE EASILY KNOWN [inaudible]
AS H. --
THIS IS A GET SOMETHING THAT IS
GOING OUT INTO OUR ATMOSPHERE
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT --
CENTER WORKED ON VERY HARD AS
MANY OF US DID IN NATURAL
RESOURCES MOST ALL OF THE
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN REMOVED.
IS A GOOD BILL THAT GOES TOWARDS
PROTECTING OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
MAKING SURE APPLIANCES ARE UP TO
STANDARDS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
MISTER COSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ARE
THIS WAS A BILL THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AND I AM A REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES AND I COULD NOT
SUPPORT WHEN THE BILL ORIGINALLY
CAME THROUGH NATURAL RESOURCES.
BUT SINCE THAT TIME A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK HAS BEEN DONE HOW
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
APPLIANCE MANUFACTURER SIDE DOW
CHEMICAL CARRIER LENNOX.
I WHO ARE NOW EITHER IN
SUPPORTER NEUTRAL IN
ADDITIONALLY CAL CHAMBER CMC A
AN AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL
ARE ARE NEUTRAL AS WELL --
THIS BILL HELP PROTECT
INVESTMENT OF JOBS AND MANY
CALIFORNIAN U. S. BUSINESSES AND
LIKE TO THINK THE AUTHOR OF FOR
WORKING NOW WITH THE OPPOSITION
IN MY AND MY OFFICE SO TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS I NOW
SUPPORT A PLANET SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE.
AND I ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
DO THE SAME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CASA.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
DESERT A LITTLE MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FOUR
KNOWS.
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THREE SEVENTEEN IS S.
B.. TEN SEVENTEEN CORKERY.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR ALLEN AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE FISHERIES MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
[inaudible]
SURE GLORIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
RESENT SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTEEN
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR BEN ALLEN.
THIS BILL WILL INCENTIVIZE
CALIFORNIA'S SWORDFISH FISHING
INDUSTRY TO TRANSITION AWAY FROM
HARMFUL GILL NETS TO MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND MORE PROFITABLE
GEAR TYPES.
YOU SUCH AS A DEEP SET BUT WE
SYSTEMS BY ESTABLISHING A
PROGRAM TO BUYBACK STATE DRIFT
GILL NET PERMITS WITH PUBLIC AND
WITH PRIVATE FUNDS.
ALONG WITH INCREASING THE
COMPENSATION FOR ACTIVE
FISHERMEN RECENT AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS THE FEAR THAT MONEY FOR
THE PROGRAM WILL NEVER
MATERIALIZE.
NOW S. B. TEN SEVENTEEN DOES NOT
SUNSET THE FISHERY UNTIL FOUR
YEARS AFTER PHILANTHROPIC
SOURCES ARE ABLE TO RAISE ONE
MILLION DOLLARS AND ADDITIONALLY
DIRECTS THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL. TO USE ONE MILLION
DOLLARS A FUNDING WE APPROPRIATE
THIS YEAR FOR WHALE AND SEA
TURTLE ENTANGLEMENT EFFORTS --
THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
SUPPORTED BY OVER TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS AND
BUSINESSES INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME CUT
COMMISSION.
THEY AMERICAN SPORTS MACHINE
ASSOCIATION THE PEW CHARITABLE
TRUSTS SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
THE CALIFORNIA SPORTSMAN'S
FOUNDATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ZOOS AND
AQUARIUMS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER HARPER YOUR RECOMMENDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I VOTED AGAINST THIS BILL WHEN
IT CAME UP BEFORE WATER PARKS
AND WILDLIFE COMMITTEE I BECAUSE
OF THE WAY IT WAS ORIGINALLY
WRITTEN IN RITUALLY PRESENTED.
BY LARA APPLAUD THE AUTHOR.
AND THOSE WHO WORK WITH THEM IN
TERMS OF REACHING AN EFFECTIVE
COMPROMISE.
AND I REALLY WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND SAY THE I THINK IT'S SO
GREAT BUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL I APPLAUD THE THAT THE
EFFORT AND WORK THAT'S BEEN PUT
INTO THIS.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER.
MARK THE TAPE ON THAT.
MISTER BRO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
ARISES A PROUD CO AUTHOR THIS
BILL.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS THE
INDUSTRY'S USE THESE MILE LONG
DRIFT NETS TO GO AFTER
SWORDFISH.
BUT THEY INADVERTENTLY CATCH
TURTLES DOLPHINS SHARKS OTHER
THINGS ARE NOT LOOKING FOR AND
SOME BAD ACTORS OF ACTUALLY
KILLED THE MAMMALS --
WHICH IS NOT WHAT WE WANT TO DO
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
SAID THERE IS A BETTER WAY.
THESE DEEP HAWKS THE SWORDFISH
ARE LOWER ON THE OCEAN FLOOR
THAN THE OTHER STUFF THAT GETS
CAUGHT IN THE NET --
THE FACT IS THERE'S ONLY
SEVENTEEN PERMITS IN CALIFORNIA
AND ONLY FIVE ARE ACTIVE SO.
WITH THE PROGRAM --
GOES UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THERE'S AN INCENTIVE TO BUY BACK
THE UNUSED PORTION OF THE
PERMITS THAT THE FISHERMEN --
HAVE -- HAVE
PURCHASED FROM THE STATE MY
LOCAL SPORT FISHERMEN ARE --
IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND SO LAST
FREE AYE THE HE WAS ROBUST KALRA
HERE RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ALSO RISE AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE
BILL AND I WANT TO THANK A THE
MEMBER FROM SAN DIEGO.
EYES WAS THAT ARE SENATE AUTHOR
FOR WORKING SO HARD.
A TO MAKE THIS A REALLY REALLY
GOOD BILL AFTER COMMENTS MY
COLLEAGUE HUNTINGTON BEACH I GOT
A LITTLE CONFUSED FOR A SECOND
BUT I'M REALLY HAPPY TO HEAR
THAT -- THIS
IS GETTING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND I THINK THIS IS GOING TO DO
THIS THIS SUCH A GREAT PRESIDENT
GOING FORWARD ON HOW WE CAN WORK
ON SOME OF THESE ENVIRONMENTAL
BILLS IN A BIPARTISAN FASHION.
MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS ARE IN THE
INDUSTRY CAN.
FOLKS IN THE INDUSTRY CAN THE
CAN THAT CAN BE RESPECTED AND
AND WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACTS ON THEM BUT ULTIMATELY
TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND FOR THE WILDLIFE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
SERVE GLORIA YOU MAY CLOSE
VIGOROUS SPEAKER IN THE SPIRIT
OF BIPARTISANSHIP I WILL TAKE
THE COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUE IN
HUNTINGTON BEACH AS MY CLOTHES
AND RESPECT WE ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY WAS GLORIA WITH THAT
PURPLE.
MEMBERS SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSE RURAL.
CALVET I SIXTY NINE KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS
AND RETAIN A FILE AND THREE
EIGHTEEN WEIRD.
THREE NINETEEN S. B. TEN FORTY
ONE COOPERATE.
CYNICAL TEN FORTY ONE BY SENATOR
LEYVA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH [inaudible]
MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SP TEN FORTY ONE WOULD REQUIRE
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO NOTIFY HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS AND FOR THOSE
PROVIDERS TO IN TURN NOTIFY
PARENTS ABOUT THE RISKS AND
EFFECTS OF LEAD EXPOSURE AS WELL
AS REQUIREMENTS.
THAT ALL MEDI CAL ENROLL
CHILDREN BE TESTED.
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION STATES THAT THERE
IS NO SAFE BLOOD LOW BLOOD.
LEAD LEVEL IN CHILDREN AND A
CHILD EXPOSED TO LEAD CAN CAUSE
PERMANENT DAMAGE TO THE BRAIN
AND NERVOUS SYSTEM.
THIS IS A FRIGHTENING THOUGHT
CONSIDERING RECENT REPORTS CHAU
THAT SOME COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE RATES.
CHILDHOOD LEAD X. LEAD POISONING
HIGHER THAN EVEN FLINT MICHIGAN.
S. B. TEN FORTY ONE WILL HELP TO
ENSURE.
THAT PROVIDERS AND PARENTS ARE
WELL INFORMED OF THE RISKS AND
EFFECTS OF CHILDHOOD LEAD
POISONING AT THE CALIFORNIA HAS
THE NECESSARY DATA. TO MAKE SURE
MEDI CAL CHILDREN ARE BEING
TESTED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINK OF ISRAEL'S.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK LIBERAL.
ON UNDERSTOOD.
DESERT OF A LITTLE MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
BUT CLERK WELL.
CLOSE RURAL TALBOTT AYE SEVENTY
TWO KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
VIOLATED.
THREE TWENTY IS S. B..
MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
BUDGET ITEMS.
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE TAKING
UP.
THESE ARE BUDGET BILLS.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
FILE ITEM NUMBER [inaudible]
THREE SEVENTY FOUR THIS IS.
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
EIGHT SIXTY TWO KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY TWO BUT
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW ACTUALLY THE STATE BUDGET
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
BUDGET FELL.
MR TANG HE MAY OPEN.
THEY COMMIT SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT
SIX TWO AMOUNTS TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET WITH MAINLY
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS.
BUT THERE A FEW KEY ITEMS
CONTAINS PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
ALLOWING THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES. TO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THROUGH THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE.
RESOLVED UNACCEPTABLE WAIT TIMES
AT FIELD OFFICES BUT THERE WAS
NO APPROPRIATION.
APPROVED AT THIS TIME THEY WOULD
HAVE TO COME BACK WHILE WE'RE IN
RECESS TO GET FURTHER APPROVAL
OF ANY APPROPRIATION.
AND ALSO ALLOCATES TWENTY THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR WATER
RELATED PROGRAMS OF THOSE ARE
BROKEN DOWN IN THIS WAY A SIX
POINT EIGHT MILLION.
FOR DRINKING WATERS IN SCHOOLS
PROGRAM BY TEN POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR EMERGENCY WELLS AND
SEPTIC REPLACEMENT. THREE
MILLION FOR WATER TAKE
REPLACEMENT. THREE MILLION FOR
WATER ASSESSMENT REPORT IT ALSO
PROVIDES TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR
SERVICES FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
FOR WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
DANISH TANK MISTER OBERNOLTE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED MISTER SPEAKER I
RISE IN OPPOSITION SB EIGHT
SIXTY TWO COLLEGE MOST OF THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS TRAILER BILL
ARE ON CONTROVERSIAL.
HOWEVER I HAVE A BIG PROBLEM
WITH THE ALLOCATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
SURE ALL AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT THAT DEPARTMENT HAS HAD IN
RECENT MONTHS WITH THE WAIT
TIMES AT FIELD OFFICES.
BUT AS THE GENTLEMAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO SAID THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES A POTENTIALLY
UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF MONEY TO THE
DMV THERE IS NO LIMIT.
AND IT'S JUST CURSORY
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT ALL THE
DEPARTMENT WOULD HAVE TO DO IS
PETITION THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. FOR FUNDING WITH AN
EXPLANATION OF WHAT THEY WANT TO
USE THAT MONEY.
FOR AND THAT THE DEAL EFFORT OF
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
APPROPRIATE THAT MONEY WITHOUT
ANY LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT FROM
US ALL WOULD REQUIRE IS A
CURSORY NOTIFICATION TO THE
CHAIR BUDGET THE CHAIR OF
APPROPRIATIONS.
AND I THINK THAT'S A VERY
DANGEROUS THING TO DO ESPECIALLY
SINCE WE JUST REJECTED THE IDEA
OF AUDITING THE DMV AND IN THAT
HEARING WHEN I QUESTIONED THE
DIRECTOR.
ABOUT HOW THE DEPARTMENT HAD
SPENT THE SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS WE APPROPRIATED LAST
YEAR FOR THE PURPOSES OF
ALLEVIATING WAIT TIMES SHE WAS
NOT ONLY UNABLE TO ARTICULATE
WHERE THAT MONEY HAD GONE.
BUT SHE ADMITTED THAT THEY DID
NOT OPEN THE FIELD OFFICES ON
SATURDAYS AS THEY WERE SUPPOSED
TO DO IN JANUARY INSTEAD THEY
WERE NOT A FULLY OPEN UNTIL
AUGUST.
SO WELL IN THAT KIND OF
ENVIRONMENT I THINK IT'S A VERY
DANGEROUS THING TO DO TO WRITE
THEM WHAT IT WHAT AMOUNTS TO A
BLANK CHECK.
I URGE A NO VOTE.
MR ACOSTA.
BE A RECKONING THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER OB.
WE'VE HEARD SOME DISCUSSION OF
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR A BUDGET
THAT TRAILER BILL AND CERTAIN
ITEMS THERE IN IT I I I I I DO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT
I HAVE SOME CONCERNS AND I THINK
WE NEED.
TO THE VERY NEAR FUTURE THERE
ARE ARE ITEMS IN THIS BILL OF
THAT ARE VERY IMPORTANT
ESPECIALLY RELATED HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AYE TESTING OF THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT THE EVIDENCE
KITS.
BUT THOSE LOOK THE ONE PIECE
THAT WAS JUST MENTIONED BY MY
COLLEAGUE AND HOW FROM BIG BEAR
THAT IS PARTICULAR TO OP
PROBLEMATIC IS THE THE DMB
FINDING.
OUT WHAT WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST
DISCUSSION NOT ONLY IN A IN A
BUDGET COMMITTEE BUT ALSO AND
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES I ASKED A VERY
SIMILAR QUESTION ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM THE FUNDING
THAT WE ALLOCATED.
FOR SATURDAY SERVICE ALL THE
ANSWER WAS NOT ONLY
UNSATISFACTORY BUT ONCE WE DID
GET AN ANSWER FROM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE DMV.
OF THE ISSUE WAS --
AND THE ANSWER WAS THAT THE
MONEY HAD BEEN SPENT ON OVERTIME
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE SATURDAY
SERVICE WE HAVE SET UP TO SEVEN
OUR LINES IN OUR D. M. V..
AND THAT IS JUST SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE WHEN PEOPLE ARE
PASSING OUT IN THE SUMMER HEAT
--
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT --
DID THIS THIS INCREASE SPENDING
MADE LITTLE TO NO DENT IN THE
DMB SAW AND ADD THEM TO THE
DELAYS AT THE LINES OF THE NB IN
MY DISTRICT AND OTHERS.
I'M DISTURBED THE BILL BASICALLY
AMOUNTS TO A BLANK CHECK TO THE
MP AS WAS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
IF MORE MONEY IS NEEDED.
ARE FOR TO ENSURE PROMPT SERVICE
THAT WE HAVE TO AGREE AT THE
EARLIEST POSSIBLE MOMENT. TO
INTO --
ISSUE AN AUDIT TO OF THE DMB
THAT WE MAKE SURE IT'S BEING
SPENT WISELY THAT IS OUR NUMBER
ONE PRIORITY.
I'VE AND AS I SEE IT WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE PEOPLE'S MONEY
IN THE BUDGET I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY BUT I
ENCOURAGE THIS LEGISLATURE.
THAT WE MUST COME BACK AND WE
MUST GET ANSWERS TO THESE VEXING
QUESTIONS ABOUT WORK TAXPAYER
MONEY IS GOING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER.
AMOS COSTED DOCTOR CHOI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND THE
MEMBERS SAW I RISE.
TODAY IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS MATTER BECAUSE OF OUR
FUNDING.
A MEASURE OF TWO THE AND THE
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
I YET ANOTHER.
ARE JUST LEGISLATURE DECIDES. TO
ATTACK THE YEAH.
EASY WAY OUT.
WHEN IT COMES TO OUR AYE ISSUES?
PLAGUING OUR OF CONSTITUENTS.
IS A VERY CLEAR THAT THE THERE
IS SOME ON OUR EFFICIENCY
PROBLEM.
NOT AT THE DMV THAT IS.
THE RELEASE ON A YACHT JOINT
COMMITTEE MET.
EARLIER THIS MONTH.
DURING THAT THE HEARING HEARING.
BE AYE DIRECTOR OF WHAT THE M.
V. STRUGGLED OUT TO PROVIDE A
SUFFICIENT DATA ON THE CALL
SOLVE TO YEAH WAIT TIMES OR ANY
SORT OF A PLAN TO FIX THEM.
HOW DOES THE JOB?
THIS BODY REACTOR.
TOWARD THIS ARE.
DEBORAH NIXON OF MATURITY.
NOT BY YOUNG HOLDING.
THIS OUR INDIVIDUAL OUR SAW.
ACCOUNTABLE LAW TO THE
CONSTITUENTS SAYS SAW.
NOT THAT WE OR SERVE.
BY THROWING OUT MORE OF DO
TAXPAYERS --
HALT OR IN THE MONEY.
ARE AT THE PROBLEM.
ALL WHY I LOCKED TELLING OUT
REQUEST OF FOUR LEGISLATIVE WELL
ORG OFTEN GOT D. M. V..
THAT OUGHT WOULD HAVE HELPED US
A TOUR OUT REALLY UNDERSTAND VIA
PROBLEM AND THE PROVIDE OUR ON
EFFECTIVE A SOLUTION.
ONCE AGAIN THE LEGISLATURE
FAILURE SO TO DO THE HARD WORK.
REQUIRED TO TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE TAXPAYER SAW ON GETTING A
GOOD RETURN ON THE LARGER AMOUNT
OF THE MONEY THAT THEY ARE
ALREADY PAY.
OFF WITH THIS SERVICE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT JUSTALL GO BACK
TO WHAT THAT THE BELIEVE ARE.
TOBY YA BOTTOMLESS PIT.
THE TAXPAYERS SAW WHAT IT.
I WORK CONSTITUENTS A DESERVE
OUR AID [inaudible]
BETTER ANSWER.
AND DUG ITSELF STUFF BETTER THAN
THIS.
I STRONGLY URGE YOU AN AWFUL
LOT.
MS BAKER YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS --
THIS WAS THE YEAR THAT WE SAW A
LOT OF COLLEAGUES EARLIER THIS
YEAR EXPRESS.
DEEP OUTRAGE AND HOW THEY FELT
THEY WERE FORCED TO VOTE.
I HEARD FROM MANY COLLEAGUES
THAT CLEARLY DIDN'T WANT TO VOTE
FOR SOME OF THE MEASURES THEY
HAD EARLIER THIS YEAR THEY WERE
JUST OUTRAGED.
I I THINK THERE WAS LIKE OUR
SPEECHES ON AND I AM SPEAKING TO
MY COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE AND I'M WONDERING
WHERE IS THAT.
WITH THIS BILL I'M GONNA VOTE
FOR IT BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN
GETTING THE RAPE KIT ISSUE DEALT
WITH IN THE STATE.
AND I BELIEVE WE NEED TO FIGHT
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND I BELIEVE WE NEED TO FIX THE
DMV AND I CANNOT THINK OF A
WORSE WAY TO TACKLE THE
CHALLENGES AT THE DMV THAN WHAT
IS IN THIS BUDGET TRAILER.
IT NOT ONLY.
COMPLETELY IGNORES THE AUDIT
REQUEST THAT WE HAD SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE AN INDEPENDENT
NONPARTISAN.
REVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES TO FIX THE
PROBLEM EVERY ONE OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS HAS BEEN SCREENING
TO US ABOUT.
I GOT LETTERS ON MY DESK HERE
FROM ELDERLY CONSTITUENTS OF
MINE WHO WAITED IN LINE FOR
EIGHT HOURS AND PASSED OUT.
INJURED THEMSELVES AND WHEN THE
EMERGENCY FOLKS CAME THE DMV
STAFF SAID TO THEM --
IF YOU GET OUT OF LINE YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO START ALL OVER
AGAIN.
SO SHE WAS TREATED FOR HER
WOUNDS BY THE EMT IN LINE WITH
EVERYBODY WATCHING.
THIS WAS DISCUSSED IN THE
HEARINGS THAT CAME FORWARD
EARLIER THIS YEAR THAT THAT WE
HAD.
WE ALSO HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES DIRECTOR SAY
THANK YOU FOR GIVING US EXTRA
MONEY.
WE SPENT ON SOMETHING OTHER THEN
WHAT WE ASK FOR AND OTHER THAN
WHAT YOU TOLD US TO DO.
WE SPECIFICALLY TOLD THEM. TO
SPEND IT ON ADDITIONAL HOURS TO
GET AHEAD OF THIS PROBLEM AND
SERVE OUR CONSTITUENTS WELL.
AND INSTEAD THEY OPEN UP
SATURDAY HOURS JUST A LITTLE BIT
THEY'RE LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT I
THINK WE HAVE A BETTER USE FOR
THIS BECAUSE WE KNOW BEST OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES.
AND SO THEY COMPLETELY CLOSE THE
EXTRA HOURS AND SPEND IT ON
OVERTIME.
AND THIS IS THE SAME YEAR IN
WHICH THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES HAD SUCH CRUMMY SERVICE
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS BUT THEY
DID PROTECT THE EMPLOYEE WHO
SLEPT FOR FOUR YEARS ON THE JOB.
AND THEY COULD NOT POSSIBLY COME
UP WITH A WAY TO FIX THAT
PROBLEM.
SO THE SOLUTION WE HAVE IS NOT
TO WORK TOGETHER.
IT'S NOT TO HAVE THE AUDIT COME
FORWARD.
IT'S NOT TO GET RID OF THAT OPS
WITH ITS NOT TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
AT THE DMV IT'S THIS IT'S TO
THROW MONEY AT IT.
UNLIMITED AMOUNT OF MONEY LET'S
JUST THROW MONEY AT IT.
LET'S NOT EVEN TRY TO FIX IT.
THERE'S ZERO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THIS MONEY THEY DON'T HAVE TO
COME BACK TO US TO KEEP SPENDING
THE MONEY THEY HAVE TO GO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND THEY HAVE NO STRINGS
ATTACHED.
THERE'S NO WORSE WAY TO DEAL
WITH THE DMV THAN TO DO THIS SO
WHERE PARTICULARLY MY COLLEAGUES
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE
WE ALL WORK VERY WELL TOGETHER
BUT WHERE IS YOUR OUTRAGE TODAY.
WHEN YOU HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
DO WITH A SODA TAX WE HAVE THE
PRIVACY BILL ALL THE OUTREACH
WE'VE HEARD ON THIS FLOOR THIS
YEAR NOT A SINGLE MIKE UP TO
EXPRESS OUTRAGE?
THAT THIS IS BEING PUT IN THE
SAME BILL.
AS RAPE KITS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FUNDING.
SO I AM VOTING YES BUT I AM
EXPECTING ALL OF US TO FIX THIS
BETTER.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY AMENDMENTS
OFFERED TO THIS BY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM.
MENIFEE [inaudible]
LAKE ELSINORE.
THOSE WERE THOSE WERE SHOVED
UNDER THE TABLE.
WHERE'S YOUR OUTRAGE ABOUT THAT.
HE WOULD EVEN LET THOSE
AMENDMENTS COME UP SO THAT THIS
COULD BE A BETTER BILL.
SO GO BACK TO YOUR DISTRICTS AND
EXPLAIN I WAS AWFULLY OUTRAGED
ABOUT A BILL THATI WAS FORCED
TO VOTE FOR BECAUSE I MIGHT LOSE
MY CHAIRMANSHIP TO COMMITTEE.
I MIGHT LOSE THIS BENEFIT OF
THIS GREAT OFFICE BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO FIXING THE DMV I WILL
DO NOTHING BUT THROW MONEY AT IT
WITH NO ACCOUNTABILITY.
VOTE THE WAY YOU WANT TO VOTE
BUT FIX THE DMV AND DO IT RIGHT.
ALL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE HAVING
CEASED.
RETAIN YOU MAY CLOSE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT ARE.
COMMENTS MY COLLEAGUE FROM
DUBLIN.
I ABSOLUTELY SURE HER AVERAGE.
IN FACT I SPENT TWO OH TWO HOURS
LAST WEEK A DMB HEADQUARTERS.
TO AT THE COMMAND CENTER.
I ALSO HAVE VISITED.
MY IDEA OF THE CENTERS IN DALY
CITY.
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO JUST WEEKS
BEFORE THAT RIGHT AFTER OUR
BUDGET HERE.
THE DB IS NOT GOING TO GET
FIXED.
BY WAVING A MAGIC WAND THE DMV
IS GONNA GET FIXED BY AGREED.
ALL OF US WORKING TOGETHER THE
MAKING SURE THAT THE MANAGEMENT
IS HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
SO THIS PARTICULAR BILL IS VERY
INTERESTING BECAUSE THERE IS NO.
THERE IS NO APPROPRIATIONS THE
DMV CAME FORWARD TO THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR PROPRIOCEPTIVE WHICH WE
REJECTED.
WE SAID THE AND WE HAVEN'T GOT
THE ANSWERS THAT ARE ACCEPTABLE.
WE DON'T AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR SO WE REJECTED THE
FUNDING.
WE REJECTED THE FUNDING AND
SAID.
WHEN YOU GET YOUR ACT TOGETHER?
WHEN YOU FIGURED OUT WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO WITH THIS MONEY WHEN
YOU WANNA FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
GOING TO FIX THE PROBLEM WE'RE
HERE TO WORK WITH YOU?
THEN AGAIN MY OFFICE IS OPEN AYE
AYE WELCOME AND I KNOW A NUMBER
OF MY COLLEAGUES ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
SHARE INTERESTED IN JOINING ME
IN THAT EFFORT TO WORK WITH THIS
DEPARTMENT TO FIX STOP PROBLEM.
IN THAT IT'S NOT THAT IT IS NOT
GOOD JUST HAPPEN OVERNIGHT IN
THE LAST.
IN THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO IT'S
GOING TO TAKE AWHILE THIS PROB
TOOK AWHILE TO GET TO US SKEPTIC
ABOUT A FIX.
IT'S GONNA REQUIRE ALL OF US TO
ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES.
AND GET TO WORK [inaudible]
NOW.
WHAT THEY CAN DO AND WHAT WE DID
LEAVE OPEN IN THIS?
IN THIS BUDGET BILL IS WHILE
WE'RE IN RECESS BECAUSE WE
CANNOT APPROVE A BUDGET BILL
WALL WE ARE OUT UNLESS WE WANT
TO CALL COME BACK.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WON'T COME
BACK IN THERE IN THE RECESSED TO
APPROVE A BUDGET BILL
[inaudible]
THERE'S ONE ME MR FONG
SO.
INSTEAD WE'RE ALLOWING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO COME
BACK TO THE LEGISLATIVE BODY
THAT CAN ACT ON IT WHICH IS THE
JOINT.
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
WHICH KEN APPROVED [inaudible]
AN APPROPRIATION [inaudible] TO
IT'S THIS PROBLEM BUT ONLY IF
THEY SATISFY.
OR QUESTIONS [inaudible]
NOW [inaudible]
AGAIN.
WHEN THEY CAME FORWARD AND WOULD
WE HAVE THE BUDGET COMMITTEE?
YOU'RE RIGHT MY QUESTIONS WERE
ANSWERED SATISFACTORY I DON'T
THINK UP MOST OF OUR QUESTIONS
WERE ANSWERED SOUNDS MUCH I
THINK WE HAD.
A FAIRLY UNANIMOUS OPINION ABOUT
THE UNTIL WE GET THOSE QUESTIONS
ANSWERED TO OUR SATISFACTION.
THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE FURTHER
APPROPRIATIONS.
NOW HAVING SAID THAT WE STILL
HAVE AT THIS POINT.
OURS LONG ONES EVERYTHING ONE OF
OUR MOST OF OUR GNP IS NOT EVERY
SINGLE.
ONE THAT NEED TO GO FIX WERE
BROUGHT TO READY GO HOME AND WE
GOT DEBTS FOR THE AND YOU CAN
DAMN WELL BE SURE.
THAT YOU KNOW I'LL BE MEETING
WITH CONSTITUENTS ALL BE
PROBABLY OUT HOW MY DMV NEXT
WEEK.
THIRD TAKE A LOOK AT THIS
PROPHECY WILL KIND OF PROGRESS
THEY'VE MADE BECAUSE YOU'RE
RIGHT WITH THE DIRECTOR
TESTIFIED.
MUCH OF WHAT SHE SAID WAS IT IN
FACT ACTUALLY BEING ROLLED OUT
THAT'S PROTECT ALL OF US.
GATHER TO WORK ON THAT.
AGAIN WE CAN POINT FINGERS WE
CAN SHARE OUTRAGE AT THE END OF
THE DAY IT'S GONNA REQUIRE US.
TO WORK HARD OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE MONTHS TO FIX THE
PROBLEM.
FOR EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
OUR CONSTITUENTS.
AND WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR
OUTRIGHT.
THANK YOU MUCH TANK THERE
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TALLEY THE I FIFTY FIVE KNOWS.
SEVENTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE TAKING UP A
SERIES OF BUDGET BILLS.
WE ARE GOING TO BE JUMPING
AROUND IN THE FILE SO THE NEXT
ITEM IS FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY ONE WHICH IS S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE CLERK CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC RESOURCES MAKING
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATES
THE BUDGET [inaudible]
MR TANK.
BUT SPEAKER THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL CHANGES TO THE
RESOURCES SEGMENT OF THE BUDGET.
EXTENDS A DATE FOR PETITION TO
ESTABLISH THE LOWER LOS ANGELES.
RIVER RECREATION AND PARKS
DISTRICT.
CLARIFY THE DEFINITIONS FOR AN
EXISTING WATER FACILITY AND
RECYCLING RECLAIMER THAT ALLOWS
FOR CERTAIN ADVANCE PAYMENTS FOR
DELTA LEVY SUBVENTION CONTRACT.
BUT WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FRONT.
THANK INVESTING SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CORPORAL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
FOR IT IS OUR TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
BUT IS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TELL A VOTE AYE
[inaudible]
SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
FIVE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS NEXT WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
A FILE ITEM.
TO FORTY TWO THIS IS S. B. EIGHT
SEVEN SIX RECOVERY.
SEVERAL EIGHT SEVEN SIX BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE HUMAN
SERVICES MAKING APPROPRIATIONS
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BUT REALLY TO THE
BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TING.
THE HE WAS SPEAKER THIS BILL --
MAKE SMALL TECHNICAL CHANGES
RELATED TO HUMAN SERVICES
CORRECT REFERENCE TO THE
TRAINING REQUIRED FOR CAL WORKS
HOME VISITS.
VISITING PROGRAM PROVIDERS
CLARIFIES THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS APPLY TO IHS
PROVIDERS INCORRECT CODE
REFERENCES RELATED TO HOME BASE
TO FAMILY CARROTS --
WITHOUT I RESPECT THAT'S RIGHT.
MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER
RAISE IT --
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX THIS BILL WILL HELP
SAFEGUARD THE SAFETY OF NATIVE
AMERICAN YOUTH IS WORTHY OF
SUPPORT AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
FAMOUS OBERNOLTE WITHOUT.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M.
WE DECIDED THAT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER THIS AREA THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESERT ABOUT [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE AROUND TOWN ABOUT AYE
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
TO FORTY S. B.. EIGHT SIX NINE
CORKERY.
SO A PLATE SIXTY NINE TO THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET THAT'S WHERE
YOU ACTUALLY COLLECTIONS BIG
CORPORATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
THAT TO ME LEGALLY TO THE
BUDGET.
MR TANK I THINK RICH SPEAKER THE
BILL APPROPRIATES ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OF ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDS PROVIDED TO SECURE.
AND IMPROVE COUNTY ELECTION
SERVICES.
IT ALSO REENACTS PROVISIONS
WHICH WE ALREADY PASSED IN THE
JUNE BUDGET PACKAGE REGARDING
THE CALCULATION OF ELECTORS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
I WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT [inaudible]
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT SIXTY NINE COLLEAGUES THIS
IS A BLATANT ATTEMPTS BY THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH TO INTERFERE
WITH THE JUDICIAL BRANCH.
ARE IN A LOCAL ELECTION.
THIS BILL WOULD RETROACTIVELY
CHANGE THE VOTER SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENTS TO QUALIFY A VOTER
INITIATIVE FOR THE BALLOT IN THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
IT IS A BLATANTLY PARTISAN
ACTION WHICH MAKES IT WORSE IF
YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME WORK IN THE
RECITALS OF THIS BILL RIGHT AT
THE TOP THE COURT CASE THAT
THEY'RE ATTEMPTING TO INFLUENCE.
THE PLAINTIFF IN THAT CASE IS
TONY COULD WORK IS THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS FEAR THE MOST.
WHEN THE PEOPLE IN POWER WANT TO
USE THEIR POWER TO CHANGE?
THE RULES GOVERNING ELECTIONS TO
KEEP THEMSELVES IN POWER.
IT OBVIOUSLY HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE BUDGET THE ONLY REASON
IT'S BEING PROPOSED AS A BUDGET
BILL.
THIS ORDER CAN BE ENACTED
IMMEDIATELY WITHOUT THE TWO
THIRDS VOTE THAT THE STATE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES.
COLLEAGUES I URGE A NO VOTE.
SURE GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET
TRAILER LANGUAGE I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THE RECORD IS ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR.
THAT LAST YEAR THIS LEGISLATURE
PASSED A PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT I WROTE AB NINE OH ONE IT
AUTHORIZE A RUNOFF ELECTIONS IN
THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
AS A RESULT OF THAT LEGISLATION
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF MY NEIGHBORS
AND CONSTITUENTS INCENDIO COUNTY
SIGNED A PETITION TO ACTUALLY
PUT THAT ON THE BALLOT THIS
NOVEMBER.
AYE AND ALLOW THEMSELVES
OPPORTUNITY VOTE TO MAKE THAT SO
TO RATIFY THE ACTION OF THIS
LEGISLATURE --
SADLY THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO --
THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE IN POWER WHO
ARE JEALOUSLY GUARDING THAT
YOU'RE HOLDING ONTO IT WITH
EVERY LAST BIT OF THEIR
FINGERTIPS OF HAVE GONE TO COURT
MULTIPLE TIMES TO OBSTRUCT THE
ACTIONS OF THIS LEGISLATURE.
AND UNDERMINE THE I DIDN'T THE
DEMANDS OF THOSE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SAN DIEGANS WHO ASKED
OF OVER THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
THEY HAVE LOST NOT ONCE BUT
TWICE AND YET THERE LEGAL
SHENANIGANS CONTINUES BECAUSE OF
COURSE THEY DON'T WANT TO GIVE
UP POWER MY COLLEAGUE FROM BIG
BEAR WAS TALKING ABOUT WHETHER
OR NOT WHO WAS HOLDING ON TO
POWER AND WHO WAS DOING WHAT.
WHAT THIS LEGISLATURE DID AND
WHAT THIS BILL MAY DO IS ALLOW
THE PEOPLE OF SAN DIEGO A
STRAIGHT UP OR DOWN VOTE ON THE
FUTURE OF THEIR ELECTIONS?
NOW MEMBERS THIS IS PRETTY
SIMPLE IF YOU BELIEVE IN
DEMOCRACY YOU WANT THE MOST
NUMBER OF PEOPLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THEIR ELECTIONS AS IT'S BEEN
DONE IN THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO FOR
FAR TOO LONG.
A VERY SMALL MINORITY OF FOLKS
GET TO SELECT THE VERY FEW
PEOPLE WHO'VE ON ONE OF THE
LARGEST GOVERNMENTS IN THIS
STATE.
WE HAVE ACTED.
THE COUNTY CONTINUES TO RESIST
THIS WILL SET THIS AND TO BAD.
AND ALLOW THE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ASKED FOR A VOTE TO
GET A VOTE ON THAT.
PLEASE I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION LET'S QUIT
HAVING THIS CONTINUAL FIGHTS IN
SAN DIEGO A WHERE THE COUNTY WHO
WANTS TO WHO JEALOUSLY GUARD
THIS WITH THIS POWER CONTINUES
TO DO SO AT ALL COSTS.
EN IN.
IGNORING THE WILL OF THE VOTERS
IN THE PETITION SIGNERS AND THE
COURTS LET'S TAKE A VOTE TODAY
LET'S PASS THIS LEGISLATION ASK
YOUR AYE THOSE.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS.
TWENTY FOUR THAT MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM. THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
SENATE BILL [inaudible]
EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN THE
CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY IN
THE STATE GOVERNMENT MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATLY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
THIS RETAIN IMAGEN OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
FORCE BUT LANGUAGE IT OPTED IN
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN BUDGET
PACKAGE.
ALLOWING FOR EMERGENCY PUBLIC
WORKS CONTRACTS AND CREATING A
STOP ORDER POLICY.
IT ALSO EXEMPTS CONTRACTS FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
COMPLETE COUNT EVER FROM PUBLIC
CONTRACTING COAT EXTEND THE
REPAYMENT DATE FOR LOANS MADE TO
LOCAL MASS TRANSIT PROVIDERS FOR
THE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION FUND.
AND PROVIDES A CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR THE HOUSING
FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SEVENTY SEVEN THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL ARE UNCONTROVERSIAL --
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THEY CAN MEMBERS WITH THAT CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON NUMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IS OUT OF VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSER ROLE TOWN THE
VOTE I SEVENTY FOUR NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO THIRTY EIGHT SB.
EIGHT SIX ONE COOPERATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY ONE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACT LIKE THE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT
MAKING A PREPARATION THEIR PORTS
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY ABILITY
TO THE BUDGET [inaudible]
MR TANK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B.
EIGHT SIX ONE ADDRESS AS PART OF
THE RECENT MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT
COURT DECISION.
AND DOES THE FOLLOWING.
CLARIFY THAT THE ALLOCATION OF
FUNDS IN THE TWENTY ELEVEN AND
IN TWENTY ELEVEN THROUGH.
TWENTY THIRTEEN WERE CONSISTENT
WITH THE DIRECTION GIVEN BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
IT ALSO STATES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT PROM WAS AWARE
OF THIS ALLOCATION OF FUNDS
DURING THE BUDGET PROCESS.
IN THE BILL ADDRESS A CERTAIN
FINDINGS IN THE RECENT COURT
DECISION THAT QUESTION THE
BUDGET PROCESS AND IS INTENDED
TO CLARIFY THAT PEACE PROCESS
ISSUES [inaudible]
A COURT.
THE DECISION IS APPEALED.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT [inaudible]
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT SIXTY ONE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THE LARGEST SETTLEMENT IN
A FINANCIAL CONSUMER PROTECTION
CASE IN US HISTORY OCCURRED WAS
OVER FORTY FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS.
IT WAS RELATED TO THE MORTGAGE
ROBO SIGNING SCANDAL WHICH I'M
SURE EVERYONE REMEMBERS --
AS PART OF THAT SETTLEMENT EACH
STATE WAS GIVEN A PIECE OF THE
SETTLEMENT TO DISTRIBUTE AND I'D
LIKE TO READ YOU FROM THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT WITH THE
DEFENDANT'S MISTER SPEAKER WITH
YOUR PERMISSION.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT SAYS
THAT FUNDS.
THE SETTLEMENT IS --
TO FIND OF THE FOR THE PURPOSES
INTENDED TO AVOID PREVENTABLE
FORECLOSURES TO IMMIGRATE THE
EFFECTS OF THE FORECLOSURE
CRISIS. TO ENHANCE LAW
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO PREVENT
AND PROSECUTE FINANCIAL FRAUD
WERE UNFAIR DECEPTIVE ACTS INTO
COMPENSATE THE STATES FOR THE
COSTS RESULTING FROM THE ALLEGED
UNLAWFUL CONTACT OF THE
DEFENDANTS.
SO THAT IS WHAT THE STATE WAS
GIVEN THE MONEY. TO DO WITH
[inaudible]
I INSTEAD THE STATE PUT ALL OF
THAT MONEY IN ITS GENERAL FUND.
TO SHORE UP THE DEFICIT THAT
OCCURRED IN THAT YEAR.
AND INEVITABLY A LAWSUIT
RESULTED AND JUST LAST MONTH A
CALIFORNIA APPELLATE COURT RULED
THAT THE STATE HAD ERRED IN
ALLOCATING THAT MONEY --
THEY RULED THAT OF THE FOURTEEN
TEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT THE
STATE HAVE BEEN GIVEN THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
OF THAT MONEY SHOULD HAVE GONE
TO THE VICTIMS.
OF THIS FORECLOSURE CRISIS.
SO THE STATE IS ATTEMPTING TO
REROUTE RIGHT THE RULES HERE AND
I THINK IT'S DEPLORABLE THAT IN
VOTING FOR THIS WE WOULD BE
TAKING THE MONEY OUT OF THE
HANDS OF THE PEOPLE FOR WHOM IT
WAS INTENDED.
THE VICTIMS.
ARE OF THIS FRAUDULENT ACTIVITY.
NOT ONE TO READ FOR YOU FROM
THIS BILL THE BILL THAT WERE
VOTED ON TODAY THE BILL SAYS.
THE LEGISLATURE FURTHER CONFIRMS
AND RATIFIES THAT BECAUSE THOSE
ALLOCATIONS WERE DISPLAYED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE THIRTEEN AND
LEFT UNCHANGED.
THE LEGISLATURE WAS AWARE OF AND
APPROVED THE ALLOCATION AND
EXPENDITURE OF FUNDS.
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE VOTING ON SO
IF YOU VOTE YES YOUR APPROVING.
THE ALLOCATION OF THOSE FUNDS A
FACTOR SAYING THAT WE WERE AWARE
OF THAT AND I DON'T SEE HOW
ANYONE COULD SAY THAT THEY ARE
AWARE OF IT IF YOU WERE ACTUALLY
HERE IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WHICH I WAS
NOT.
SO COLLEAGUES ARMORED URGE YOU
TO REJECT THIS WHAT'S SPEND THAT
MONEY WE GOT THE MONEY IN THE
GENERAL FUND WE ARE NINE BILLION
DOLLAR BUDGET SURPLUS THIS YEAR.
WHAT'S PUT THAT THREE HUNDRED
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS WHERE
THE COURT SAYING IT OUGHT TO BE
IN THE HANDS OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE AFFECTED BY THIS CRISIS.
AND NOT SHORING UP THE STATE'S
DEFICIT AYE ORIGINAL VOTE.
FAMOUS OBERNOLTE MR ACOSTA.
I THINK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
ALSO RISE IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY ONE AND WITH
PERMISSION I'D LIKE TO SHARE A
BRIEF STORY ABOUT TO ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AND THEIR THEIR
SITUATION --
WITH MY COLLEAGUES HERE THIS THE
STORY OF THAT.
THIS IS A STORY OUT ABOUT --
MAN LOSING HIS HOUSE AND TWENTY
TEND TO AN ABUSIVE FORECLOSURE
ORLANDO R. GONI.
IS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER IN MY
DISTRICT SELLING MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT.
WHEN IS BUSINESS STOP RECEIVING
MEDICARE MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HE HAD TO PULL UP PUT
ALL?
PUT ALL THIS MONEY INTO HIS
BUSINESS AND STRUGGLE TO MAKE
MORTGAGE PAYMENTS.
IS HE TRIED TO WORK WITH THIS
BANK SEEKING REFINANCING A
LOOKING FOR OF THE SOLUTIONS BUT
THE BANK REFUSED TO HELP A
MENACE FAMILY.
IN TWENTY TEN THE BANK
FORECLOSED ON HIS FAMILY'S HOUSE
AND HE WAS FORCED TO MOVE HIS
THREE CHILDREN.
OUT WHILE STILL TRYING TO KEEP
HIS BUSINESS AFLOAT HE NEVER
QUITE RECOVERED AND NOW
FORTUNATELY HIS --
HIS SON IS ABLE TO HELP WITH
THIS BUSINESS NOW BUT HE STILL
HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO PURCHASE
ANOTHER HOME.
AND THIS IS JUST ONE EXAMPLE OF
MANY COMING OUT OF MY DISTRICT
NOT TO MENTION THE OTHER SEVENTY
NINE ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS
REPRESENTED HERE.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY THE
CENTER FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING
IN TWENTY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES PER DAY ON AVERAGE LOST
THEIR HOMES BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT AND TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN MORE THAN A
QUARTER MILLION CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES OUT WERE SERVED WITH A
NOTICES OF DEFAULT.
AND IN TWENTY ELEVEN CBS
REPORTED THAT FIVE OF THE TEN
WORST CITIES FOR FORECLOSURE IN
TWENTY TEN WERE IN CALIFORNIA.
DENYING HELP TO VICTIMS OF ABUSE
OF FORECLOSURE FORECLOSURES IS
UNJUST AND UNFAIR AND COLLEAGUES
IT'S UNCONSCIONABLE THAT WE
WOULD CONTINUE TO IGNORE WHAT
THE COURTS ARE TELLING US TO DO
AND REFUSE TO GIVE THE MONEY
BACK TO OUR CONSTITUENTS.
WHO ARE IN NEED OF HELP YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THAT THE
BUDGET SURPLUS WE'VE ALL BEEN
BRAGGING ABOUT HOW GREAT THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY IS DOING AND
YET?
WE ARE LOOKING AT FRANKLY MY
VIEW ABSCONDING WITH THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT SHE GO TO MORTGAGE
--
A DEFAULT RELIEF THAT GOES TO
PEOPLE THAT SHOULD HAVE IT THEY
SHOULD HAVE HAD IT BACK THEN WE
STILL CAN RIGHT THIS WRONG AYE
COURAGE A STRONG NO VOTE.
ON THIS ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ALL DISCUSSION HAVING CEASE.
MR TANG YOU A CLOSE WE WISH I
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES FROM VALENCIA
BIG BEAR --
THIS FORECLOSURE CRISIS WITH
SOMETHING THAT WAS VERY PERSONAL
TO ME I SPEND.
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME IN
MY PREVIOUS JOB AS THE ASSESSOR
RECORDER IN SAN FRANCISCO
LOOKING AT THE FORECLOSURE
CRISIS -- AS
YOU KNOW THE COUNTY RECORDER'S
WHERE I'VE ALL THE LENDERS COME
TO FILE ALL THE NOTICE OF
DEFAULT ON WAS THE FIRST
REPORTER IN THE COUNTRY. TO
ISSUE AN AUDIT REQUEST OF ALL
THOSE DOCUMENTS WE FOUND OUT
THAT THERE WAS.
ARE ACTUALLY FRAUDULENT BEHAVIOR
OUR BEHAVIOR THAT WAS ARE
DISCOVERED BY MUCH OF WHAT WAS
UNCOVERED IN THIS PARTICULAR
COURT CASE.
I AND WALDRON THE ACTIONS OF
THOSE LENDERS WERE ACTUALLY AN
EXCUSABLE THE DEPREDATIONS OF
DEVASTATION THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
WAS A HAS BEEN AND CONTINUES TO
BE FELT FOR YEARS A THAT IS NOT
WITH THIS PARTICULAR BUDET
THIS BUDGET BILL IS REALLY
DEALING WITH STATE
CONSTITUTIONAL AUTHORITY.
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
LEGISLATURE'S ABILITY TO
APPROPRIATE.
AND WHILE WE WORK HERE AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME THE YEARS OF
201-220-1120 TWELVE ALL THE WAY
THROUGH --
TWENTY FOURTEEN THOSE --
BUDGET YEARS.
AT TIMES WERE [inaudible]
CHALLENGING.
AND THAT NOW THOSE LEGISLATORS
IF YOU TALK TO THEM HOW TO MAKE
A VERY --
CHALLENGING DECISIONS THE
DECISIONS THAT THEY ARE FRANKLY
WOULD NOT WISH ON ANY OF US.
WOULD NOT WISH TO RELIVE --
BUT THEY AREN'T DECISION IS
REALLY THE ULTIMATE AUTHORITY OF
THIS LEGISLATURE TO APPROPRIATE.
THE FUNDING FOR OUR GENERAL FUND
AND FOR THIS BUDGET.
AUNT DOT IS WHAT THIS BUDGET
BILL CLARIFIES THIS BUDGET TO
CLARIFY THAT THE LEGISLATURE'S
AUTHORITY.
IS ENSHRINED IN THE CONSTITUTION
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
TAKE AN OATH EVERY TWO YEARS TO
DEFEND.
AND IT IS JUST CLARIFYING THAT
PARTICULAR ACTION THAT THAT
LEGISLATURE DURING THOSE
APPROPRIATE YEARS.
APPROPRIATED THE MONEY FULLY
KNOWING THAT THIS ACTION WAS TO
BE TAKEN AND WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY OUTRIGHT.
AND WITH THAT THE CLERK GLOBAL
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTED THIS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER TO SARAJEVO
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLAND SALLEY VOTE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS.
TWENTY THREE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT MEMBERS WE ARE TAKING A
FILE ITEM.
TO THIRTY NINE S. B. EIGHT SIX
SEVEN THE CORPORATE RATE.
SEVERAL EIGHT SIXTY SEVEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TO THE
LEGEND LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
BUREAU MAKING A PREPARATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TECH.
THANK YOU ALL THIS --
PARTICULAR BUDGET BILL STEMS
FROM OUR LEGISLATIVE WORKING
GROUP WHICH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GLENDALE --
CHAIRED.
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE HER IN
THE ARE WORKING COMMITTED ALSO
MY OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM ST YOUR
COUNTY --
CHAIR AND THIS THIS WORK ON THIS
BUDGET BILL ESTABLISHES A UNIT
IN THE LEGISLATIVE.
OUR COUNCIL BUREAU TO PROVIDE IN
A VISE AND INVESTIGATE SERVICES
TO LEGISLATURE BLIGHTED TO
WORKPLACE MISCONDUCT.
REQUIRES THE UNIT TO ACCEPTED
INVESTIGATE REPORTS IN
COMPLAINTS AUTHORIZED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
REQUIRES LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL TO
RETAIN MY CONTRACTOR PANEL OF
OUTSIDE EXPERTS TO REVIEW
INVESTIGATIONS AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS TO LEGISLATURE.
INAPPROPRIATE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS UNIT.
WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US RIGHT.
MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SIXTY SEVEN ALTHOUGH I THINK
IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
THAT WE HAVE TO SPEND OVER
MILLION DOLLARS OF TAXPAYER
MONEY TAKING THIS ACTION THE
DISCLOSURES THAT HAVE OCCURRED
THE LAST YEAR MAKE IT CLEARLY --
OBVIOUS THAT THIS ACTION IS
NECESSARY AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE AND
MISTER COOLEY.
YES IS A VERY IMPORTANT BUDGET
BUDGET MEASURE TAKING A BY CAMEL
APPROACH TO THESE ISSUES.
IT IS GROUNDBREAKING BOTH FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LEGISLATURE.
AND REALLY LOVE SAY BODIES
NATIONALLY.
SO WE WE MADE POLICY DECISIONS
BASED ON THE WORK OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE.
THE JOINT RULES COOLEY THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY AND THIS IS NOW
EXECUTION OF THAT.
POLICY WORK VERY VERY IMPORTANT
VERY GROUNDBREAKING.
MS FRIEDMAN YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK
YOU SINCE THIS IS PROBABLY THE
ONLY OPPORTUNITY I'M GOING TO
HAVE TO DO THIS I WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
A PARTICULARLY SPEAKER RENDON
AND PRO TEM ATKINS FOR THEIR
AMAZING SUPPORT AS WE WORKED
TOGETHER IN A BICAMERAL MATTER.
TO CRAFT REALLY GROUND FOR
SETTING POLICIES TO PREVENT
SEXUAL HARASSMENT FROM HAPPENING
IN THIS BUILDING.
AND WHAT WE'VE DONE IN TERMS OF
SETTING UP AN INDEPENDENT UNIT
WHICH OF COURSE THIS BILL WILL
NOW FINANCE.
IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT'S
BEEN DONE IN STATE HOUSES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY AND FOR LEADERSHIP
TO HAVE.
TAKEN THE STEP. TO GIVE UP THEIR
OWN POWER. TO ALLOW THIRD PARTY
TO COME IN AND A COMMITTEE TO
COME IN. TO ADJUDICATE AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS IN TERMS OF
RESPONSE AWAY FROM THE SENSE OF
BIAS AND POLITICAL INFLUENCE
THAT OFTEN PERMEATES THESE KINDS
OF DECISIONS.
IS REALLY REMARKABLE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE PROCESS OF
MANY HEARINGS AND MANY MANY
MONTHS.
WE RECEIVED NOTHING BUT SUPPORT
FROM THE MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE.
I TAKE THIS WHERE THE COMMITTEE.
ON THE SENATE SIDE AND THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE FELT THAT IT
SHOULD GO.
SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE THAT
WAS INVOLVED I'M VERY PROUD TO
BE ABLE TO CAST A AYE VOTE FOR
THIS MEASURE TODAY.
THIS IS SHOWING A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF OF RESOURCES TOWARDS
THIS EFFORT IT SHOULD REALLY
SHOWS THE SERIOUSNESS BY WHICH
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE TAKES
THESE ISSUES.
WITHOUT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK GOODNESS FRIEDMAN SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE AND TELL A VOTE I
SEVENTY KNOWS.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP
MEMBERS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE S. B.. EIGHT
SEVEN THREE COOPERATE.
SAMPLE EIGHT SEVENTY THREE BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MAKE
THEIR PREPARATION THEREFORE TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER CHAIR.
I THINK IT SPEAKER S. B. EIGHT
SEVEN THREE PROVIDES OF
LEGISLATIVE RATIFICATION FOR TWO
BARGAINING UNITS BARGAINING UNIT
NINE WHICH IS THE ENGINEERS
UNIT.
IN BARGAINING UNIT TEN WHICH IS
THE SCIENTIST UNIT.
INCLUDES A SOUTH SALARY INCREASE
FOR THE ENGINEERS UNIT OF FOUR
POINT 5% EFFECTIVE JULY FIRST
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND ANOTHER 4%
INCREASE.
EFFECTIVE JULY WIND. TWENTY
NINETEEN FOR THE SCIENTIST
PARKING UNIT AND WHAT YOU
INCLUDES A 5% INCREASE.
OFFER BOTH TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY THE SALARY
INCREASES ARE COMMENSURATE WITH
WHAT IS --
BELIEVED TO BE --
SALARY INCREASES IN STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE UNITS ARE REMAIN
COMPETITIVE.
THAT ALSO MAKES CONTRACT VALID
FOR ONLY A TWO YEAR PERIOD WHICH
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN ELLIOTT
RECOMMENDATION.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FEDERAL.
SURE OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER I
AM CERTAINLY PROPONENT OF FAIRLY
COMPENSATING OUR STATE EMPLOYEES
AND I ACTUALLY USUALLY VOTE IN
SUPPORT.
OF THESE MEMORANDUMS OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH OUR
BARGAINING UNITS BUT I HAVE TO
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF THESE
PARTICULAR MEMO USE.
I'M CONCERNED WITH THE OVERALL
LEVEL OF COMPENSATION INCREASE
AS THE CHAIR SAID THESE
INCREASED COMPENSATION BETWEEN
FOUR AND 5% FOR THESE BARGAINING
UNITS IT'S CLOSER 25% THE
AVERAGE.
AND THIS IS IN AN ERA WHEN
INFLATION IN THE STATE ACCORDING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
BEEN RUNNING LESS THAN 3%.
AND IN ADDITION TO THOSE ARE
COMPENSATION INCREASES THEIR
INCREASES TO THINGS LOCKED.
BONUSES BONUSES FOR EDUCATION IN
UNIFORM ALLOWANCES TAKEN
TOGETHER SO IT'S GONNA BE A VERY
COSTLY PACKAGE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M CONCERNED
THAT IF WE GRANT THESE LEVEL OF
COMPENSATION INCREASES TO ALL OF
OUR BARGAINING UNITS.
IT'S JUST NOT SUSTAINABLE IN THE
LONG TERM I ALSO HAVE A CONCERN
ABOUT SPECIFICALLY THE MO YOU
FOR BARGAINING UNIT.
NINE THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
YESTERDAY ISSUED A REPORT AN
ANALYSIS OF THIS AMMO YOU AND IN
THAT REPORT THEY POINTED OUT
THAT THIS AMMO YOU WILL CAUSE
SUBSTANTIAL PROBLEMS FOR
CALTRANS IF PROPOSITIONS SIX IS
PASSED BY THE VOTERS IN
NOVEMBER.
FOR THOSE REASONS I URGE A NO
VOTE.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
THANK YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH I
CAN RUN VERY ROUGH RESPECTFULLY
I'M.
MINOR DISCREET WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIG BEAR --
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS DOES.
FAIRLY COMPENSATE THESE
INDIVIDUALS I KNOW FOR A FACT IN
SAN FRANCISCO WERE I'VE
EXPERIENCED THE CITY COUNTY MOST
OF THE BAY AREA COUNTY
GOVERNMENTS ACTUALLY PAY.
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN OUR
STATE SALARIES SO THE BAY AREA
PARTICULAR WE HAVE VERY AYE
DIFFICULT TIME.
UPROOTING RETAINING --
HIGHLY COMPETENT SCIENTISTS AND
ENGINEERS ARE BELIEVE THIS IS A
FAIR OUR CONTRACT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR APPROVAL.
I WISH TING WITH THAT CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THIS OUR A LITTLE MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESERT ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TO I THE VOTE EYES
FIFTY FOUR KNOWS.
EIGHTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP MEMBERS WERE MOVING.
BACK IN THE FILE TO FILE ITEM TO
FORTY THREE FILE ITEM TO FORTY
THREE IS S. B. [inaudible] EIGHT
SEVEN EIGHT CORPORATE.
SAMPLE EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT BY
THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
TAXATION MAKING APPROPRIATION
THERE FOR TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET [inaudible]
MISTER TECH.
I THINK IT WOULD SPEAKER S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN A MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE FILM TAX CREDIT
LANGUAGE ADOPTED IN THE BUDGET
PACKAGE.
CLARIFY THE DEFINITION OF ON USE
CREDITS IN THE PROCESS FOR
ALLOCATING THEM.
CHANGES THE DEADLINE FOR ELLIOTT
EACH WHICH REPORT ON THE FILM
TAX CREDIT TO JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND ALLOWS
FOR THE ALLOCATION OF ANY
UNCERTIFIED CREDITS BY THE FILL
COMMISSION. TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
BUT THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT THE
LEGISLATURE RECENTLY MADE MAJOR
CHANGES TO THE MOTION PICTURE
AND TELEVISION PRODUCTION TAX
CREDIT IT MAKES SENSE TO DELAY
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
REPORTING.
FROM THAT TECH CREDIT UNTIL WE
CAN SEE HOW THAT TAX CREDIT IS
WORKING AND I GET BETTER
INFORMATION ON HOW IT MIGHT NEED
TO BE ADJUSTED IN THE FUTURE AYE
URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE SEEN
NO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO IS ARE A LITTLE MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS THERE TO
VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY VOTE [inaudible]
I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
NEXT UP MEMBERS HAS FALLEN.
TO FORTY FOUR S. B..
EIGHT SEVENTY NINE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AND ACTUALLY THE
PUBLIC SAFETY MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BUT RELATED
TO THE BUDGET.
MISTER TECH.
I THINK BUT SPEAKER A. S. B.
EIGHT SEVEN NINE MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO REFLECT ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS INCLUDED THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET.
CLARIFIES THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
RESPONSE CERTIFICATE PROCESS FOR
PAROLEES IN THE CALIFORNIA
TRAINING PROGRAM.
RESTATES EXISTING LAW RELATED TO
THE DISCLOSURE OF PAPERS
OBTAINED BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR.
AND RE APPROPRIATES FIVE POINT
TWO MILLION OF THE TWENTY
FIFTEEN TWENTY SIXTEEN POST
FUNDING.
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIGHT.
MISTER OBERNOLTE MISTER SPEAKER
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE THE RE
APPROPRIATIONS OF THOSE FUNDS
WHICH ARE LEFT OVER FROM THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN BUDGET ACT.
WILL HELP US TRAIN MORE LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL THAT'S
VERY SUPPORTABLE AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS AND VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR TOWN I THAT I SEVENTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
AND FINALLY MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
THREE SEVENTY THREE SB.
EIGHT FORTY SIX A CORPORATION
CYNICAL A PRETTY SIX BY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY TEMPLATE MET
MAKE THE PREPARATION THEREFORE
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET
[inaudible]
MISTER TECH.
I THINK IT WOULD SPEAKER S. B.
EIGHT FOUR SIX MAKES TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND REQUIRES A PART OF
HUMAN RESOURCES. TWO COULD
EVALUATION OF REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES IN THEIR ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR.
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES TO REVIEW POLICIES IN
THE STATE CONTRACTING MANUAL AND
TRAINING ARE PROVIDED TO STAY
PERSONAL RELATED TO REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION.
PURCHASES FOR STATE EMPLOYEES
AND REQUIRES TGS REPORT PURCHASE
INFORMATION ON THE INTERNET.
UP PROVIDES CLEAR PLAGUE WAS
JUNE TRAILER BILL RELATED TO THE
CURRENT COUNTY HOSPITAL IN THE
CURRENT COUNTY EMPLOYEES
RETIREMENT ASSOCIATION.
AND PROVIDES CLEAN UP LANGUAGE
TO THE JUNE TRAILER BILL THAT
ACKNOWLEDGES INDEMNIFY HAS.
PASSED THE LABOR PRACTICES WERE
FEE COLLECTION WAS ALLOWED.
I WITHOUT A RESPECT FOR US
RIGHT.
THEY WERE STAYING.
MISTER OBERNOLTE ERECTOMAX
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT FORTY SIX
EARLIER THIS YEAR THE SUPPORT
SUPREME COURT RULED IN JANICE
VERSES ASKED ME THAT PUBLIC
SECTOR EMPLOYEES.
CANNOT BE PAID ARE COMPELLED TO
PAY UNION DUES.
HOWEVER THE COURT WAS BUTTE ON
WHETHER OR NOT THAT RULING
APPLIED BEFORE THE RULING WAS
MADE.
SO THE COURTS WILL BE DECIDING
THIS OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS IN FACT LAST MONTH SEVEN
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS FILED A
LAWSUIT SEEKING CLASS ACTION
STATUS IN WHICH THEY SOUGHT READ
DISGORGEMENT OF THE UNION DUES
THAT THEY HAD PAID.
PRIOR TO THE RULING.
THIS BILL IS A BLATANT ATTEMPT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO MEDDLE IN
PRE JUDGING THAT CASE.
IT'S COMPLETELY INAPPROPRIATE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO BE
PREJUDGING AND PUTTING PRESSURE
ON THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM WE SHOULD
LET THE COURT SYSTEM WORK.
I ALSO HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THIS.
A LANGUAGE BEING INCLUDED IN A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
BECAUSE IT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THE BUDGET AND I SUBMIT THE
ONLY REASON WHY WE'RE VOTING ON
IT AS A BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
IS SO THAT IT CAN TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
WITHOUT THE TWO THIRDS VOTE THAT
THE STATE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES
FOR AN URGENCY PROVISION. FOR
THAT REASON FOR THOSE REASONS
ICE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A NO
VOTE.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM ATTAINING
A CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER I S. B. EIGHT FOUR SIX
WE BELIEVE NOT SPECIFICALLY
REFER VISION JUST CLARIFIES --
LEGAL --
BEHAVIOR THAT ALREADY OCCURRED
IT IS FURTHER CODIFIES THAT IN
RECERTIFY THAT WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIGHT.
THEY WISH CHIANG AND WITH THAT
CORP LIBERAL.
ON MEMBERS.
THOSE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALENT ABOUT
EYES FIFTY ONE KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THAT MEASURE PASSES
AND MISTER.
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION.
THEY CAN IS SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT WILL SIXTY TWO WAY THE
FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW
THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO
MEET.
JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN THE
ECONOMY TO HEAR A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY TWO CARILLO ON
THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH AT
NINE AM IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO HEAR
AB FIVE FOURTEEN SALAS ON
THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH AT
NINE AM.
AND ROOM FOR FORTY FOUR
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE
TO HEAR AB NINETEEN FOURTEEN
FLORA AND AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
SIX QUIRK ON THURSDAY AUGUST
THIRTIETH AT NINE AM IN ROOM
FORTY TWO UP.
TO COMMUNICATIONS AND CONVEYANCE
COMMITTED HERE AB NINE THIRTY
NINE LOW ON THURSDAY AUGUST
THIRTIETH AT NINE THIRTY AM IN
ROOM.
FOUR FORTY SEVEN THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO MEET OUT ON FOUR
LADA.
AND A. B. THIRTY TO FORTY EIGHT
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY ON
THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH AT
NINE THIRTY AM IN ROOM ONE
TWENTY SIX AND PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO
HEAR A. B. SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
TING ON FRIDAY AUGUST THIRTY
FIRST.
AT NINE THIRTY AM IN ROOM.
ONE TWENTY SIX WITHOUT
OBJECTION.
THE REQUEST IS GRANTED.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO ALLOW THE
ASSISTANT SPEAKER PRO TEM TO
TAKE UP.
FOR ITEMS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CONCURRENCE ITEMS BY MS
FRIEDMAN.
AND WE WILL FINISH UP WITH THE
SENATE THIRD READING ITEM BUT WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE THIS IS CONCURRENCE. TO
ALLOW MISS FRIEDMAN TO TAKE UP.
A NUMBER OF ITEMS STARTING WITH
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SIX FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SIX IS AB.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY THREE
COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND ACT LIKE A HOUSING.
THIS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS MADE TO AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY THREE IN THE SENATE
OF THE FOLLOWING.
CHAPTER AND AMENDMENTS WITH AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY SEVEN AN SP
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN THE BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES IT PASSED
THE SENATE FLOOR THIRTY NINE TO
ZERO WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE.
THINGS FRIEDMAN SAY NO
DISCUSSION BATES CLARK WELL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON.
PARA VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE THE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT AND MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO MOVE A FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY ONE AB THIRTY NINETY
EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY NINETY
EIGHT BY SELLING MEMBER FREEMEN
AND ACTUALLY THE RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY.
SPEAKER MEMBERS THE TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WELL FIRES
TAUGHT US ALL VALUABLE LESSONS
ABOUT PREPAREDNESS.
POLICY MAKERS IT'S OUR DUTY TO
ENSURE THAT THE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY OUR MOST VULNERABLE
AS FAR AS STRONG AS THEY CAN BE.
AB THIRTY NINETY EIGHT
STRENGTHENS THE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS REQUIREMENTS IN
PLACE FOR ALL RESIDENTIAL CARE
FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING IN
NATURE I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
NAMES FRIEDMAN SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE QUIRK WELL UP THERE ALL.
THE SENATE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE TALLY VOTE
I SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN NEXT STEP IS FILE
ITEM.
SEVENTY FOUR AB [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE SIXTY TWO COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACT LIKE
ALCOHOLISM OR DRUG ABUSE.
MS FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AMENDMENTS MADE
TO A. B. THIRTY ONE SIXTY TWO IN
THE SENATE DID THE FOLLOWING AT
THE REQUEST OF THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE REMOVE THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES POST THE ADDRESS.
OF ANY NEW PROPOSED TREATMENT
FACILITY AT FORTY FIVE DAYS
PRIOR TO APPROVING ANY NEW
APPLICATIONS.
MADE OTHER TECHNICAL CHANGES AT
THE REQUEST OF THE DEPARTMENT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
WORK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO JUMP IN
THE FILE THE FOLLOWING HIM SAID
--
PER ME FILE ITEM. NINETY EIGHT
NINETY EIGHT IS AB. TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN AND ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE
ENROLLMENT.
MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY SIX
CLARIFIES SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
COUNTY RESPONSIBILITIES AND
TIMELINES IN THE INTER DISTRICT
TRANSFER PROCESS AND PROVIDES
GREATER TRANSPARENCY FOR PARENTS
AND STUDENTS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE TECHNICAL AND ADDRESS THE
CHATTERING ISSUE THE BILL IS
RECEIVED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY.
ASK THAT WE CONTINUE THAT TODAY
WITH AN AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THINGS FRIEDMAN SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
WHAT IS THERE TO VOTE ON THE
WRIST VOTERS OUT OF THEM?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE.
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY FIVE KNOW ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
THE FINAL CONCURRENCE ITEM FROM
IS FRIEDMAN IS FILE ITEM
.
ONE SIXTY ONE MISS FRIEDMAN I
HAVE THAT AS A PASS AND RETAIN.
I HAVE THAT AS A PASS RETAIN.
WE CAN JUMP.
TO BACK TO SET UP THEIR READING
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT FILE ITEM.
THREE SIXTY EIGHT WHICH IS SJ
OUR THIRTY IS A THIS IS FILE
ITEM THREE SIXTY EIGHT SJ OUR
THIRTY CORKERY.
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION.
THIRTY BY A SENATOR MCGUIRE
RELATIVE TO THE AMTRAK NATIONAL
NETWORK.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER BAKER I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT AS SHE OUR
THIRTY AS A CO AUTHOR.
AMTRAK WAS CREATED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO ASSUME THE COMMON
CARRIERS OBLIGATIONS A PRIVATE
RAILROADS PROVIDE INTO INTERCITY
PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE
THROUGHOUT THE U. S..
AMTRAK'S OPERATES A NATIONWIDE
RAIL NETWORK SERVING MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED TO FIVE HUNDRED
DESTINATIONS IN FORTY SIX STATES
THE DISORDER DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA AND THREE CANADIAN
PROVINCES.
AND ADDITION TO SERVING AS A
CONTRACTOR IN VARIOUS CAPACITIES
FOR SEVERAL COMMUTER RAIL
AGENCIES.
AMTRAK NATIONAL NETWORK OP THE
TRAINS OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDE.
MANY MANY TRIMS THE CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORT THE COAST STARLIGHT THE
SOUTHWEST CHIEF IN THE SUNSET
LIMITED.
THE STATE INVEST ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR TO SUPPORT
ITS THREE INNER CITY SERVICE
HURTS.
THE CURRENT FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION HAS PROPOSED TO
CUT FUNDING FOR AMTRAK LEAVING
THOUSANDS OF PASSENGERS STRANDED
CUTTING HUNDREDS OF GOOD JOBS
AND IT WILL PUT THOUSANDS OF
VEHICLES INTO OUR ALREADY
CONGESTED HIGHWAYS.
AS CHAIR THIRTY URGES CONGRESS
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
PORT THE RETENTION OF INVESTMENT
IN THE NATIONAL RAILROAD
PASSENGER CORPORATION.
NATIONAL NETWORK AMTRAK.
AMTRAK IS CRITICAL AND I URGE
YOU ALL TO SIGN ON TO THIS
RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS FREEMAN SO YOU
WOULD LIKE CO AUTHORS.
HEY I'M NOT TRAIN COOPER THIS
BILL.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLE MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR COOPER [inaudible]
CO AUTHORS.
ON S. CHAIR.
THIRTY THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE THERE ARE FORTY NINE
CO AUTHORS ADDED.
THIS IS AN SJ ARE WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL VOTE MEMBERS CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO WERE DOWN.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT
ICE WHICH TO NO ZERO THAT
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
[inaudible]
MS FREEDMAN.
BECAUSE OF THE WAIVER YOU CAN
TAKE UP THAT CONCURRENCE ITEM.
WERE GOING TO RETURN A
CONCURRENCE THAT WAS FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY ONE AB.
TWENTY EIGHT OH TO COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY A A TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND I
PLAN TO INSURANCE.
MISTREATMENT THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AMENDMENTS MADE
TO AB TWENTY EIGHT  TWO IN
THE SENATE TO THE FOLLOWING.
CLARIFY THE BILL DOES NOT APPLY
TO CLAIMS FOR BENEFITS UNDER
WORKERS COMPENSATION POLICY
EXCEPT AS OTHERWISE PROVIDED
THEM LAW LIMITS WITHHOLDING FROM
A QUALIFYING DISABILITY
INSURANCE PAYMENT TO AN OBLIGOR
A 50%.
OF THE CLAIM FOR BENEFITS
ASSURES THE GOOD FAITH
REQUIREMENT TO EVERY ACTION THAT
IS SHIELDED FROM LIABILITY
ALLOWS FOR THE DISCLOSURE OF
AGGREGATE DATA THAT IS NOT
REVEAL ANY PERSONALLY
IDENTIFIABLE INFORMATION.
THIS BILL PASSED THE SENATE WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE THIS IS A BILL
ABOUT --
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVEN'T PAID PAST CHILD SUPPORT
CAN HAVE THAT MONEY WITHHELD
FROM INSURANCE SETTLEMENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS FREEMAN SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON DESIRE TO
GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSE ROLES HIVE BUT I SIXTY NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND NOW MEMBERS WERE
GOING TO RETURN TO THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE WHERE WE WERE
PRIOR TO OUR BUDGET.
ITEMS AND MISTER CHIU DAVID CHIU
HAD AN ITEM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
THREE TWENTY S. B. TEN FORTY
FIVE CORPORATE.
SENATE BILL TEN FORTY FIVE BY
SENATOR WIENER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY CONSERVATORSHIP.
MISTER CHAIR.
I CAN MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
I RISE -- I
RISE AT THE REQUEST OF SENATORS
WIENER AND STERN TO PRESENT SP
TEN FORTY FIVE WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A PILOT PROGRAM. TO
ALLOW FOR THE APPOINTMENT OF A
CONSERVATOR FOR PERSON WAS
INCAPABLE OF CARING FOR HIS OR
HER OWN HEALTH AND WELL BEING.
DUE TO A SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS
OR SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER.
CURRENT CONSERVATORSHIP LAW DOES
NOT HAVE BILLY TO CARE FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE
DISORDERS OTHER THAN ALCOHOLISM.
THIS PILOT WILL PROVIDE FOR THE
LEAST RESTRICTIVE AND MOST
CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE PLACEMENT
INCLUDING SUPPORT OF HOUSING
WITH WRAPAROUND SERVICES WHERE
POSSIBLE.
THIS PILOT WOULD CREATE A NARROW
TOOL FOR THE COUNTIES OF SAN
DIEGO LOS ANGELES AND SAN
FRANCISCO. FOUR UP FOR CARE FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THOSE SUFFERING FROM
SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESSES AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS.
MANY AMONG THIS POPULATION ALSO
FACE CHRONIC HOMELESSNESS.
THIS REPRESENTS A TINY SUBSET OF
OUR OVERALL POPULATION IN MY
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE IT'S AN
ESTIMATED THAT --
THE POPULATION WOULD BE 1% OF
OUR OVERALL HOMELESS POPULATION.
S. B. TEN FORTY FIVE WOULD
MAINTAIN FULL DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS FOR PEOPLE FOR WHOM
CONSERVATORSHIP IS SOUGHT
JUDICIAL PROCEEDINGS.
REPRESENTATION BY COUNSEL AND A
REQUIREMENT FOR PERIODIC RENEWAL
AND REASSESSMENT.
IN OUR CITIES.
WE HAVE RUN OUT OF OPTIONS OUR
SYSTEM HAS BEEN FAILING TO THIS
GROUP OF EXTREMELY SICK
INDIVIDUALS.
SOME OF WHOM ARE LITERALLY DYING
ON OUR STREETS CYCLING THROUGH
EMERGENCY ROOMS PSYCHIATRIC
WARDS MENTAL HEALTH FACILITIES
AND OUR JAILS.
WERE LOSING PEOPLE EVERY DAY ON
OUR STREETS AND I THINK MANY OF
US WOULD AGREE THAT IT IS NOT
ACCEPTABLE FOR US TO DO NOTHING.
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPPORT.
FAMOUS YOU SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON OUR MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
INTEL IS A VOTE I SIXTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY ONE IS S.
B..
TEN FIFTY KERKORIAN CYNICAL TEN
FIFTY BY SENATOR LARA AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY TO INMATES.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT S. B. TEN FIFTY ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR LARA.
S. B. TEN FIFTY INSURERS THAT
EXONERATED PEOPLE ARE GIVEN
EVERY POSSIBLE RESOURCE AS THEY
TRANSITION BACK INTO THE
COMMUNITY.
EXCLUDING ACCESS TO MEDICAL CAL
FRESH WORK TRAINING PROGRAMS AND
GET MONEY.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THERE
HAVE BEEN A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
AND NINETY NINE EXONERATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA.
EACH YEAR ABOUT TEN PEOPLE OR
EXONERATED AFTER SPENDING MANY
YEARS BEHIND BARS.
THE IRONY IS THAT WE PROVIDE
SERVICES AND GATE MONEY.
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE COMMITTED A
CRIME BUT WE DO NOT DO THE SAME
FOR THE INNOCENT.
S. B. TEN FIFTY IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE.
SUPPORT PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WRONGLY.
CONVICTED BY OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED WIDESPREAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
PAYMENTS JONES SAWYER SAY NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WORK WELL
OVER THERE ALL.
OUR MEMBERS FOR THEIR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO GO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS THERE TO
VOTE
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WELL I DON'T THREE TWENTY TWO IS
S. B..
TEN SEVENTY ONE KERKORIAN.
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY ONE BY
SENATOR ROTH AND OTHERS AND
ACTING THE PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
MISSOURI.
ONE YOU MISTER SPEAKER S. B. TEN
SEVENTY ONE WILL REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
DEVELOP ADOPT AND CLEMENTA
POLICY TO AWARD CREDIT. TO
MILITARY PERSONNEL AND VETERANS
WHO I HAVE A JOINT SERVICES
TRANSCRIPT.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY ONE HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I'VE.
THANK AN IS THERE WHEN SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLARK WELL
OVER THE ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THESE ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
QUIRK WELL CLOSER ALL ANTI ABOUT
ICE FIFTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE FILE ITEM.
THREE TWENTY THREE S. B..
TEN SEVENTY TWO COOPERATE
CYNICAL TEN SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY THE CLIMATE CHANGE
[inaudible]
MS RAYOS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
LEYVA AND IS A PROUD COAUTHOR I
PRESENT TO YOU SP.
TEN SEVENTY TWO A BILL WHICH
CREATES THE REGIONAL CLIMATE
COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM TO BE
ADMINISTERED BY THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL.
THIS NEW PROGRAM ON POWER
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
CLIMATE TO PROGRAMS HELPING THEM
TO ACHIEVE TANGIBLE SUCCESS.
TOWARD CREATING HEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES.
DESPITE THE STATE SPENDING
MILLIONS TO COMBAT POLLUTION IN
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THOSE
VERY PLACES ARE STRUGGLING TO
ACCESS.
CRITICAL FUNDING WHICH
COMPROMISES ARE CLIMATE ACTION
GOALS [inaudible]
S. B..
SP TEN SEVENTY TWO IS ABOUT
EQUITY IN RESPONSE TO AN ART
URGENT NEED BY ALIGNING OUR
CLIMATE PROGRAMS [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
WHY DON'T?
MS REYES THANK YOU SP TEN
SEVENTY TWO IS ABOUT EQUITY AND
RESPONSE TO AN URGENT NEED BY
LINING.
OUR CLIMATE PROGRAMS WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF OUR STATE'S MOST
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ADDRESS [inaudible]
WITHOUT. FOR BLOB RURAL AND
UNDERSERVED.
IS THERE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE SALVO EYES.
FORTY EIGHT KNOWS NINE THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
THREE TWENTY FOUR IS SB TEN
EIGHTY THREE CORPORATE.
SAMPLE TEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR MITCHELL AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY THE CHILD WELFARE
[inaudible]
MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS FOR THE PROMISE OF THE
WAY WE DID THE CONTINUE OF CARE
REFORM BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WAS. TO RE VISIT IT
EVERY YEAR AND ENSURE THAT WE
ARE ADDRESSING IMPLEMENTATION
CHALLENGES THAT ARISE ONE OF
THOSE IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES
HAS BEEN THE APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR RESOURCE FAMILIES.
AND WHAT SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY
THREE BY SENATOR MITCHELL DOES
IS ENSURE SAID THOSE RESOURCE
FAMILIES GET THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED WHILE THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH THE RESOURCE FAMILY
APPROVAL PROCESS.
AS WE WORK TO STREAMLINE THAT
PROCESS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THOSE FAMILIES ARE SUPPORTED SO
THAT THEY CAN TAKE HELP TAKE
CARE OF SOME THE MOST VULNERABLE
CHILDREN THAT WE HAVE.
I ASK FOR YOUR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
S. B..
TEN EIGHTY THREE FAMOUS DON'T
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THESE ARE DIVERT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU VOTE AYE [inaudible]
SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM.
THREE TWENTY FIVE IT'S S. B. TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN CORPORATE SENATE
BILL TEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
ROTH ACTING TO THE PROP ASSESSED
CLEAN ENERGY PROGRAM
[inaudible]
MS AGUIAR-CURRY.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
LEGISLATION RELATING TO PACE
THAT WAS ENDING ENACTED LAST
YEAR REQUIRES CLEANUP.
AND SENATOR ROTH AND I ARE BOTH
CARING MEASURES TO ENACT THOSE
CHANGES.
S. B. ONE ZERO EIGHT SEVEN
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY IN THE
PACE PROGRAM AND PROVIDES THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
WITH AUTHORITY TO TAKE PROMPT.
ACTION WE'RE BELIEVES THAT THE
PUBLIC MAY BE AT RISK AND
CONNECTION WITH THE MARKETING OF
PACE ASSESSMENTS.
S. B. TEMP EIGHTY SEVEN IS
SUPPORTED BY CONSUMER GROUPS
MEMBERS OF THE MORTGAGE LENDING
INDUSTRY REALTORS AND THE
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
ALTHOUGH SOME OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL REMAINS SENATOR ROTH HAS
TAKEN A NUMBER OF THE AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S BOTH
SERIOUS OUTSTANDING CONCERNS.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS A YEAR CURRY SEEN
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIS ARAB VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO ITEM THREE
TWENTY SIX SP TEN NINETY SEVEN
MADAM.
FOR SENATE BILL TEN NINETY SEVEN
BY SENATOR HUESO AND OTHERS IN
ATLANTA LEAD POISONING.
THANK YOU SO MEMORY IS HERE
RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ARISE TO
PRESENT.
S. B. TEN NINETY SEVEN AN
IMPORTANT BILL THAT RELATES TO
CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING CASE
MANAGEMENT DATA.
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH IS
REQUIRED TO PREPARE BIANNUAL.
REPORT TO A BI ANNUAL REPORT
DESCRIBING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
CASE MANAGEMENTEFFORTS FOR
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN EXPOSED
TO LEAD.
SP TEN NINETY SEVEN WILL
INSTRUCT THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH.
WHEN PREPARING THEIR BI ANNUAL
REPORT?
SCRUBBING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
CASE MANAGEMENT EFFORTS RELATED
TO LEAD POISONING IN CHILDREN.
TO INCLUDE SPECIFIED INFORMATION
FOR EACH COUNTY INCLUDING THE
NUMBER OF CHILDREN TESTED FOR
LEAD POISONING.
THIS BILL WILL HELP CALIFORNIA
BETTER UNDERSTAND CHILDHOOD LEAD
LEVELS.
LEAD HAZARDS AND THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF LEAD ABATEMENT.
S. B. TEN NINETY SEVEN HAS
PASSED OUT OF POLICY COMMITTEES
WITH STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND NO NO VOTES FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM
AYE VOTE.
ON SP.
TEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
MEADOW PARK WAS OPEN.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
METAPHOR CAN MAKE CLOTHES THE
ROLLING TELLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
FIVE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING OUT ITEM THREE TWENTY
SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN FIFTEEN
METAPHOR PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
AND FIFTEEN BY SENATOR HELL
ACTUALLY TO TAXATION SOME EVER
BERMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB ELEVEN FIFTEEN
WILL EIGHT NONPROFITS IN
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY
INCREASING THE PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION CAP.
FROM TEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
NONPROFITS THAT DO NOT RECEIVE
ANY TAX CREDITS OR INCENTIVES
FROM THE STATE OR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES HAVE A CAP PLACED ON
THE AMOUNT OF PROPERTY TAX THAT
MAY BE EXEMPTED ANNUALLY.
WITH THE EVER RISING HOME PRICES
IN THE BAY AREA AND OTHER
CALIFORNIA CITIES THIS CAPITAL
CONTINUE TO BE AN ISSUE FOR
THESE CHARITIES AS THEY
CONTINUE.
TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
FOR LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MEDICAL
COMMITMENT A ROLL-ON MEMBERS
BOWED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
HOW THE VOTES AYE SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM A THREE TWENTY
EIGHT S. B..
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE CLERK WILL
READ SENATE ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
BY SENATOR JACKSON AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PAID FAMILY
LEAVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP AS
SPEAKER AT SB ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE A EXPANDS THE PAID FOR
FAMILY LEAVE PROGRAM THAT
EMPLOYEES PAY INTO TO ALSO
EXTEND TO THOSE WHO ARE
PREPARING FOR A FAMILY MEMBER.
A IN THE ARMED FORCES GOING INTO
DEPLOYMENT --
THIS COULD BE FOR A SHORT TERM A
LITTLE LONG TERM AGAIN SELF
FUNDED SO PAID FOR ALLOWS THEM
TO LEAVE THE FAMILY LEAVE AT THE
VERY PAY INTO FOUR MILITARY
DEPLOYMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLL
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
ONE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE TWENTY NINE
SB ELEVEN THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SENATE ELEVEN THIRTY BY SENATOR
LEYVA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
DEMAND IT HOMES BEACON
APPROPRIATION THERE FOR SOME
EVER OUT YOUR CURRY THANK YOU
GONNA MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS SP
ELEVEN THIRTY WOULD SIMPLY
REINSTATE.
MOBILE HOME OWNERS AS ELIGIBLE
PURCHASE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONED A
PROGRAM.
THIS MEASURE WILL HELP TO KEEP
LOW INCOME DISABLED PERSONS AND
SENIORS IN THEIR HOMES AT A TIME
WHEN THEY NEED THAT HELP MOST.
FOR MANY YEARS THE STATE
PROPERTY TAX CUTS POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM.
HOUSE HELP THE LOWER INCOME
RESIDENTS AND HOUSEHOLDS WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE PROGRAM SO THEY
DO NOT LOSE THEIR HOMES.
ONTO A CAC TAX SALE.
DURING THE RECESSION OF THE
PROGRAM WAS ELIMINATED BUT WAS
LATER REESTABLISHED HOWEVER
REAUTHORIZING LEGISLATION DID
NOT INCLUDE MOBILE HOMES.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY WILL CORRECT
THAT OMISSION SO THAT ELIGIBLE
RESIDENTS DO NOT RISK LOSING
THEIR HOME WHEN THEY HAVE
TROUBLE PAYING THEIR PROPERTY
TAXES.
S. B. ELEVEN THIRTY HAS EARNED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY THREE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE THIRTY S.
B. ELEVEN THIRTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SENATE ELEVEN THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG OTHERS
ACTUALLY TO ENERGY.
SOME MEMBER HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MEN OF SPEAKER --
SB ELEVEN THIRTY ONE REQUIRES
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
AUTHORIZE ELECTRICAL AND GAS
CORPORATIONS TO PROVIDE REBATES.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND OTHER
INCENTIVES TO INDUSTRIAL
AGRICULTURAL COMMERCIAL
RESIDENTIAL AND PUBLIC SECTOR
CUSTOMERS TO INCREASE ENERGY
EFFICIENCY.
BEGINNING JULY FIRST TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THE GOAL IS TO
CREATE A PROGRAM THAT IS
TRANSPARENT.
PREDICTABLE AND THAT LIVES.
BY I SAID A PUBLISHED RULES NOT
ARBITRARY AND ENDING AND
SUBJECTIVE REVIEW.
WITH SMART METERS AGGREGATED
DATA AND CUTTING EDGE SOFTWARE
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT CAN ACTUALLY BE
DEPLOYED.
AS A RESOURCE FOR THE GREAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN A REQUEST TO SPEAK MADAM
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE THIRTY ONE
SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ SENATE ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
ACTUALLY TO NUTRITION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SOME MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
SENATE BILL ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
WILL ALLOW FOR PLANT BASED MEALS
TO BE AN OPTION IN STATE
HOSPITALS AND PRISONS.
YOU WERE I HOW THE FOOD
PREFERENCE BEGIN BRING PREPARE
BY THE MEAL THE SUITS ARE
RELIGIOUS ETHICAL DIETARY NEEDS.
PEOPLE INSTITUTIONAL SETTING TO
NOT HAVE THIS OPTION.
GOING TO THE UNITED NATIONS
HUMAN RIGHTS OF THE HUMAN RIGHT
TO ADEQUATE FOOD INCLUDES FOOD
THAT IS CULTURALLY ACCEPTABLE TO
THE CONSUMER.
WE WANT PEOPLE THESE FACILITIES
TO HAVE THE DIGNITY OF CHOICE.
PLANT BASED AYES APPROVING
HEALTHIER AND BETTER FOR OUR
CARBON FOOTPRINT LESS WATER AND
ENERGY INPUT ARE NEEDED FOR
PLANT BASED AGRICULTURE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING THAT NO WORSE NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY FIVE KNOWS SEVEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER. TO ITEM.
TWO SEVENTY SEVEN S. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN MADAM CLERK PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BUT SENATOR STERN AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY TO ENERGY
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WOULD CREATE VOLUNTARY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM THAT WILL PROVIDE
INCENTIVES TO BUILDERS TO ADOPT
A RANGE OF CLEAN.
AND EFFICIENT EQUIPMENT AND NEW
HOMES AND UPSTREAM INCENTIVES
TARGETING RETAILERS
MANUFACTURERS.
CUSTOMER EDUCATION AND
CONTRACTOR TRAINING.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN IS
TECHNOLOGICALLY NEUTRAL TO
ENABLE BUILDERS AND CUSTOMERS TO
SELECT.
FROM A RANGE OF TECHNOLOGIES AND
TO SMASH EMISSIONS [inaudible]
SLASH EMISSIONS --
EITHER WAY.
A 30% OF THE INCENTIVES WILL BE
DEDICATED TO LOW INCOME HOUSING
ENSURING THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
WILL BENEFIT FROM LOWER UTILITY
BILLS AND REDUCE POLLUTION.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
WILL EMPOWER CALIFORNIANS BY
PROVIDING AFFORDABLE OPTIONS
WHEN THEY NEXT REPLACE THEIR
FURNACE OUR WATER HEATER AND
SAVE ON UTILITY COSTS AFTER THEY
BUY A NEW HOME.
SB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR THANK
YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
.
MISTER HOLDEN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER TIE THEM.
TO SIXTY ONE S. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX MADAM HER
PLEASE READ.
SENATE ELEVEN FIFTY SIX BY
SENATOR LEYVA AND ACTUALLY THE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
SOME WOULD.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SIX IS JUST
ABOUT ONE THING.
PREVENTING FINANCIALLY
INTERESTED TREATMENT CENTERS
FROM FINDING WAYS TO UNDERWRITE
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE COVERAGE
FOR THEIR PATIENTS.
IN ORDER TO PAD THEIR PROFITS.
THEY'VE BEEN DOING SO BY
STEERING PATIENTS TO APPLY FOR
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE PLANS
INSTEAD OF A PATIENT'S MEDICARE
OR MEDICAID COVERAGE WITH ONE
GOAL. TO MAXIMIZE THEIR PROFITS.
PREMIUMS FOR VULNERABLE PATIENTS
ARE BEING PAID FOR EITHER
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY BY THESE
TREATMENT CENTERS AND IT IS NO
COINCIDENCE THAT THESE POLICIES
HAVE HIGHER REIMBURSEMENT RATES
FOR TREATMENT.
THE WHAT THE PATIENT'S ALTERNATE
COVERAGE WOULD PAY.
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
FACILITIES DIALYSIS CLINICS AND
OTHERS CAN BOOST THEIR PROFITS
BY MORE THAN A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER PATIENT ANNUALLY.
BY STEERING PATIENTS INTO
COMMERCIAL COVERAGE THAT MAY NOT
FIT THE PATIENT'S NEEDS.
THIS RESULTS IN HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
UNNECESSARY AND INCREASED HEALTH
CARE RELATED SPENDING THE GETS
SPREAD ACROSS EVERY ONE OF US.
IN THE FORM OF INCREASED
PREMIUMS. TO PREVENT THIS ABUSE
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SIX WOULD
REQUIRE FINANCIALLY INTERESTED
ENTITIES WHENEVER THEY PAY FOR
THE HEALTH INSURANCE ON BEHALF
OF A PATIENT. TWO ONE INFORM THE
PATIENT THAT THERE'D BEEN SIGNED
UP FOR HEALTH INSURANCE AND
EXPLAIN TO THE PATIENT ALL THE
COVERAGE OPTIONS. TO DO AGREED
NOT TO STEER PATIENTS INTO A
PARTICULAR COVERAGE OPTION.
AGREE TO A PAID THE PATIENTS
PREMIUMS FOR THE FULL PLAN YEAR.
AND INFORM TO HELP ENSURE THAT
FINANCIALLY INTERESTED ENTITY
WILL PAY THE PATIENTS PREMIUM
FOR THE YEAR.
THE BILL ALSO HOLDS PATIENT
HARMLESS BY ALLOWING THIRD PARTY
PAYMENTS TO CONTINUE WITHOUT
COVERAGE DISRUPTIONS AND SIMPLY
REMOVES INCENTIVE.
THE FINANCIAL PREFER FINANCIALLY
INTERESTED PROVIDERS.
A GAME THE SYSTEM FOR THEIR OWN
INTEREST RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE
BROUGHT ON THE SUPPORT OF HEALTH
ACCESS TO CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
AND IS REMOVED THE OPPOSITION BY
THE E. W..
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU OF SOME GOVERNMENT
WONDERS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
THIS BILL IS ABOUT ONE THING AND
ONE THING ONLY AND THAT IS
UNIONIZING THE EMPLOYEES WHO
WORK AT SOME OF THESE DIALYSIS
CLINICS I'VE RECEIVED.
COUNTLESS EMAILS FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS I WENT TO THE
DIALYSIS CENTER IN MY IN MY
DISTRICT TWO MILES FROM MY HOUSE
AND SPOKE WITH A GENTLEMAN THERE
WHO'S A HOLOCAUST SURVIVOR HE'S
ONE OF THE TOUGHEST GUYS I'VE
EVER MET.
HE'S BEEN THROUGH A HELL OF A
LOT IN HIS LIFE ME WAS IN TEARS
TERRIFIED OF WHAT IS GOING ON IN
THIS CAPITAL WITH RESPECT TO
THEIR TREATMENT.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT BACKING
EMPLOYEES BACKING CERTAIN
COMPANIES INDOOR CORNERS THAT
THE UNIONIZED THEIR EMPLOYEES DO
NOT PEOPLE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I'M OPPOSED S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY
SIX BECAUSE IT'S A BAD DEAL FOR
PATIENTS AND IT'S A BAD DEAL FOR
TAXPAYERS INNOCENCE S. B. ELEVEN
FIFTY SIX ALLOWS PRIVATE
INSURERS TO DUMP PATIENTS.
FROM THE PRIVATE INSURANCE AND
PUSHED THEM ON THE TAXPAYER
FUNDED COVERAGE LIKE MEDICARE
AND MEDICAID OUT.
MANY OF THESE PATIENTS HAVE PAID
PREMIUMS FOR THEIR PRIVATE
HEALTH COVERAGE FOR MOST OF
THEIR LIVES BUT THROUGH NO FAULT
OF THEIR OWN.
NOW THEY'RE SIX A NEAT SECOND
NEED DIALYSIS A IN REQUIRE
SENDING A HELPING HAND FROM
CHARITIES TO KEEP THEIR
COVERAGE.
S. B. ELEVEN FIFTY SIX PUSHES
PATIENTS ON A MEDICAL AND
MEDICARE FORCING TAXPAYERS
INSTEAD OF PRIVATE HEALTH
INSURERS TO PAY FOR THEIR CARE.
ALL OF THIS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT THE HEALTH PLANS
VOLUNTARILY ENTER INTO THE
CONTRACTS WITH DIALYSIS
PROVIDERS PROVIDE HEALTH CARE
QUIRK DIALYSIS PATIENTS.
THE HEALTH PLANS CAN HAVE IT
BOTH WAYS AND IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT AT THE HEALTH PLANS ARE
ALLOWED TO DROP PATIENTS
INTEREST AND RECEIVE CHAIR WILL
ASSISTANCE TO PAY THEIR
PREMIUMS.
IT'S NOT GOOD FOR PATIENTS
EITHER I URGE.
YOU ALL TO VOTE NO ON S. B..
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER AMEND
OUR SIDE RIGHT IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ELEVEN FIFTY SIX NO MATTER WHAT
YOU HAVE HEARD IN THE MATTER
WHAT YOU THINK.
YOU CARE ABOUT PROTECTING THE
NEEDS OF OUR PATIENTS.
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS.
THAT.
WE SHOULD NOT ALLOW A COMPANY TO
PROFIT BY GAMING THE SYSTEM BY
DIRECTING MONEY TO A CHARITY
THAT PAYS FOR INSURANCE THAT
FALL SHORT OF WHAT THE PATIENT
NEEDS.
A WHAT YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TOLD IS
THAT SOMEONE WHO HAS A
TRANSPLANT AND HAS THIS
COMMERCIAL INSURANCE WILL NOT
HAVE THE SUPPORT THAT THEY WILL
NEED. FOR THREE YEARS TREATMENT
THAT THEY WOULD GET AFTER THE
TRANSPLANT BUT THEY HAVE
MEDICARE AS THIS BILL WAS TRYING
TO DIRECT PEOPLE. TO TAKE THEY
WILL HAVE THREE YEARS OF ONGOING
SUPPORT TO ENSURE THAT THINGS
ARE GOING WELL POSTS --
TRANSPLANT AGAIN THIS BILL
SIMPLY SAYS LET'S NOT ALLOW A
COMPANY TO GAME THE SYSTEM TO
MAKE BIG PROFITS OFF OF PATIENTS
INTO LEAF PATIENTS IN THE LURCH
WITHOUT THE SUPPORT.
THAT THEY NEED IN THEIR TIME OF
NEED I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL.
THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES NOT ADD UP
ELIMINATE [inaudible]
EXPLAIN WHY. 20% OF THE DIALYSIS
PATIENTS HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE.
OR THEY CAN GET IT SOMEHOW
ACCORDING TO WHAT PEOPLE ARE
SAYING HERE.
THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY TRUE.
IF THEY DO NOT HAVE INSURANCE
THEN THEY HAVE A FEW CHOICES
THEY CAN GO AND GET IN
INDIVIDUAL POLICY IN WHICH CASE
THEY'LL BE UNDERWRITTEN.
AND REFUSE COVERAGE.
THEY CAN ALSO GO WITH OBAMACARE
A CA WHICH IS RAPIDLY
DETERIORATING.
THAT'S ALSO PROBLEMATIC.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE.
THAT HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE HAVE
GROUP INSURANCE.
OR RETIREMENT PLANS THROUGH
GROUPS.
IT'S ALSO SAID ON THE FLOOR
HERE.
THAT THESE COMPANIES ARE PAYING
THE PREMIUMS.
THAT'S ILLEGAL YOU CAN'T DO IT.
IT'S CALLED REBATE.
THAT'S ALSO COVERED IN THE
INSURANCE CODE.
SO I'M LOOKING AT MANY THINGS
HERE THAT DO NOT ADD UP.
IT CERTAINLY DON'T ADD UP TO ME.
20% THAT WANT PRIVATE INSURANCE.
HAVE ALWAYS HAD THE PRIVATE
INSURANCE IN MOST CASES.
IF THERE WITH.
BUT INSURANCE COMPANY THAT THEY
BEN WITH FOR TWENTY THIRTY
YEARS.
NOW THAT THERE ARE NEXT RAMOS.
AND A THREAT LIFE THREATENING.
THEY WANT TO STAY WITH THAT.
CARRIER THAT THEY BELIEVE IN
THAT'S ALWAYS PAID THEIR CLAIMS.
SO I DON'T SEE WHERE THE DECK
HAS BEEN SHUFFLED HERE. FOR THE
BENEFIT OF A OF A DIALYSIS
COMPANY IT JUST DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE HAVING
CEASED ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
MAY CLOSE.
THEY COMMENCEMENT CARE A
NEIGHBOR HEARD MANY THINGS ABOUT
THIS BILL I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT I WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SUPPORTERS TO
ENSURE THE VULNERABLE PATIENTS
WILL NOT BE HARMED BY THIS BILL.
MY DESIRE WAS TO REMOVE THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVE THAT HAS
ALLOWED FOR PROFIT TREATMENT
CENTERS. TO INAPPROPRIATELY
BENEFIT FROM THE SYSTEM.
I BEEN TO SUIT MADE AT THE TO
SAY THE LEAST THAT SOME
OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL HAVE HAD
YET DIE I HAVE HAD THE AUDACITY.
TO ARGUE THAT THIS BILL
PRESERVES INSURANCE COMPANY
PROFITS.
INSURANCE COMPANIES ACTUALLY
HAVE A MEDICAL LOSS RATIO PLACE
THAT LIMITS THEIR PROFITS.
CAN THE SAME BE SAID FOR PROP
FOR PROPAGANDA CENTERS NO THAT
CAN'T BE.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY FUNDING MONEY
THROUGH THIS THROUGH IS THROUGH
A FOUNDATION TO HELP PAY FOR
PEOPLE'S PLANS.
HE'S PUBLICLY TRADED COMPANIES
HAVE A VIRTUAL MONOPOLY ON THE
DELIVERY OF CARE.
THE NET WORTH OF THESE COMPANIES
APPROXIMATELY TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE A DIRECT
IMPACT ON 1% OF THEIR PATIENTS
THE 1% RECEIVING PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE.
IS A CHANGE TO THE RIGHT
MEDICARE RATES FOR THIS 1% OF
PATIENTS GOING TO DEVASTATE
THEIR BUSINESS OR IS IT JUST
GOING TO HAVE A BIT OF AN
IMPACT.
ON BILLION DOLLAR PROFITS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM CLERK YOU MAY
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MR WOULD MOVE THE CAR
[inaudible]
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ORDER. TO THIRTY TWO SB.
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN MEDICAL
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ITEM FORTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ATLANTA
WELLING GAS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
WHEN OFFSHORE OIL PLATFORMS
THEIR IN STATE WATERS ARE
ABANDONED.
THE COME AND THE COMPANIES
BANKRUPT OR NOT IN A POSITION TO
REMEDIATE IT FALLS ON THE
STATE'S GENERAL FUND TO DO SO.
CURLY STATE LANDS COMMISSION AND
THE DIVISION OF OIL GAS AND YOU
THEIR MAKE RESOURCES.
ASK FOR BONDS FROM COMPANIES IS
THEY PUT THESE FACILITIES IN THE
BONDING AMOUNTS OF APPROVED TO
BE ENTIRELY INADEQUATE AND WE
END UP.
SPENDING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
REMEDIATE THESE PLATFORMS.
I'M HAVE SENATOR HERTZBERG I'M
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON ON SB
ELEVEN FORTY SEVEN I WILL NOTE
THAT IT'S GONE UNDERGONE
SIGNIFICANT AMENDMENTS IN FACT
AMENDMENTS TAKING IT
APPROPRIATIONS OF REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THINK UC KNOW DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
BENEFIT YOU MAY CLOSE THE RULING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO ITEM THREE THIRTY
THREE SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT AM
FOR PLEASE READ.
SENATE PULLUM FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR PAN ACTUALLY MEDI CAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THING ABOUT A SPEAKER
A MEMBERS SB ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
ALLOWS DENTED CAO PROVIDERS TO
BE REIMBURSED. FOR SILVER DIE
MEAN FLUORIDE OR STF STF IS A
LIQUID THAT IS APPLIED TOPICALLY
TO THAT USED TO SLOW OR STOP THE
GROWTH THE CAVITIES.
THIS IS A NON INVASIVE PROCEDURE
COULD BE BENEFICIAL TO CHILDREN
INDIVIDUALS WILL DEVELOP
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
ELDERS ARE OTHERS WHO MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO RECEIVE TRADITIONAL
TREATMENT.
THOUGH TO DECAY IS PREVENTABLE
IT REMAINS THE MOST COMMON
CHRONIC DISEASE OF CHILDHOOD AND
CONTINUES TO AFFECT PEOPLE
ACROSS THEIR LIVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON SB.
ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT THANK YOU
SING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THAT A PURPOSE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS GO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
NOW MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS YOUR THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS AYE AND PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL.
ON ITEM. THREE OH NINE S. B..
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MADAM PERKY MAY CLOSE THE ROLAND
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY TWO
NO SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSED
.
WE ARE MOVING AHEAD AND FILE
ORDER TO ITEM THREE FORTY FOUR
SB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE METAPHOR
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
BY.
SO IF YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
LOTT.
SP THIRTEEN NINETY ONE WOULD AND
THE CURRENT PRACTICE OF TRYING
CHILDREN WHO WERE AGES FOURTEEN
AND FIFTEEN AS ADULTS IN
CRIMINAL COURT AND SENDING THEM
TO ADULT PRISON.
THIS IS A PRACTICE THAT STARTED
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES AT A
TIME WHEN POLICY MAKERS BELIEVE
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WERE FULLY
DEVELOPED BY THE AGE OF THIRTEEN
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH HAS TO BUNK
THAT.
COGNITIVE SCIENCE HAS SHOWN
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO MAKING
POOR DECISIONS AND EASILY MISLED
BY ADULTS.
A QUARTER OF YOUNG PEOPLE UNDER
EIGHTEEN HAVE A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THESE YOUTH
HAVE NOT COMMITTED THE MOST
SERIOUS CRIMES FOR EXAMPLE A FEW
YEARS AGO IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ALMOST
THREE QUARTERS OF THE YOUNG
PEOPLE UNDER SIXTEEN WHO WERE
SENT TO ADULT COURT RESENT FOR
NON HOMICIDE CRIMES SUCH AS
BURGLARY.
ROBBERY AND ASSAULT. FOR THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE CHARGED WITH
HOMICIDE THE MAJORITY WERE NOT
THE PRIMARY ACTOR AND LIKELY TO
HAVE HAD AN ADULT CHO CO
DEFENDANT.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT THE
YOUNGEST TEAMS IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
BUT ALSO RECEIVE AGE APPROPRIATE
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS. TO
REBUILD TAPE THEM INTO HEALTHY
AND MATURE ADULTS THOSE WHO
COMMIT THE MOST HEINOUS AND
SERIOUS CRIMES WILL STILL BE
PUNISHED THROUGH INCARCERATION
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE
JUSTICE.
WHICH IS PRISON WITH AGE
APPROPRIATE AND REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE BY SENATOR LOTT AT THIS BILL
ENSURES THE CALIFORNIA RETURNS
TO PRIORITIZING REHABILITATION
AND POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT. FOR
FOR YOUTH WE CANNOT SPEAK OF
THIS BILL AS IF IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S NEVER BEEN DONE BEFORE
CALIFORNIA DID NOT ALWAYS TRY
FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS
AS ADULTS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
CALIFORNIA CHANGE THE LAW TO
ALLOW YOUTH UNDER SIXTEEN TO BE
TRIED AS ADULTS THESE POLICIES
WERE CREATED IN AN ERA WHERE WE
WERE AFRAID OF YOUTH CRIMES AND
WE REACTED BY SPREADING AND
BELIEVING THE MYTH.
OF THE SUPER PREDATOR WE CANNOT.
FULL OF COLOR BROWN AND BLACK
YOUTH.
TRY IT AND THE SYSTEM FOR ADULTS
WHERE THEY WILL NOT GET THE
SUPPORT THAT THEY NEED TO
REHABILITATE.
RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED THE
YOUTH ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DIFFERENT FROM ADULTS AND
CAPABLE OF REMARKABLE CHANGE
GIVEN THE PROPER SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
pBASED ON SOLID EVIDENCE AND
RESEARCH NOT FEAR OR HYSTERIA
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THAT WOULD
CHANGE THE LIVES OF SO MANY
YOUNG PEOPLE THINK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER THANK YOUMADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS ARE RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE AT YOUR
PUBLIC SAFETY AND AND THE BOARD
MET BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR I'VE
SEEN FIRST INTERFERE IN THE EYES
OF OUR USE THAT THEY TRIED TO
COME TO GRIPS WITH FACING TIME.
IN AN ADULT PRISON MANY OF THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE IN THIS
POSITION BECAUSE A SOME KIND OF
TRAUMA.
OR ABUSE THAT THEY HAVE
EXPERIENCED WHICH WENT UNTREATED
WE OFTEN OFTEN HEAR ABOUT THE
VERY GREGIS IN SERIOUS CASES IN
THE NEWS.
BUT THAT IS NOT THE RATIONALE
FOR THE MAJORITY OF THE USED ME
AND SENT TO THE ADULT SYSTEM.
ABOUT 70% OF THE U. WHO ACTUALLY
GET SENT TO THE ADULT SYSTEM ARE
FOR NON HOMICIDE CRIMES.
OF THESE 92% OF YOUTH OF COLOR
WE KNOW THAT A YOUNG PERSON'S
BEST CHANCE OF REHABILITATION IS
IN THE JUVENILE SYSTEM.
CHILDREN DON'T BELONG IN THE
ADULT SYSTEM IS FOR THESE
REASONS THAT I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS MEASURE TODAY
AND I URGE ALL OF YOU TO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER SO
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WE'VE HEARD
MUCH ABOUT --
THE DEFENDANTS IN CASES LIKE
THIS SO NOW LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
ACTUAL VICTIMS.
OKAY WE HEAR TIME AND TIME AGAIN
ON THIS FLOOR ABOUT.
THE YOUTH ABOUT HOWELL THEIR
UNFAIRLY TARGETED THEIR UNFAIRLY
INCARCERATED.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT THE VICTIM.
WHEN THE ASSISTANT DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS IN IN MY DISTRICT TOLD
ME THIS STORY ABOUT A DEFENDANT?
THAT WITHIN HIS COURT ROOM HE
THE KID WAS FIFTEEN YEARS OLD HE
SAID THAT WAS THE ONE DEFENDANT
HE WAS MOST AFRAID OF A YOUNG
MAN WHO LOWERED A YOUNG WOMAN.
THAT HE DOES FRIENDS NEW.
THEY WERE ACQUAINTANCES THAT SHE
LORD OR BOARD HER. TO AN
ABANDONED HOME.
SET HER ON FIRE.
AMONG MANY OTHER HORRIBLE
DISGUSTING AWFUL THINGS THAT
THEY DID TO HER.
AND KILLED HER HE WAS FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD IT WAS PREMEDITATED.
THIS IS THE TYPE OF CASE THAT
MIGHT LEE AND ONE IN IN IN IN
ADULT COURT [inaudible]
RATHER THAN.
THE JUVENILE COURT.
IT IS UNUSUAL.
THAT A MINOR WOULD BE TRIED AS
AN ADULT AND DON'T QUIT THIS IS
NOT HAPPEN ALL THE TIME USED IN.
VERY EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES --
THIS ISN'T HAPPENING EVERYDAY
AND I THINK YOU OUGHT TO THINK
VERY CAREFULLY.
ABOUT THE VICTIMS IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND LISTEN A
LITTLE LESS.
ABOUT WHAT TYPE OF CHILDHOOD THE
DEFENDANT MIGHT OF HAD AND THINK
ABOUT THE CHILDHOOD.
THAT SOME OF THESE VICTIMS WILL
NEVER HAVE.
WITH THAT I URGE YOU KNOW VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
IT'S EASY TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
TEENAGERS ARE NOT AS RESPONSIBLE
AS ADULTS HOWEVER WHEN TEENAGERS
COMMIT VIOLENT FELONIES THEY
SHOULD BE HELD RESPONSIBLE FOR
THEIR ACTIONS.
THIS BILL LIMITS THE DISCRETION
PROSECUTORS HAVE IN HOW THEY
PROSECUTE FELONIES COMMITTED BY
JUVENILE OFFENDERS AGE FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD BY PREVENTING
PROSECUTORS FOR BRINGING
CHARGES.
THAT THESE OFFENDERS ARE AN
ADULT -- OR
IN ADULT COURT.
EXISTING LAW ALREADY SAFEGUARD
JUVENILE OFFENDERS ALLOWING
HEARINGS TO DETERMINE A MINER'S
FITNESS FOR ADULT COURT IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN VOTERS PASSED
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN WHICH
FURTHER RESTRICTED PROSECUTORS
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO TRY
JUVENILES IN ADULT COURT.
PROPOSITION FIFTY SEVEN REPEALED
THE PRESUMPTION OF FITNESS FOR
ADULT COURT FOR JUVENILE
OFFENDERS MAKING THE PROSECUTION
OF JUVENILE OFFENDERS IN ADULT
COURT INCREDIBLY RARE IN
RESERVE.
FOR ONLY THE MOST HEINOUS OF
CRIMES.
IN DETERMINING OFFENDERS FITNESS
FOR ADULT COR A COULD JUDGE
CONSIDERS THE CIRCUMSTANCES THE
GRAVITY AND THE SOPHISTICATION
OF THE OFFENSES COMMITTED BY THE
MINOR.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE PRESERVE
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WHICH THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA ALREADY
SUPPORT BY ALLOWING JUDGES TO
DETERMINE AN OFFENDER'S FITNESS
ON A CASE BY CASE.
BASIS IT IS OUT THAT MANY OF
THOSE THESE MOST HEINOUS OF
CRIMINALS WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PAROLE POTENTIALLY AT AGE TWENTY
FOUR I I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LAKE ELSINORE WHO BROUGHT
UP THE SUBJECT OF WHERE THE
VICTIM'S RIGHTS.
IN THIS PARTICULAR SITUATION WE
NEED TO BE CONCERNED WITH
SPECIFIC DETERRENCE BY MAKING
SURE THAT THESE MOST HEINOUS OF
CRIMINALS ARE BEHIND BARS AND
NOT ABLE TO RECOMMIT.
THEIR CRIMES.
THIS BILL MAKES OUR CITIES.
OUR ROLE AREAS AND AREAS
THROUGHOUT THE CAL STATE A
CALIFORNIA NEED MORE DANGEROUS
LESS SAFE.
LET'S REJECT THIS BILL AND VOTE
NO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALLEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THIS BILL IS CRIMINAL.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW JUVENILES
AGE FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN GUILTY
OF MURDER [inaudible]
ARSON [inaudible]
VIOLENT RAGE [inaudible]
KIDNAPPING [inaudible]
TORTURE.
NO LONGER BE TRIED AS ADULTS.
UNDER THE MISTAKEN [inaudible]
FANTASY.
THEY WERE SOMEHOW [inaudible]
NOT RESPONSIBLE.
WE'RE NOT ABLE. TO UNDERSTAND
THE SEVERITY OF THEIR ACTS.
PLEASE CHEN WHILE TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW VERY CLEARLY.
I DON'T CARE.
AND NOR SHOULD ANYONE THIS BODY.
WORD A CITIZEN OF THIS COUNTRY
HERE.
IF THEY WERE AWARE.
OR NOT AWARE.
OF THE SEVERITY OF THEIR
ACTIONS.
WHEN THEY MURDERED [inaudible]
FORCIBLY RAPED.
TORTURED AND KIDNAPPED VICTIMS.
THESE ARE CRIMES.
THESE ARE THE WORST CRIMES THAT
WE KNOW OF THESE PERPETRATORS.
OF THESE CRIMES.
SHOULD FACE THE MAXIMUM
[inaudible]
POSSIBLE PENALTIES.
THEY SHOULD BE HELD TO FULL
ACCOUNT. FOR THE ACTIONS OF
THEIR NEEDS.
AND I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW
[inaudible] TO ALLOW.
THESE PERPETRATORS OF THE WORST
CRIMES THAT WE KNOW OF POSSIBLY
BE ELIGIBLE FOR PAROLE.
WITHIN A DECADE.
IS NOT ONLY THE JUSTICE. TO THE
VICTIMS OF THESE CRIMES IT'S AN
INJUSTICE. TO OUR ENTIRE SOCIETY
[inaudible]
JUVENILES.
THERE ARE FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
THE COMMITTING THE WORST CRIMES.
SHOULD BE TREATED AS ADULTS.
THEY SHOULD FACE.
THE FULL COURT SYSTEM.
AND THE FULL SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA GREEN.
SENSIBLE PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
AGREE.
VICTIMS RIGHTS ADVOCATES AGREE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGREES.
DON'T LET JUSTICE TURN A BLIND
EYE [inaudible]
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE PERPETRATORS.
ARE SLIGHTLY YOUNGER.
THESE ARE THE VERY WORST CRIMES.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT MINOR
OFFENSES.
AND THINK FOR A MOMENT IF ANY OF
THESE CRIMES WAS BE PERJURY
AGAINST YOU OR ANYONE THAT YOU
KNOW.
WOULD YOU WANT.
THE PERPETRATOR OF THIS CRIME.
BACK OUT ON THE STREET.
WITHIN A DECADE.
OR AT ALL.
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
THINK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHOPPERS.
YOU KNOW I'VE A STRUGGLE OVER
THIS BILL [inaudible]
AND NOW [inaudible]
IT.
AND MAYBE BECAUSE IN THE SIX
YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE I'VE TAKEN
THE TIME TO VISIT A SOME
PRESENCE.
I'VE TAKEN THE TIME TO GO SEE
SOME THE JUVENILE SYSTEMS.
AND MY BACKGROUND AS SOME OF YOU
MAY KNOW IS AT FIRST SEVEN YEARS
I WAS A DIRECTOR OF A CHARTER
SCHOOL.
IN IN THIS CHARTER SCHOOL THOSE
BETWEEN DIVIDING LOS AND THESE
TWO COMMUNITIES ARE ALWAYS AT OF
AB FIGHTING EACH OTHER YOU'RE
TALKING. FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD KIDS.
BUT AT THE SCHOOL WAS A SAFE
SPOT.
AND THAT THE SCHOOLS WITH THE
PLACE I WOULD SEE HIM GET
TOGETHER AND INDIVIDUAL YOU SEE
ON THE STREET WHAT ACT A CERTAIN
WAY WOULD NOT THE SAME WAY IN
THE SCHOOL.
I SIGH KIDS RISE UP TO THEIR
OCCUPATION THERE BILLY DO GREAT
THINGS. ONE OF THE SADDEST
EVENTS I HAD IN MY TIME IS A
SCHOOL THAT IS ONE YOUNG MAN WHO
WAS A BIG KID.
AND OVER THE SUMMER TIME HE HE
HAD COME TO US BECAUSE HE WAS
BASICALLY KICKED OUT THE OTHER
SCHOOLS.
BUT HE CAME TO SCHOOL ANY WAS
STUDYING HE WAS WARNING ME WAS
UNDERSTANDING HIS ROLE WITHIN
SOCIETY.
BUT OVER THE SUMMER TIME HE WENT
BACK HUNG AROUND SOME OF HIS
FRIENDS AND GOT INVOLVED IN
INCIDENTS SOMEBODY WAS KILLED.
HE'S IN JAIL TODAY. FIFTEEN YEAR
OLD IN JAIL.
HAD A FUTURE.
YOU NO.
IT'S EASY TO SAY.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE DAHLE SIR
MAKING MISTAKES.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE THESE KIDS
ARE COMING FROM WHAT EXPERIENCES
ARE GOING THROUGH.
HE WASN'T AN EVIL KID HE WAS IN
THE WRONG PLACE AT THE WRONG
TIME.
BECAUSE YOU IS THE BIG GUY GOT
IN THE MIDDLE OF IT.
YOU KNOW WE LOST A GREAT LEADER
WE PUT HAVE MANAGERIAL.
WE AS A SOCIETY.
NEED TO LOOK AT OUR PRESENT SEE
HOW MANY PEOPLE WE ON TRACK
CARCERI SEE WHO'S IN THERE SEE
WHAT'S GOING ON WITHIN HOURS.
IN OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR FAMILIES
AND TAKE A BROADER VIEW THE
EASIEST THING IN THE WORLD IS IT
TAKES SOMEBODY AND THROWN IN
JAIL AND SAY TO HELL WITH YOU.
THAT'S THE EASIEST THING TO DO.
THE HARDEST THING TO DO IS TO
FIND OUT WHY ARE THEY THERE HOW
CAN I HELP THEM AND I'VE SEEN
COUNTLESS OF THE YOUNG PEOPLE
COME BACK AND SAY.
I WAS A LITTLE THOUGHT I WAS A
GANG MEMBER BUT IN THE SYSTEM OF
THE JUVENILE COURTS IT TOOK AWAY
MY TATTOOS I LEARNED HOW TO READ
I LEARNED OF VALUES.
AND I WANNA BE PART OF THE
SOCIETY THEY'VE BEEN IN MY
OFFICE AND I KNOW THEY'VE BEEN
IN YOUR OFFICES [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
LET'S TAKE A BROADER VIEW OF
WHAT THE SOCIETY IS ABOUT.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM OUR PRISON
SYSTEM WE HAVE A PROBLEM IN A
JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
I JUST WANT PEOPLE AWAY BECAUSE
OF THEIR EXPERIENCES IS WRONG.
I'M STRONG SUPPORTING THIS
BECAUSE I BELIEVE WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING IN THE PAST ISN'T
WORKING.
WE NEEDED CHANGE US LET'S GO TO
THE FUTURE AND GIVE THE YOUNG
WOMEN AND MEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THERE'S THAT THEY'VE
MADE.
I WAS A LITTLE FOG ONE TIME.
YOU PROBABLY WERE.
LET'S GET MY BREAK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I ALSO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
THIRTEEN NINETY ONE A AND I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT HIM MOST
MEMBERS THAT YOU HAVEN'T DONE IT
I WOULD ENCOURAGE GOING TO VISIT
SOME JUVENILE FACILITIES.
SEE SOME OF THE TREATMENTS THEY
HAVE ESTABLISHED NOW SEE SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT NOW ARE IN
PLACE THAT PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE
BEFORE.
WHEN I WENT TO VISIT A IN IN MY
COMMUNITY HAS SOME OF MY MY
FORMER STUDENTS WORK IN THERE MY
FORMER STUDENTS WHO HAD SOME
TROUBLE WHEN THEY WERE GROWING
UP IN?
ABLE TO FIND THEIR WAY TO HIGHER
EDUCATION AND OUR WORKING IN THE
SYSTEM TO HELP PEOPLE TURN THEIR
LIVES AROUND.
AGAIN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN YEAR OLDS
MEMBERS --
MAYBE ONE DAY ON THIS FLOOR THIS
WEEK I'M GONNA DO OF RECOGNITION
OF WOMEN SERVING IN THIS BODY
FOR ONE HUNDRED YEARS THIS IS
THE ANNIVERSARY OF IT --
ONE OF THE WOMEN WHO.
THE FIRST COUPLE YEARS --
FROM AND A SAILOR.
BUT WHEN THE FOR FIRST WOMEN.
THAT WAS ALSO RESPONSIBLE FOR
ABOLISHING THE DEATH PENALTY FOR
CHILDREN RECENTLY THAT.
USED TO HANG THEM [inaudible]
CHILDREN.
WE DID THAT.
IN THE STATE.
SHE THOUGHT IT WASN'T A GOOD
IDEA AND THAT SHE SAID
PERMISSION TO READ [inaudible]
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WOMEN WEALTHY YOUNG.
NEVER HANGING IT'S ALWAYS THE
FRIENDLESS AND THE POOR WHO FACE
THE GALLOWS [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE HAVEN'T CHANGED OUR SYSTEM
THAT TERRIBLY MUCH WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TODAY TO SAY TO OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WE HAVE SET UP
SERVICES FOR YOU WE HAVE
REHABILITATED OUR SYSTEM SO THAT
THERE ARE PROGRAMS.
AND SERVICES IN JUVENILE
FACILITIES TO HELP YOU TURN YOUR
LIFE AROUND.
YOUR WORTH REDEMPTION I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBER.
I WASN'T GOING TO SPEAK ON THIS
ITEM BUT I FEEL COMPELLED TO
SPEAK ON THIS ITEM --
FIRST WELL LAST MY COLLEAGUES
WHO AYE VOTE IN THIS BILL --
ONE I SPEAK AS A AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW AS A FORMER POLICE OFFICER.
AND THEN. TO FOR A FATHER WHO
LOST.
THEIR CHILD WHO WAS KILLED.
THE ADULT WOMAN WHO HE KILLED
OUR SON.
WAS AN ADULT WOMAN.
SHE WAS IT. FOURTEEN A FIFTEEN
BUT THE COMMUNITY IN WHICH I WAS
RAISED IN.
HAD A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
OBSTACLES WITH PEOPLE GROWING UP
YOUNG PEOPLE.
BUT I DON'T WANT YOU TO HEAR
SOMETHING A STORY ABOUT A YOUNG
MAN WHO I JUST MET HIM OFFICE
JUST THIS WEEK.
THIS YOUNG MAN [inaudible]
GREW UP.
WITHOUT A FATHER.
THIS YOUNG MAN GREW UP GETTING
INVOLVED IN GANGS AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE.
HANNA ROUGH AND TOUGH LIFE
GROWING UP.
HE DID SOMETHING HE WASN'T
SUPPOSED TO HAVE DONE.
AND HE WAS SENTENCED AS A
JUVENILE. TWO TWENTY THREE
YEARS.
WELL YOU KNOW WHAT HE DID IN
THOSE AND WHEN HE WAS
INCARCERATED.
HE TOLD ME HE READ THE ENTIRE
NEW TESTAMENT.
FRONT AND BACK.
HE ALSO TOLL ME THAT IT WAS
BECAUSE OF THE PEOPLE THAT WITH
IN AND THAT WAS WORKING WITH TO
THOSE INDIVIDUAL SAW SOMETHING
IN HIM THAT HE DID NOT SEE
WITHIN HIMSELF.
HE HAD A SECOND CHANCE ON LIFE.
SOME OF YOU IN THIS ROOM KNOW
ABOUT GRACE AND MERCY AND YOU
WOULD NOT BE HERE AFTER GRAYSON
MERCY WITH ALL YOUR LIFE.
AND WHAT THIS BILL TALKS ABOUT.
IS GIVEN IN APPLYING SOME GRACE
AND MERCY TO FOURTEEN AND
FIFTEEN YEARS OLD WHO HAVE MADE
MISTAKES IN THEIR LIVES.
WHO NOW HAVE A SECOND CHANCE TO
GET A [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WE'VE ALL MADE
MISTAKES SOME OF THOSE NEVER GOT
CAUGHT FOR THE MISTAKES WE'VE
MADE.
AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
GIVES THESE YOUNG PEOPLE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY YES.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
WAS SAYING IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
HIDEOUS CRIMES MURDERS AND
THINGS OF THAT NATURE NOT
UNDERSTAND THAT.
NO ONE UNDERSTANDS IT MORE THAN
I DO WHO LOST A CHILD.
BUT THESE INDIVIDUALS NONE OF
YOU ARE HERE.
WILL MAKE THE SAME MISTAKES THAT
YOU DID WHEN YOU WERE. FOURTEEN
AND FIFTEEN YEARS OF AGE.
AND SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY
IS A LOW THESE YOUNG PEOPLE TO
RUN A NEW STORY.
TROUT A NEW CHAPTER IN THEIR
LIVES GIVE THEM THAT OPPORTUNITY
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
IT RIGHT. TO COMMENT CONTACT TO
SEE SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN SEE
WITHIN HIMSELF THE SOMEBODY ELSE
ALL WITHIN SADDAM'S WITHOUT ONE
SIDE THEMSELVES.
IT'S SO THIS BILL REPRESENTS
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND THAT CHANCE
SO RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT ARE
VOTE.
ON THREE FORTY FOUR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM EUROPE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I DIDN'T
--
I TO RISE TO SPEAK.
IN FAVOR OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
ONE AND I WANT TO START BY
REJECTING [inaudible]
RESOUNDINGLY REJECTING THIS
NOTION THAT ANY.
PERSON WHO SITS ON THIS FLOOR
SOMEHOW DOES NOT CARE ABOUT
VICTIMS OF CRIME.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS
IT'S A CANARD AND IT HAS NO
APPLICABILITY HERE.
I'D ASK YOU INSTEAD TO THINK
ABOUT CHILDREN.
WHO HAVE IN FRONT OF THEM TO DO
WORSE [inaudible] ONE DOOR
[inaudible]
LEADS FROM A CHILDREN'S WORLD.
TO ADULT.
PRISON WORLD.
A COMPLETELY FOREIGN WORLD FOR
ANY OF THESE CHILDREN.
AND WE KNOW WHAT LIES DOWN THAT
PATH.
BECAUSE MIXING CHILDREN IN THAT
WORLD LEADS THEM. TO A LIFE IN
PRISON THAT WILL HAVE NO AND IN
THAT LEADS TO NO GOOD.
EVEN IF THEY GET OUT OF PRISON
BECAUSE IT WILL AFFECT THEM.
SO SO DEEP IN THEIR SOULS THE
OTHER DOOR LEADS TO A WORLD OF
POSSIBILITIES AND NOT EVERYBODY
WHO ENTERS THAT DOOR.
IS NECESSARILY GOING TO RESTORE
THEIR LIVES.
BUT I'D LIKE TO A A TELL YOU
ABOUT AN EXPERIENCE I HAD ONLY A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
WHEN I WENT --
TO VISIT THE INCIDENT COMMAND
CENTER FOR THE CAR FIRE.
A FIRE THAT THAT THAT DESTROYED
HOMES THAT HAS --
RESULTED IN TAOS AND THEY'RE AT
THE INCIDENT COMMAND CENTER.
WERE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO WERE
RESTORING THEIR LIVES WHO ARE
PRISON INMATES.
WHO WANT TO DO SOMETHING
PRODUCTIVE AND WANT TO RETURN TO
SOCIETY AND BE PRODUCTIVE HUMAN
BEINGS AND IN THIS FOR THOSE
YOUNG PEOPLE?
THAT THIS BILL IS SO IMPORTANT.
AND FOR THEM THAT I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SAW LIKE SO MANY I
HAD NOT INTENDED TO SPEAK I FELT
THAT.
MUCH OF THE MESSAGE WAS CLEAR.
UP WITH REGARDS TO IT BUT I JUST
WANNA SOMEHOW ANOTHER REMIND US
[inaudible]
THAT.
WE CAN NOT CONTINUE DOWN THE
SAME PATH THAT WE'VE GONE FOR
THE NUMBER OF YEARS.
I MEAN WE KNOW THAT IF WE
CONTINUE DO THE SAME THING THAT
WE'VE ALWAYS DONE WILL GET THE
SAME RESULTS.
NONE OF US CAN PROBABLY STANDING
SAY THAT THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN
FAIR.
HAS BEEN JUSTIN HAS BEEN
EFFECTIVE IN KEEPING US SAFE.
WE FEEL NO SAFER BY
INCARCERATING YOUNG PEOPLE AT
THE AGE OF FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN
OR NOT INCARCERATING HIM.
EIGHT FOURTEEN FIFTEEN WE CAN'T
SAY THAT WE FEEL COMFORTABLE IN
OUR HOMES THAT WE'VE DONE THE
RIGHT THING IN THIS SENSE.
WE'VE DONE NOTHING BUT BUILT AT
A PRISON SYSTEM INDUSTRIAL
COMPLEX IN TERMS OF OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM THAT MOST OF US
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF BUT WE HAVE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FOR LONGER
PERIODS OF TIME.
WE HAVE DESTROYED FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN WE'VE TAKEN AWAY THE
FOUNDATION OF SO MAD MANY HOME
SIMPLY BY INCARCERATION.
WE CONDEMN YOUNG PEOPLE EARLY IN
LIFE AND I CAN TELL YOU THAT
WHEN YOU DO THAT THERE IS NO
POSITIVE RESULT THE WEEK THAT
COMES OUT OF IT.
A PERSON IS BROKEN FOR MANY MANY
YEARS IF THEY EVER RECOVERED
THEMSELVES.
IN MY OTHER LIFE I USED TO SING
IN PRISONS.
AND I WENT TO LOTS OF PRISONS
EVERY SUNDAY AT DIRECTOR ACQUIRE
THAT WENT TO PRISONS WHERE
PRISON MINISTRY.
AND I HAVE THE UNFORTUNATE
PLEASURE OIL OR FORTUNATE IN
SOME SENSE TO MEET SOME YOUNG
PEOPLE WOULD BEEN INCARCERATED
FOR TEN FIFTEEN YEARS.
AND TO WATCH THEIR BEHAVIOR.
THE FACT THAT THEY HAD MISSED
OUT ON SO MUCH OF LIFE.
SMALL THINGS THEY WOULD
BASICALLY IMMATURE NO THINKING.
BUT ALSO HAD BEEN ABUSED
SIGNIFICANTLY IN THE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND IT WAS NOT A PRETTY PICTURE.
AND I REALIZE IS THAT SEVERAL OF
THEM THAT I SAW WHO WOULD IN A
FIFTEEN AND SIXTEEN AND NOW WE
KNOW THIRTIES.
THAT WAS THE TRAGEDY THAT WE
HAVE LOST A LIFE.
AND I FIRMLY BELIEVE IS A NATION
AND A STATE WE CAN DO BETTER.
WHEN HOUSING GOT A ONE TIME I
WOULD TO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT TO OBSERVE WHAT THEY
WERE DOING?
AND WAS REALLY QUITE INTERESTING
BECAUSE THEIR ASSUMPTION IN A
SOCIETY.
IS THAT WHEN THEIR CHILDREN DO
THINGS THAT ARE WRONG.
IT IS A DIRECT REFLECTION UPON
THE FAMILIES FROM WHICH THEY
COME.
AND THEY'VE BEEN BEGIN TO WORK
WITH THE FAMILY AND THE CHILD IN
THE JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
RESTORE THAT FAMILY AND RESTORE
THE CHILD BACK TO BEING A
PRODUCTIVE CITIZEN.
THEY DON'T INCARCERATE THEM AND
THROW THEM AWAY THAT SEVERAL THE
SOAPS FACILITIES IN OUR CROWD
THAT I VISITED.
AND IT WAS INTERESTING TO WATCH
THE YOUNG PEOPLE AS THEY BEGIN
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WAS MISSING
IN THE LIVES OF THE FAMILY WAS
MISSING IN THE LIVES OF OF THE
CHILDREN AND WHAT SKILLS WERE
DEVELOPED FOR THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE
AND TRYING TO RESTORE NOT JUST
THEM.
BUT RESTORE THEIR FAMILIES BACK
TO BEING [inaudible]
THEY BELIEVE THESE CHILDREN ARE
REALLY THE PRODUCT OF THEIR
FAMILIES AND IF THE TRUCK
TOGGLES ASTRAY THE MAYBE TO WORK
TO RESTORE THE FAMILY AND THE
CHILD.
I WAS MOST IMPRESSED WITH THAT
SYSTEM BECAUSE I SAW YOUNG
PEOPLE BEING RESTORED AND I SAW
FAMILIES BEING RESTORED AND I
SAW WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN A
CIVILIZED SOCIETY.
WE CAN AND WE MUST DO BETTER.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE DOWN THIS
PATH AND TO HAVE THE VICIOUS
IDEA THAT WE CAN JUST THROW
PEOPLE AWAY BECAUSE WE DON'T
CARE WE CARE ABOUT THE VICTIM WE
CARE ABOUT THAT THE PERSON WHO'S
PERPETRATED THE CRIME WAS NOW
GOING TO BE A VICTIM OF THE
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO WORK
HARD TO RESTORED TO GIVE OUR
CHILDREN WHAT THEY NEED.
AND WE CAN TALK ABOUT ALL THE
IMPACT WE TALK ABOUT ALL THE
ISSUES MOST OF THESE KIDS AND I
HAVE POOR LITERACY SKILLS WE'VE
DONE A POOR JOB IN EDUCATING
THEM IN OUR SCHOOLS.
WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW WHO IT
EITHER THEY'RE NOT AT SCHOOL ARE
THEY NOT COMING OR SOMETHING'S
GOING WRONG THEIR FAMILIES A
WORKING WITH POOR INCOME THEY
HAVE LIMITED RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN.
MANY OF THESE HOMES KIDS ARE
COMING FROM UNSTABLE
ENVIRONMENTS WITH IT BEING
EVICTED FROM HOUSE TO HOUSE AND
HAVE TO DO SOMETHING ELSE.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THESE ARE OUR
CHILDREN.
AND THEY A DIRECT PRODUCT OF
WHAT WE HAVE BUILT AS A SOCIETY
FOR OUR FAMILIES AND WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO TRY TO NEVER
GIVE UP ON THEM AND TO WORK TO
RESTORE THEM BACK TO FULL
CITIZENSHIP OF FULL
PARTICIPATION IN SOCIETY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU AYE
BOTH WITH THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
BECAUSE CLEARLY WE CAN AND WE
MUST DO BETTER THAN WE'VE DONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA MATTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES ON
MOTIVATED BUT AT THE SAME TIME
SOUND THAT WERE SPEAKING TO HALF
OF ROOM.
OF LEGISLATORS WHO ARE NOT HERE.
TO TAKE IN THE DEPTH OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
I'M ALSO YOU KNOW ONE IN THERE
JUST COMMEND OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
OCEANSIDE [inaudible] FOR
SPEAKING.
TRUTH TO POWER AS MY PREDECESSOR
WOULD SAY.
FROM COACHELLA.
HE HIT THE NAIL RIGHT ON THE
HEAD.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT [inaudible]
YOUNG CHILDREN [inaudible]
TALKING ABOUT.
CHILDREN WHOSE MINDS ARE
CONTINUING TO DEVELOP AS
RESEARCH.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN HAS
DEMONSTRATED.
THAT IT ISN'T UNTIL YOUR MID
TWENTIES.
BRAIN HAS FULLY DEVELOPED.
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
COGNITIVE NEED REASONABLE
[inaudible] TO MAKE
[inaudible]
THESE DECISIONS.
I GOTTA TELL YOU.
I'M HERE BECAUSE OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT I'VE
RECEIVED.
AS I'D LIKE TO MENTION THAT
THREE OR FOUR SECOND CHANCES.
THAT WERE HANDED TO ME. TO BE
ABLE TO TURN TO PAGE.
AND BE ABLE TO FULFILL.
THE GOALS AND ASPIRATIONS OF MY
PARENTS AND OF COURSE THOSE THAT
WE'VE SET FORWARD TO BE ABLE TO
BE.
PRODUCTIVE CITIZENS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND PROBABLY
REPRESENT.
OUR DISTRICT BUT THIS REALLY.
IS ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
DON'T GET.
IN ALL SHAKEN UP BY THE WILLIE
HORTON.
SCARE TACTICS THAT WE SEE THAT
BECAUSE WE BOTH. FOR PEOPLE AND
ARE CONSIDERATE ABOUT PEOPLE'S
LIVES IN THE IMPACTS ON THE LONG
TERM.
THAT THESE TYPES OF POLICIES
COULD HAVE OR NOT.
BY NOT SUPPORTING A BILL LIKE
THIS.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIFTEEN AND
SIXTEEN YEAR OLD WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT THEY SHOULD NOT BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
WE'RE JUST SAYING BUT THEY
SHOULD NOT BE TREATED LIKE
ADULTS.
AND PUT INTO A SYSTEM.
WHERE WE WILL SEE?
DETRIMENTAL AFFECTS.
AND ULTIMATELY SEE AN INDIVIDUAL
RETURNED BACK INTO THE
INSTITUTION.
AND THE FINAL OUTCOME OF THAT IS
SOMEONE WHO UNFORTUNATELY WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO INTEGRATE
THEMSELVES BACK INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND BE A PRODUCTIVE CITIZEN OF
OUR COMMUNITIES I'VE SEEN THAT
FIRST HAND [inaudible]
GROWING UP.
IN THE BODY HEALS OF PORCELLO
WHERE.
MY BEST FRIENDS WHO LIVED ACROSS
THE STREET THEIR MOTHER SOLD
HEROIN [inaudible]
A FATHER [inaudible]
DOMESTIC ABUSER.
NOW WHAT CHANCES DOES THAT YOUNG
PERSON HALF. TO BE ABLE.
TO GO ON A POSITIVE TRAJECTORY.
AND ULTIMATELY HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITIES THAT MANY OF US
HAVE HAD [inaudible]
UNFORTUNATELY.
THEY GOT NO LEG UP.
THOSE ARE THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT
MANY YOUNG PEOPLE OF COLOR.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA ARE
IMPACTED BY.
I HAVE A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD.
AND HIS MOTHER AND I HAVE CALL
PARENTED HIM FOR THE LAST
[inaudible] TEN YEARS.
AND CREDIT TO HER FOR THE WORK
THAT SHE'S DONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT BOY IS ON TRACK AND ON
POINT.
BUT I GOTTA TELL YOU I THINK
ABOUT HIM EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND I THINK BACK TO THE THINGS
THAT I GOT TO SEE AN EXPERIENCE
WHEN I WAS FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AND
I WOULD NEVER.
EVER WANT HIM TO BE PUT IN THOSE
TYPES OF PREDICAMENTS AND
BECAUSE MAYBE BEING AT THE WRONG
PLACE AT THE WRONG TIME.
HANGING OUT WITH SOMEONE. ONE
AFTERNOON AND SOMETHING TERRIBLY
GOES DOWN.
MY SON ALTHOUGH YOU SEEN HIM
HE'S A LITTLE TALLER THAN ME
HE'S GOT A BIGGER MUSTACHE THAN
HALF OF YOU HERE HE'S A LITTLE
KID.
SITTING IN FRONT OF THE VIDEO
GAMES.
DOING HIS HOMEWORK.
YEAH EVERY NOW AND THEN IS A
TEENAGER WHO KINDA GETS A LITTLE
SNAPPY HIM THERE BUT HE'S A
LITTLE BOY.
AND I CAN IMAGINE HIM BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE OR RESPONSIBLE FOR
INACTION WHERE HE'S TREATED LIKE
AN ADULT.
THAT'S NOT RIGHT.
AND SO THAT'S WITH HIS BILL IS
ABOUT.
IS GIVING PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
BUT DONE SO IN A WAY IN WHICH IT
WILL REGISTER IN THEIR MIND.
AND PERHAPS SAID AMONG THE
TRAJECTORY. TO BE PRODUCTIVE
CITIZENS OF OUR COMMUNITY THAT'S
WHY SUPPORT HIS BILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT ALL OF YOU
DO.
TOO THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK I WILL RETURN
TO MR CHIU FOR HIS CLOSING
BECAUSE THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND LET ME THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
ENGAGING IN THIS INCREDIBLY.
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION.
AND LET ME JUST TAKE A FEW
MOMENTS TO SEPARATE RHETORIC
FROM FACT --
TO OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
HUNTINGTON BEACH WHO ARE
SUGGESTING THAT ALL OF THESE
CHILDREN.
ARE MURDEROUS.
THAT SIMPLY IS NOT TRUE AS I
SAID IN MY OPENING.
YOU APAMA GROUNDS ARE YOU
OBJECTING --
YOU KNOW I MIGHT BUY ASSESSMENT
OF THIS BILL THE INCOME PISSED
MURDERERS WHO HAVEN'T BEFORE
DINNER FIFTEEN YEARS OLD AND IT
WAS JUST MIS CHARACTERIZED BY
THE AUTHOR QUE I DON'T SEE A
GROUNDS FOR OBJECTION THAT'S NOT
A POINT OF ORDER LET'S RETURN.
IS NOT WELL TAKEN WILL RETURN TO
MISTER TO THE RHETORIC THAT WAS
USED TO OPPOSE THIS BILL IS
SUGGESTING THAT MANY OF THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE MURDERS.
THAT IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE THREE
QUARTERS OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE.
HAVE NOT COMMITTED THE CRIME OF
HOMICIDE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BURGLARY ROBBERY AND ASSAULT. TO
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM ELSINORE WHO
SUGGESTING THAT SOMEHOW IF WE
SUPPORT THIS WE ARE NOT
SUPPORTING VICTIMS.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYONE IN
THIS CHAMBER WHO DOES NOT STAND
A 1000% FOR VICTIMS.
AND THE SUGGESTION THT SOMEHOW
VICTIMS.
ARE NOT GETTING THEIR FAIR DAY.
THE DIVISION OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
WHERE A FOURTEEN AND FIFTEEN
YEAR OLD WOULD GO IF THEY DON'T
GO TO ADULT PRISON IS PRESENT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUNG PEOPLE
WERE GONNA BE SPENDING MANY MANY
YEARS.
BEEN INCARCERATED BUT AT LEAST
THEY'RE BEING INCARCERATED IN
THE ENVIRONMENT WHERE THERE AGE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES TO ADDRESS
IT.
BULLETS TALK ABOUT FUTURE
VICTIMS IF THE GOAL OF THE
PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEM.
IS TO TRY TO BRING DOWN THE
NUMBER OF FUTURE VICTIMS THE
STATISTICS ARE CLEAR.
IF YOU'RE FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN
YEARS OLD AND YOU GO TO STATE
PRISON AND YOU DO YOUR TIME AND
YOU COME OUT YOU ARE MORE LIKELY
TO COMMIT CRIMES WE ARE LESS
SAFE.
I WANNA JOIN IN THANKING THE
COURAGE OF OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
OCEANSIDE. FOR YOUR PERSPECTIVE
YOU REFER TO YOURSELF AS SOMEONE
IN YOUR EARLIER DAYS AS A LITTLE
THOUGHT.
WHO MAY HAVE MADE SOME DECISIONS
YOU DID NOT WANT AND YET TODAY
YOU STAND HERE?
ON THE FLOOR OF THE STATE
ASSEMBLY.
THAT'S THE KIND OF SYSTEM THAT
WE WANT TO BUILD.
WE WANNA SEE FUTURE ROCKY CHAVEZ
SAYS HEAR HELPING US AS
POLICYMAKERS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SHARE AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM COACHELLA DID.
MY OWN PERSPECTIVE.
AS THE SON OF IMMIGRANTS I OFTEN
WONDERED AS I WAS GROWING UP IN
MY HIGH SCHOOL YEARS. THREE
SECONDS IS ALL TAT MADE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THAT
SEPARATED.
MY EXPERIENCE FOR MY FRIEND'S
EXPERIENCE.
SO MANY OF US CAN TELL THE
STORIES OF WHAT HAPPENED BUT FOR
THE GRACE OF GOD WHEN WE WERE
FOURTEEN OR FIFTEEN AND SOMEHOW.
WE GOT TO GO TO COLLEGE WE GOT
TO GO TO LAW SCHOOL WE GOT TO
BECOME LEGISLATORS AND OTHERS
DID NOT.
LET ME AND WITH A FEW QUESTIONS
I WANNA ASK EVERYONE TO THINK
ABOUT THIS IF YOU ARE NOT
DECIDED YET ON THIS BILL.
WHEN YOU WERE?
FOURTEEN WHEN YOU WERE FOURTEEN
DID YOU MAKE [inaudible]
EVERY DECISION.
THE SAME WAY YOU WOULD MAKE THAT
DECISION WHEN YOU'RE AN ADULT.
IF YOU HAVE A FOURTEEN YEAR OLD
SON OR DAUGHTER.
DO YOU THINK YOUR SON OR
DAUGHTER.
MAKES THE SAME DECISIONS THAT
YOU HOPE THAT THEY WOULD MAKE AS
AN ADULT.
IF THE ANSWER TO THOSE QUESTIONS
ARE NOW.
I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THINK YOU WITH THAT MADAM CORKY
MAY OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL AN ITEM TO SEVENTY
SEVEN S. B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ADEQUATE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY THREE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING AFFORD
AHEAD AND FILE ITEM IN FILE
ORDER TO ITEM.
THREE SIXTY S. B. AID NINETY
FIVE MADAM CLERK PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY FIVE BY
SENATOR NGUYEN AND OTHERS IN
THAT PLANE TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER KALRA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT S. B. EIGHT NINETY FIVE
TO REQUIRE THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION. TO DEVELOP
MODEL CURRICULA ON THE VERY
IMPORTANT TOPICS OF THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN REFUGEE
EXPERIENCE THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE AND LONG HISTORY AND
CULTURAL STUDIES.
IN MY CAPACITY AS REPRESENTATIVE
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN RESIDENTS IN
SAN JOSE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO
WITNESS THE RESILIENCE OF THE
VIETNAMESE REFUGEES WHO CAME
HERE AFTER THE VIETNAM WAR.
TORE APART A COUNTRY LEFT
FAMILIES TO FLEE FROM POLITICAL
PERSECUTION.
THE CAMARO ROUGE IS ONE OF THE
DEADLIEST PERIODS IN HISTORY
CURRENTLY GLOSSED OVER OFTEN IN
TEXTBOOKS.
LED BY POL POT THE CAMBODIAN
GENOCIDE WIPED OUT ANY
INDIVIDUAL DEEMED A POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
THE AMONG PEOPLE WHO COMPRISE AT
THE GROUP WITHOUT A NATION BUT
DISSENT FROM CHINA AND SOUTHEAST
ASIA.
BASED A MAJOR UPHEAVAL FOLLOWING
THE NORTH VIETNAMESE INVASION OF
LAOS DURING THE VIETNAM WAR.
IT WOULD TAKE DECADES FOR THE US
GOVERNMENT WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SECRET WAR ALLOWS AN HONOR THE
AMONG VETERANS WHO FOUGHT
ALONGSIDE AMERICAN VETERANS. TO
THE ATROCITIES OF WAR CAME TO
STORIES OF PEOPLE WHO PERSISTED
AND CHARTER THEIR WAY TO
AMERICAN SHORES. FOR A BETTER
LIFE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
LET US EDUCATE OUR CHILDREN
ABOUT THE REALITIES AND TRAUMA
PAST AND PRESENT OF ALL OF OUR
REFUGEE AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S NO WAY NO BETTER WAY TO
COMBAT.
THOSE HISTORICAL ATROCITIES AND
STRUGGLES AND TO OVERCOME THEM
WITH EDUCATION UNDERSTANDING AND
COMPASSION.
S. B. EIGHT NINETY FIVE IS A
MAJOR STEP FORWARD FOR THE
SOUTHEAST ASIAN COMMUNITY.
AND ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
CAUCUS AND I ARE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING THE WORK TO REPRESENT
LAOTIAN MEDIAN AND OTHER
SOUTHEAST ASIAN HISTORY IS IN
OUR CLASSROOMS AS WELL.
WE MUST MINDFULLY PRIORITIZE
ETHNIC STUDIES IN ORDER TO TELL
THE STORIES AND HISTORIES OF ALL
REFUGEES AND IMMIGRANTS THAT
COMPOSE.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
CERTAINLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE FIRST STEP
TOWARDS ACTUALLY REPRESENT THE
COURAGE STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE
OF THOSE WHO CALL AMERICA HOME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I BO.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR FULL
ATTENTION TO A SUMMER DALY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
KNOWLEDGE AND UNDERSTANDING OF
ONE'S HISTORY AND CULTURE IS AN
EMPOWERING TOOL.
IN THE ORANGE COUNTY AREA ALONE
THERE ARE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND RESIDENTS OF VIETNAMESE
CAMBODIAN AND MOM DESCENT.
MANY THOUSANDS RESIDE IN THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT.
THIS BILL WILL SERVE TO
HIGHLIGHT THE CHALLENGES AND
TRIUMPHS.
DESERVING CULTURAL AND ETHNIC
GROUPS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE I'M QUITE PROUD TODAY TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL.
EIGHT NINETY FIVE THE IDEA FOR
WANTING ME TO GET INVOLVED WITH
INCLUDING THE MOM HISTORY CAME
FROM THE MONK'S STORY FORTY
YEARS THAT WE HAVE AT THE BIG
FRESNO FAIR GROUNDS. FORTY YEARS
AGO THEY CAME HERE FROM THE
SECRET WAR AND CAME TO PLACES
LIKE FRESNO.
BUT WE WERE STARTING TO SEE THAT
THEIR HISTORY WAS BEING LOST.
THAT THEIR ABILITY TO PASSED
DOWN FROM ONE GENERATION TO THE
NEXT WHAT'S NOT HAPPENING AND
THEY TOOK IT UPON THEMSELVES. TO
STAND UP AND TO DOCUMENT THAT
HISTORY.
NOW HERE TODAY WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A MODEL
CURRICULUM THAT WE GET TO TEACH
TO FUTURE GENERATIONS ABOUT THE
SACRIFICES THAT THE VIETNAMESE.
AMONG AND THE LAOTIANS HAVE MADE
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND THEIR
IMMIGRATION HERE TO OUR GREAT
COUNTRY.
THIS IS A WONDERFUL MEASURE
PRESSED TO SUPPORT AND WANT TO
THANK THE SENATOR FOR BRING IN
THIS FORM.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY.
SOME MEMBER COOLEY RECOGNIZE.
COLLEAGUES I'M HONORED TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS I HAVE A
GRANDSON.
OF LONG HERITAGE.
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN TO
RECOGNIZE.
THEY GIVE THEM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB.
EIGHT NINETY FIVE AYE I THINK
THROUGH MANY CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE BY --
OUR OUR FAMILIES IN THE
SOUTHEAST ASIAN COMMUNITIES I IN
MY DISTRICT THAT HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS OF THAT
SERVE CAMBODIAN LAOTIAN --
VIETNAMESE AND FAMILIES FROM THE
MONK COMMUNITY AT WHO MAY
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO HOW
TO KEEP OUR KIDS SAFE IN SCHOOL
HOW TO EXPAND HEALTH PROGRAMS
AND MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
FITTING WAY TO SUPPORT OUR
STUDENTS --
WHO COME FROM SOUTHEAST ASIAN
BACKGROUND TO LEARN?
FROM THE EXPERIENCES OF THOSE
AND TO SEE HOW THAT ALL OF OUR
EXPERIENCES ARE CONNECTED HOW WE
OVERCOME STRUGGLE BY WORKING
TOGETHER IN UNITY OF THIS IS A
GREAT STEP FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU A MODEM SPEAKER SAM
MEMBER I RIGHTS IN SUPPORT OF
SB.
EIGHT NINETY FIVE AND THANK
SENATOR WIN FOR INTRODUCING THIS
VERY IMPORTANT MEASURES. FOR
MANY OF MY CONSTITUENTS IN THIS
IN THE DISTRICT.
HE'S TRAGEDY EVENTS THIS TRAGIC
EVENT IN THE HISTORY WERE
ACTUALLY REAL REAL LIFE
EXPERIENCES FOR THEM.
THEY LIVED THROUGH THEM THEY
SUFFER.
AND THEY SURVIVE.
AND NOW THEY'RE HERE TO IMPROVE
THEIR LIFE AND THE LIFE OF BUT
BUILT DEADLIER LUFF WANTS.
AND THEY ARE THE LUCKY ONES.
MANY VIETNAMESE BOAT PEOPLE DID
NOT SURVIVE TO JOURNEY.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL TO
ENSURE DEAD TO FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
WELL UNDERSTAND THE PAST AND
LEARN FROM IT.
THERE'S ALSO GOOD FOR OUR
CHILDREN TO UNDERSTAND.
DUBBED THE PRICE OF FREEDOM DOES
NOT COME CHEAP.
I URGE YOUR BIBLE.
THINK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER.
I'M SORRY GOING TO THE CORNER OF
THE ROOM A SOME EVER PATTERSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'VE GOT --
JOINT AND ASK EVERYONE TO
SUPPORT THIS IS WELL THERE ARE.
OFTEN TIMES WHEN WE CAN COME TO
THIS FLOOR.
AND SAY UP.
GREEN BUTTON THAT I PUSH HAS
SOMETHING TO DO.
DEEPLY WITH ME MY FAMILY MY
CHILDREN.
MANY OF YOU KNOW THE STORY BJ'S
ART MY OLDEST SON OF VIETNAMESE
HE CAME ON THE BABY LEFT UP IN
BY THE SEA FIVE DAYS THAT.
PRESIDENT FORD.
SENT OVER --
HE IS OUT OF PLUMBER
[inaudible]
CONTRACTOR.
SUCCESSFUL HE IS ARE ONE OF MY
STAUNCHEST SUPPORTERS AND ARDENT
CRITICS.
THAT SOMETIMES OUR KIDS ARE.
I PUSH THE GREEN BUTTON TODAY ON
BEHALF OF BJ PATTERSON
[inaudible]
A VIETNAMESE.
BUT ASEAN'S REPEATEDLY REMIND
ME.
SAYS THAT I'M FROM VIETNAM.
OUR BUT I'M A 100% AMERICAN.
AND I'M A 100% PATTERSON.
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY REALLY
SOMETHING SPECIAL TO CELEBRATE I
PUSH THE GREEN BUTTON FOR BJ
TODAY AND ALL THE PRE BJ'S THAT
ARE IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY ALL DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
HAVING SEES WILL RETURN TO A
SUMMER KALRA FOR CLOSE INCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
INSIGHT AND FOR THEIR SUPPORT
AND THANKS TO SENATOR WHEN FOR
OFFERING.
THIS BILL SPEC WE ASK FOR MY
BOAT.
THANK YOU WITHOUT MADAM CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
META CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE MOVING NOW ITEM THREE
FORTY EIGHT S. B..
FOURTEEN FORTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SEVERAL FOURTEEN FORTY BY
SENATOR HUESO ACT AND ENERGY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SP
FOURTEEN FORTY OF WHICH I AM A
PROUD CO AUTHOR WHICH SEEKS TO
PROVIDE A PATHWAY. FOR THE D.
CARBONIZATION OF OUR NATURAL GAS
SYSTEM AND FOR THE STATE TO MEET
THE ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION AND
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
GOALS ESTABLISHED UNDER S. B..
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE LARA IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE CPUC IN
CONSULTATION WITH PIERRE BE TO
CONSIDER ADOPTING SPECIFIC BIO
METHANE PROCUREMENT TARGETS OR
GOALS FOR EACH GAS CORPORATION.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE TARGETS
OR GOALS TO BE COST EFFECTIVE
THE BIO METHOD TO BE INJECTED
INTO PIPELINES IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE CAPTURE OR PRODUCTION OF THE
BIO MAT THING TO DIRECTLY WITH
THE RESULT IN ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO FURTHER
DEVELOP A PATHWAY FOR RENEWABLE
BY A METHANE TO BE INJECTED INTO
THE GAS PIPELINE SYSTEM THEREBY
DISPLACING FOSSIL GAS AND
RESULTING IN A REDUCTION IN THE
CARBON INTENSITY AND OUR CAP A
NATURAL GAS SYSTEM.
S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
IS SUPPORTED BY OVER FOURTEEN
ENTITIES INCLUDING UTILITIES
ORGANIZED LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL
NONPROFITS WASTE COMPANIES AND
SANITATION AGENCIES.
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS HAVE
REMOVED ALL ENVIRONMENTAL AND
RATE PAYER OPPOSITION THE SIERRA
CLUB IN OUR D. C. UNIT FOR
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS EARTH --
JUSTICE AND OTHERS HAVE REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION FOR ALL THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT.
THANK YOU SEEN OF REQUEST TO
SPEAK MATTER PURPOSE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MISTER GRAYSON MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING OUT OF
FILE ORDER TO ITEM THREE FIFTEEN
S. B. TENDO FOR MADAM CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SEVERAL TEN OF FOUR BY SENATOR
WIENER ACTUALLY MENTAL MENTAL
HEALTH THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TAKING UP S. B.. ONE
THOUSAND FOUR ARISE TODAY'S
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR.
S. B. ONE THOUSAND FOR SEEKS TO
STANDARDIZE AND STRENGTHEN
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION TREATMENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA BY ESTABLISHING
STRATEGIC PRIORITIES. FOR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
FUNDED PROGRAMS.
PROP.
SIXTY THREE THE PROP SIXTY THREE
OF INITIATIVE MANDATES THAT
COUNTIES MUST SET ASIDE 20% OF
FUNDS YOU PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SERVICES TO STOP
THE CYCLE OF UNTREATED MENTAL
ILLNESS.
THESE PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION FUNDS ARE CRUCIAL.
REAL CHANGE COMES WHEN WE FOCUS
MORE RESOURCES ON INTERVENING AT
STAGE ONE BEFORE PEOPLE'S LIVES
SPIRAL OUT OF CONTROL.
THERE'S FAR MORE WE COULD BE
DOING TO ENSURE THAT.
THE MONEY CALIFORNIA SPENDS ON
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS NEARLY
HALF A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
HAS A MEASURABLE IMPACT.
HOWEVER THERE ARE CURRENTLY
GLARING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
GAPS ACROSS CALIFORNIA WAS SOME
COUNTIES HAVING COMPREHENSIVE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS.
WHILE OTHERS DO NOT.
S. B. ONE THOUSAND FOUR
ESTABLISH IS A STATEWIDE
STRATEGY FOR THE PREVENTION AND
EARLY INTERVENTION FUNDS
COUNTIES RECEIVE EACH YEAR WHILE
IMPROVING REPORTING DATA.
BY DEFINING WHAT AFFECTED
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION PROGRAMS LOOK LIKE
WE WILL BE ABLE TO CLOSE THE
GAPS IN ACCESS.
EQUALITY THAT PERSIST AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
S. B. ONE THOUSAND FOUR HAS
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES AND I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER KILEY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AS A CO
AUTHOR OF THE SITE MEASURE I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR IMPROVING
THE DELIVERY OF MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA.
OVER TWO POINT TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS.
AYE AND BUT OVER HALF REPORT
THAT THEY DO NOT RECEIVE ANY
TREATMENT FOR A PRIMARY CARE
DOCTOR OR A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL.
THAT'S OVER A MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE NOT GETTING
THE HELP THAT THEY NEED.
AND WE ALL KNOW HOW TRAGIC THE
CONSEQUENCES OF UNTREATED MENTAL
ILLNESS CAN BE.
FROM HOMELESSNESS TO DROPPING
OUT OF SCHOOL TO UNEMPLOYMENT TO
IMPRISONMENT.
NOW IN ONE WAY OR STATE'S
RESPONSE TO THE SCALE OF THIS
PROBLEM AYE HAS BEEN CLEAR AND
THAT IS TO PROVIDE A LOT MORE
FUNDING.
I OVER THE LAST DECADE WE'VE
SEEN BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN NEW TAXES GOING TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
BUT IN THE WAY THAT REALLY
MATTERS OUR RESPONSE HAS BEEN
ALTOGETHER INADEQUATE.
AS REPORT AFTER REPORT FROM THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION AND THE
STATE AUDITOR HAVE SHOWN AND
WHAT SOUNDED THE ALARM ABOUT THE
QUESTIONABLE RESULTS WERE
GETTING FOR ALL OF THE SPEND.
THIS BILL IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IT PRIORITISES MENTAL HEALTH
ACCESS FOR KIDS AND TEENS.
WE KNOW THAT 50% OF ALL LIFE
TIME PIECES OF MIT MENTAL
ILLNESS BEGIN BY THE AGE OF
FOURTEEN WE ALSO KNOW THAT
SUICIDE IS THE THIRD LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH.
IN USED AGES.
TEN TO TWENTY FOUR THIS BILL
HELPS TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE BY
PROVIDING MORE GUIDANCE TO
COUNTIES ON HOW BEST PRIORITIZE
PREVENTION INTERVENTION FUNDING
PROVIDED BY THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT.
IT REQUIRES THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION TO
INCLUDE CHILDHOOD TRAUMA
INTERVENTION EARLY PSYCHOSIS
DETECTION SUICIDE PREVENTION AND
COLLEGE MENTAL HEALTH PROGRAMS
IN A STATEWIDE STRATEGY FOR
COUNTIES TO FOLLOW.
THERE IS STILL MUCH MUCH MORE
THAT WE NEED TO DO BUT THIS BILL
IS AN IMPORTANT STAFF AND I URGE
AND I BET.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARAMBULA THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS.
I RISE AS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
SENATE BILL ONE THOUSAND AND
FOUR I BELIEVE THAT DRAMA
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION IS CRUCIAL FOR THE
MENTAL HEALTH.
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE AND OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND USING OR MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDING FOR THIS IN
EACH COUNTY WOULD ALLOW US TO
CLOSE CLICK GAPS IN TREATMENT
AND ACCESS THAT WE ARE SEEING
ACROSS THE STATE.
BOLSTERING PREVENTATIVE CARE IS
AN EFFECTIVE USE OF OUR STATE
FUNDING AND IS FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE IT ALLOWS US
TO INVEST IN LESS EXPENSIVE
DETECTION.
AND INTERVENTION EARLY ON SO
THAT WE DO NOT FACE COSTLY
EXPENSES FOR LATE TREATMENT OF
AVOIDABLE CAUSES.
THEREFORE I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
FOR SENATE BILL ONE THOUSAND AND
FOUR THINK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
REQUEST TO SPEAK I WILL RETURN
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER MULLIN FOR
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS.
I THANK I THANK MY COLLEAGUES
FOR THEIR WORDS PLOTS SENATOR
WIENER FOR HIS WORK ON THIS
ISSUE AS WELL AS OF THE FORMER
SENATE PRESIDENT PRO TEM DARRELL
STEINBERG FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
AND PROUD TO WELL BE A CO AUTHOR
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CORP IS OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES
MEMBERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE REQUIRED WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS IT WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
CONCURRENCE ITEMS TO ALLOW
SPEAKER MULLIN TO TAKE UP HIS
BILLS.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM.
NUMBER.
TWENTY TWO AB SIX OH FIVE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIX OH FIVE BY SOME
MEMORABLE OF ANOTHER'S AN
ACCOLADE CARE FACILITIES THANK
YOU SO MEMBER MULLIN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
AND MEMBERS AB SIX OH FIVE
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO DEVELOP A SINGLE LICENSE FOR
CHILDCARE CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA
SERVING CHILDREN FROM BIRTH UP
TO THIRTEEN YEARS OF AGE.
THE CURRENT MULTI LICENSE SYSTEM
IS ADMINISTRATIVELY BURDENSOME
TO CHILDCARE FACILITY OPERATORS
IN A STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT WE
SERVE FAR FEWER INFANTS THAN PRE
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN ACROSS THE
STATE.
CALIFORNIA ORIGINALLY CREATED
THIS MULTI LICENSE STRUCTURE IN
AN ATTEMPT TO PROTECT CHILDREN
AND FOR THAT REASON AB SIX OH
FIVE REQUIRES THAT WE MAINTAIN
THE HIGHEST SAFETY STANDARDS.
WHILE SIMPLIFYING THE SYSTEM I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENT.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER QUICKLY IS OPEN
THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES I SIXTY ONE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM THIRTY
FOUR AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX TO
QUICKLY THREE SO MIDDLE TWENTY
SIX TWENTY SIX BY SOME MEMBER OF
ALL MULLIN AND OTHERS AND I
BELIEVE CHAO CARE SERVICES SOME
EVER MULLIN.
THEY WERE GIVEN MADAM SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS TODAY THERE ARE A
TOTAL OF THIRTEEN COUNTIES
AFFORDED FLEXIBILITY IS AND
EXCEPTIONS.
STATEWIDE REQUIREMENTS FOR
FAMILIES LIVING IN RECEIVING
CHILDCARE SERVICES.
IN THOSE COUNTIES UNFORTUNATELY
THOSE EXCEPTIONS HAVE CREATED
INEQUITIES AMONGST THOSE
PROVIDING AND RECEIVING
CHILDCARE SERVICES BETWEEN
COUNTIES.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX MAKES A
NUMBER OF STATEWIDE CHANGES TO
SUBSIDIZE CHILDCARE AND
CALIFORNIA'S THE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
BETTER SERVE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES IN EVERY COUNTY IN OUR
STATE.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE AFTER BIPARTISAN
PAT A PASSAGE IN THE SENATE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE THANK YOU
SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER
QUICK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY NINE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE NOW MOVING TO ITEM.
SIXTY THREE AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
TWO MISTER CORPORATE.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY TWO BY SOMEONE REMOTE OF
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE HOUSING
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MULLIN.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO
ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT TO ADJUST INTEREST
RATES ON LOANS COUPLED WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
UTILIZING FEDERAL LOW INCOME
HOUSING TAX CREDITS WHEN NEEDED
TO MAKE PROJECTS FEASIBLE.
THE BILL SEEKS TO MAKE IT EASIER
FOR DEVELOPERS TO BUILD THAT
REHABILITATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MR ON MOVES A CALL
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY THREE AB TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY FIVE
BYSOME MEMBER MULLIN
AGGRAVATING LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THANK YOU SO MEMBER MULLIN.
AND FINALLY MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE CLARIFIES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITY
LOFT THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO SPECIFY.
THAT ED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AUTHORITY CAN USE FUNDS FOR THE
REHABILITATION EXPANSION OR
CONSTRUCTION OF EMERGENCY
SHELTERS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING. FOR THE
HOMELESS SENATE AMENDMENTS ALSO
ALLOWING AUTHORITY TO FINANCE
WATER SEWER OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
THIS MISTER MULLIN MOVES A CALL
WE ARE MOVING. TO OUR
CONCURRENCE FILE WE'RE STARTING
WITH ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB
TWENTY TWO TEN MISTER CORPORATE
GREED.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO TEN BY
SOME WE WERE MCCARTY IMMACULATE
PUBLIC POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY YOU RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THIS MEASURE IS OF
COURSE BACK ON CONCURRENT FROM
THE SENATE THIS IS THAT MEASURE
TO HELP OUR REFUGEE STUDENTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
INTEGRATE IN A ROLE IN THE ROLE
IN OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ASKING
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAKE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY ONE AT NO
.
ZERO MOVING A ITEM TWELVE IS
PASS AND RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM
THIRTEEN AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
TWO MISTER QUICK THREE SO ME
ROLL TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO BY
SOME [inaudible]
GLORIA ANOTHER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
PLEASE RESENT AB THIRTY TWO
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY TWO ALSO
KNOWN AS CALIFORNIA'S
SUSTAINABLE ON HOW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACT WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE SAID AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE FLOOR AREA RATIO.
ABOUT BASS BONUS IN THE BILL
DOES NOT SUPERSEDE OR PREEMPTS
SO FAR BONUSES THERE ARE IN
EXISTENCE ARE THOSE THAT ARE
ADOPTED DIFFERENTLY.
ADDITIONAL SENTIMENTS ARE
CLARIFYING IN NATURE THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
NOR DEBATE MISTER CLARK PLEASE
OPEN THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTES AYE SIXTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LOOK
THE CALL ON ITEM SIXTY THREE AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO MISTER
CORE PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE
MISTER QUIRK YOU MAY CLOSE.
THE ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FORTY SEVEN KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MOVING TO ITEM
ONE EIGHTY THREE EIGHT BE TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE I ON LIFTING THE
CALL MISTER CLERK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW.
I DON'T FOURTEEN IS PASS AND
RETAIN MOVING TO ITEM FIFTEEN A.
B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT MISTER
CORPORATE.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
CUNNINGHAM ACCOLADE PEOPLE
INSTRUCTION THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY EIGHT IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE IT IS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
AND IT PROTECTS CHILDREN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUIRK MAY OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE OUR ON
TELLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
ITEM SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN PASS
AND RETAIN A MOVING TO ITEM
EIGHTEEN AB.
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE MR COR
PLEASE READ SO MIDDLE TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLOOR ANOTHER
SNACK LATER VEHICLES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
YOUR RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTY NINE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WILL PROVIDE CLARITY.
NEEDED TO BETTER REGULATE.
IN THE EMERGING MOTOR SCOOTER
RIGHT TECHNOLOGY AB TWENTY
NINETY NINE RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES AND
RESPECT LAST RIVAL.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST I DO
SEE REQUEST TO SPEAK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PEROT YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
QUESTION THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WELL I WONDER IF THIS IS THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FIRST BILL.
NO IT ISN'T [inaudible]
OKAY.
ON MY OWN TIME I JUST I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL.
AND A WONDER IT WHAT MAKES YOU
AN EXPERT IN MOTORIZED SCOOTERS.
WELL ALLOW HIM TO ANSWER IT IS
CLOSE.
THANK YOU LOOK I LOOK FORWARD TO
THAT RESPONSE IN YOUR CLOTHES.
OKAY MISTER FLORA.
ENLIGHTEN US IN LIGHTNESS WELL
IT WILL JUST GO WITH IT'S THE AN
AGE GAP YOU KNOW THE GUYS OF MY
AGE CAN YOU KNOW CATEGORY WE
TEND TO BE MORE PROGRESSIVE AND
HOW WE TRAVEL.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW OUR COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO GET TO AND FROM
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO WHILE
LEAVING THEIR VEHICLES PARKED IN
THE GARAGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL.
THANK YOU WITH THAT.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELE THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
HER CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL ON ITEM THREE FORTY
EIGHT S. B. FOURTEEN FORTY
MISTER CLARK PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. TO CORKY MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY ONE KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO A BACK IT IN FILE
WATERTIGHT IN NINETEEN AB THIRTY
THIRTY TWO MISTER QUICKLY ST.
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY THIRTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER AN
ACCOLADE MATERNAL HEALTH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRAZIER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS A.
B. THIRTY THIRTY TWOS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE HOSPITALS WITH THE
PERINATAL UNIT TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A PROGRAM. TO EDUCATE
MOTHERS AND HOSPITAL STAFF ABOUT
CARMEN MATERNAL MEANT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES INCLUDING.
POSTPARTUM DEPRESSION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS GIVE HOSPITALS
FLEXIBILITYIN IMPLEMENTING THE
PROGRAM I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE FOR MOTHERS AND
CHILDREN.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN OF
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWENTY AB
SIXTY MISTER CORPORATE THREE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY BY SOME
WOMEN WERE SANTIAGO ACCOLADE
SHALL CARE AND DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU AND SPEAKER AB SIXTY
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THAT
HELPS FAMILIES TRANSITION OF THE
CAL WORKS PROGRAM --
CHILDCARE STAGES.
I THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
HAD RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
EXPECT THAT'S WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE RAW.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
IT'S A QUICKLY CLOSER UNTIL HE
DEVOTES SIXTY SIX I KNOW ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE.
OUR CONCLUDE IN MOVING TO ITEM
TWENTY ONE AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SEVENTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK SILVA
ACCOLADE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT
THANK YOU SO MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
FELLOW MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO SIMPLY
REQUIRES THAT PEACE OFFICERS
COMPLETE A REFRESHER TRAINING ON
RACIAL PROFILING AND IMPLICIT
BIAS.
ANNUALLY RATHER THAN EVERY FIVE
YEARS.
MATTERS OF PREJUDICE AND BIAS
HAVE THAT PERFECTED COMMUNITY
RELATIONS ACROSS THE STATE AND
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE CONFRONT
THESE ISSUES AND TRAIN OUR
OFFICERS. FOR THAT REASON THIS
BILL WAS SPONSORED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE ORANGE
COUNTY SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND
ENJOYS THE SUPPORT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE LAW
ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION.
AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO HAS RECEIVED
NO OPPOSITION AND PASSED THE
SENATE WITHOUT ANY NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER QUIRK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM TWENTY THREE A.
B. FIFTEEN ELEVEN MISTER
QUICKLY.
THREE SOME PEOPLE FIFTEEN ELEVEN
BY SOME ALONE OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
SENSING THE CLARITY OF SIERRA
PACIFIC MEDIUM.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MENACING
REMEMBERS AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER CORPS PLEASE OPEN AROUND
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE THE
MEASURE PASSES.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM TWENTY FOUR
A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO ESTHER
QUICKLY STREET.
SUMMIT ROW EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AND
OTHERS ARE NOT RELATED CRIMES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL WILL HAVE
COME HOPE COMBAT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BY MAKING IT A
FELONY TO CONTACT A MINOR.
OVER THE INTERNET WITH INTENT TO
COMMIT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
SIMPLY ADDED CO AUTHORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ON MEMBERS BOTH DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
NEXT IS ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO MISTER
QUICKLY STREET ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULDN'T ACCOLADE
TO EDUCATION FINANCE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD THINK
AMEND SPEAKER AB NINETEEN SIXTY
TWO IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
AFTER AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN IN
THE SENT TO THE LAKE THE SENATE
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION.
BILL HAS REALLY RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE HIS ARE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY NINE NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
NEXUS ITEM TWENTY SIX A. B.
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY WILL
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR BY SOME
MEMBERS CERVANTES ANOTHER TO
NATALIE SEX.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKERMEMBERS STAMP
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR FOR
CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS THIS BILL SEEKS TO
PROVIDE CLEAR ACCURATE AND
TRANSPARENT INFORMATION. TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE PUBLIC WITH.
NOTICE ABOUT PRESENCE OF A SEX
OFFENDER IN THEIR COMMUNITY AB
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR WILL CLOSE
A LOOPHOLE AND PROVIDE PUBLIC
SAFETY WITH --
MORE TOOLS TO TRACK REGISTERED
SEX OFFENDERS THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY OUR ATTORNEY
GENERAL HAVE YOUR PESETA AND THE
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
SIMPLY OUT CO AUTHORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS WHO.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND HOW THE VOTES I SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
NEXUS ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY FIFTEEN MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN BY SOME MEMORY AS AN
ACCOLADE PUPIL INSTRUCTION THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISE YOUR
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY AB.
TWENTY FIFTEEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WHICH WOULD REQUIRE
STOOD SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO OFFER
PROPER INSTRUCTION ON THE
COMPLETION OF THE FAB SO AND
DREAM ACT APPLICATIONS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS OUR TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING THIS BILL IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE THAT
AIMS TO PROMOTE.
COLLEGE READINESS AND AWARENESS
BY ENSURING THAT OUR STUDENTS
KNOW ABOUT THE RESOURCES
AVAILABLE THAT CAN HELP FUND AND
FURTHER THEIR EDUCATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER FOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES ICE FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS NINE OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING OUT ITEM TWENTY EIGHT E.
BE TWENTY AND SIXTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIXTY FOUR
BY SOME REMEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO WATER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIXTY FOUR
WHICH IS BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE --
SENATE AMENDMENTS ADD ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES THAT
WILL ENSURE THE PROTECTION OF
THE INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT GRANT FUNDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
.
PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE.
UNTIL A THE VOTES I SEVENTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN MEMBERS I AM.
I AM PREPARED TO LOOK THE CALL
IN ITEM TO SIXTY ONE S. B.
[inaudible] ELEVEN FIFTY SIX
THE COURT PLEASE POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY FOUR KNOWS.
NINETEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK AND
FILE ORDER TO ITEM TWENTY NINE
AB.
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOUR THE CLERK
PLEASE READ SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
TO THIRTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
JONES SAWYER AND ACT LIKE A
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SENATE EVER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY FOURTH BACK
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENT
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
OUR TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING THE
NATURE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IAGO.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE COOKBOOK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
LIVING TO ITEM THIRTY AB.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE MR CLERK
PLEASE READ SO WE WILL TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE BY SOME WE WERE
MARK STONE ANOTHER SNACK LATER
POLLINATORS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
STONE.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THIS BILL IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ACT
CLARIFICATIONS THAT WERE ASKED
FOR BY THE FARM BUREAU AND%
WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD.
I ASK FOR CONCURRENT.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
HOME MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE RULE.
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FIFTY
SEVEN NO SIX THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW. TO ITEM THIRTY ONE
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSUME IT'LL
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER KALRA NAPOLI HOME CARE
SERVICES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY FIVE THE
SENATE EMPHASIZED THE OPT OUT
METHOD FOR HOME CARE IS BE A
SIMPLE PROCEDURE AND STRIKE UP
THE STATUS THE BACK ON
EXAMINATION.
ON THE EXISTING WEBSITE REGISTRY
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE HAS REMOVED
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE IS CRITICAL
TO THE HOME CARE A WORKFORCE IS
PRIMARILY COMPOSED OF WOMEN
WORKING ISOLATED SETTINGS AND
ACCESS TO TRAINING AND SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THERE ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
THREE NO TWENTY TWO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY TO AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR NINETY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU
AND ACT LIKE A VITAL RECORDS
SENATE MEMBER TROOP.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY
WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR A
HOMELESS INDIVIDUAL TO GET A
BIRTH CERTIFICATE AND THUS
REDUCE BARRIERS TO RECEIVING
IDENTIFICATION DOCUMENTS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS LIMIT THE
NUMBER OF REQUESTS FOR A FREE
BIRTH CERTIFICATE THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL MAY MAKE TWO THREE IN
A YEAR.
THE BILL CONTINUES TO HAVE NO
OPPOSITION HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY
NO VOTES AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR THE UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH THE SENATE.
AND ASSEMBLY FLOOR ASK YOU TO
VOTE FOR ONE LAST TIME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE NOW ON ITEM THIRTY FIVE AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SO MIDDLE TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
TWO BY SOMEWHERE MEDINA AND
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE IT SHOULD
FINANCIALLY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
WE GET THE RIGHT PANAMANIAN
BROTHER.
PRESENT --
AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY TWO WHICH
IS COMING BACK FROM CONCURRENCE
ON AMENDMENTS MADE IN THE
SENATE.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
IN NATURE.
THE BILL HAS RECEIVED STRONG
PARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES FOR
OPPOSITION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK TO QUIRK WAS OPEN THE ROLE
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLL
INTELLIGIBLE ITS AYE SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT IN.
MOVING NOW BACK ON FILE ORDER TO
ITEM THIRTY THREE AB TWENTY FIVE
FOURTEEN MISTER CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
FOURTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN
AND OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THURMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
CONTINUING THE MOMENTUM OF THE
PANAMANIAN CAUCUS.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE FOURTEEN WHICH IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS PROGRAM WOULD PROVIDE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH GRANTS TO
ESTABLISH AND EXPAND DUAL
LANGUAGE IMMERSION PROGRAMS
DEVELOPMENTAL BILINGUAL PROGRAMS
FOR ENGLISH LEARNERS IN EARLY
LEARNING TOOL LANGUAGE LEARNER
PROGRAMS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE
SIXTY ONE NO SIX THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
MOVING TO ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY ONE BY SOME LIBERAL
MARK STONE ACCLIMATE LIKELY TO
AGRICULTURAL LABOR RELATIONS.
SOME MEMBERS STONE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TAKE YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY ONE IS TO ADDRESS
THE LAYS ONCE AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS HAVE AGREED TO UNIONIZE.
AND YET THE GROWERS THAT THE
FOLKS THAT THEY'RE WORKING WITH
REFUSED TO HONOR THAT CONTRACT
FOR BARGAIN IN GOOD FAITH THIS
IS BUT AN ISSUE GOING BACK.
TO NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE WHEN A
GROUP OF STRAWBERRY WORKERS OR
TOMATO WORKERS RATHER ORGANIZED.
ALE ARE BE RULED ON IT AND
DEMANDED THE CONTRACT AND THAT
CONTRACT WAS BASICALLY IGNORED
FOR DECADES BEING THE WORKERS
DID NOT GET THE BENEFIT OF THEIR
BARGAIN.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT PUTS
INTO PLACE SOME STRUCTURE AND I
FEEL ARE BE TO ISSUE AN ORDER
WITHIN ONE YEAR AND SET SPECIFIC
TIME LINES SO THAT THE WORKERS
CAN GET THE BENEFIT AND AND
ULTIMATELY BE PAID UNDER THE
WAGE ORDERS?
THAT AIR ALE ARE BE.
ORDERS IN THESE KINDS OF CASES
THEN THE WORK OF UFW WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION OVER
THIS LAST YEAR A. B..
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE
REPRESENTS THAT AGREEMENT AND I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
WHICH IS CONCURRENCE IN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS WHICH REFLECT
THE DEAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEN NO DISCUSSION OF
MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
SOME NEVER STONE MOVES A CALL.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT
KERKORIAN.
SO WE WILL TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
EIGHT BY SO WE WERE MAIENSCHEIN
AND OTHERS NATALIE TO HEALTH
FACILITIES THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SEVEN NINETY EIGHT WAS
AMENDED IN THE SENATE IT IS BACK
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN OUR REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY DEVOTES I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
AB TWENTY EIGHTH THIRTEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER AROUND
SNACK RELATE TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
Q. MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN
THAT WOULD CODIFY VERBATIM THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT
CREATED THE CALIFORNIA
CYBERSECURITY.
INTEGRATION CENTER.
OKAY A SUCH AS THE AS THE MEMBER
OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MA'AM SPEAKER RISES A
PROUD JOINT AUTHOR OF THE V.
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTEEN THIS WILL.
HELP MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA'S
LEADERSHIP AND CYBERSECURITY
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET THIS
DONE FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS NOW
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IT'S A MEMBER IRWIN DO
YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I THINK YOU
WITHOUT MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE YOU
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON ITEM THIRTY NINE AND FORTY WE
WILL PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM [inaudible]
FORTY ONE THE MINUTE
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON ITEM.
FORTY ONE MOVING OUT ITEM FORTY
TWO EACH A A B. THREE FORTY NINE
MISTER QUICK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE THREE FORTY NINE BY
SOME WEAVER MCCARTY AN ACCOLADE
TO MEDI CAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIS IS
ONE OF OUR BILLS THIS YEAR
RELATE TO THE OPIOID EPIDEMIC IN
CREATING SOME REMEDIES TO
ADDRESS THEISSUE IN CALIFORNIA
IT WOULD STREAMLINED THE RATE
SETTING PROCESS. FOR THE DRUG
MEDI CAL PROGRAMS FOR THE
MEDICALLY MEDICATION ASSISTED
TREATMENT.
AND ALLOW OUR OUR CENTERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO EXPAND
SERVICE AND DRUG REHABS REJECT
REHAB.
CENTERS THANKS.
THANK YOU IS SEEING THAT NO
REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER CLERK
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM FORTY
THREE AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THREE MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE NINETY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO AIR
AMBULANCE SERVICES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON.
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL IS
CRUCIAL TO ENSURE EMERGENCY AIR
AMBULANCES CAN CONTINUE
PROVIDING LIFESAVING SERVICES.
TO RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THESE THEIR AMBULANCES
HAVE PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN
DISASTER RESPONSE.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE WILL
BRING UP THE MEDI CAL RATE FOR
THOSE PROVIDERS OR FOR THESE
PROVIDER RATES THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN ADJUSTED FOR OVER TWENTY
FIVE YEARS SENATE AMENDMENTS.
PROHIBIT BALANCE BILLING AND
ENSURE THAT THE PATIENT IS ONLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ORDINARY OUT
OF POCKET.
SPENCE IS OUR COST THANK YOU AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR THANK YOU SING THEIR REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER COURT PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
ITEM THIRTY NINE AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY FOUR MISTER QUICKLY.
THREE SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE
NINETY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
HOLDEN THAT RELATE TO BUILDING
STANDARDS.
THANK YOU SEEN THEM NO REQUEST
I'M SORRY OF MISTER HOLDEN
PLEASE READ --
JUST THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY FOUR WOULD
REQUIRE THE VISION OF THE STATE
ARCHITECT TO REVIEW THE EXISTING
DISABILITY ACCESS STANDARDS FOR
PUBLIC RESTROOM STALLS.
THIS BILL WOULD TASK THEM WAS
DEVELOPING IN PROPOSING TO THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION.
FOR CONSIDERATION UPDATED
STANDARDS ON THE REQUIRED NUMBER
OF AMBULATORY ACCESSIBLE STALLS
AND PUBLIC RESTROOMS.
ANY CHANGES TO THE BUILDING
STANDARDS WILL BE MADE AFTER
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY FOUR ANSWERS OF SENIORS
AND THOSE OF LIMITED MOBILITY
CONTINUE TO BE CONSIDERED WHEN
NEW CONSTRUCTION WORKERS THIS IS
A BILL IDEA CAME.
DIRECTLY FROM MY DISTRICT I
REQUEST YOUR IBOOK.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK QUIZ OPEN
THEIR ALL.
A MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
YOU CLICK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL ON ITEM THIRTY SIX AB TWO
SEVEN FIVE ONE THE CLERK WILL
POST.
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE RULING
TALIBAN BOATS EYES FORTY FOUR
KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING OUT ITEM FORTY ONE ACR
ONE SEVENTY THREE MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SOME CURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
SEVENTY THREE BY SOME WE'VE EVER
GLORIA OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE
LITTLE SAIGON CULTURAL
COMMERCIAL DISTRICT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ACR ONE
SEVENTY THREE IS BACK FROM THE
STATE OR WHAT ON CONCURRENT
STATEMENT AMENDMENTS CLARIFY.
THAT DECIDED TO ONLY BE PLACED
ON STATE ROUTE FIFTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM FORTY FOUR A.
B. THREE FORTY SEVEN MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
THREE FORTY SEVEN BY SOME
REMEMBER CHAO ACKLINGTON WEIGHTS
AND MEASURES THANK YOU SO MEMBER
CHAO YOUR RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB.
THREE FORTY SEVEN EXTENDS THE
SUNSET THEY FOR THE COMMERCIAL
WEIGHING AND MEASURING DEVICE
REGISTRATION PROGRAM TO JANUARY
FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS MADE CHANGES TO THE
FEE SCHEDULES FOR SOME DEVICES.
BUILT THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUIRK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES AYE SIXTY ONE NO ONE
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
MOVING TO ITEM FORTY FIVE AB.
FIVE FIVE THREE THE CLERK PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY RULE FIVE FIFTY THREE
BY SOME WOMEN WERE DALY AN
ACCOLADE TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
SOME MEMBER DALY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM.
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS PAID FROM THE RETURN TO
WORK FUND.
THE BILL IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE
THAT THE FULL ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS PAID IN
BENEFITS EVERY YEAR.
SENATE AMENDMENT STREAMLINED THE
PAYMENT SYSTEM BY NUMBER ONE
ENSURING THAT ALL ELIGIBLE
RECIPIENTS RECEIVE BENEFITS
AFTER THE INSURER OR CLAIMS
ADMINISTRATOR.
NOTIFIES THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS OF THE
WORKERS ELIGIBILITY.
AND SECOND AND LAST REDUCING THE
BURDEN ON DIR BY REQUIRING
PAYMENT ON A PRO RATED BASIS
JUST ONCE A YEAR.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES EYES FORTY NINE NO
SEVENTEEN THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM FORTY SIX
A. B..
NINE HUNDRED THE CLERK PLEASE
READ ASSUME PEOPLE NINE HUNDRED
BISON THE RIVER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ANOTHER FROM ACCOLADE
TO CRIME VICTIMS OF MAKING
APPROPRIATIONS ARE.
FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
THANK YOU AB NINE HUNDRED WILL
HELP VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SEVEN AMENDMENTS AT
A CO AUTHORS ADDRESS AN ISSUE
REGARD THE DISTRIBUTION OF
COMPENSATION OF TO MINORS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY TWO
NO.
ZERO WE ARE MOVING OUT ITEM
FORTY SEVEN A. B. TEN THIRTEEN
MISTER PURPLISH READ.
SOME PEOPLE TEN THIRTEEN BY SOME
RIVER BELOW AN ACCOLADE TO
ELECTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH BENEFIT YOUR MEMBERS
A. B. TEN THIRTEEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH RESPECTIVE.
REMOTE VOTE BY MAIL SYSTEMS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS I PREPARED TO LIFT THE
CALL AND ITEM TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
SB SIXTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
POST.
ALL MEMBERS ALL THOSE WHO.
WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE
CALL.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN
FILE ORDER TO ITEM.
FORTY AB. THIRTY TO FIFTY ONE TO
QUICKLY ST.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TO FIFTY ONE
BY THE COMMITTEE ON VETERANS
AFFAIRS AND ACCOLADES ARMORY
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
THIRTY TO FIFTY ONE WOULD
AUTHORIZE THE SALE OF SIX
ARMORIES FOR AND THEN
UNDEVELOPED PIECE OF LAND ONCE
INTENDED FOR AN ARMORY.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
THE SILMAR ARMORY TO BE OFFERED
TO A SPECIFIC JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
RULING TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK IN A
FILE ORDER TO ITEM FORTY EIGHT
EP.
SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE MR CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE SIXTEEN SIXTY ONE
BUY SOME MEMORABLE LIMON OF
ACCOLADES A SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B. SIXTEEN
SIXTY ONE IS A TECHNICAL BILL
THAT CONFIRMS STATE LOTS OF THE
FEDERAL.
EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS ACT ALSO
KNOWN AS ASSET.
THE TWENTY FIFTEEN SUCCESSOR OF
THE FEDERAL NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND
ACT SENATE AMENDMENTS RESOLVE
CHAPTER NOW ISSUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT RULE
SIXTY TWO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE LABOR
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TO HEAR AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY FOUR RUBIO.
ON FRIDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST
UPON CALLED CHAIR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM FORTY
NINE AB EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE
MISTER COR PLEASE READ SOME AGO
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE BY SIMPLY
REVERTS OUR TACKLING TO
INFORMATION PRIVACY. SEVEN
MEMBER CHAO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B.
EIGHTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL REQUIRE
CONSUMER CREDIT REPORTING
AGENCIES. TO REPAIR VULNERABLE
COMPUTER SYSTEMS IN A TIMELY
MANNER.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS REMOVE ALL
THE OPPOSITION AND MATE --
TO TECHNICAL CHANGES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A I DON'T.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING OUT ITEM FIFTY AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY MR QUICKLY SERENE
SOMEONE WILL EIGHTEEN SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE TO HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE SOME EVERY MONTH.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY WILL MAKE SURE
THAT CANCER PATIENTS CAN AFFORD
THEIR LIFESAVING ORAL ANTI
CANCER MEDICATION TREATMENT.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO ADD A JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SUNSET DAY
AND HAS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IN BOTH HOUSES.
THIS SLIME PROVES THE QUALITY OF
LIFE OF CANCER PATIENTS AND
PROVIDES GREATER ACCESS ACCESS
TO LIFE SAVING TREATMENT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE MISTER CORPORATE OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON AVERAGE VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY NO.
TO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
LIVING NOW TO ITEM FIFTY ONE A.
B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
BY SO MEMORABLE LACKEY ANOTHER
TONIGHT RELATING TO GUIDE SIGNAL
AND SERVICE DOGS MAKING
APPROPRIATION OR FOR SOME MEMBER
LACKEY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS LEGISLATION PROVIDES
IMPORTANT PROTECTIONS TO THE
DISABLED COMMUNITY AND THE
CAMPAIGNS A DEPEND ON AND ASK
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU'RE SEEING A
DISCUSSION MISTER QUICK QUIZ
OPEN THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE FOR THIS
ARTICLE.
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY THREE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS OR HEARD IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY TWO A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN SEVENTY BY
SOME MEMORY AS ANOTHER PERSON
ACCOLADE TO EMPLOYMENT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE.
BILL WOULD EXTEND FROM ONE YEAR
TO THREE YEARS THE FILING
DEADLINE FOR WHICH EMPLOYMENT
RELATED CLAIMS PROTECTED UNDER
THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT HOUSING.
ACT.
ARE TO BE FILED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING.
SENATE AMENDMENTS LIMIT THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL TO ONLY APPLY
TO EMPLOYMENT HARASSMENT CLAIMS.
AND CLARIFIED THAT THIS BILL
SHALL NOT BE INTERPRETED TO
REVIVE LAPSED CLAIMS.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY IS A WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL AND HAS CO
AUTHORS FROM ACROSS THE AISLE.
IT CAN TAKE SIGNIFICANT TIME FOR
VICTIMS TO COME FORWARD AS THEY
MAY FEAR RETALIATION.
OR FALSELY BELIEVE THAT
HARASSMENT THAT THE HARASSMENT
WILL STOP.
THE CAN SHOULD NOT BE PREVENTED
FROM ASSERTING THEIR RIGHTS
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE OF DEADLINES
A DID NOT REFLECT REAL WORLD
CHALLENGES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
ARE AYE RISE AS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR OF A. B..
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THE ME TOO
MOVEMENT HAS SHOWN US THAT THE
STATUS QUO IS NOT WORKING
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
VICTIMS MAY NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE
COMING FORWARD RIGHT AWAY OR
EVEN A YEAR LATER.
THIS BILL ALLOWS A VICTIM UP TO
THREE YEARS TO FILE A CLAIM.
THIS BILL TAKES A VERY
REASONABLE STEP TOWARD
PROTECTING THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN A
VICTIM OF ABUSE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO FURTHER REQUEST
TO SPEAK.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WELL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
FIFTY TWO NO SIX THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON ITEM FIFTY
THREE A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE MISTER COURT PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
TO DRIVER'S LICENSES.
SENATE OBERNOLTE THINK MADAM
SPEAKER AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY
THREE IS BACK FROM THE SENATE.
THIS BILL ELIMINATES THE FEE
CHARGED HER VETERANS FOR A
VETERANS DESIGNATION ON A
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'SLICENSE OR
STATE ID CARD.
SENATE AMENDMENTS MERELY DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION SLIGHTLY TO
REDUCE COSTS AND ADD CHAPTER IN
OUT AMENDMENTS I REQUEST YOUR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN FARM
SIGN.
THIS POST THE ROLE.
A LITTLE LATE MICROPHONE WENT UP
STRIKE THE ROLE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VOEPEL YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
--
I DO A LOT OF WORK WITH VETERANS
[inaudible]
AND IT MEANS A LOT TO GO TO THE
DMV AND YOU ALSO HAVE TO GO TO
YOUR COUNTY VETERANS --
DEPARTMENT AND HAVE YOUR DD TWO
FOURTEEN CONFIRMED.
SO THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO WORK
FOR THIS DMV LICENSE.
MEANS A LOT TO THE VETERANS NOT
TO HAVE TO PAY THE MONEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU IF THERE ARE
NO FOR THE REQUEST TO SPEAK THE
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE NEWSWIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONFERRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
FIFTY FOUR AB NINETEEN THIRTY
NINE MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
BY SIMPLY RIVER STEINORTH
ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE TO CRIME
VICTIMS IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION OF FOUR SOME.
TIME WORTH THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB NINETEEN THIRTY NINE
IT'S BACK FROM THE SENATE ON
CONCURRENCE.
RECENT AMENDMENTS LIMIT EXPENSES
STICKS THREE DAYS A PET BOARDING
AT A MAXIMUM COST OF FORTY
DOLLARS PER DAY. FOR ALL OF THE
VICTIMS PETS TO ADDRESS COST
CONCERNS ADDITIONALLY DOUBTS IN
CHAPTER NOT LANGUAGE THE BILL IS
HAD OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
IVA.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY
EIGHT KNOWS.
ONE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM.
FIFTY FIVE AB NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSUME PEOPLE NINETEEN FIFTY ONE
BY SWIMMER BROUGHT ON ONE OTHER
PERSON ACCOLADE PEOPLE
ASSESSMENTS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL.
BETTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
NINETEEN FIFTY ONE ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADMINISTER A
COLLEGE ENTRANCE EXAM SUCH AS
THE SAT OR ACT INSTEAD OF THE
STATE REQUIRED ASSESSMENT. FOR
ELEVENTH GRADE STUDENTS.
SENATE MOMENTS AT A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET CLARIFY A PEER REVIEW
PROCESS AND AUTHORIZED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TWO FORMER CONSORTIUM.
TO NEGOTIATE A CONTRACT.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED NO NO
VOTES THIS BILL MOVES CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS FORD AND IMPROVES.
INCREASES COLLEGE ACCESS I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUIRK WAS OPEN THE
WRONG.
NUMBER.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE? TO CLICK YOU
MAKE CLOTHES ARE ON TELLY THE
VOTES AYE SIXTY EIGHT NO.
ZERO ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY SIX
AB TWENTY TWELVE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWELVE BY
SOME BEAVER MEDINA ANOTHER
PERSON ACCOLADES SCHOOL
INCOMMUNICADO AS EMPLOYEES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE AT A CO AUTHOR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER
CORPORATE OPEN THE MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
A CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY FIVE NO TWENTY
THREE THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
INCURRED IN.
LIVING TO ITEM FIFTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY FIFTY SIX MCCORKLE READ.
ASSUME OF BILL TWENTY FIFTY SIX
BY SOME WE WERE REWARDED GARCIA
ACRYLATE TO MOBILE HOME PARKS TO
MAKE THE APPROPRIATION OF FOUR
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA YOUR
RECOMMEND SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
AB TWENTY FIFTY SIX MOBILE HOME
PARK REHABILITATION IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE FROM SENATOR.
SPECTER HAS FOR RIVAL.
THAT'S HOW TO DO IT.
SEEING THEIR REQUEST TO SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
VOTE [inaudible]
MR.
MEMBERS IS REQUIRES.
FIFTY FOUR ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MISTER QUIRK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES ICE
FIFTY FOUR NO SEVENTEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MOVING TO ITEM FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT
BE.
TWENTY SIXTY MR QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIXTY
BY SOME WE WERE WHO ARE EVER SEE
ANOTHER SOME ACCOLADES WATER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA.
JUST TRYING TO FIX MOBILE HOME
PARKS FOR GRANDMA'S GRANDPARENTS
AB.
TWENTY SIXTY WATER GRANTS
ADVANCE PAYMENTS IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK ME I WILL.
THANK YOU.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCORDANT.
WE ARE MOVING NOW TO ITEM FIFTY
NINE AB TWENTY ONE NINETEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE NINETEEN
BY SOME THE RIVER GLORIA ANOTHER
SNUGGLING FOSTER CARE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE
NINETEEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THIS BILL ENSURES THE
TRANSGENDER AND GENDER NON
CONFORMING YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
HAVE ACCESS TO APPROPRIATE
HEALTH.
AND BEHAVIORAL CARE SERVICES A I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO IS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTE RETIRE DEVOTE?
THE CLERK YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TALLY THE VOTES EYES FORTY
FOUR KNOWS TWENTY ONE THE
SENTIMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM SIXTY AB.
TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX MISTER
QUIRK PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER GLORIA ANOTHER
SNACK WILLING TO ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER GLORIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SIX IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE WITH AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS CHAPTER NOW
PROVISIONS RELATED TO AB TWO
THOUSAND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
TELLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY KNOWS
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON ITEM SIXTY ONE
AB.
TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE CLERK
PLEASE READ SOME A HOLE TWENTY
TO TWENTY FIVE BY SIMPLY REMOVE
THE BONE AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU SO MEMBERS AMONG.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO TWENTY FIVE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
LOOKS AT CLOUD BASED DOCUMENT
RECORD STORAGE PROVISIONS THE
BILL HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO BOTH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT IN.
LIVING TO ITEM SIXTY TWO AB
TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE MISTER
QUICKLY THREE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER KALRA ANOTHER PERSON
ACCOLADE TO MEDI CAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY THREE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WOULD EXPAND THE NUMBER OF
ASSISTED LIVING WAIVER SLOTS
BEYOND THE CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED.
370-021-8000 FIVE HUNDRED THIS
IS LIVING WAIVER PROGRAM TAKE
SENIORS IN NURSING HOMES WE
DON'T NEED THAT LEVEL OF CARE.
AND PLACE THEM IN AN ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY OR PROVIDE
SERVICES TO SENIORS SO THEY CAN
REMAIN AT HOME. TO ENSURE
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE STATE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS INCLUDE.
ABA SPECIFICITY THAT AT LEAST
60% OF THE NEW SLOTS BE RESERVED
FOR PERSONS TRANSITIONING FROM A
NURSING HOME.
AND ALSO THE LEAST REQUIREMENT
THE PROVIDER REIMBURSE SURVEYS
TAKEN ACCOUNT THE INCREASING
CALIFORNIA'S MINIMUM WAGE
ASSOCIATE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AIBO.
THANK YOU SEEING NO DISCUSSION
MISTER QUICKLY IS OPEN THE ROLE
OF ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE I MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROWING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
PREFERRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY FOUR AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FOUR MISTER
QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX
THIRTY FOUR BY SIMPLY RIVER CHAO
ACTUALLY TO INSURANCE THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS SAT AB
TWENTY SIX THIRTY FOUR IS
PACKED.
FULL CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL REQUIRES AN INSURER TO
PROVIDE NOTICE TO A POLICY
HOLDER OF A FLEXIBLE PREMIUM
LIFE INSURANCE POLICY.
WHILE COMING CALMLY KNOWN AS
UNIVERSAL LIFE INSURANCE.
WHATEVER THE POLICY IS SUBJECT
TO AN INCREASE IN THE COST OF
INSURANCE CHARGE.
OIL MINISTRY IF I EXPENSE
CHARGE.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
HAS RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AYE
ELSEWHERE AYE BUT THANK YOU
SEEING NO DISCUSSION MISTER
QUIRK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ANTI THE VOTES I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY FIVE AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN BY SOME
RIVER GALLAGHER HAGGLING TO
WILDLIFE HABITAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY SEVEN WHICH WOULD
ESTABLISH A PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE
LANDOWNERS TO MAINTAIN COVER
CROPS TO HELP WATERFOWL AND
OTHER WILDLIFE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I SEE NO REQUEST TO SPEAK.
WITHOUT MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO IS HIRED TO VOTE?
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI
THE VOTES I SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO THAT THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SIXTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY THREE BY
SOME LIBERAL DONALD MONOPOLY TO
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE SIMPLY SEEKS
TO ALIGN FEDERAL AND STATE
SCHEDULING OF HYDROCODONE
COMBINATION PRODUCTS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT CHATTERING
LANGUAGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AND I'VE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE NOW ON ITEM SIXTY EIGHT A.
B. TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY TWO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND ACCOLADES THE
GOVERNMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER OVER
OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MENACE WEAKER AB TWENTY TWENTY
TWO IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS
BILL CLARIFIES ITS A STATE
AUDITOR MAY USE PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
WHEN DETERMINING WHEN A LOCAL
ENTITY IS A RISK THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS MERELY RESOLVE THE
CHAPTER NOW CONFLICT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE?
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE COURT WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS BURDENS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM SIXTY NINE AB
THIRTY THIRTY SIX MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THIRTY SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
INOCULATE THE SOLID WASTE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
THIS MEASURE DEALSWITH THE USE
OF FOOD WASTE FOR FOR ANIMAL
FEED.
SENATE MEMBERS CLARIFIED
TIGHTNESS APPLICATION WITHIN THE
EIGHTH DECEMBER JUST FOR OUR
QUESTION AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO DEBATE WHOSE
QUICKLY OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES EYES
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY AB THIRTY
FORTY THREE MISTER COURT PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FORTY THREE
BY SOME WE WERE BERMAN
ACKLINGTON PEOPLE NUTRITION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB THIRTY FORTY THREE
WOULD MAKE A NUMBER OF CHANGES
TO IMPROVE AND INCREASE ACCESS.
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA SENATE AMENDMENTS
REDUCE ANY POTENTIAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE START UP.
AN EXPANSION GRANT PROGRAM THE
CHANGES IN AB THIRTY FORTY THREE
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ACCESS TO
SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS
RECOGNIZING THAT GOOD NUTRITION
IS ESSENTIAL FOR LEARNING IN
SCHOOL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN CONCURRENCE AND SENATE AND
MEN.
THANK YOU I SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE MOVING ITEM SEVENTY TWO
E. B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY SIX
MISTER COURT FISHERIES.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE TWENTY
SIX BY SOME WE WERE PRO ACCURATE
THE CONTRACTORS.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER BRO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER THIRTY
ONE TWENTY SIX AMENDS THE
FINANCIAL OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO A
CONTRACTOR WOULD OBTAINING A
BOND.
THE BILL PRECLUDES THE USE OF
FILING A CASH DEPOSIT IN THE
BANK IN LIGHT OF SEVERE CONSUMER
PROTECTION ISSUES.
WHEN POSTING CASH'S ALTERNATIVE
TO THE BOND THE BOARD HAS NO
JURISDICTION OR CONTROL OVER
THIS WHEN THIS OCCURS A
CONSUMERS UNABLE RECEIVE THEY'RE
ENTITLED FUNDS INVENTIVE A
CLAIM?
AND A CONTRACTORS IN VIOLATION
SENATE MEMBERS DESERVE THE
CASHIER'S CHECK AS AN
ALTERNATIVE SHOULD THERE BE ANY
DIFFICULTIES TO SECURING A BOND
TO ASSURE ATTY.
AB THIRTY SIX ONE TWENTY SIX A
SPONSORED BY THE STATE
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD THANK
YOU AND ASK FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE
SENTIMENTS.
WHO QUE SEEING NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPORATE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE?
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I
SEVENTY ONE ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ITEM SEVENTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY ONE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
ONE BY SOME WE WERE LOW AND
OTHERS AND THE BUREAU OF
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BENEFIT REMEMBERS THIS BILL IS
BACK FROM THE SENATE FOR
CONCURRENCE ON THE BUREAU OF
AUTOMOTIVE REPAIR FOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS BOTH THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLE ON TELLY THE BOATS I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED AND
ITEM SEVENTY FIVE IS AB THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY RULE THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOME WOMEN CHAVEZ AND
OTHERS ARE NOT RELATED
TRANSPORTATION.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SCHABAS AND
SECRETARY A. B. THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
IT BRINGS NORTH COUNTY
TRANSISTOR COMPARED WITH OTHER
LOCAL TRANSIT DISTRICTS I ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SEVENTY
TWO NINE ZERO AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN.
WE ARE ON ITEM SEVENTY SIX AB
THIRTY TO TWELVE MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSUMING WILL THIRTY TO TWELVE
BY SOME REMEMBER ONE OTHER
PERSON I BELIEVE THE SERVICE
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IRWIN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
MADAM SPEAKER AB THIRTY TO
TWELVE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND ZERO
NO VOTES SENATE AMENDMENTS
PREVENT AB THIRTY TO TWELVE FROM
CHAPTER RING OUT RECENTLY PASSED
LEGISLATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I THINK YOU I SEE NO
REQUEST TO DEBATE THE ITEM
MISTER FOR PLEASE.
OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DIED ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
MADAM CLERK YOU MISTER CLARK YOU
MAY CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES I SEVENTY NO ZERO OF THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CAN
PRUDENT.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY SEVEN AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY RULE THIRTY TO SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAHAM
ACTUALLY TRIBAL GAMING OF THE
CLEARLY YEARS HE THEIR UP TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY SOME
EMIGRATE.
THEY MATTER SPEAKER A. B. THIRTY
TO SIXTY TWO RATIFIES THE TRIBAL
GAMING COMPACT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SAN AS BAND OF
MISSION INDIANS WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIDE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
I'M SORRY MISTER QUICK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOUR VOTES
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY FOUR
NO ZERO IN THE URGENCY I SIXTY
FOUR KNOWS HERE ON THE MEASURE
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT AB
SIX THIRTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER THIS AREA AND
OTHERS ACCOLADE CLINICAL
LABORATORIES ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
THIS AREA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB SIX
THIRTEEN AUTHORIZES A PERSON
WITH SPECIFIED QUALIFICATIONS TO
PERFORM A TOTAL PROTEIN TEST
USING A DIGITAL AUTOMATIC DEVICE
IN A LICENSE PLASMA COLLECT
COLLECTION CENTER TO DETERMINE
THE ELIGIBILITY.
OF A POTENTIAL DONOR DONATED
PLASMA IS THE STARTING MATERIAL
FOR SEVERAL THERAPIES THAT TREAT
RARE CHRONIC AND SOMETIMES LIFE
THREATENING DISEASES.
AUTHORIZING MORE PEOPLE TO
PERFORM THIS TEST WILL
STREAMLINE THE PROCESS FOR
COLLECTING DONATIONS.
A SENATE AMENDMENTS WERE RESULT
OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF A PUBLIC HEALTH TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS ABOUT DONOR
SAFETY THE FORMALLY REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION AS A RESULT --
I THINK YOU EN AT RESPECTFULLY
ASTORIA AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I AM SEEING NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER CLARK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS WROTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING ITEM SEVENTY NINE AB
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOR THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER AS AARON
ACCOLADE HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
THANK YOU OF SOME GOVERNANCE
AREA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I'M
PRESENTING AB --
FIFTEEN THIRTY FOUR WHICH
REQUIRES A HEALTH PLAN TO PERMIT
AN HIV SPECIALIST TO BE AN
ELIGIBLE PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER
AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WHERE TECHNICAL IN NATURE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
ITS JOURNEY.
IT'S BEEN A LONG JOURNEY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THE CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
TWO NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY DB
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN MISTER
CLERK PLEASE HURRY ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN NINETY SEVEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON INSURANCE AN
ACCOLADE TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THIS BILL CODIFIES A NEW
UNIT WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS.
THAT WILL USE ADVANCED ANALYTICS
TO IDENTIFY PREVIOUSLY
UNDETECTED FRAUD.
IN THE WORKERS COMP SYSTEM.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS REQUIRE
THAT THE DEPARTMENT ADOPT
SPECIFIC PROCEDURES AND GOALS
AND REPORT RESULTS TO THE
LEGISLATURE EVERY THREE YEARS.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEING NO REQUEST TO SPEAK THE
CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE RIGHT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY
SIX KNOW ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY ONE AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE THE CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE BY SOME
WOMEN WERE DALY AND OTHERS ARE
NOT WILLING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION MISTER DALY.
YOUR RED INK YOU AGAIN MADAM
SPEAKER REMEMBERS THIS IS
ANOTHER WORKERS COMP BILL.
IT PERTAINS TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION BENEFITS FOR
CALIFORNIA PEACE OFFICERS WHO
WERE INJURED WHILE TAKING ACTION
TO PROTECT LIVES IN ANOTHER
STATE.
SUCH AS DURING THE MASS SHOOTING
IN LAS VEGAS LAST YEAR.
SENATE AMENDMENTS MAKE IT CLEAR
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO HAVE
THE DISCRETION.
PROVIDE BENEFITS TO PEACE
OFFICERS INJURED WHILE
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC IN ANOTHER
STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE FOR CONCURRENCE WITH THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK.
THE COURT PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ON TELLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY TWO
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME A BILL SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER STEINORTH
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE STATE
PARKS ASSEMBLY MEMBER STEINORTH.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN SIXTY TWO IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE RECENT
AMENDMENTS EXTEND THE REPORTING
DATE BY ONE YEAR.
THIS BILL HAS UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN NO REQUESTS TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
IN TELLING THE VOTES I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE ON ITEM EIGHTY
THREE A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR BY SOME WE'VE EVER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
OF PEOPLE'S. SEVEN NEVER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THAT AMENDMENTS TAKE
IN THE SCENT NETWORK CLARIFYING
AND ENSURE THAT THERE WAS.
NO CONFLICT WITH LABOR CODE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS EIGHTEEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
LIVING TO ITEM EIGHTY FOUR AB
TWENTY TWENTY MISTER QUICKLY
STREET.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AND OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE THE CAMPUS.
SOME MEMBER QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY TWENTY PASSED WITH
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WHEN
WAS FIRST HEARD IN THIS HOUSE.
THE LAST TEMPORARY CANNABIS
EVENTS TAKE PLACE AT ANY VENUE
EXPRESSLY PERMITTED BY A LOCAL
JURISDICTION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS AT THE
SUGGESTION OF THE MEMBER FROM
PALMDALE.
I STRENGTHENED PUBLIC SAFETY BY
GRANTING THE BUREAU OF CANNABIS
CONTROL OF LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
POWER.
A SHUTDOWN NONCOMPLIANT EVENTS
AND LEVY A PENALTY ON BAD
ACTORS.
OUR AMENDMENTS WERE DRAFTED IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND VARIOUS STAKE HOLDERS AB
TWENTY TWENTY PASSED OUT OF THE
SENATE WITH STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
CONTINUES TO HAVE NO OPPOSITION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN THAT NO REQUEST
TO SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS REQUIRES FIFTY FOR ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
MR CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES.
EYES FIFTY FIVE KNOWS ELEVEN THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
WE ARE NOW ON ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
AB TWENTY EIGHTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE BY SOMEONE RIVER COOLEY AN
ACCOLADE TO FOSTER YOU.
THANK YOU SOME NEVER COOLEY YOUR
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY EIGHTY
THREE RELATES TO FOSTER USE.
THE SURVEY THOSE WHO BEEN VERY
TRAUMATIZED IN THEIR LIFE
SITUATION.
OF THEY TAKE A HIGH LEVEL OF
SERVICES AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
THIS MEASURE WILL STRENGTHEN
THEIR ACCESS TO SERVICE AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL.
BY CONNECTING IT TO STATE
RESOURCES SENATE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THE PALETTE OF SERVICES
THE STATE'S WILL PROVIDE.
THE COUNTIES ALSO ADDRESS
IMPORTANT CONFIDENTIALITY RULES.
THEY'RE GOOD AMENDMENTS ARE
QUESTION I VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTED AS I THE
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING TO ITEM EIGHTY SIX AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY
THREE BY SOME REPAIRMEN OTHERS
AN ACCOLADE THE TEACHERS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THURMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER IN
MEMBERS ARE RICE BUSY IN AB
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE A BILL
SPONSORED BY CALLED QUALITY
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH WOULD GIVE TEACHERS THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED SUPPORT OUR
LGBTQ YOUTH.
LGBTQ STUDENTS OFTEN FACE VERBAL
PHYSICAL AN ONLINE HARASSMENT IN
SCHOOL AND SOMETIMES OUT OF
SCHOOL.
MORE THAN 90% OF LGBTQ STUDENTS
REPORT HEARING ANTI LGBT Q.
REMARKS AMONG OTHER
DISCRIMINATORY ACTIONS BY THEIR
PEERS.
THAT'S WHY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
TEACHERS AND STAFF BE EQUIPPED
WITH THE TRAINING AND TOOLS THEY
NEED TO SUPPORT OUR YOUTH THIS
BILL REQUIRE THAT TEACHERS IN
MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL RECEIVE
TRAINING.
ABOUT LGBTQ SUPPORT SERVICES
THAT ARE SPECIFIC TO THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE SCHOOLS
ARE.
THE BILL REQUIRES TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS IN GRADE SEVEN TO
TWELVE IN ALL OF THE SORT
CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES AT THOSE
SCHOOLS.
ON SITE A COMMUNITY RESOURCES
FOR SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEN A REQUEST TO SPEAK MISTER
CORPORATE OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE YOU MAY
CLOSE THE ROLE ANTI THE VOTES
EYES FORTY NINE KNOWS.
TEN THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN REMOVING TO ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY THREE MISTER QUIRK PLEASE
READ.
SOME EVIL TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE BY SOME WE WERE
MAIENSCHEIN AND OTHERS AND I
PLAYED A HEALTHCARE SOME NEVER
MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
THREE IS BACK IN THE ASSEMBLY A
CONCURRENCE AFTER TAKING
AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE.
AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED ALL
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CLERK WAS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
ANTI THE VOTES I SIXTY SEVEN
KNOWS HERE OF THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN
.
LIVING TO ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT
EIGHTY TWENTY TWO OH SEVEN
MISTER CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO OH
SEVEN BY SIMPLY RIVER EGGMAN
AGGRAVATED SEXUAL ABUSE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU MANAGE SPEAKER
MEMBERS OF THIS IS A SUSAN
EGGMAN BILL AB TWO TWO ZERO
SEVEN A BACK FOR CONCURRENT
SIMPLY SETTING A DATE BY WHICH
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES HAS TO ESTABLISH
POLICIES. FOR BEST PRACTICES FOR
SEXUALLY TRAFFIC CHILDREN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WE ARE AYE VOTE
ON SUSAN EGGMAN. TO TO A SEVEN
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SUSAN
EGGMAN.
MR CLERK PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTE ALL THOSE MEMBERS
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON EVEN BE TO
TO A SEVEN BY SUSAN EGGMAN
PLEASE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRING TO VOTE ON SUSAN EGGMAN
SPILL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
ON SUSAN EGGMAN SPILL AB TWENTY
TWO OH SEVEN PLEASE VOTES.
MISTER QUICK PLEASE CLOSE OUR
OWN TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES SIXTY NINE NOSE ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING TO ITEM
EIGHTY NINE AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN MISTER CORPORATE.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTEEN BY SOME WOMEN REMARKS
STONE ACCOLADE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES.
THANK YOU AS A MEMBER STONE
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
THAT AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING I ASK FOR
CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEN A REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL CALL THE
ROLL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE NO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE CLERK MAKE CLOSER UNTIL I
THE VOTES I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MOVING NOW TO ITEM NINETY AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE MISTER
CLERK PLEASE READ.
SOME WIGGLE TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
ONE BY SIMPLY RIVER CARILLO
ANOTHER PERSON ACTUALLY TO WATER
USE EFFICIENCY.
SOME AMERICA RIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I PROBABLY RISE --
ON AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
FROM THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE
FIFTY FIRST DISTRICT A BILL THAT
WOULD IMPROVE LANDSCAPE WATER
USE EFFICIENCY IS BACK FROM
CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN THE SENATE
REDUCE THE FISCAL IMPACT OF THE
BILL MAKING THE LANDSCAPE
INSPECTION PROVISIONS
PERMISSIVE.
AND MAKE THE CLARIFYING CHANGES
THIS AMENDMENTS BE THE MOMENT
HAVE REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION AND
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THINK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SING A REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CLERK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS BOTH.
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER CLARK PLEASE CLOSE A
ROWING TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES
FORTY SIX NO NINETEEN THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
I AM NINETY ONE PASS TEMPORARILY
MOVING TO ITEM NINETY TWO AB.
TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT TO
QUICKLY.
THREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
FORTY EIGHT BY SOME REMEMBER
GIPSON OTHERS INOCULATED
JUVENILES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON
YOU ARE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM --
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY EIGHT IS
BACK ON THE FLOOR FOR CURRENTS.
OF AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL IN
NATURE TO ENSURE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE FACILITIES
ARE EXCLUDED FROM THE BILL.
THIS -- BILL
HAS RECEIVED.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
I MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
MR CLARKE YOU MAY CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY EIGHT KNOWS.
NINETEEN THE SENATE MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO ITEM
NINETY THREE AB.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE THE
CLERK PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
THREE BY SOME WEBER WOOD WATER
GARCIA AND OTHERS AND I CLEAN
AIR POLLUTION THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA.
MISS THAT MATTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FOUR
VICTORIES BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THAT'S DO WITH.
AIR POLLUTION PREVENTION IN OUR
SCHOOLS RESPECTFULLY ASK
ARRIVAL.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER CORPUS OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY NINE NO
0% AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE ARE ON ITEM NINETY FOUR AB
TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE MISTER CLERK
PLEASE READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE
BY SOME THE RIVER SANTIAGO AN
ACCOLADE TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY FIVE OH FIVE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH RESPECTFULLY
ASK AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER KIRK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
SORRY TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE SIXTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
MOVING BACK AND FILE ORDER TO
ITEM NINETY ONE AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTEEN MISTER QUICKLY THREE SO
MIDDLE TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER CALDERON ACCOLADE
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTEEN IS
BACK.
FROM THE SENATE ON CONCURRENCE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
IN [inaudible]
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU SEEN OUR REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTES I. SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
HEARD IN WE ARE NOW ON ITEM
NINETY FIVE AB.
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN THE CLERK
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX FOURTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER
CARILLO ANOTHER CYNICAL INTO
OUTDOOR EXPERIENCES [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
TWENTY SIX FOURTEEN IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT THAT WILL ASSURE THAT
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA CAN ACCESS.
AND ENJOY THE NATURAL RESOURCES
OF ARE SPACE OF OUR STATE
BECAUSE WHO DOES ALL OF THE
GREAT AYE OUTDOORS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
THE LOOK.
MR CLERK PLEASE CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES HIGH SIXTY
NO ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
ITEM NINETY SIX IS AB TWENTY SIX
FIFTEEN MISTER COURT PLEASE
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN
BY SOME REMEMBER CARILLO
ANOTHER'S INOCULATED STATE
HIGHWAYS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO.
BACK AT IT AGAIN MADAM SPEAKER
THINK YOU AB TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENT SO ASSURE
THAT ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA CAN ACCESS AND
ENJOY OUR STATE BEAUTIFUL PARK
IT HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO
OPPOSITION AND PASSED THE SENATE
FLOOR IT UNANIMOUSLY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU I SEE NO REQUEST TO
SPEAK MISTER QUICK PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES I SIXTY SIX
KNOWS 0% AMENDMENTS ARE PREPARED
AND
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE ITEM
.
NINETY NINE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NINETY NINE AB.
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY TWO BY MISS
CARILLO [inaudible]
CORPORATE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CARILLO ACCOLADE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES [inaudible]
THIS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER ARE
BACK TO BACK ON THE WHEELS OF
STEEL HERE.
THANK YOU AYE THIS IS AB TWENTY
EIGHT SEVENTY TWO BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN IN
THE SENATE MAKING THAT --
CLARIFYING AND COST REDUCTION
CHANGES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO DJ CHO
BECAUSE THE CUT MASTER
APPRECIATES THAT REFERENCE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
PURPLE OF THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
AND TALLY THE VOTES SWITCHED TO
KNWS.
THIRTEEN SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE HUNDRED AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME IRAQI
ASSEMBLY BUT RODRIGUEZ AND
OTHERS INOCULATED VEHICULAR AIR
POLLUTION.
THIS RODRIGUEZ MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE BACKING FOR
PRINT CURRENTS.
THIS BILL APARTHEID'S REBATES
FROM THE CLEAN VEHICLE REBATE
PROJECT TO LOW INCOME UP IT'S A
RESPECT AFTER I WROTE.
SEEING NO DISCLOSURE DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
PARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU ABOUT ICE SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE NO.
ONE IS AB.
TWENTY NINE THIRTEEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
THIRTEEN BY SOME EMERALD
WOULDN'T ACT RELATED BUILDING
PERMITS DOCTOR WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTEEN HIS BACK
AGAINST CONCURRENT HER
CONCURRENCE AFTER AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKING IN THE SENATE UNDER
CURRENT LAW BUILDING PERMIT IS
VALID FOR SIX MONTHS THE BILL
WOULD SIMPLY INCREASE THAT TO
TWELVE MONTHS.
RESPECT WE ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS FUNDS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE TO ROLL.
AND TELL YOU VOTE AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM.
ONE NO.
TWO IS AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE FIFTY
TWO BY SOME REMEMBER MARK STONE
ACCURATELY JUVENILE RECORDS
MISTER STONE.
THEY GIVE US IS BIGGER AND
MEMBERS SENATE AMENDMENTS
ADDRESS SOME DATA REPORTING
QUESTIONS I ASK.
FOR CONCURRENCE IN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
NAME IS STONE SEEN NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TYLER BY SEVENTY KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE OH THREE IS AB [inaudible]
TWENTY NINE SIXTY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE SIXTY
BY SOME REMEMBER BERMAN THAT
ACTUALLY CHILDCARE DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES [inaudible]
MISTER THURMOND.
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES STRAIGHT
OUT OF RICHMOND ON THE ONES AND
TWOS I RESENT AB TWENTY NINE
SIXTY TWO YOU.
THIS IS A BILL ABOUT CHILDCARE
CREATES A CHILDCARE PORTAL.
THAT PROVIDES RESOURCES TO ALL
FAMILIES [inaudible]
THERE'S NO.
THERE HAD BEEN NO NO VOTES TO
DATE AND I APPRECIATE THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON THIS BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DON'T CALL TO COME BACK MEMBERS.
C. NOTICE YESTERDAY COURT LEVEL
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSER ALTERNATIVE
THAT I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
FILE ITEM --
ONE FOREST.
TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE NINETY EIGHT BY SOME WE
WERE BLOOM ANOTHER CYNICAL IN
THE BUSINESS [inaudible]
MR BELOW.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
I RISE TO PURPOSE POP UP PRESENT
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY EIGHT IT'S
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN OF THIS BILL IN THE SENATE
NARROW DEFINITIONS.
AND THE AMENDMENTS HAVE REMOVED
OPPOSITION FROM A OF THE HOME
FURNISHINGS ASSOCIATION IN THE
MATTRESS INDUSTRY.
I RESPECTFULLY UP.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOMS SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSER ROLE ANTI
ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY TWO KNOWS TWELVE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
FILE ITEM.
ONE OH FIVE IS AB THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MISTER KANSEN CHU
CORPORAL RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT BY SOME MEMBER KANSEN CHU
AN ACCOLADE HEALTH FACILITIES
MISTER CHIU THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER SAM MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY
EIGHT HE IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
DR MA'AM AND IS TO INCLUDE THAT
SUNSET DATE TO ALLOW FOR A
REVIEW OF THE DATA.
GENERATED BY THE AT TO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
WHAT I SIXTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
FILE ITEM ONE OF SIX IS AB
THIRTY ONE TWELVE PURPLE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE TWELVE
BY SOME IMMIGRATION ACCOLADE THE
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
[inaudible]
SIR GRAYSON.
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IS BACK
CURRENTS SENTIMENTS ADD SENATOR
HUESO IS A CO AUTHOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ARE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT IN FILE ITEM ONE
OF SEVEN IS AB. THIRTY ONE FORTY
TWO COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FORTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW ONE
OTHER PERSON ACCOLADE HEALING
ARTS.
MR LOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A B.
THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO ONE US
SEVERAL SUNSET BILLS TO EXTEND
THE ACUPUNCTURE BOARD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE.
MEMES HELLO SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE --
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE TO DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW ABOUT I
SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM ONE
AWAY IT IS A. B. THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN BY SOME IMMIGRATION OTHERS
NOT ONLY THE GAS CORPORATIONS
[inaudible]
MR
.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
TO WE SEND THE VOTE ON AB.
THIRTY ONE TWELVE MISTER GRAYSON
IS GOING 2%.
AGAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE ZERO SIX A. B. [inaudible]
THIRTY ONE TWELVE MR GRACE IN
YOU MAY PRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TAKE TO TODAY AB THROWS
A GRAYSON MISTER GRAYSON MY
APOLOGIES WE HAVE TO OFFICIALLY
HAVE THAT READ BEFORE GOD HAS AT
CORKERY.
CYNICAL THIRTY ONE TWELVE BY
SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON THAT
REALLY THE CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
NOW MEASURE GRAYSON EMAIL.
THANK YOU VERY GOV.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY A. B. THIRTY ONE TWELVE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE ADDITION OF AN
ORDER IN. TO THE SALE OF BUTANE
CANISTERS OVER A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLILITERS WHICH WILL
DISCOURAGE ITS USE IN THE
ILLEGAL MANUFACTURING A BUTANE
HONEY OIL.
SENTIMENT SENATE AMENDMENTS
CHANGE THE EFFECTIVE DATE OF
JULY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THANK
YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON SEEN NO
DISCRETION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND A BUT I SEVENTY
NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
AND THEN MISTER GRAYSON WE'RE
GOING TO STAY WITH YOU THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE AWAIT.
AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SEVEN THE
CORPORATE.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
SEVEN VICE AND WEBER GRAYSON
OTHERS AND I BELIEVE THE GAS
CORPORATIONS.
MR GRACE AND YOU MAKE IT OPEN
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIRTY ONE AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY SEVEN IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE SEND AMENDMENTS
ADD SENATOR HUESO IS CO AUTHOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS THERE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE TO ROLL.
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE.
GOING TO MOVE AHEAD IN THE FILE
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY NINE THAT IS A BE.
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER MURATSUCHI
AND OTHERS ARE NOT RELATED STATE
LANDS.
ITS WERE SEEKING THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FIVE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE ST AMENDMENT IS
PROCEDURAL NATURE.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BOTH HOUSES
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK GOODNESS MURATSUCHI SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
[inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MR MURATSUCHI BOOK THE COMPLEX.
MURATSUCHI MOVES TO CALL
OKAY
MEMBERS BACK IN FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE OH NINE AB.
THIRTY TWO OH FIVE BY MISTER
O'DONNELL.
CORPORAL RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO OH FIVE
BY SOME RIVER O'DONNELL ANOTHER
SNACK POLICE SCHOOL FACILITIES
MISTER O'DONNELL MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB THIRTY TWO A FIVE
REQUIRE SCHOOL MODERNIZATION
PROJECTS SEEKING STATE SCHOOL
FACILITIES BOND FUNDS. TO
INCLUDE LOCKS ON CLASSROOM DOORS
THAT CAN BE LOCKED FROM THE
INSIDE.
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
IF YOU'VE EVER BEEN IN A
LOCKDOWN OF THE SCHOOL.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS REQUIRED TO
HAVE INSIDE DOOR LOCKS AND ADD
AN IMPLEMENTATION DATE I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER O'DONNELL
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON --
MEMBERS DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE VOTE AYE
SIXTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM. ONE TEN AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY FIVE THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO THIRTY
FIVE BY THE COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION ACT RELATED POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION [inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS TAKEN OF THE
SENATE CHANGE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S.
OFFICE REPORTING DATE ON
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES.
REMEDIATION PROGRAM RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCE
AND SENATE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WELL
OVER THE ROLE.
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE OF IT I SEVENTY
TWO NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM.
ONE ELEVEN IS AB SEVENTEEN
NINETY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY NINETY BY
SIMPLY RIVER SALAS AND OTHERS
INOCULATED VALLEY FEVER
[inaudible]
SIR SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THIS
BILL WOULD ENACT THE VALLEY
FEVER EDUCATION EARLY DIAGNOSIS
AND TREATMENT ACT REQUIRE.
DPH CONDUCT A VALLEY FEVER
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN TO
COMMUNICATE WITH LOCAL HEALTH
HEALTH JURISDICTIONS.
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS AND DOCTORS
PROVIDERS AND A PUBLIC.
I MEMBERS ON A PERSONAL NOTE I
JUST WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR TAKING THE TIME TO ALLOW ME
TO TALK TO YOU GUYS ABOUT VALLEY
FEVER.
WHAT MEANS TO CALIFORNIANS UP
AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE?
AND ALSO I'D LIKE TO THANK MY MY
JOIN AUTHOR WHO ACTUALLY HAD
VALLEY FEVER.
AND I SHARING HIS EXPERIENCE AND
WHY THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE TOOLS
NECESSARY --
THAT DOCTORS HAVE THE TOOLS
RESOURCES THAT THAT THAT THEY
NEED SO THAT THEY DIAGNOSIS CAN
BE DONE CORRECTLY AND I I DO
WANT TO THANK MY JOIN AUTHOR
FROM CONCORD SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CELIS.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTE I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE TWELVE IS AB.
TWENTY ONE TWELVE KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWELVE
BY SOME THE RIVER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY THE CRISIS INTERVENTION
[inaudible]
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU THIS BILLS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE I EXPECT LASSEN AYE
VOTE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VALUES ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT AYE
SEVENTY NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN IS AB.
TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
FIVE BY SOME MEMBER BUT DAVID
CHIU AND ACT LIKE A CIVIL
ACTIONS [inaudible]
CHIU.
THANK YOU MISTER DJ.
AB. TWENTY ONE EIGHTY FIVE WOULD
ALLOW IN CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES
THE USE OF A PSEUDONYM IN LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS TO PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALS WITH GREATER ACCESS
TO THE COURTS SENATE AMENDMENTS
NARROW THE BILL.
SPECIFICALLY TO GUARDIAN AD
LITEM AS WITH REGARDS TO THEIR
CHILDREN AND REQUIRE THE COURTS
TO MAKE SPECIFIC FINDINGS TO
PRESERVE ANONYMITY.
THESE AMENDMENTS REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION AND I APPRECIATE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS YOU SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE --
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSE ROLE.
INTEL THE VOTE I SUCCEED NO ZERO
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN IS AB.
TWENTY THREE FIFTY TO COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE FIFTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN
ACCOLADE TO ELECTIONS.
MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
TWO IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE WITH
RESPECT TO REPORTABLE ERRORS.
AND THE COUNTY REGISTRAR OF
VOTERS RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
GOOD IS THERE TO VOTE CLERK WILL
[inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TALLY OF OF I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTEEN THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY TWO BY MISTER DALLI
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TALLY ANOTHER PERSON ACCOLADE TO
RECYCLING.
MISTER DALLI THE MAN'S BIGGER AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY TWO IS BACK
ON TO CURSE THE SENATE THE
SENATE MINUTES ADDED LANGUAGE
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO. THIRTEEN THE BILL MAY
TECHNICAL CHANGES AB THREE TO
ACQUIRE THE SECRETARY OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION TO
CONVENE THE LITHIUM ION CAR
BATTERY CYCLING ADVISORY GROUP.
TO DISCUSS POLICIES FOR EASE AND
RECYCLING OF ELECTRIC
[inaudible]
VEHICLE BATTERIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AN AYE VOTE.
NAME A STALLION SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE TO ROLL.
TALLY THE VOTE I SEVENTY ONE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTEEN IS AB.
TWENTY NINE FOURTEEN
APPROPRIATE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE FOURTEEN
BY SOME REMEMBER COOLEY AN
ACCOLADE TO CAMPUS [inaudible]
SIR COOLEY.
COLLEAGUES THIS MEASURE RELATES
--
TOO ALCOHOL AND CANVAS CONVERSE
INFUSED ALCOHOL IT AS PROVISIONS
ON THIS SUBJECT A STATUTE SENATE
AMENDMENT HAD.
TO ADD LANGUAGE OF INTEREST TO
THE A. B. C. ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE
CONTROL.
GOODMAN SERGEANT AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
EGGMAN SCHOOLEY.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE VOTE EYES SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN IS AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY SEVEN RECOVERY.
SOME PEOPLE THIRTY TO FIFTY
SEVEN BY THE COMMITTEE ON
NATURAL RESOURCES AND NOT RELATE
TO NATURAL RESOURCES.
MR MURATSUCHI THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THAT NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE ALBINISM ARMAMENT
OMNIBUS BILL IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
A SENATE AMENDMENT IS TECHNICAL
IN NATURE DOOR WITH NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE OF ON I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE KURT IN FILE
ITEM.
ONE NINETEEN IS AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SEVEN SO
BEFORE BY ASSEMBLYMAN WILLIE
BROWN AND OTHERS NATALIE TO
ANIMAL ABUSE.
MISS LAMONT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY FOUR
AUTHORIZES ENCOURAGES AN
ADDITIONAL STEPS BE TAKEN TO A
VET THE INDIVIDUALS SEEKING TO
ADOPT PETS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN AYE
VOTES.
THANK YOU MS AMOUNT SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE --
MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL.
CALVET I SIXTY SIX NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN [inaudible]
THIS IS.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ACR. TWO
THIRTY FOUR KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THIRTY FOR BY SO MEMBER PER
RUBIO AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
BREASTFEEDING AWARENESS MONTH
[inaudible]
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT ACR TO THIRTY FOUR A
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
RESOLUTION WAS WHICH RECOGNIZES.
AUGUST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS
BREASTFEEDING AWARENESS MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA ISRAEL HAD MINOR
TECHNICAL AMENDS DONE IN THE
SENATE AND IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE.
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO.
SAME NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
ON NUMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED THIS ADDED
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
IS FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY ONE H. A
R. FORTY SIX PURPLE READ.
ASSUMING JOINT RESOLUTION FORTY
SIX BY SOME REMEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER ANOTHER SHOW THROUGH TO
FEDERAL ZERO TOLERANCE
IMMIGRATION POLICY.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
IS ON CONCURRENCE BECAUSE THE
SENATE ADDED CO AUTHORS I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WAS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES FORTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO IS AB
SIXTEEN NINETEEN CORKERY.
SO ME BILL SIXTEEN NINETEEN BY
SO MEMORY BERMAN OTHERS ARE NOT
RELATED SEXUAL ASSAULT
[inaudible]
ESTHER BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES IN MOST CASES OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS TO FILE A CIVIL CASE
IS TWO YEARS.
THIS TIME FRAME IS NOT REALISTIC
FOR MANY SEXUAL ASSAULT
SURVIVORS WHO ARE RECOVERING
FROM THE PHYSICAL AND EMOTIONAL
TRAUMA OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AB SIXTEEN NINETEEN WOULD EXTEND
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
GIVING ADULT PLAINTIFFS TEN
YEARS FROM THE DATE OF THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT OR THREE YEARS
FROM THE DATE OF DISCOVERY OF AN
ILLNESS OR INJURY.
THAT RESULTED FROM THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT WHICHEVER IS LATER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THING IS BERMAN SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE VERGE
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE THAT I FIFTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY THREE AB EIGHT TWENTY
NINE CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHT TWENTY NINE BY
SIMPLY MEMBER DAVID CHIU AN
ACCOLADE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THE SEARCH YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IN THE MIDST OF ARE
HOMELESS AND HOUSING STATE
CRISIS AND SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE.
THERE'D BEEN AFFORDABLE AND
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS
THAT BEEN SLOWED OR STOPPED
BECAUSE PROJECTS ARE REQUIRED TO
GET A LETTER OF ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
FROM A LOCAL CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER.
IN WHOSE DISTRICT THE PROJECT IS
LOCATED AS A CONDITION RECEIVING
FUNDING.
AS A RESULT OF THIS POLICY
PROJECTS HAVE BEEN HOME BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T GET THE SIGN OFF OF A
SINGLE LOCAL ELECTED.
THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE USE
OF AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT LETTER AS
A THRESHOLD CONDITION TO APPLY
FOR FUNDING.
IF THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT ALSO
RECEIVE STATE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO EXPEDITE THE
CREATION OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND MAXIMIZE OUR STATE
INVESTMENT WE NEED TO REDUCE
THESE BARRIERS TO APPROVING.
LOCAL HOUSING PROJECTS THE BILL
DOES NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION AND
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT.
SAME IS TRUE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESERT A LITTLE MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
BURKE WELL.
THOSE ARE ALL.
COUNTY VOTE EYES FIFTY NINE NO
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY FOUR AB FOURTEEN
FORTY FIVE AND MISS RATES
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN FORTY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER RAY ASSN
ACRYLATE TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
THIS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER.
CARE EGGMAN MEMBERS.
LAST YEAR CONGRESS PASSED
LEGISLATION THAT MADE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
FEDERAL TAX CODE WHICH AMONG
OTHER AMONG OTHER THINGS CREATED
OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
THE GOAL OF THE ZONES TO ADDRESS
POVERTY IN LOW.
INCOME AREAS SPECIFICALLY
THROUGH THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
OPPORTUNITY FUNDS.
INVESTMENTS THROUGH THIS
MECHANISM ALLOW THE ENTITY OR
INDIVIDUAL TO ELIMINATE FEDERAL
TAXES ON UNREALIZED CAPITAL
GAINS.
AS AN INCENTIVE TO INVEST IN
DOES DESIGNATED ZONES.
IN APRIL THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
TREASURY CERTIFIED CALIFORNIA'S
NOMINATED OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
DESIGNATING EIGHT HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE CENSUS TRACTS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THAT ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
PROGRAM.
AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE SIMPLY
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING A CITY.
OR COUNTY PARTICIPATING IN A
TRANSACTION INVOLVING PUBLIC
PROPERTY. TO BE PROVIDED WITH
BASIC INFORMATION RELATING TO
THE PROJECT'S DEVELOPMENT.
THIS INFORMATION INCLUDES THE
TIMELINE FOR THE COMPLETION OF
THE INVESTMENT ACTIVITY.
THE NUMBER OF LOCAL JOBS
ESTIMATED AND WORKFORCE
UTILIZATION STRATEGIES.
AB FOURTEEN FORTY FIVE ENSURES A
PRIOR TO PRIORITIZATION.
PUBLIC BENEFIT WHEN THERE'S
PURCHASE OR LEASE OF PUBLIC
LAND.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS RACE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CARPAL OPEN THE ROLL-ON --
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE VERGE
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY ONE
KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY FIVE IS AB.
FIFTEEN SEVENTY THREE THE
CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER BLOOM
ACCOLADE TO FISHERIES
[inaudible]
MR BLOW.
MISTER SPEAKER THERE'S SOMETHING
FISHY GOING ON HERE.
B. BECAUSE A BE FIFTEEN SEVENTY
THREE WILL PROVIDE DIRECTION
THAT AUTHORITY TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
TO ESTABLISH A STATE OF HOP
EXPERIMENTAL FISHERY PERMITS.
THIS PROGRAM WILL SPUR COST
EFFECTIVE IMPROVEMENTS IN STATE
FISHERY MANAGEMENT IT'S A
REINTRODUCTION OF A PRIOR OF MY
PRIOR BILL.
THAT CONTAINS REVISIONS THAT
WERE NEGOTIATED BETWEEN MY
OFFICE AND SPONSORS.
I END THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE CALIFORNIA'S LONG BEEN
LEADING THE NATION WORLD AND
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICY IN
SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT OUR
FISHERY PRACTICES JOIN THAT
FIGHT SO PLEASE DON'T FLOUNDER.
AND DON'T GIVE ME ANY CARP.
PLEASE VOTE I ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE --
MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE.
I TELL YOU ABOUT ICE FIFTY ONE
NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE TWENTY SIX HE BE. FIVE OH
FIVE BY THIS COMEY AERO
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIVE ALL FIVE
BY SOME THE RIVER CARILLO
ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS.
THIS COMING YEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB FIVE OH FIVE RETREAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW
JUDGE TO EXTEND THE TIME FOR
DISCLOSURE OF AN EXPERT WITNESS.
TO ONE HUNDRED DAYS IN MATTERS
BROUGHT BY THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA.
THESE MEDICAL EXPERTS PROVIDE
EXPERT TESTIMONY RELATIVE TO THE
CASE AS WALLACE CONDUCT
PROFESSIONAL COMPETENCY MEDICAL
AND PSYCHIATRIC EXAMS.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES INFORMATION
TO REAP BE PROVIDED UP WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS AND WITH THIS THAT
BILL DOES IS GIVE UP MORE TIME
TO FOR THE PRESENTATION OF THESE
EXPERT WITNESSES --
IF AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
BELIEVES THAT IT'S APPROPRIATE
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COME HERE SEE
NOTE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPOOL OVER THE ROLE.
OUR MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS THERE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTES
AYE SIXTY THREE NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN [inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
CALDERON.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. FOR YOUR
MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE SIXTY
THREE TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TEAM TO TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER NINE
ON SECOND READING SP.
ONE TWENTY ROTH WITHOUT
REFERENCE TO THE READING FILE.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU WE OPPOSE THEM --
MOTION AND THAT'S FOR WORLD.
MS WALDRON IS WITHHOLDING
UNANIMOUS CONSENT.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISTER
BONTA SECONDS ON THE RULE
SUSPENSION MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
AYE VOTE AND MISS WALDRON IS IF
FOR NO VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN
I. MISS WALDRON NO.
IT TAKES FORTY ONE OF THE RULES
SUSPENSION.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE.
AYES FORTY SEVEN KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
TAKE UP WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE.
THIS IS SENATE BILL.
ONE TWENTY SENATE BILL.
ONE TWENTY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO
FILE CLERK WILL READ.
SENATE BILL ONE TWENTY BY
SENATOR ROTH AND ACTUALLY IN THE
WATER [inaudible]
THIS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I AM
PROUD 2% SP ONE TWENTY ON BEHALF
OF SENATOR ROTH A BILL TO
ENHANCE PROTECTIONS OVERSTATES
DESERT BY CREATING A PROCESS FOR
THE STATE TO ASSESS PROPOSALS.
TO EXPORT DOES OUR GROUNDWATER
TO OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE.
THERE IS A NEED FOR GREATER
STATE OVERSIGHT A PROJECTS THAT
SEEK TO TAKE WATER OUT OF THE
DESERT AND SEND IT TO OUR URBAN
AREAS.
LAST YEAR I WAS SURPRISED TO
LEARN THAT A PROJECT IS
PROPOSING TO EXTRACT FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER
ANNUALLY FROM BENEATH THE MOJAVE
DESERT.
AND EXPORT THE WATER TO WATER
AGENCIES OVER TWO HUNDRED MILES
AWAY WHEN THE UNITED STATES
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY INDICATED THAT
IT CAN ONLY SUSTAIN A MAXIMUM
TEN THOUSAND ACRE FEET.
DESPITE THE US DEPARTMENT OF THE
INTERIOR'S LONGSTANDING CONCERNS
ABOUT THE EFFECT THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD HAVE A NATURAL SPRINGS IN
THE MOJAVE.
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
REVERSED LONGSTANDING POLICIES
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS.
CONSIDERING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ABDICATED ITS
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT ITS
PUBLIC LANDS IN THE MOJAVE THE
STATE HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
ENSURE THE REVIEW THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY INTENDED TO TAKE
PLACE BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BEFORE AUTHORIZING A PROJECT
THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT SUCH A
FRAGILE ECO SYSTEM.
FURTHERMORE CONSIDERING THE
CONFLICTING ESTIMATES ON THE
AMOUNT OF WATER THAT CAN BE
SUSTAINED ONLY SIXTEEN A PLEA
ATTRACT EXTRACTED A SERVER
PROVIDED BY COULD THESE THE
PROJECTS APPLICANT.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
FIGURES THE STATE MUST CONDUCT
SCIENTIFIC ANALYSIS BEFORE
ALLOWING THE EXTRACTION OF WATER
FROM THE DEAD THIS DESERT
AQUIFER.
IF IT IS FOUND THAT THE REGION
CAN SUSTAINABLY SUPPLY FIFTY
THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF WATER
ANNUALLY THEN LET'S AUTHORIZES
PROJECT IN ALLOWED TO MOVE
FORWARD.
HOWEVER WE MUST ENSURE THE
SCIENTIFIC REVIEW THAT WE ARE
EXPECTING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
TO UNDERTAKE IS COMPLETED FIRST
IF WE'RE GOING TO MAKE AN
EDUCATED DECISION.
YESTERDAY AND THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE WANTS
SENATOR ROTH PRESENTED THIS
BILL.
HE SAID SOMETHING INTERESTING HE
SAID YOU KNOW I DON'T CONSIDER
MYSELF TO BE AN ENVIRONMENTALIST
I GENERALLY DON'T LIKE A LOT OF
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY HE SAID.
BUT WE ONLY HAVE ONE SHOT WHEN
IT COMES.
TO THIS AQUIFER IS NOT COVERED
BY SIGMA AT THE SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT THAT
THE REST OF THE AQUIFER IN THE
STATE.
ARE A BARGE A SUBJECT TO TO WE
KNOW THAT A FOR GROUND WATER
AQUIFER IS OVERDRAWN IT CAN
COLLAPSE AND WE NEVER GET IT
BACK AGAIN.
SENATOR ROTH ASKED ALL OF THE
PARTIES OVER AND OVER AGAIN HE
SAID IF THIS FAILS ARE YOU GONNA
BE RESPONSIBLE ARE YOU GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE ARE YOU GONNA BE
RESPONSIBLE.
NONE OF THEM SAID THEY WOULD
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
RESPONSE.
OR THAT --
AND TAKE IT ON THEMSELVES.
THE STATE THIS THIS AQUIFER IS
SURROUNDED BY EXTREMELY FRAGILE
PROTECTED FEDERAL LANDS AND WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY AS
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
PROJECT DOES ANY HARM TO THOSE
LANDS.
I WILL ALSO POINT OUT THAT THIS
IS NOT JUST AN ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUE I'VE EVER FROM NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES IN THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT ABOUT THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF WATER AND
SPRINGS.
AND HOW LOSING THOSE SPRINGS
WOULD BE DEVASTATING TO THEIR
CULTURES THEY ARE STRONGLY IN
FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
I HAVE ALSO HEARD FROM
CALIFORNIANS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE ABOUT THE NEED TO PROTECT
OUR BELOVED CALIFORNIA DESERT.
WITHOUT I WOULD URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR LEVINE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THE HEARSE MISS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THE
MOJAVE DESERT IS ONE OF THE MOST
ARID REGIONS IN NORTH AMERICA IT
RECEIVES LESS ANNUAL
PRECIPITATION THEN THE SONORAN.
DESERT IN GREAT BASIN YET OVER
200-030-0401 PLANT SPECIES ARE
FOUND IN THE MOJAVE AS WELL AS
MUCH WILDLIFE INCLUDING A
NUMBER.
OF ENDANGERED SPECIES AND
IMPERILED SPECIES ANY PROPOSAL
TAKE WATER FROM THIS EXCEEDINGLY
DRY.
ECOSYSTEM THAT STILL MANAGES TO
THRIVE WITH PLANTS AND WILDLIFE
MUST BE SUBJECT TO THE UTMOST
SCRUTINY POSSIBLE.
CLIMATE CHANGE WILL LIKELY TO
DISRUPT THE DESERT'S ECOLOGICAL
BALANCE EVEN FURTHER IN THE
YEARS TO COME WHICH IS ANOTHER
REASON THAT THE WATER PROJECT
THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF AB ONE
TWENTY WARRANTS MORE
EXAMINATION.
TO THE BEST PEER REVIEWED
SCIENCE THIS BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE THIS PROJECT RECEIVES THE
THOROUGH SCIENTIFIC REVIEW THAT
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS AYE URGING AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
MR MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
HERE RECOMMENDS.
A COLLEAGUE SAID WE HEARD THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AND THE NATIONAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
THIS BILL IS --
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR TO A BILL
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
INTRODUCED LAST YEAR.
ARE A BILL THAT RECEIVED A RARE
LETTER OF SUPPORT FROM GOVERNOR
BROWN.
WHERE HE TALKED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING?
TIGHTENED REVIEW TO PROTECT THE
PROCESS AND SENSITIVE ECOSYSTEM
THAT WE HAVE IN THE MOJAVE
DESERT.
SO WE HAVE.
OUR STRONG INDICATION THAT THIS
IS A STRONG SUPPORTER BY
GOVERNOR BROWN.
THIS BILL IS ALSO ARE SUPPORTIVE
WE RECEIVED LETTERS AND FROM
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM.
FROM UNITED STATES SENATOR DIE
AND ALL HIGHLIGHTING THE THAT
THE FACT THAT THIS IS A TOP
PRIORITY FOR OUR STATEWIDE
LEADERSHIP.
I URGE.
MY COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL [inaudible]
YOU BROKE [inaudible]
YOUR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
SP ONE TWENTY SIX TO PROHIBIT
THE KIDDIES PROJECT AND PROPOSES
TO ELIMINATE THE SUPPLY OF
WATER.
THAT CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS
ANNUALLY.
THIS PROJECT IMPROVES THE LOCAL
WATER SUPPLY RIBAT RELIABILITY.
AND REDUCES DEMAND FOR IMPORTED
WATER FROM THE DELTA AND THE
COLORADO RIVER.
COULD EASE IS CLOSER TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA POPULATION CENTER SO
LESS ENERGY IS NEEDED TO MOVE
THE WATER.
THIS WILL HELP MANAGE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ENERGY MAN'S REDUCE
EMISSIONS AND STABILIZE WATER
RATES.
THIS PROJECT WILL CREATE NEW
GROUND WATER STORAGE
OPPORTUNITIES IMPROVE THE WATER
QUALITY BY LOWERING THE SAW
CONTACT.
FROM THE COLORADO RIVER.
THE PROJECT WOULD CREATE SPORT
OVER FIFTY NINE HUNDRED JOBS
GENERATE MORE THAN EIGHT HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
INCLUDING FIVE POINT FOUR
MILLION PER YEAR FOR THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY BUDGET.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROJECTS THAT PROCESS HAS BEEN
EXTENSIVELY REVIEWED
PERSEVERANCE SEQUEL. TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN THE TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THE SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT WHICH IS A WATER
DISTRICT IN MY DISTRICT.
CONDUCTED AN EIGHTEEN MONTH
PUBLIC REVIEW PROCESS DURING
WHICH INFORMATION WORKSHOPS
EDUCATIONAL SEMINARS PUBLIC
HEARINGS WERE HELD. TO ENCOURAGE
DIALOGUE FROM THE COMMITTEE IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE FOLLOWING
YEARS OF ANALYSIS FIELD STUDIES
PUBLIC REVIEW.
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
CERTIFIED THE FINAL III ARE.
FEDERALLY AND APPROVE THE
PROJECT UNDER SEQUEL THE FBI ARE
SUMMARIZED THE PROJECT WOULD
AVOID ANY SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS TO
DOESN'T RESOURCES.
INCLUDING CRITICAL RESOURCES OF
THE DESERT ENVIRONMENT SUCH AS
VEGETATION MOUNTAIN SPRINGS
WATER AND AIR QUALITY.
ALSO AS A RESPONSIBLE AGENCY
UNDER SEQUESTRATION BERNADINE
FACILITY IN A REVIEW PROCESS
OF THE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
MODERATING AND MITIGATION
PROJECT. 200-012-2000 TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN APPROVALS OF THE
KIDDIES PROJECT WERE CHALLENGED
IN COURT [inaudible]
THESE CASES WERE WITHDRAWN OR
OTHERWISE DISMISSED AND SIX
PRECEDED THE TRIAL IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN THE ORANGE
COUNTY SPIRIT COURT DENIED ALL
THE SEQUEL CLAIMS AGAINST THE
PROJECT AND UPHELD THE PROJECT'S
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
AND APPROVALS THESE RULINGS WERE
APPEALED TO THE CALIFORNIA COURT
OF APPEALS FOURTH DISTRICT.
AND THAT WAS UPHELD IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND IN THE
COURT CASE.
IT WAS CLEAR THAT THE GROUND
WATER PLAN.
WAS TO AVOID [inaudible]
ADVERSE IMPACTS.
AN UNDESIRABLE RESULTS TO THE
REGION INCLUDING.
GROUND WATER AQUIFERS TAPPED BY
THE PROJECT.
LOCAL SPRINGS BRIAN RESOURCES IN
BRISTOL AND COULD THESE DRY
LAKES AIR QUALITY VEGETATION IN
THE MOJAVE DESERT REGION AND
ALSO AFFECTED ADJACENT AREAS.
ALONG THE COLORADO RIVER AND ITS
TRIBUTARIES.
THIS WOULD ADD TWO MORE REVIEWS
TO THE SECRET PROJECTS DISREGARD
DE THOROUGH SECRET PROCESS THAT
WAS APPROVED.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WE GO BACK
TO SEE QUIRK AND WE DEMAND
PROJECTS GO THROUGH IT.
SOME WE EXEMPT FROM SEQUEL BUT
THIS ONE WAS APPROVED BY SEQUEL
WHICH IS THE GOLD STANDARD AND
NOW WE'RE SAYING.
THAT IT'S NOT.
IF THIS PROJECT COULD RESULT IN
THE SIX POINT ONE BILLION DOLLAR
SAVINGS AND AVOID COSTS OVER A
FIFTY YEAR PERIOD DISTANCE DOT
AFFECT ANY OF THE SACRED
MONUMENTS IN THE DESERT.
THIS IS BAD PRECEDENT ANY OTHER
PROJECT IN YOUR DISTRICT TO GOES
TO SEE GROW. ONE DAY SOMEBODY
COULD COME AND SAY NOT THAT
WASN'T GOOD ENOUGH LET'S DO IT
AGAIN I ASK FOR NO THE MR
OBERNOLTE.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES TO DISS IN MY
DISTRICT.
SO I KNOW A LOT ABOUT THIS
PROJECT.
AND I ASSURE YOU IT IS
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLEX.
THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES TO
CONSIDER HERE.
I HAVE TO OBJECT TO THIS BILL
JUST.
ON THE BASIS OF THE PROCESS WERE
FOLLOWING.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT THIS.
WE'VE GOT A PRIVATE PARTY THAT
OWN SOME PRIVATE LAND AND THEY
HAVE INVESTED MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IN TRYING TO DEVELOP A PROJECT.
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH EXHAUSTIVE
REVIEW BOTH ENVIRONMENTALLY AND
OTHERWISE THEY'VE GONE FOR
REVIEW BY THE COUNTY SAN BERTINO
THEY'VE BEEN REVIEWED --
WITH SEQUEL WITH US
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT
THEY'VE GOT A FILE A FEDERAL
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT THAT
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH.
ITS TAKEN THEM YEARS AND YEARS
TO GET TO THIS POINT.
AND AT THE VERY LAST MINUTE.
WE'RE GONNA PULL THE RUG OUT
FROM UNDER THEIR FEET.
AND TELL THEM THAT THEY HAVE TO
DO MORE THEY CAN'T GO FORWARD
THAT'S WRONG.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE FOR THE PROJECT OR
AGAINST THE PROJECT THAT'S
WRONG.
THAT DOESN'T GIVE THOSE PART OF
THOSE PEOPLE DUE PROCESS AND
IT'S DEPRIVING THEM OF THE FAIR
USE OF THEIR PROPERTY.
IT'S NOT RIGHT TO INTRODUCE A
BILL THE LAST WEEK OF SESSION
AND RAM RAILROADED THROUGH HERE.
WERE WERE VOTING ON IT THE DAY
AFTER IT FIRST PASSED OUT OF
COMMITTEE.
LET ME POINT OUT ALSO THAT WE
HAVE THE SIMILAR BILL THAT WE
HEARD LAST YEAR.
THAT BILL WENT THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS.
THIS BILL HAS GONE THROUGH
APPROPRIATIONS ONE NOT.
WE'RE BEING ASKED TO VOTE ON
THIS PRECIPITOUSLY WITH NO
DELIBERATION AND I ONE OBJECT TO
JUST ON GENERAL PROCESS SO
PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS.
AND IF WE WANT TO HAVE A REASON
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS PROJECT
AND LET'S DO THAT.
WHAT'S COME BACK NEXT YEAR AND
WILL SIT DOWN AND WHATEVER
REASON PROCESS THAT FOLLOWS THE
RULES.
AND NOT DISOBEYS EVERY RULE THAT
WE HAVE THIS CHAMBER AS THIS
LEGISLATION HAS PLEASE VOTE NO.
STERN HARPER.
HERE RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I RISE TO OPPOSE S. B. ONE
TWENTY BECAUSE IT RUNS ROUGHSHOD
OVER PROPERTY RIGHTS.
CURRENTLY SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO
TRANSFER WATER CANNOT BE DENIED
THE USE OF A WATER CONVEYANCE
FACILITY PROVIDED THAT THERE IS
UNUSED CAPACITY IN THAT
FACILITY.
AND FAIR COMPENSATION IS PAID
FOR THAT USE.
THE KIDDIES WATER PROJECT AS
POINTED OUT BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
OUT DANA POINT.
PROPOSES TO PUMP AND THEN
TRANSFER FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET PER YEAR AT LEAST PARTIALLY
TO THE COLORADO RIVER AQUEDUCT
OPERATED BY THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT.
AND IT WOULD INDEED.
SERVE MANY OF THE FOLKS WHO ARE
IN MY DISTRICT AS WELL AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM DANA POINT IN
SOUTHERN ORANGE COUNTY.
AND WE'VE ALSO HEARD THE
VIEWPOINT FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BIG BEAR LAKE THAT REPRESENTS
THE AREA IN PARTICULAR.
BUT BY PROHIBITING THIS TRANSFER
FOR THE KIDDIES PROJECT THIS
BILL PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE A
SUPPLY OF WATER THAT COULD MEET
THE NEEDS. FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE ANNUALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PROJECT WATER SUPPLIES COULD
RESULT IN SIX POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS.
AND AVOIDED COSTS OVER A FIFTY
YEAR PERIOD.
THESE BENEFITS WOULD NOT ONLY BE
REALIZED BY THE PROJECT
SUBSCRIBERS BUT EXPERIENCED BY
ALL WATER USERS THROUGHOUT THE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION
BECAUSE OF COURSE.
THIS IMPACTS ALL OF US IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ARE NEED FOR
WATER.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THIS IS
PRECEDENT SETTING WELL THIS BILL
CONTINUES.
OR PERTAINS TO THE COULD THESE
WATER PROJECT IT SETS THE TABLE
FOR FUTURE LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
TO MAKE END RUNS AROUND SI KHOA.
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM DANA POINT.
POINTED OUT.
THEY HAVE SPENT THE MONEY.
I GET THE APPROVALS UNDER THE
PROCESS AND ALL THIS DOES IS IT
JUST CRUMPLES UP THAT PAPER AND
THROWS IT OUT.
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IN OUR
STATE IS KEY WHETHER IT'S ENERGY
WHETHER IT'S WATER WHETHER IT'S
TRANSPORTATION.
BUT IF WE'RE GOING TO PULL THE
RUG FROM UNDER OUR PROJECTS LIKE
THIS.
WE SHOULD SAY GOODBYE TO ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO INVEST IN
CALIFORNIA FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS LIKE THIS BECAUSE THEY
WON'T BE ABLE TO TRUST THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AFTER YOU PUT IN
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE APPROVALS.
HERE WITHIN THIS STATE.
I GET IT THAT THIS PROJECT MIGHT
NEED NOT BE POPULAR AMONG SOME
OF THE MAJORITY.
MIGHT NOT BE POPULAR MAKING A
PURPLE UP A PARTICULAR U. S.
SENATOR.
THAT IS NOT RIGHT. FOR US TO
PULL THE RUG FROM UNDER THIS
PROJECT IN THIS WAY IT IS WRONG.
IT IS UNFAIR.
AND IT IS OWN SHOTS.
AND FRANKLY I'M SURPRISED.
THAT SO MANY WOULD TRY TO TURN
THEIR BACKS ON THESE PRINCIPLES
WITHIN THIS BODY I STRONGLY URGE
A NO VOTE ON THIS UNDERHANDED
BILL [inaudible]
MS WALDRON [inaudible]
YOUR RECORD.
KIM MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
--
I RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL.
BY PROHIBITING THE TRANSFER OF
THE KIDNEYS PROJECT THIS BILL
PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE A SUPPLY
OF WATER.
THAT CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE ANNUALLY
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LET ME
REPEAT THAT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ANNUALLY --
AS A MEMBER FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE BIGGEST
ISSUES IN MY DISTRICT IS WATER.
AND THE VEIL ABILITY OF WATER --
IN A REASONABLE PRICE THAT
AFFECTS ALL OF US IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES.
OUR HOMES THE ABILITY TO GROW
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND WATER ALON'S SO.
THIS IS --
IF TO TWENTY YEARS THE PROJECT
HAS FINALLY GOT A PATH TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND NOW THIS BILL ARRIVES.
TAKING A PRIVATE PROPERTY RIGHTS
THE PROJECT IS ALL ON PRIVATE
LANDS NOT PUBLIC LANDS.
THIS BILL SO ITS A PRECEDENCE
THE COULD NEEDS PROJECT HAS
ALREADY BEEN THROUGH THE SEQUEL
PROCESS NOW ADDING ANOTHER STEP
TO SEEK WHILE.
THIS CAN HAPPEN TO ANY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT OF THIS
BILL HAVE PASSES DO WE REALLY
WANT TO STOP SITES RESERVOIR
TEMPERANCE FLAT.
THE DIESEL PLANTS THAT ALREADY
TAKE LONG ENOUGH IN MY DISTRICT
TO BE IN MY AREA TO BE APPROVED.
THIS PROJECT INCREASES
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SUPPLY.
KILLING THIS PROJECT WILL
INCREASE PRESSURE ON
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY STRESSED
WATER RESOURCES IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
THE LAST THING WE SHOULD BE
DOING IS REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
WATER AVAILABLE TO OUR CITIZENS
ARE FARMS.
AND OUR ECONOMY'S I URGE A NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON.
MR CHOW YOUR RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE TWENTY S. B. ONE TWENTY N.
SURE IS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LANDS COMMISSION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
MAKE A FINDING THAT THE TRANSFER
WILL OF WATER FROM THE
UNDERGROUND BASE IN UNDERLYING
DESERT LANDS WILL NOT ADVERSELY
AFFECT.
THE NATURAL OR CULTURAL
RESOURCES OF FEDERAL OR STATE
LANDS PRIOR TO THE TRANSFER
BEING ALLOWED.
THE DESERT ECOSYSTEM AND KNOW
MOJAVE DESERT IS EXTREMELY
FRAGILE.
SMALL CHANGES CAN HAVE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS I'M
CONCERNED THAT THERE HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT STUDIES THAT RANGE
WIDELY AND POTENTIAL IMPACT.
THAT COULD THESE PROJECT COULD
HAVE ON THE ECOSYSTEM.
HAVING THE ADDITIONAL STUDY OF A
PROJECT AFFECTING STATE LANDS
ESPECIALLY FOR FRAGILE.
DESERT ECOSYSTEMS IS
APPROPRIATE.
SO WE DON'T INADVERTENTLY CAUSE
IRREPARABLE HARM.
S. B. ONE TWENTY FULFILLS THAT
GO.
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR IDEA.
NAME IS CHAU.
DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND AND
MEMBERS.
I RISE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF THE
THE PIECE OF THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION SB.
ONE TWENTY AND I DO THAT WITHOUT
--
WITH UNDERSTANDING AT LEAST IN
MY MIND THAT --
WHEN I WAS APPROACHED BY FOLKS
WITH THE COULD THESE PROJECT I
WAS INITIALLY IN FAVOR OF WHAT
THEY WERE SAYING?
BECAUSE I BELIEVE IN PROCESS AND
PROCEDURE AND THAT WHEN YOU
AGREE TO A CERTAIN PROCESS IN A
PROCEDURE YOU LIVE BY THAT
PROCESS AND PROCEDURE.
AND I WAS LED TO BELIEVE THAT
EVERYTHING WAS IN LINE AND
EVERYTHING WAS CORRECT.
UNTIL I GOT A COPY OF THE
TIMELINE.
AND I REALIZE THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD REQUIRED AN
ADDITIONAL REPORT TO BE DONE THE
NEPA.
OUT TO BE DONE ON THIS PIECE OF
PROPERTY.
AND IT WAS IN PLACE TO BE DONE
UNTIL OBVIOUSLY ADMINISTRATIONS
CHANGED.
AND THE LAWS IN THE A CONCERN
THE ENVIRONMENT WERE RELAXED.
AND THEREFORE THEY WOULD THEN
TAKE IT OUT OF THE NEPA PROCESS
A BECAUSE OUR CURRENT PRESIDENT.
DID NOT OBVIOUSLY OVERTURNED A
LOT OF THINGS THAT OBAMA PUT IN
PLACE AND ONE OF THINGS PUT IN
PLACE WAS THE STUDY FOR THE NEPA
BEEPER.
OF STUDY TO BE DONE ON THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT.
AND BECAUSE THAT WAS IN PLACE IN
MY MIND THAT ALSO DEFINED THE
RULES OF THE GAME.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THEN THOSE
RULES CHANGE WE GET A NEW
PRESIDENT WHO THEN DECIDES TO
RELAX ALL THE STANDARDS AND
REMOVE THEM FROM THIS PROJECT TO
DO THE LAST STUDY THAT'S DONE.
SO NOT THAT I'M.
NOT AS KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT
OTHERS WITH REGARD.
FARMERS IN THE WATER IN THIS SO
ON BUT I DO BELIEVE IN PROCESS
IN THE GAMES AT A BEER.
AND THIS GAME WAS IN PLACE FOR
THEM TO DO THIS FINAL REPORT.
BUT BECAUSE THEY ONE OF THE
PERSONS WHO NOW IS ON THE
INTERIOR COMMITTEE IS ONE OF THE
OWNERS ARE ADVOCATES OF OF OF
THE COULD THESE.
THIS WAS THEN TAKEN OFF THE LIST
AND THEN PUT ON A HIGHER LISTS
OF BASICALLY TO ALLOW THIS
PROJECT TO MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT
DOING NEPA. TO ME THAT'S UNFAIR.
THE PROCESS WAS IN PLACE I
SHOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT AND THEY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PREPARED TO DO
IT AND FOR THAT REASON AS WE
LOOK DEAL WITH AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT CONTINUES TO WANT TO
RELEASE.
AND TO ROUTE TO RELAX ALL OF THE
PROCESSES CONCERNING THE
ENVIRONMENT I'M IN FAVOR OF THIS
BECAUSE IN CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE
AND PROCESS AND WE BELIEVE IN
STUDIES THAT WE BELIEVE IN
LOOKING CAREFULLY AT THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE BEEN
THROUGH SEQUEL THERE OTHER
PROCESSES THAT YOU HAVE TO GO TO
PEOPLE WAS ONE AND THIS REQUIRES
THAT TO TAKE PLACE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOTH SB.
ONE TWENTY THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I WHEN I
AUTHORED THE WATER BOND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOURTEEN I SPENT.
ABOUT EIGHTEEN MONTHS TRAVELING
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
ASSESSING THE PLUSES AND MINUSES
OF VARIOUS WATER PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
BASED ON THAT EXPERIENCE I'M
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SP.
ONE TWENTY THE COULD EASE WATER
PROJECT WOULD TAKE WATER FROM A
DESERT ENVIRONMENT WERE
GROUNDWATER REPLENISHMENT IS
LIMITED.
S. WE WANT TWENTY WOULD NOT BE
NECESSARY IF IT WEREN'T FOR THE
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
KIDDIES AND THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHICH HAS
MIRACULOUSLY DECIDED THAT THE
PROJECT DOES NOT NEED FEDERAL
REVIEW.
GIVE THE ABDICATION A FEDERAL
RESPONSIBILITY AND THE ABSENCE
OF FEDERAL REVIEW SP ONE TWENTY
INSURERS.
OUR DUE DILIGENCE.
HAVING THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION DETERMINE WHETHER
SUCH A WATER TRANSFER ADVERSELY
AFFECTS STATE LANDS WOULD SEEM
TO BE PRETTY OBVIOUS AND
RESPONSIBLE OVERSIGHT.
THE DESERT IS ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
TREASURES.
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON S. B. WHEN.
TWENTY THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THAT WILL BE OUR CLOTHES.
QUIRK LUBLIN ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK.
WILL CLOSE THE ROLL EYES FORTY
FIVE NOTES.
TWENTY THAT MEASURE PASSES
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A PAIR TO LIVE THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY NINE THAT IS AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISHED
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLES.
AND TALLY VOTE.
I FORTY FOUR KNOWS.
TWENTY TWO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN
.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A
FORTY FIVE MINUTE RECESS UNDER
CALL OF THE SPEAKER.
IS RECESS UNDER CALL FORTY FIVE
MINUTES WE WILL BEGIN TAKING UP
I PROMPTLY AT SEVEN THIRTY THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING IN ROOM FOUR THIRTY
SEVEN IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM.
FORTY TWO OH TO TRANSPORTATION
OF FOUR THIRTY SEVEN
APPROPRIATIONS AND ROOM FORTY
TWO A TWO FORTY FIVE MINUTE
RECESS UNDER CALL.
WE'LL SEE YOU BACK HERE PROMPTLY
AT
SEVEN THIRTY MEMBERS WE ARE
BACK IN SESSION
MEMBERS PLEASE
RETURN OF FLORA.
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE REPORT TO THE
FLOOR WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP
ITEMS RIGHT NOW.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
WE ARE AT FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY SEVEN WHEN WE FIND
MISTER LEVINE THERE'S MISS
LEVINE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN A. B. [inaudible] FOURTEEN
THIRTY SIX AND THE CLERK WILL
READ.
AT SOME LEVEL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX BY SOME NEW MEMBER LEVINE
AND OTHERS AND I PLAYED THE
HEALING ARTS.
MR LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX IS A BILL THAT REQUIRES
MARRIAGE AND FAMILY THERAPISTS
EDUCATIONAL PSYCHOLOGISTS.
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKERS AND
PROFETAS TIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS. TO RECEIVE SUICIDE
PREVENTION TRAINING FOR
ASSESSMENT TREATMENT AND
MANAGEMENT.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE ALL MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS HAVE THE
TOOLS THEY NEED. TO ASSESS TREE
IN REFER INDIVIDUALS WITH
SUICIDAL IDEATION.
AS RESULT THIS BILL WILL HELP
DECREASE THE GROWING NUMBER OF
SUICIDES IN CALIFORNIA AND SAVE
LIVES.
MEMBERS YOU PROBABLY HEARD ME
TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE BEFORE
THIS IS A ISSUE I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR ABOUT FOUR YEARS
AND A NUMBER OF BILLS LAST YEAR.
WE PASSED MY BILL THAT I DID THE
EXACT SAME THING FOR
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
IN THIS YEAR WITH THIS BILL WE
HAVE REMOVED ALL OPPOSITION
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION AT ALL.
TO THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE BECAUSE FOR
THOSE WHO ARE SEEKING HELP.
AS A FORMER MARINE CITY RESIDENT
A OF MARIN AND I TELL PIOUS HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATE TO PATRICK COR
SAID. FOR EVERY DARK NIGHT
THERE'S A BRIGHTER DAY ASPIRIN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
A CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND SALAS ABOUT
EYES.
FIFTY FOUR NO ZERO THIS SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK. TO DOCTOR QUIRK SIDE ON
THIS IS.
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTEEN AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY FOUR BY SOME A MEMBER
QUIRK INEPTLY TO HAZARDOUS WASTE
[inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
OF THIS IS THE SAVE THE MINNOWS
BILL.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY FOUR
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE ROLE. TO VALUE
WAIT AND ADOPT HUMANE OPTIONAL
ALTERNATIVES TO THE CUTE.
AQUATIC TOXICITY TEST FOR
HAZARDOUS WASTE IDENTIFICATION.
IT RECEIVED NO NO VOTES AND
MANAGE TAKEN IN THE SENATE WERE
TECHNICAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK DOT QUIRK SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARPOOL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL THE VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX NOW
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE OUT FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
EIGHT THIS IS BACK IN REGULAR
FILE ORDER FILE ITEM.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT AB.
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NAZARIAN AND OTHERS ACTUALLY
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
TWENTY EIGHT SIXTY THREE WILL
GUARANTEE THAT CONSUMERS PAY THE
LOWEST AVAILABLE COST FOR THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS.
AND IT'LL ALSO GUARANTEE THAT
pYOUR CONSTITUENTS LOVE YOU FOR
VOTING FOR THIS BILL.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHERE I VOTE.
THANK YOU MENTION THIS THIS
AREA.
SENIOR DISCLOSURE DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
IS THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIES BUT I FIFTY
SEVEN NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE TWENTY NINE AB. TWENTY EIGHT
NINETY NINE COOPERATE.
SOME LEGAL TWENTY EIGHT NINETY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER RUBIO
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
CANNABIS MISS RUBIO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY NINE IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE.
WHICH PROHIBITS THE CANNABIS
LICENSE FEE FROM PUBLISHING OR
DISSEMINATING ADVERTISING OR
MARKETING WHILE THE LICENSE IS
SUSPENDED.
WE TOOK AMENDMENTS IN THE SENATE
TO FOCUS ON ADDRESSING SUSPENDED
LICENSES BEING ADVERTISED.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE THE CLERK
WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED AND
EVER SINCE
FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY AB NINE NINETY EIGHT
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE NINETY EIGHT
BY SOME REMEMBER GRAYSON AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY TO CRIME VICTIMS
[inaudible]
MISTER GRAYSON.
RETURN MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
NINE NINETY EIGHT IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE SENATE AMENDMENTS
DELETE THE PREVIOUS CONTENTS OF
THE BILL AND INSTEAD OFFER A
CITIES COUNTIES AND COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
TO ESTABLISH DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAMS THESE TEAMS
WILL CONSIST OF PERSONNEL WHO
ARE TRAINED IN THE MANAGEMENT OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES.
AND WHO ARE QUALIFIED TO PROVIDE
A BROAD RANGE OF SERVICES
RELATED TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR
HUMAN TRAFFICKING THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY TEAM IS AN
ESTABLISHED MODEL FOR ASSISTING
INDIVIDUALS.
AND FAMILIES STRUGGLING WITH
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE AB NINE
NINETY EIGHT WILL ALLOW VICTIM
ADVOCATES TO COOPERATE AND
LEVERAGE RESOURCES FOR THE
VULNERABLE VICTIMS OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
A AYE VOTE IN EFFORTS TO SUPPORT
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING IN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THANK YOU MISS GRAYSON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO GO?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TELL YOU ABOUT
AYE SIXTY NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY ONE IS AB TWELVE FOURTEEN
BY MR STONE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWELVE FOURTEEN BY
SALLY MEMBER MARK STONE AND
ACTUALLY TO JUVENILES
[inaudible]
MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS WHEN ADULTS ARE
DETERMINED TO BE INCOMPETENT
STAND TRIAL THEIR PROCEDURES IN
PROGRAMS TO HELP ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES.
NOT TRUE WITH OUR JUVENILES AND
THEY TEND THE LANGUAGE.
AND JUVENILE HALLS WITH OUT ANY
SUPPORT OR ANY HELP.
BEEN WORKING WITH.
THE PROBATION OFFICE IS A
CALIFORNIA COME UP WITH AN
ANSWER TO THAT SOLUTION.
THAT IS THIS BILL.
THAT WE HAD SOME ISSUES WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON CERTAIN RULES
THAT SOME SOME OF THE JUVENILES
THEY SEVEN SEVEN BE OFFENDERS WE
HAVE ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES BY
WORKING CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S WITH THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE I ASK FOR YOUR
CONCURRENCE INSIDE AND
AMENDMENTS.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
.
MISTER STONE WAS A CALL
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY TO AB SEVEN HUNDRED JONES
SAWYER.
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN HUNDRED BY
SOME REMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
OTHERS ACTUALLY AFTER
ADVERTISING.
MISTER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
SEVEN HUNDRED WAS AMENDED IN THE
SENATE TO EXTEND THE SUNSET ON
EXEMPTION TO THE OUTDOOR.
ADVERTISING AT FOR ADVERTISING
DISPLAYS LOCATED ON THE PREMISES
OF AN ARENA.
JANUARY ONE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO JANUARY.
ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE AB SEVEN
HOW DO IT WILL GIVE THE LOS
ANGELES FOOTBALL CLUB LA FC MORE
TIME TO SET UP ADVERTISING
AROUND THE STADIUM AS PERMITTED
BY LAW.
THE LA FC IS THE NEWEST
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS FRANCHISE IN
CALIFORNIA PLANE OF FIRST SEASON
THIS YEAR.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
DR VOTE.
NAME IS JONES SAWYER SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE I'M.
WAS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE SIXTY ONE KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY THREE PASS A RETAIN
ON FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY FOUR
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY FIVE THAT BRINGS US
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SIX A. B.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY TO CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND I
THINK I'LL CALL IT BEVERAGES.
MS ADHERE CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY VOTE TO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WITH NO OPPOSITION.
SENATE AMENDMENTS NARROW THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL AND ADDED BEER
IN SPIRIT MANUFACTURES TO WINE
MAKERS US INTO THESE TWO MAY USE
AN EMAIL ADDRESS WEBSITE AND
PICTURE OF AN EVENT SPACE.
OR RESTAURANT IN A SOCIAL MEDIA
POST ABOUT THE SPECIAL EVENT.
LIKE A WINEMAKERS DINNER OR
TASTING A. B. C. EXPRESSED
CONCERN ABOUT TECHNICAL ENDED
AFTER THE AMENDMENT DEADLINE AND
WANTED TO STATE FOR THE RECORD
THOUGH I INTEND TO CLEAN THIS
UP.
IF NECESSARY NEXT YEAR AYE
ASPREY AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE.
THE ROLAND TELL ABOUT AYE SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SAN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND I WAS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM. ONE THIRTY FOUR ONE
THIRTY FOUR AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN
BY MR SANTIAGO THE CLERK WILL
READ.
AT SOME LEVEL TWELVE SEVENTEEN
BY SOME NUMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY DOT CULT BEVERAGES
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THIS MATTER IS OF GRAVE CONCERN.
AB TWELVE SEVENTEEN AUTHORIZED
THE DEPARTMENT OF ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL TO ISSUE A
SPECIAL GENERAL ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGE LICENSE.
THE HOLLYWOOD FOREVER CEMETERY
IN LOS ANGELES FOR INDOOR.
AND OUTDOOR EVENTS --
A I'VE REHEARSED THIS A
PRESENTATION CAREFULLY.
AND YOU WILL NOT BE LET DOWN
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO.
CA NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ITEM THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TIED ABOUT I SIXTY
ONE NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
BACK IN REGULAR FILE ORDER.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY SEVEN AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY NINE BY MISTER BERMAN.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN AND ACTUALLY THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES [inaudible]
MR MERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES A BE TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY NINE WILL BRING PARITY TO
CALIFORNIA LAW BY APPLYING
EXISTING QUALIFICATIONS FOR
BRADY AND DISTILLED SPIRITS
WHOLESALERS.
THE BEER WHOLESALERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M.
WAS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSER ALL.
TYLER I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
EIGHT A. B..
FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU AND ACT LIKE HOUSING.
SIEU.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A
BILL TO ALLOW CERTAIN KINDS OF
DEVELOPMENTS ON PUBLIC TRUST
LANDS IN MY CITY.
THIS BILL IS A CLEAN UP BILL TO
THAT TWO THOUSAND TWELVE LAW TO
ALLOW A FORMER PARKING LOT IN MY
CITY TO BE DEVELOPED IN TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY UNITS.
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND A
CHILDCARE CENTER BY CLARIFYING
THE DEFINITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO INCLUDE MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING.
AND ALSO TO CLARIFY THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT CAN INCLUDE OTHER
USES CONSISTENT WITH THE PUBLIC
TRUST AND THE BURDEN ACT.
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION AND WE'VE
HAD ZERO NO VOTES IN WITHOUT
RESPECT WE ASK FOR AN IBOOK.
THEY MISS YOU SEEN NO
DISCUSSION.
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CARP
WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TELEVOTE I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE WANT TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
ONE THIRTY NINE AB.
THREE TEN A CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TEN BY SOME
A MEMBER MEDINA AND OTHERS AND I
PLAYED COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE AT A CO AUTHOR I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
IN CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MR MEDINA.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE WELL
MEMBERS.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL TIE OF I
SUCCEED NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY ONE THIS IS AB
[inaudible]
TWELVE NINETY KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BUILT TWELVE NINETY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY THE EVIDENCE.
MR OBERNOLTE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWELVE NINETY IS
FINALLY BACK FROM THE SENATE'S
BEEN OVER THERE YEAR.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES WHO IS THE
HOLDER OF THE ATTORNEY CLIENT
PRIVILEGE WHEN A DISPUTE ARISES
BETWEEN A WARD A CONSERVATIVELY.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS REFLECT A
COMPROMISE WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL VERY CRAFT CAREFULLY
CRAFTED LANGUAGE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESERT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER OWNER AND TELL YOU WHAT I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
FILE ITEM. ONE ONE FORTY TWO IS
AB EIGHTEEN OH FIVE THE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN A FIVE BY
SOME THE MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACTUALLY COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
MISTER WHEN --
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
EIGHTEEN OH FIVE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND ZERO NO VOTES SENATE
AMENDMENTS FURTHER SPECIFY.
THE CONDITIONS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MUST MEET TO RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR THE STUDENT EQUITY
AND TREATMENT PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE ON NUMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE SIXTY THREE
NO ZERO SEVEN AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND WELL ITEM ONE
FORTY THREES AB.
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE BY SOME REMEMBER ME CAL
WORKS.
MR MAIENSCHEIN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE AFTER
TAKING CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS IN
THE SENATE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW CAO WORKS
RECIPIENTS RECEIVING TEMPORARY
HOUSING ASSISTANCE TO USE THEIR
PAYMENT TOWARDS SHARE HOW SHARED
HOUSING.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
SMOKE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
WORK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I
SIXTY SIX KNOWS ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY FOUR IS AB
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE BY SOME THE MEMBER WOULD
AND ACTUALLY THE HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES.
DOCTOR WOULD THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
REQUIRES SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES TO REPORT TO THE
OFFICE OF STATEWIDE HEALTH
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT WHETHER
OR NOT.
THE SKILLED NURSING FACILITY OR
THEIR PARTNER HAS AN OWNERSHIP
OR CONTROL.
INTEREST OF 5% OR MORE IN A
BUSINESS THAT PROVIDES ANY
SERVICE TO THIS SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THINK IT ACT WOULD SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE CORP WILL OPEN
ROLL-ON.
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS OF
A DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO GO [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU BUT I
THROUGH BEFORE.
KNOWS FIVE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED AND WANT TO PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY FIVE THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
ONE FORTY SIX AB NINETEEN NINETY
NINE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NINETY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER CHAO
ACTUALLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MISTER SHALL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS A. B.
NINETEEN NINETY NINE IS BACK.
FOR CONCURRENCE THE BILL
ESTABLISHES.
THAT PROVIDE BROADBAND SERVICES
AND EXPANDS THE TYPES OF LOCAL
AGENCIES THAT MAY PROVIDE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SERVICES.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ACT UP
PROVISIONS TO AVOID CHAPTER IN
CONFLICTS I ASK WHERE I WILL.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
THOSE ARE ALL TIED ABOUT EYES
FORTY FIVE KNOWS.
TWENTY SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
THIS IS FILE ITEM [inaudible]
ONE FORTY SEVEN DOCTOR QUIRK.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN IS AB
TWENTY ONE ELEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY ONE ELEVEN
BY SOME A MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES.
DOCTOR QUIRK THANK YOU SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB.
TWENTY ONE ELEVEN WILLOW LYING
CAO WORKS EXCEPTION PROVISIONS
SIMILE SIMILARLY TO THOSE.
USED FOR CAL FRESH MEMBERS TAKEN
IN THE SENATE REQUESTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
TO FACILITATE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE BELL AB TWENTY ONE ELEVEN IS
CO SPONSORED BY THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY.
AND THE ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
OUR CLUB NARAL.
THIS ARAB MOON ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE TALLY THE VOTE AYE
[inaudible]
SIXTY THREE KNOWS.
ONE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
IS FILE ITEM. ONE FIFTY FILE
ITEM.
ONE FIFTY AB.
TWENTY ONE SIXTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY
BY SOLELY ON RETIREMENT NECKLINE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES
[inaudible]
MR THURMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ARE RICE PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY THIS BILL MAKES A SMALL
TECHNICAL FIX WITH CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS TO A BILL WE DID LAST
YEAR.
PROVIDE CLASSIFIED WORKERS --
CLASSIFIED BENEFITS TWO
PLAYGROUND WORKERS ON OUR SCHOOL
CAMPUSES WHAT WE DIDN'T KNOW
THEN LAST YEAR'S THAT WE
INADVERTENTLY OMITTED --
THOSE SAME A PLAYGROUND WORKERS
WHO WORK ON CAMPUSES AT MARIST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BUT NOW WE KNOW SO
WE'VE INTRODUCED THIS BILL TO
CORRECT THAT.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW NOW YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THEY MISSED THURMOND.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
IN DESIRE TO VOTE.
IT IS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARAB VOTE
.
YOUR COUNTY IS TOO SHORT MISTER
THURMAN [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
DON'T MESS WHO REMEMBERS IT
LATE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE.
TELL ABOUT ICE.
FORTY TWO KNOWS.
TWENTY THREE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY ONE
A. B.. TWENTY THREE NINETEEN
KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE NINETEEN BY SOME A MEMBER
DOES AREA AND ACTUALLY THE
FOREIGN LANGUAGE EDUCATION
[inaudible]
MISTER NAZARIAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB.
TWENTY THREE NINETEEN SIMPLY THE
LEADS THE TERM FOREIGN LANGUAGE.
FROM THE EDUCATION CODE AND
REPLACES IT WITH THE TERM WORLD
LANGUAGE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE FOR THIS VERY CHALLENGING
BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE COMMISSION IS AIRING SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROAD.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THEIR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE AYES SIXTY SIX KNOWS ONE
SENATE AMENDMENTS CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY TWO AB [inaudible]
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
IRWIN AND OTHERS ACT LIKE
AGRICULTURE [inaudible]
MR WHEN.
MISTER SPEAKER A BE TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE THIS VERY WONDERFUL
BILL WOULD SEEK TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR FARMERS AND
RANCHERS SEEKING.
TRANSITION TO CLIMATE SMART
AGRICULTURE SENATE AMENDMENTS
LOWER THE AMOUNT OF THE PROGRAM
FUNDS THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
USED FROM TACTIC. FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FROM 1525% I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HER WITH THESE AMENDMENTS.
LIAM IS THERE ONE SCENE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
KIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
A DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ROLE TIE ABOUT
I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY THREE IS AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY FOUR CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
ARAMBULA AND ACTUALLY THE
MEDICATION ASSISTED TREATMENT.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FOUR IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE THIS BILL
WILL REMOVE BARRIERS TO SOME OF
THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
INNOVATIVE TREATMENT OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS.
RELAPSE PREVENTION AND OVERDOSE
REVERSAL IN MEDICATION ASSISTED
THERAPY COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS
MATT.
MEDICATIONS USED IN MATH ARE
APPROVED BY THE FDA AND MATT
PROGRAMS ARE CLINICALLY DRIVEN
AND TAILORED TO MEET EACH
PATIENT'S NEEDS.
AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FOR WILL
HAVE A DIRECT AFFECT IN REMOVING
BARRIERS TO ACCESSING HIGH
QUALITY EVIDENCE BASED CARE AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
MISTER ALAN.
I LIKE TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
THIS IS AN INCREDIBLE BILL.
THAT IS GOING TO HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE A FACT THAT I I WOULD
URGE EVERYONE TO PAY ATTENTION
DR ARAMBULA WHEN HE SPEAKS IS A
PHYSICIAN HERE. ONE OF THE
MEDICATIONS LISTA THIS BILL IS A
IS A MEDICATION ALL NALTREXONE.
NOW TRICKS ON IS COMMONLY USED.
TO BLUNT THE EUPHORIC EFFECTS
[inaudible]
OF OPIOIDS [inaudible]
ALCOHOL.
A EVEN STIMULANTS.
SUCH AS METHAMPHETAMINES
[inaudible]
THIS.
SUBSTANCE HAS BEEN PROVEN SO
EFFECTIVE.
AND SO FREE FROM SIDE TO FACT.
THAT ALEX ARE ABLE TO TAKE THIS
DAILY OR EVEN GET A SHOT ONCE
PER MONTH.
AND THEY CAN STILL ATTEMPT TO
USE THE DRUG OF THEIR CHOICE BUT
THEY WILL NO LONGER GET THAT
EUPHORIC HIGH.
AND THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST
[inaudible]
POSSIBLE.
MEDICAL TREATMENTS AVAILABLE
[inaudible]
STOP ADDICTION.
THIS IS A GREAT BILL.
THIS IS A GREAT IDEA.
THIS WILL BRING HEALTH.
REAL HELP TO THE OPIOID CRISIS
IN CALIFORNIA.
PLEASE WHAT I THEY MYSTERON SEE
NO ADDITIONAL [inaudible]
DISCUSSION I'M SORRY.
DOCTOR EGGMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
BUT THANK YOU ABOUT MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I I AM JUST GLAD
THAT IN THIS HOUSE THAT WE ARE
WILLING AND ABLE. TO USE EVERY
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO COMBAT
ADDICTION AND I ALSO ENCOURAGE
AND I'VE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THAT WILL BE THE CLOTHES.
QUIRK CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DECIDE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE AND HOW YOU VOTE
EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS THREE
SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED
IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK TO TAKE A FILE ITEM.
ONE FORTY EIGHT THIS IS MR
ACOSTA.
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY FIVE
CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE BUY SOME THE MEMBER COST
AND OTHERS ENACTED INTO LICENSE
PLATES.
MR ACOSTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY FIVE IS
BACK ON CONCURRENCE AS A SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL AUTHORIZING
THE PERSONALIZATION OF GOLD STAR
FAMILY LIFE THE SERIOUS SUBJECTS
ARE.
A GROUP A PERSONALIZE A GOLD
STAR FAMILY LICENSE PLATES A
SENATE AMENDMENTS ALLOW THE DMB
TO CHARGE THE NORMAL SPECIALIZED
PLATE VEHICLE STRUCK FAMILIES
CHOOSE TO PERSONALIZE.
BUT THEY CAN STILL GET
SERIALIZED PLATE FOR FREE AND
DELAYS THE BUT IMPLEMENTATION
FOR ONE YEAR IT'S ENJOY
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY ENCOURAGE
THAT TODAY WITH YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR ACOSTA.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OVER THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLL TALENT ABOUT I SIXTY
SIX KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT AND MEMBERS THIS
IS FILE ITEM BACK IN REGULAR
FILE WATER.
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY FOUR AB TWENTY FOUR OH
TO BY MISTER LOW THE CLERK WILL
READ.
AS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR A TWO
BY SELLING AYE LOW ACTING
CANNABIS [inaudible]
MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MS SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS A. B. A TWENTY FOUR
OH TWO IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
WITH RESPECT TO PROTECTING
[inaudible]
CONSUMER PROTECTION HOW IN
CANNABIS USAGE RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
SEEN NOTICE GUSHER DEBATE.
CORPORAL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE WHAT
ICE.
FIFTY ONE KNOWS NINE THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY FIVE AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE CORPORATION.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE BASICALLY MEMBER BERMAN
ATLANTA TAXATION.
THE SUBURBAN.
THANK YOU MR LA MISTER SPEAKER
AND COLLEAGUES ARISE RESENT AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE A BILL
TO MODERNIZE THE SHARING OF
INFORMATION BETWEEN ASSESSORS
AND TAXPAYERS.
SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT
THE BILL APPLIES TO PREVIOUSLY
DIGITIZED RECORDS AND RESTATES
THE APPLICABILITY OF THE RULES
OF CONFIDENTIALITY.
COVERING THE ASSESSOR TAXPAYER
RELATIONSHIP.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON CONCURRENCE AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
A COMMENCEMENT.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTER THIS OUT OF VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE OF A NICE
FORTY THREE KNOWS TWENTY FOR THE
SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY SEVEN MRS ONE FIFTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY FIVE THIRTY ONE
BY MISTER.
GALLAGHER THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
ONE BY SELLING NUMBER GALLAGHER
ATLANTA COURTS.
MISTER GALLAGHER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENT IT'S A GREAT BILL.
I WOULD URGE YOUR AYE THOUGH --
YOU HAVE YOU VOTE AGAINST IT I
AM MAD AT YOU.
I GOT NOTHING BUT LOVE FOR YOU.
BUT I HOPE YOU GOT AN AYE VOTE
IN THEIR FORM HERE I THINK YOU.
THEY RISK GALLAGHER.
SEEING THEIR DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE
ON THE SIDE OF THE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF OF THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLL TELL YOU THAT I
SIXTY FOUR NO [inaudible]
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY EIGHT AB [inaudible]
TWENTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN ARE ARE
YOU ARE YOU OKAY THEM SMOKERS
[inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
SEVEN BY SOME A MEMBER MCCARTY
MR MCCARTY LITTLE TIED UP HERE
MISTER SPEAKER AND I KNOW YOU'LL
MAKE IT A GREAT JOKE AT THE END
OF THIS.
THIS IS OUR TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAM THAT WAS PART OF THAT
BUDGET PROCESS THIS YEAR.
BACK WITH SOME TECHNICAL
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISS REGARDING THE
SAME NOTE DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE IN THE SENATE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED SARAH VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSER ROLE.
AND TALLY VOTE ICE SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE FIFTY NINE AB TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY FIVE BY MR LACKEY
[inaudible]
KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
FIVE BY SOME LACKEY AN EXCELLENT
VEHICLES [inaudible]
MISTER LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL BELIEVES THE PENAL
CODE SECTION RELATIVE TO MINORS
CHRONIC TRUANCY AND SUBSEQUENT
DRIVER'S LICENSE SUSPENSION AND
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THING WAS LACKING SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FLOOR.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
IT IS OUR DIVERT ALL MEMBERS.
VOTER DECIDED THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE VOTE I SEVENTY
ONE NO.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
ONE SIXTY AB TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE CORPOREAL.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
AND ACTUALLY THE STATE
GOVERNMENT.
MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY SEVEN
FORTY NINE IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AMENDMENTS IN THE
SENATE.
ADDED PROVISIONS THAT CLARIFY
TIME FRAMES FOR ONE STATE AGENCY
OR ENTITY MUST BE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH REQUIREMENTS FOR MOBILE
FRIENDLY.
GOVERNMENT WEBSITES THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION I WAS.
THEY RESPOND TO SENIOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
I'M.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLIED ABOUT I
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA JUMP TO
FOLLOW AT A ONE SIXTY THREE
ALLEN ONE SIXTY THREE IS AB
TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY EIGHT HARPER
READ.
THAT'S ONLY WHAT TWENTY EIGHT
THIRTY EIGHT BY SELLING Y. LOW
ACTUALLY GAMBLING.
MR LOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS WEEKEND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
EIGHT STOPS IN THE SIXTY DAY
LIMIT ON THE AMOUNT OF TIME THE
BUREAU OF DOWN THE CONTROL HAS
TO REVIEW LOCAL ORDINANCE AND
MAKES RECOMMENDATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON NUMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
EYES SEVENTY NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY FOUR AB TWENTY NINE OH
TO COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE A TO
BY THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND TOXIC
MATERIALS AND ACTUALLY TO
HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES.
DOCTOR QUIRK OF THIS IS A
COMMITTEE BELL.
BOB SENTIMENTS WERE TECHNICAL I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY HAD A QUIRK.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLE TELL BUT I
SEVENTY NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY SIX THAT BRINGS US TO
FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN AB THIRTY
SEVENTY SEVEN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
SEVEN BY SOME THE MEMBER
CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY TO
VEHICLES.
MS COME HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY SEVENTY
SEVEN IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE
FROM THE SENATE.
THE SENATE AMENDMENTS CLARIFY
THAT A MINOR MUST SHOW PROOF OF
A HELMET AND ATTEND A BICYCLE
SAFETY COURSE WITHIN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS AFTER THE
CITATION HAS BEEN ISSUED.
ITS CLARIFICATION BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE.
FAMOUS CARRIER TO SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
THIS ARE TO VOTE OR MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
BURKE WELL CLOSE ROLE TALLY
VOTE.
ICE SEVENTY KNOWS.
ZERO THE SENATE AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY.
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SIXTY EIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO TAKE OUT FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY TWO THIS IS A B..
THREE FIFTEEN THE CORPORATE
RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER WHAT AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGEMENT [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBER
MEMBERS PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGERS REFERRED TO AS P.
BEYONCE PLAY A MAJOR ROLE IN
NEGOTIATING THE PRICES OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH PLANS AND PURCHASERS.
GRADING FORMULARIES AND MANAGING
THE PHARMACY BENEFITS FOR
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS.
DESPITE THEIR SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
VERY LITTLE IS KNOWN ABOUT HOW
PBM IS OPERATE.
UNLIKE OTHER PARTICIPANTS IN THE
HEALTHCARE ARENA TBMS OPERATE
WITH LITTLE NO OR WITH NO
OVERSIGHT OR REGULATION.
DESPITE TOLL REVENUES ESTIMATED
IN THE HUNDREDS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AS THE COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS CONTINUE TO ESCALATE IT'S
CRITICAL THAT ALL ASPECTS OF THE
PHARMACY SUPPLY CHAIN BE OPEN.
TRANSPARENT IN ORDER TO
APPROPRIATELY ASSESS THE IMPACT
IT HAS ON THE COST OF THE DRUG.
DELIVERY SYSTEM AND ALSO THE
COST OF HEALTHCARE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY'D ACT WOULD THE SCENE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE COURT LIBERAL.
MEMBERS.
THIS AREA VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO'S OUT OF
VOTE [inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL CHILDHOOD ICE.
FIFTY NINE NO ZERO THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY FOUR AND PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY SIX WE ARE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT AND PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM ONE AND
EIGHTY IT'S A MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY ONE AB. NINETEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN FIVE MISTER LACKEY
THAT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY
AND OTHERS IN ATLANTA DISCOVERY.
MISTER LACKEY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE.
THIS BILL WILL GRAB POST
CONVICTION DISCOVERY ACCESS IN
THE MOST HIGH STAKES CASES.
ALLOW INNOCENT PEOPLE TO REDUCE
THE AMOUNT OF TIME THEY SPEND
BEHIND BARS FOR CRIMES THEY DID
NOT COMMIT.
AND I WOULD ASK YOUR SUPPORT ON
THIS MEASURE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
EMORY.
THANK YOU AGAIN MR LACKEY SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
BIZARRE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTER
THE DATA VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE CALVET I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE
BACK IN THE FILE. TO TAKE UP A
COUPLE OF ITEMS.
THAT WERE SKIPPED.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
ONE SIXTY FIVE AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTEEN BY MR HOLDEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
EIGHTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN
AND ACTUALLY THE VEHICLES MISTER
HOLDING.
A FAMOUS SPEAKER AB TWENTY NINE
EIGHTEEN IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO CRAFT
LANGUAGE TO INCLUDE IN THE
CALIFORNIA DRIVER'S HANDBOOK
INFORMATION REGARDING A PERSON'S
CIVIL RIGHTS.
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP.
THE DRIVER'S HANDBOOK INCLUDES
SUGGESTIONS ON HOW TO CONDUCT
ONESELF DURING A STOP.
BUT STOPPED SHORT OF STATING THE
RIGHTS OF THE DRIVER.
THIS INFORMATION WILL BE
DEVELOPED IN CONSULTATION WITH
THE HP AND POST.
BEING INFORMED OF THESE RIGHTS
ARE CRITICAL IN SITUATIONS THAT
CAN QUICKLY GO FROM CALM TO
WORSE AB TWENTY NINE EIGHTEEN
STILL ADDRESS THE EXTENT AND
LIMITATIONS OF THE PEACE
OFFICER'S AUTHORITY.
DURING A TRAFFIC STOP IN THE
RIGHTS OF DRIVERS AND PASSENGERS
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE.
NAME IS HOLDEN SEE NO DISCUSION
DEBATE QUIRK WELL OPEN THE
RIGHT.
I'M.
SORRY ABOUT ALL THE MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE OF ICE
FIFTY TWO KNOWS FOR SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP FILE
ITEM.
ONE SIXTY NINE THIS IS AB.
THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX BY MISS
WALDRON.
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE SEVENTY SIX BY SOME A NUMBER
WALDRON AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE INDIAN CHILDREN.
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS A. B. THIRTY ONE SEVENTY
SIX CHANGES CALIFORNIA LAW TO
COMPLY WITH THE FEDERAL BUREAU
OF INDIAN AFFAIRS.
TWENTY SIXTEEN INDIAN CHILD
WELFARE ACT REGULATIONS.
THE INDIAN CHILD WELFARE ACT
ALSO KNOWN AS IT WERE.
WAS ENACTED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WHILE
GREAT PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE IN
PROTECTING NATIVE AMERICAN
CHILDREN FROM WHOLESALE
SEPARATION FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
MORE WORK NEEDED TO BE DONE AS A
RESULT THE BUREAU OF INDIAN
AFFAIRS CREATED REGULATIONS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL INDIAN CHILDREN
WERE RECEIVING THE SAME
PROTECTIONS ACROSS THE NATION.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX SIMPLY
SEEKS TO CHANGE CALIFORNIA LAW
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
THIS MOSER HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THEY MISS WALDRON SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CARP WELL OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED SARAJEVO.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TALBOT I SEVENTY
KNOWS ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN [inaudible]
FILE ITEM.
IS FILE ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY ONE AB.
THIRTY TO FORTY NINE CORPORATE
RATE ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY TO
FORTY NINE BY THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY AND ACTUALLY TWO
ATTORNEYS [inaudible]
MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
IS THE ANNUAL BAR DO THIS BILL
IT'S THE REAUTHORIZATION FOR THE
BARD TO CHARGE ATTORNEYS DO.
AND IT ALSO CONTINUES THE REFORM
OF THE STATE BAR THAT THIS BODY
HAS LED OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS SENATE AMENDMENTS LATELY
NARROW THIS BILL AND ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON CONCURRENCY SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
NAME IS STONE SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO MOVE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRED OF THOUGH
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY VOTE I
SIXTY NINE NO [inaudible]
ZERO THE SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO TAKE UP.
ITEM [inaudible]
ONE SEVENTY FOUR THIS IS
[inaudible]
MAYBE [inaudible]
SIX TWENTY SIX KERKORIAN.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY SIX BY
SELLING MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAIN TO THE
CALIFORNIA RECALL FOOD CODE.
WHICH GARCIA MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB SIX TO SIX IS BACK
FROM THE SENATE FOR CONCURRENCE.
OUR OFFICE HAS WORKED WITH THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONSUMER
PROTECTION TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES
TO ENSURE THE BILL.
IS STRONG PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS AND ACCESSIBLE TO
THE SHIPS WE ARE HOPING WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE.
OF THIS NEW OPPORTUNITY
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
NAMES GARCIA.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
WE DECIDED VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
KIRK WELL.
CLOSE A ROLL TIDE OF IT I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS.
ARE CONCURRENT AND GOING TO
STAY.
GOING TO STAY WITH MISTER GARCIA
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY AB [inaudible]
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN THE CORKERY.
AT SOME LEVEL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
BY SIMPLY MEMBER EDUARDO GARCIA
AND OTHERS AND EXPLAINED OUTDOOR
RECREATION MISTER GARCIA.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN THE CALIFORNIA
OFFICE OF OUTDOOR RECREATION
NOT.
IS BACK FOR CONCURRENCE FROM THE
SENATE.
SPECTER YES FREE AYE VOTE.
SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CORPORAL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE A MISTER
CALDERON SIDE IN THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT A. B.
[inaudible]
EIGHTEEN FIFTY EIGHT CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT BYTES EVERY MEMBER
CALDERON AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
THE STUDENT FINANCIAL AID.
WHICH KALRA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS OF THIS BILL EIGHTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT IS BACK FROM THE
SENATE START OFF AS A GREAT BILL
OF COURSE WAS MADE EVEN BETTER
BY GOOD COLLEAGUES IN THE
SENATE.
AND ALL THEIR INFINITE WISDOM.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
NAMES CALDERON.
SENIOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
HARTWELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
VOTE I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE.
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT IN
.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY FOUR THIS IS AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE BY DOCTOR
QUIRK.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER QUIRK
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS
[inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK SPEAKER I RISE. TO PRESENT
TO YOU AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY FIVE
FOR CONCURRENCE.
ALL THIS STATISTICAL PROCESS
KNOWN AS RISK LIMITING AUDIT.
SAVE MONEY AND TIME WHILE
PROVIDING RAPID VERIFICATION OF
ELECTION RESULTS.
THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
SENATE REMOVE ALL OPPOSITION TO
THE BELL THIS MEASURES FOR
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SICK ARMY
YES THANK YOU THAT QUIRK SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THE CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE ROLL-ON.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT FOR THE BELL
MEMBERS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
THE CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
CALVET AYE.
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT
WHATEVER CHARGE IN THE SENATE
THIRD READING FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM. THREE FORTY
SEVEN SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THE
CORKERY SAMPLE FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
ACTUALLY THE MURDER [inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN A BILL
THAT LIMITS MURDER PROSECUTIONS.
PEOPLE WHO INTENDED TO KILL
[inaudible]
ACTUALLY KILL.
AIDED AND ABETTED A MURDER.
OR BEHAVED WITH RECKLESS
INDIFFERENCE TO HUMAN LIFE.
BY DOING SO S. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN REFORMS
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING LAW.
BY MAKING CLEAR THE DISTINCTION
[inaudible]
BETWEEN INDIVIDUALS --
PARTICIPATED.
IN AN UNDERLYING CRIME
[inaudible]
FROM INDIVIDUALS.
CHOSE TO TAKE SOMEONE'S LIFE.
OR DIRECTLY AIDED AND TAKING OF
THAT LIFE [inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA.
PERSON CAN BE CONVICTED OF
MURDER.
FACE LIFE IN PRISON.
WITHOUT KILLING ANYONE.
OR EVEN OR EVEN WITNESSING THE
MURDER.
UNDER WHAT'S CALLED.
THE FELONY MURDER RULE.
A FEW DAYS AGO I HAD THE
PLEASURE OF MEETING [inaudible]
BOBBY GARCIA.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO BOBBY
GARCIA WAS SIXTEEN YEARS OLD.
HE WAS LIVING A ROUGH LIFE.
MAKING BAD CHOICES THE GROUPS OF
FRIENDS THAT HE HUNG OUT WITH
[inaudible] ONE NIGHT HE AND A
GROUP OF FRIENDS.
MADE THE TERRIBLE DECISION. TO
ROB A GANG MEMBER.
IT WASN'T UNTIL BOBBY WAS PICKED
UP BY THE POLICE.
AND INTERROGATED THE NEXT DAY.
THEN HE LEARNED THAT ONE OF HIS
FRIENDS STAB AND KILL.
THE ROBBERY VICTIM.
AFTER THEIR HAD ALL FLED THE
ROBBERY.
BOBBI HAD NO INTENTION.
A MURDER IN ANYONE.
HE DID NOT COMMIT THE MURDER.
HE HAD NO WEAPON ON HIS PERSON.
AND HE WAS NOT EVEN AT THE SCENE
OF THE CRIME.
YET HE WAS FACING ALIVE SENTENCE
WITHOUT PAROLE.
UNDER THE FELONY MURDER RULE.
BOBBY WAS TOLD.
THAT IF HE PLED GUILTY.
HE WOULD AVOID LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE.
AT THE AGE OF SIXTEEN HE WAS
GIVEN TWO OPTIONS.
THE JURORS FOR ORDER PLEASE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IT'S GIVE MR MEDINA YOUR
UNDIVIDED ATTENTION.
AT THE AGE OF SIXTEEN WHO WAS
GIVEN TWO OPTIONS.
SPEND THE REST OF HIS LIFE IN
PRISON.
OR PLEAD GUILTY AND HAVE THE
POSSIBILITY [inaudible]
A PAROLE.
HE PLED GUILTY [inaudible]
TODAY.
THE YOUNG MAN THAT I MET BARBARA
BOBBY GARCIA.
IS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
OF THE JESUIT.
STORAGE OF JUSTICE.
INITIATIVE.
AND PROVIDES COUNSELING TO
INCARCERATED MEN AND WOMEN
[inaudible]
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
BOBBY IS MARRIED WITH TWO
DAUGHTERS.
AND A THREE YEAR OLD.
IN A TWO MONTH OLD. TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN BOBBY WAS RELEASED FROM
CALIFORNIA PRISON.
AFTER SERVING TWENTY TWO YEARS.
FOR A MURDER HE DID NOT COMMIT.
IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT.
CALLED THE FELONY MURDER RULE
BARBARIC.
BECAUSE IT DIVORCED INTENT
[inaudible]
FROM RESPONSIBILITY.
THE JUSTICES SAID.
ONLY THE LEGISLATURE COULD FIX
THE PROBLEM.
TIME TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
IS NOW.
THIS STATUE RATIONALLY TREATS
PEOPLE.
WHO DID NOT COMMIT MURDER?
THE SAME WAY IT TREATS PEOPLE
WHO DID COMMIT MURDER.
THE FELONY MURDER RULE IS NOT
ONLY AND JUST ON HIS FACE.
IT IS UNJUST IN ITS APPLICATION.
THIRTY SECONDS OF US MILLION
AVERAGE AGE OF A NON KILLER
SENTENCE UNDER FELONY MURDER IS
BETWEEN NINETEEN AND TWENTY
YEARS OLD. 72% OF THE WOMEN
SERVING LIFE SENTENCES FOR
MURDER AND CALIFORNIA WERE NOT
THE KILLER.
THEY WERE CONVICTED UNDER THE
FELONY MURDER RULE.
BEFORE I STARTED TEACHING IN THE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS I TAUGHT AT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR WOMEN
[inaudible] TWO YEARS AND THERE
I MET MANY WOMEN WHO HADN'T
KILLED ANYONE.
BUT WE'RE REMORSEFUL.
BUT THEY WERE INCARCERATED UNDER
THIS RULE.
I STAND TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN BECAUSE IT
PRESERVES THE HARSHEST
PUNISHMENT FOR THOSE WHO
INTENTIONALLY PLANNED OR
ACTUALLY COMMITTED THE BURGER.
THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE LIKE BOBBY
WHO WERE INCARCERATED UNDER THIS
RULE WHO NEVER COMMITTED MURDER
AND ARE READY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY. TO ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEIR PORTION
OF THE CRIME.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS
NOT A GET OUT OF JAIL FREE CARD
FAR FROM IT.
EACH DEFENDANT CAN STILL BE
CHARGED AND IS STILL GUILTY.
OF THE SERIOUS FELONY HE OR SHE
COMMITTED.
AND THOSE WHO PETITIONED FOR RE
SENTENCING.
ACCESSIBLE WILL ALSO BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE UNDERLYING
FELONY.
PLEASE PLEASE INCLUDE A SERVANT
MEDINA.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON S. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISS MEDINA MS RUBIO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I STAND
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN MEMBERS
ACCORDING TO A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN SURVEY BY THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND
RESTORED JUSTICE 72% OF WOMEN
SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE UNDER
CALIFORNIA'S FELLA FELONY MURDER
RULE.
WERE NOT THE PERPETRATORS AND
DID NOT COMMIT MURDER.
MANY OF THOSE CASES.
WOMEN WERE PHYSICALLY ABUSED BY
THEIR IN INTIMATE PARTNER. ONE
WOMEN'S ORGANIZATION WHO OFFERS
COUNSELING AND SUPPORT IN
WOMEN'S PRISONS IN CALIFORNIA
WROTE.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF AND
CARSHARE INCARCERATED WOMEN WE
WORK WITH WHO WERE SENTENCED
UNDER THE FELONY MURDER RULE
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE AND
WORK CRIMINALIZE FOR SURVIVAL
ACTS.
THESE WOMEN ARE NOT MURDERERS.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
ENSURES THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO
PUNISH THOSE WHO SHOULD BE
PUNISHED.
BUT WITH A PUNISHMENT THAT IS
SCALED TO THE LEVEL OF THE
PERSON'S INVOLVEMENT IN THE
CRIME.
IT ALLOWS US TO DISTINGUISH
THOSE WHO ACTUALLY KILLED FROM
THOSE WHO DID NOT.
AN IMPORTANT JUST AN APPROPRIATE
DISTINCTION.
THANK YOU AND I URGE YOUR VOTE
ON SP.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THING WAS
RUBIO MISTER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES WITH S. B. FOURTEENTH
THAT.
THIRTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA ONCE
AGAIN HAS THE CHANCE TO MAKE AN
IMPORTANT.
AND NEEDED REFORM TO OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WITH SP
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN AN
INDIVIDUAL MAY ONLY BE
CONVICTED.
OF MURDER SIR CERTAINLY A
SERIOUS AND HORRIBLE CRIME.
IF THE INDIVIDUAL [inaudible]
I'M.
OLD WILLINGLY PARTICIPATED IN AN
ACT THAT RESULTS IN A HOMICIDE
OR AN ACT THAT CLEARLY WITH
INTENDED TO RESULT IN A
HOMICIDE.
AND THE PURPOSE OF OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS TO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE. FOR THE SPECIFIC
CRIMES THEY HAVE COMMITTED.
IN A FAIR AND LEGAL PROCEEDING
BUT WITH EXISTING LAW THE FELONY
MURDER MURDER RULE.
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS THE CASE
UNFORTUNATELY UNDER THE FELONY
MURDER RULE A PERSON CAN BE
CHARGED WITH THE MOST SERIOUS
CRIME IN OUR PENAL CODE.
EVEN KNOW THEY INDISPUTABLY
NEVER COMMITTED THAT CRIME.
THAT IS WRONG WE CAN CHANGE THAT
TODAY.
THE TIME HAS COME.
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR SKINNER
AND ANDERSON FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL FOR ALL THE HARD WORK IN
FIGHTING FOR THIS MUCH NEEDED
CHANGE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
YOUR COOPER YOUR RECOGNIZE THAT
MISTER SPEAKER THIS BILL IS
RETROACTIVE APPLYING TO THOSE
WHO ARE TO BE CONVICTED OF
MURDER.
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
UNDER THIS BILL THAT OBJECTION
THANK YOU UNDER THIS BILL WILL
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS SERVING TIME
FOR MURDER.
HAVE TO SHOW IN ORDER TO QUALIFY
FOR RECENT THING.
AND ALSO WHAT WILL THE BURDEN OF
PROOF BE.
THE PROSECUTION EVERY SENSE AND
OSTERMAN ANY MAY TAKE THAT NOW
OR YOUR CLOTHES.
I DO TO MY CLOTHES.
MR MEDINA WILL ADDRESS THAT
QUESTION IN HIS CLOTHES MISTER
COOPER OKAY THE CONVICTED
MURDERER ONLY IT'S A SHOW THAT
HE IS.
THAT HE WAS CHARGED AND
CONVICTED OF MURDER.
BOTH NOT THE ACTUAL KILLER MAJOR
PARTICIPANT.
ME MAKE IT CLEAR.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THE
STANDARD OF BURDEN OF PROOF. FOR
THE RECENT THING A CONVICTED
MURDERER BEYOND THAT.
IT ONLY REQUIRES A PERSON BE
DECLARED THEIR NOT THE ACTUAL
KILLER.
OR A MAJOR PARTICIPANT.
IS ON THE PROSECUTION TO PROVE
OTHERWISE AND WITH LESSONS RETRY
THE CASE.
THIS WILL BECOME PUBLIC MATIC
UNDER ME SCENARIOS ESPECIALLY
TROUBLING IN CASE THERE WAS A
CONVICTED MURDERER.
JODI PLED GUILTY.
IN THOSE PLEA BARGAINS THERE'S
NO RECORD OF TESTIMONY TO TRIAL
TRANSCRIPT REVIEW SOURCES A PLEA
BARGAIN.
IN THIS CASE IS WE DON'T HAVE
THE EVIDENCE.
THE END RESULT WOULD BE THAT
THOSE WHO PLED GUILTY AND
ATTORNEY SERVING TIME FOR MURDER
WILL BE RELEASED.
THE LOW ESTIMATE MOST CONVICT
FOR MURDER THEN MINIMALIST SIX
IN A PERSON'S.
NOW NUMBER COMES FROM THE
PROPONENTS OF THE BILL.
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION WITH NUMBER TO BE
MUCH HIGHER.
BOTTOM LINE WITH HIS BILL DOES
IS RESULTS CONVICTED MURDER IN
MANY CASES WITH NO
DOCUMENTATION.
EVERY TRIAL TRANSCRIPT EVERY
TRIAL EVIDENCE TO REFUTE
CONVICTED MURDERERS AND TEN
DURING THE CRIME.
BUT LET'S BE HONEST HERE ON
THIS.
THIS IS HIGH RISK BEHAVIOR IN
STOCKTON THE MYSTICAL THING
MURDER.
DRIVER DRIES UP DROPS THREE GUYS
OFF THE GOING THE BANK WITH GUNS
TO ROB A BANK AS HIGH RISK
BEHAVIOR THE DRIVER NEVER WHEN
IT.
OKAY PLEASE DROP THEM OFF TO GO
ROB A BANK.
SHE GOT KILLED INTO BAD GUYS
WERE KILLED THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE
THINK ABOUT THAT LOVE MARIJUANA
RIPOFF YOU'RE GOING WITH GUNS SO
A LOT OF THESE THINGS HAPPEN
DURING HIGH RISK BEHAVIORS.
AND THE WOMEN THEIR VICTIM OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ABSOLUTELY BUT
A LOT OF THESE CASE IF THEY KNEW
THEIR BOYFRIENDS CARRY GUNS.
I'M A RECIPROCAL LIKE THAT
BEFORE AND DONE THIS IN BOTH TO
BE FOR FELONY MURDER IT HAPPENS
A LOT SO RARELY SOMEONE KNOW HEY
I KNOW I DID THIS IS GOING ON
THEY SEE IT IS TO THE GUN THEY
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
CRAZY RIGHT NOW.
RECENT HUNDRED LIFERS A MONTH
THING IN CALIFORNIA.
S. CCR HER LIFE WAS A MONTH.
AB ONE ONLINE PROP FORTY SEVEN
PART FIFTY SEVEN PROP FIFTY FOUR
LIKE EARLIER SOME WITH EARLIER
WILL TALK ABOUT VICTIMS.
WE NEVER TALK ABOUT VICTIMS EVER
[inaudible]
EVER.
LOOKING WHICH CRAFTING WELL
THERE'S BEEN EIGHTY FOUR BILLS
IN TWO YEARS BUT WHAT 60% PASSED
[inaudible]
REALLY.
WHAT THE COME DOWN?
TO THIS IS OF RULE FOR A REASON
TO AFFIX IT LET'S FIX IT RIGHT
AND DO IT RIGHT.
BUT FOR THAT TO HAPPEN THE
DRIVER JUST TO GO THROUGH AND
GET.
A ROBBERY CONVICTION.
IT IT COMES OUT IN.
ACCOUNTABILITY THERE'S NO
ACCOUNTABILITY RIGHT NOW.
BUT YOU'RE TAKING SOMEONE TO
COMMIT A CRIME LIKE THAT
TYPICALLY.
MUSCLES CLIENTS KNOW SOMEONE NEW
HEY I KNOW WE CARE TONIGHT
NUCLEAR TO GUN.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA.
THOSE ARE FEW AND FAR BETWEEN
FANTASIZE ALL DAY.
I NEED YOUR REST AYE PRICKLE
PROSECUTE CASES I WORK GAINES
[inaudible]
ALBERTA HOMICIDE.
SO THIS IS ACCURATE.
BUT YOU CAN JUST TALK ABOUT ALL
DAY BUT AT WHAT POINT DOES THE
VICTIM MAKE A DIFFERENCE WILL
PUT IS A VICTIM EVER MATTER.
THAT'S BY THE MOST FRUSTRATING
PART THE FAMILIES WHAT ABOUT
THEIR FAMILIES.
THE PERSON SUSPECT HE GETS TO GO
HOME WITH HIM CAN WRITE TO ME CO
INCOME VISIT THEM PUT MONEY AS
BOOKS.
WHAT IF THE VICTIM?
THEN OF GRACE.
ALSO AT SOME POINT WE KNOW WE
GOT A FIX ALL THIS NOT TELL YOU
WHAT. TO COME HOME TO ROOST.
THAT'S WHAT YOU INITIATIVE IN.
TWENTY TWENTY ON CRIME STUFF.
IF PEOPLE ARE FED UP.
YEAH NOT THAT'S THAT'S THE
BOTTOM LINE WHO REPRESENT
REPRESENT EVERYBODY THE VICTIMS
ALSO.
BUT YOU NEVER HEAR THE VICTIMS
IN HERE.
AND LOOK A SENTIMENTAL CALL THE
WANT BUT WHEN YOU'RE IN THERE
YOU CAN A DEAD BODY.
AND I DID THAT FOR MANY MANY
YEARS.
LOT OF DEAD BODIES OUT OF
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIME.
THE DESERVE TO DIE.
YOU HOPE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THIS REALLY MAKES NO SENSE.
KNOW HOW FAR WE GONNA GO.
WHAT IS YOUR FAMILY MEMBER
LAYING THERE DEAD?
I DIDN'T KNOW I DIDN'T KNOW.
I CAN TELL YOU COMEY ENTERS I
SAT IN ON HOMICIDE SUSPECTS.
ACCOMPLICES THAT NEW WHEN YOU
REALLY DIG DOWN DEEP AND ASK THE
RIGHT QUESTION TO THE RIGHT IF
YOU.
THEY KNEW THAT PERSON.
WHAT'S THE BIG THAT BEHAVIOR.
THIRTY SECOND ONE SHOULDN'T
JUSTIFY THIS.
IF YOU WERE FIX THINGS FIX
THINGS RIGHT DON'T GEMMA THROUGH
THE DAMP THROUGH BILL WITH JEFF
THROUGH A BUNCH OF THINGS FIX A
RIGHT HAVE A CONVERSATION.
THAT GETS IT DONE IF YOU WANT TO
GET DONE THERE'S NO HURRY.
HERE WE ARE YOU KNOW TWO DAYS
LEFT SESSION THREE IS WHATEVER
IT IS AND WORKING ON THIS.
THEIR TIME TO WORK ON THIS AND
DO IT RIGHT THIS IS DOING THE
WRONG WAY OUR SPEC YOUR JOURNAL
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
MISTER MURATSUCHI YOUR RECKLESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE AYE.
SPEC FULLY RISE IN OPPOSITION.
TO S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
AND LET ME TELL LET ME TELL YOU
WHY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY OF YOU
HAVE READ.
AND IF THE COMMITTEE ANALYSES ON
THIS BILL [inaudible]
BUT YOU'RE CLEARLY I THINK WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THAT THE FELONY
MURDER.
RULE NEEDS. TO BE REFORM IT
NEEDS TO BE CHANGED WE'VE HEARD
SEVERAL ANECDOTAL EXAMPLES.
OF HOW.
PEOPLE THAT HAD MINIMAL
INVOLVEMENT OR NO SHOWING OF
INTENT A COMMITMENT OR ANY IN
ANY OF THE SERIOUS CRIME.
WOULD -- BE
CONVICTED OF MURDER UNDER THE
FELONY MURDER RULE.
BUT THIS BILL.
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT SOLUTION.
WE NEED TO WORK ON GETTING THIS
RIGHT BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO
LEAD. TO THE RELIEF.
OUR OF OF PEOPLE ON THIS IS
GOING TO LEAD.
TO A FURTHER PAIN AND SUFFERING
OF CRIME VICTIMS THERE'S A
REASON WHY THE CRIME VICTIMS
UNITED IN CALIFORNIA --
POSTED THIS IF YOU READ.
THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
IT TALKS ABOUT HOW THIS BILL
PROVIDES NO EXCEPTION TO ALLOW
FOR A TRIAL TRANSCRIPT TO BE
USED IN A RE SENTENCING HEARING
SO THAT'S GOING TO BE. TO
REQUIRE THE CALLING OF ALL
VICTIMS ALL WITNESSES OFF FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN THE ORIGINAL CASE. TO TESTIFY
ONCE AGAIN TO REOPEN THE PAIN
AND SUFFERING THAT THEY WENT
THROUGH THROUGH THE ORIGINAL
CASE [inaudible]
NEXT.
THE BILL TALKS ABOUT THEIR
ANNOUNCES TALKS ABOUT HOW.
IN CASES THAT RESULT THROUGH A
NEGOTIATED PLEA WHICH IS THE
VAST MAJORITY OF ALL FELONY
CASES.
NO SUCH RECORD EXISTS.
IN TERMS OF TRANSCRIPTS EGGS.
COR A COURT RECORD TO RELY ON IN
SO VIRTUALLY ALL PARTICIPANTS.
AND THESE FELONY MET RUMORS
WOULD QUALIFY FOR RELIEF TO
WHICH THEY MAY NOT BE ENTITLED.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
THIS BILL IS PLACING THE BURDEN
ON THE PROSECUTION TO PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT.
THE PETITIONERS DO NOT QUALIFY
HER RE SENTENCING SO IN OTHER
WORDS THE PRESUMPTION IS WITH.
THOSE.
CONVICTED OF FELONY MURDER TO BE
RE SENTENCED.
THIS IS NOT THE RIGHT SOLUTION
TO THE PROBLEM OF FELONY MURDER
IS THIS WILL REALLY THIS WILL
LEAD TO THE RELEASE [inaudible]
OF THOSE WE SHOULD NOT BE
RELEASED THIS THIS WILL.
THIS WELL THIS GOES TOO FAR.
IT REOPENS IT REQUIRES CRIME
VICTIMS TO HAVE TO RE OPEN THE
PAIN.
OF HAVING TO COME BACK TO COURT
TO TESTIFY ONCE AGAIN TO
JUSTIFY.
WHY THEY FEEL THAT?
THE PERSON SHOULD BE
[inaudible]
BEHIND BARS [inaudible]
I ASK.
THAT WE DO THIS RIGHT.
AND WE REJECT THIS BILL.
MISS GONZALEZ FLETCHER YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS CRITICAL BILL [inaudible]
BECAUSE VICTIMS DO MATTER
[inaudible]
IN VICTIMS.
SHOULD FEEL GOOD WHEN WE PUT
AWAY THEIR ACTUAL KILLERS
[inaudible]
BUT NOBODY.
PINES PIECE TO PUT AWAY.
OTHERWISE [inaudible]
LESS CULPABLE [inaudible]
INDIVIDUALS.
WHEN SOMEBODY IS KILLED?
AND THAT HAS HAPPENED AGAIN.
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
I VENTURE TO SAY ANY OF US.
WHO WENT TO LAW SCHOOL WHEN WE
FIRST?
STARTED CRIMINAL LAW AND LEARNED
ABOUT THE FILM THE RULE FILLING
MURDER ALL.
WE'RE EXPOSED HOW ARCHAIC.
IN I'M JUST IT COULD BE.
I KNOW BECAUSE THE CASE LAWS
THAT WE SAW WERE ALWAYS.
PLEXI WE HAD A LOOK AT HOW
PERPLEXING IT WAS TO GET THROUGH
THE IDEA THAT CALIFORNIA.
ACTUALLY HAS THIS.
AND SIMILAR THINGS BROUGHT UP ON
THIS FLOOR.
OUR LITTLE I THINK OUTDATED IN
THE ANALYSIS BECAUSE I KNOW.
THAT THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN.
IN THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
ALLOWS THE DA'S A COURT TO USE
ALL MATERIALS AND ALL EVIDENCE
IN THE RE SENTENCING CASE.
THE BURDEN IS ON THE PETITIONER.
TO A ALLOW FOR A CASE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
OF COURSE WE'VE EXEMPTED ALL
CASES A DEAL WITH A COP KILLER.
SO THERE WERE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
TO SOME OF THE CONCERNS.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT --
THERE MIGHT BE CONCERNS BECAUSE
THIS IS A PERFECT.
I CAN'T EVER EXPECT SOMETHING
THAT'S PERFECT BUT I CAN TELL
YOU.
AND IF IF ANYONE HERE HAS HAS
SPOKEN TO SOME OF THE FOLKS
[inaudible]
TO AREN'T PERFECT HAVE MADE SOME
MISTAKES IN THEIR LIVES.
WHAT WOULD HAVE NEVER KILLED
SOMEBODY?
WOULD HAVE NEVER PARTICIPATED IN
SOMETHING THAT RESULTED IN A
DEATH.
IN GETS OUR SPENDING THE REST OF
THEIR LIVES IN JAIL.
BECAUSE OF WHAT SOMEBODY ELSE
DID.
WE TALKED EARLY ON THIS FLOOR
ABOUT MAKING ISTAKES WHEN WE
WERE YOUNGER MAKING MISTAKES
THROUGHOUT OUR LIVES.
IT'S AMAZING TO ME BECAUSE SOME
OF US ON THE SWERVE MADE
MISTAKES AS ADULTS.
BEEN ARRESTED AS ADULTS.
THEIR MISTAKES THAT ARE MADE.
IT SHOULD NOT RESULT IN AN
INDIVIDUAL SPENDING THE REST OF
THEIR LIFE IN PRISON FOR MURDER
THEY DID NOT COMMIT.
WOULD NOT COMMIT.
HAD NO INTENTION OF BEING
COMMITTED AND DID NOT
PARTICIPATE IN HELPING IT
[inaudible]
COMMITTED.
EXCEPT BEING THERE.
DRIVING A CAR.
BEING WITH A LOVED.
ONE A BOYFRIEND OR HUSBAND
OFTEN.
THIS IS ABOUT JUSTICE. FOR THE
ACTUAL VICTIM BECAUSE THE ACTUAL
PERPETRATOR SHOULD BE THE ONE
SPENDING THE REST THEIR LIVES IN
JAIL.
INTO OFTEN WE'VE HEARD STORIES
ABOUT THE PERSON WHO IS
ACTUALLY.
SHOOTING THE GUN OR CAUSING THE
MURDER MAKING A PLEA DEAL.
AND THE PERSON WHO.
MIGHT HAVE MADE SOME MISTAKES IN
SHOULD SPEND TIME IN JAIL FOR
THEIR MISTAKES.
SPEND REST OF THEIR LIFE IN
PRISON FOR THE ACTUAL MURDER.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IT'S NOT
JUSTICE IN THE SHOULD BE FIXED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
NAME IS GONZALEZ FLETCHER
[inaudible]
ALL DEBATE.
AND DISCUSSION HAVING CEASED.
MR MEDINA YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
DISCUSSION. TO ANSWER MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO.
THE BURDEN OF PROOF IS INITIALLY
ON THE PETITIONER.
SHOW THAT THEY CAN MAKE THE CASE
THAT THEY DID NOT KILL.
TEND TO KILL.
OR ACT RECKLESSLY IN THE CRIME
THAT THEY WERE CONVICTED OF
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL MAKES
CLEAR.
THAT THE PETITIONER PASSED TO
SET.
FOR A VALID ARGUMENT UNDER
PENALTY OF PERJURY.
WITH EVIDENCE FROM THE COURT
RECORD.
IN ORDER TO BE CONSIDERED FOR RE
SENTENCING.
S. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN WILL LIE
IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
ENGLAND.
IRELAND CANADA.
AND STATE SUCH AS ARKANSAS Y.
[inaudible]
TACKY MASSACHUSETTS AND
MICHIGAN.
ALL WHO HAVE REFORM THEIR MURDER
STATUES.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN CALIFORNIA HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BETTER SERVE THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE.
S. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN IS A
PRUDENT MOVE.
IT'S CAN BRING NEEDED COURSE
PARENTS THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE SAFETY
BY HOLDING PEOPLE.
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR OWN
ACTIONS.
I ASK YOU RESPECTFULLY TO VOTE
YES.
I ON S. B..
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MR MEDINA.
AND WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO GO
.
ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO GO
.
MEMBERS I AM VERY TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN THIS IS S. B..
SIXTY FOUR CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOUGH.
DESIRE TO GO [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
TELL YOU ABOUT.
ICE THIRTY THREE KNOWS.
THIRTY SIX THE MEASURE FAILS
[inaudible]
WRITTEN.
DOCTOR EGGMAN NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION.
MEMBERS HAVE A PAIR TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM.
WHEN?
THIRTY ONE AB TWELVE FOURTEEN
CORPORAL POST.
AND MEMBERS VOTERS TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER WHICH TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
THREE NO.
SEVENTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
THE CONCURRENCE FILE.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SIX AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY FIVE BY MS RAY S..
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND
ACTUALLY THE GREENHOUSE GASES.
ISRAEL'S.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY FIVE WHICH IS
BACK FOR CONCURRENCE
[inaudible]
SENATE WITH AMENDMENTS THIS BILL
CLARIFIES ELIGIBILITY FOR NEW
TYPES OF PROJECTS OF THE THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN TRUCK BUS
AN OFF ROAD VEHICLE.
AND EQUIPMENT PROGRAM AT THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD.
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY FIVE HAS NO
OPPOSITION HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES.
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE HOME MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE.
FIFTY SIX NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN A. B.. TWENTY
THREE THIRTY EIGHT BY MISTER
LEVINE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE AND ACTUALLY THE TALENT
AGENCIES.
MISTER LEVINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB TWO
THIRTEEN TWENTY THREE THIRTY
EIGHT REQUIRES TALENT AGENCIES
TO MAKE EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT NUTRITION AND
EATING DISORDERS AVAILABLE TO
THEIR ARTISTS AND TALENT.
THIS ITEM IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE WE REMOVED A FEE FOR
MINERS TRAINING CLARIFY THE ROLE
OF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER THE
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST.
AN AYE VOTE [inaudible]
THEY MICHELINE.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VETERANS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE THE CLERK
WILL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE BUT I FIFTY
SIX KNOWS.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM WHEN.
EIGHTY EIGHT IS AB [inaudible]
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX BY SOME A MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO EMERGENCIES.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY GOOD EVENING
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX IS BACK FROM
THE SENATE UNANIMOUSLY.
THIS BILL WILL EASE AND
STANDARDIZE THE PROCESS FOR
CLINICS IN THE PHARMACIES O
CONTINUE TO DELIVER HEALTH CARE
DURING A STATE OF EMERGENCY WHEN
THE PHYSICIAN WHEN THE PHYSICAL
CLINIC IS NOT ACCESSIBLE.
THIS WORK WILL KEEP PATIENTS
HEALTHY.
AND AVOID UNNECESSARY STRAIN ON
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS WHEN A
DISASTER OCCURS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOU AYE VOTE.
NAME IS A YEAR CURRY SAYING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
QUIRK LOCAL THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTED THIS OUT OF OF ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE TIE THAT I
SIXTY THREE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
VIOLIN.
ONE NINETY FILE ITEM ONE
NINETIES AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE [inaudible]
MISTER BERMAN.
YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE.
IN AN EFFORT TO RAISE AWARENESS
ABOUT THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
AND INCREASE PARTICIPATION.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CENSUS ON THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S WEBSITE.
AND IN PUBLIC ELECTION MATERIALS
SUCH AS THE STATE VOTER
INFORMATION GUIDE SENATE
AMENDMENTS CLARIFY THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE SHALL
PRIORITIZE MESSAGES.
THAT ARE DESIGNED TO OVERCOME
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES TO A
COMPLETE COUNT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO THEY WAS
BERMAN.
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP LOCAL ROLL-ON INVOKE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TIME BUT I FIFTY FIVE
KNOWS FIVE SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE TO FILE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY TWO THAT IS AB TWO
THOUSAND FIVE BY MISTER
SANTIAGO.
INCORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THOUSAND AND
FIVE BY SOME THE MEMBER SANTIAGO
AND ACTING TO CHILD ABUSE
REPORTING.
MISTER SANTIAGO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWO
THOUSAND FIVE IS BACK FROM
CONCURRENCE FOR THE SENATE
EXPECT LAST NIGHT THOUGH.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
THIS ARE TO VOTE ALL NUMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF THOUGH.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
WORK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
TELL THE VOTE AYE.
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY THREE WELL IN.
ONE NINETY THREE AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY NINE FIFTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY EIGHT
WOULD ALLOW ADVISORY COMMITTEES
TO MEET VELJA TELECONFERENCE
PROVIDED THEY MEET CERTAIN
REQUIREMENTS.
MEASUREMENTS TAKEN IN THE SENATE
WERE TO QUESTION BE TURNING
GENERAL'S OFFICE AND REMOVED.
OPPOSITION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE THE
CLERK WILL.
OPEN THE RIGHT [inaudible]
ALL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL [inaudible]
CLOSER ROLE.
CHILD THAT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO
CENTER AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT.
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE FILE
ITEM.
ONE NINETY FIVE AB THIRTY ONE
NINETY TWO BY MISTER O'DONNELL.
HARPER RATE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE NINETY TWO BITES AND
REMEMBER O'DONNELL AND OTHERS
ACTUALLY MEDI CAL [inaudible]
MISTER O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THREE ONE NINE TWO REQUIRES THE
D. H. CS TO DEVELOP A MEDI CAL
BILLING ON A GUY. FOR CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON
CONCURRENCE.
THEY MISS O'DONNELL SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CLARK WELL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THEM RISK
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT ABOUT
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ROLE AND TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK ONE ITEM
TO FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY FOUR THIS IS FILE
ITEM.
ONE NINETY FOUR AB.
TWENTY NINE EIGHTY COOPERATE.
ASSEMBLY WILL TWENTY NINE EIGHTY
BY SOME A MEMBER GIPSON AND
ACTUALLY CANNABIS.
MISS YOUR GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
NINE EIGHTY WHICH IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE WITH
AMENDMENTS ADDING CHAPTER RING
OUT LANGUAGE.
OF THIS MEASURE HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THEY CAN WHICH GIPSON SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CARP LOCAL THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DECIDED VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ROLE TALBOT EYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS NINETEENTH SENATE
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRENT AND
MEMBERS WERE GOING TO MOVE BACK
IN THE FILE THE FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY ONE AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO BY MISTER SANTIAGO.
OUR QUARRY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX THIRTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO AND ACTUALLY THE
PACKAGING AND LABELING.
MISTER SANTIAGO.
FIGURE SPEAKER AB TWENTY SIX
THIRTY TWO IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE RESPECTFULLY ASKING
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION DEBATE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE SIDE OF ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRABLE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER SARAJEVO.
CLERK WILL CLOSE YOUR ALL TIME
ABOUT I SIXTY SIX ARMY I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT.
THIS IS FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY SIX MAYBE THIRTY TO
FIFTY CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO FIFTY BY THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY AND ACTUALLY THE
CIVIL LAW.
MISTER STONE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
AB THIRTY TO FIFTY IS THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S ANNUAL
CIVIL OMNIBUS BILL CIVIL OMNIBUS
BILL.
I ASK FOR YOUR CONCURRENCE IN
SENATE AMENDMENTS.
NAME A STONE SEEN NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CORP LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE ON THE VERGE
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLERK WILL.
CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ICE FOR TO
FIVE KNOW SEVEN SENATE
AMENDMENTS.
OUR CONCURRED IN.
FILE ITEM [inaudible] ONE NINETY
SEVEN BOTTOM.
ONE NINETY SEVEN AB.
THIRTY TO SIXTY ONE CORPORAL
RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO SIXTY
ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER LOW
ACTUALLY CANNABIS MR LOW.
BID YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB THIRTY TO SIXTY ONE
AS THE COMMITTEE CANNABIS.
ANIMUS.
AND RESPECT WE ASK DR VOTE.
SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE CLERK
WILL OVER THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTE.
WHAT IS THERE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DECIDED THOUGH?
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE RURAL TYPE BUT
I SIXTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO SENATE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT IN.
LET ME DO THIS NOW BEFORE I
FORGET THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE WILL BE MEETING UPON
ADJOURNMENT.
AND ROOM.
FOR THIRTY SEVEN ROOM FOR THIRTY
SEVEN UPON ADJOURNMENT SHOULD
THAT EVER HAPPEN
.
YOU AND MEMBERS WE ARE
[inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR [inaudible]
CONSENT CALENDAR.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM.
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THE
CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND A
CONSENT CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO EIGHTY SIX BY FAMILY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE RELATIVE TO SICKLE
CELL DISEASE AWARENESS MONTH.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG THE
CONSENT COUNTER ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT THIS IS THE
SENATE CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS IS THE CONSENT [inaudible]
CALENDAR.
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
SINCE THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
TELL THEM BUT I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON CONSENT.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TO THE A I SEVENTY FIVE NO ZERO
SENATE CONCURRENT SHOULD ONE
FORTY EIGHT I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO SENATE CONCURRENT LUCIEN
ONE SIX SIX I SEVENTY FIVE NO
ZERO AND SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
ONE FOURTEEN I SEVENTY FIVE NO
.
ZERO MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCIND THE ACTION WHERE BY THE
ASSEMBLY CONCURRED AND SENATE
AMENDMENTS TODAY ON ITEM.
TWENTY ONE AB FIVE SEVENTY TWO
QUIRK SILVA PLEASE ORDER THE
BILL BACK TO THE UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE REQUEST IS
GRANTED.
MEMBERS HAVE PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL [inaudible]
THIS IS AND PART MAIN FILE ITEM
THREE FORTY SEVEN SP.
FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN MEDINA
SKINNER MEDINA.
CORPORAL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE
.
MR MEDINA REPLACES A CALL.
MEMBERS I'M GOING TO LIFT THE
CALL ON FILE ITEM.
THREE FORTY FOUR MEMBERS I WANNA
LIVE THE CALL ON FILE ITEM THREE
FORTY FOUR THIS IS. THIRTEEN
NINETY ONE A CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IN THIS AREA
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL TELL YOU
ABOUT.
I FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY ONE
THAT MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE SEVENTY SEVEN POINT.
TWO I AM RE REFER IN THE
FOLLOWING BILLS TO COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY SIXTY ONE GLORIA AND
AB NINETY ONE CERVANTES TO THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE.
AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN GONZALEZ
FLETCHER TO BANKING AND FINANCE
AND THEN IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
AB FIVE SIXTY FIVE BLOOM TO
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT.
AND AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR
THURMAN. TO LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT.
AND MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
MISTER CALDERON THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WAS SIX
TO EIGHT OF ALL NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
FOLLOWING COMMITTEES TO ME.
TRANSPORTATION COMMUNITY HERE A.
B. THIRTY SIXTY ONE GLORIA AND
MAYBE NOT CERVANTES TODAY UPON A
GERMAN OF SESSION.
AND ROOM FOR THIRTY SEVEN LABOR
EMPLOYMENT TO HEAR AB TWENTY
THREE THIRTY FOUR THURMAN ON
FRIDAY AUGUST THIRTY FIRST UPON
CALL THE CHAIR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT REQUEST
IS GRANTED
.
MEMBERS WE MAY DO VOTE CHANGES
WHILE WE'RE WAITING FOR
DIRECTION [inaudible]
MS RUBIO.
GIVE A CHANGE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY ONE FROM
AND I TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY ONE I IT'S NOT VOTING
[inaudible]
THOUGH CHANGES.
MISS SURVIVE TESS [inaudible]
BUT CHANGE.
YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
VOTE CHANGED SB SIXTY FOUR I TO
NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES SENATE
BILL SIXTY FOUR I IT'S NOT
VOTING [inaudible]
MISTER BIGELOW.
BIGELOW S. B. SEVEN HUNDRED NO
TO AYE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW SENATE
BILL SEVEN HUNDRED NO TO AYE.
AB TWO NINE NINE EIGHT NOTE I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AS I
WILL TWO NINE EIGHT EIGHT NOTE I
BIGELOW A B. NINETEEN FIFTY
THREE ITEM NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
SEVEN HIGH TONIGHT VOTING
[inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
UP WALDRON FILE ONE OF FOR A. B.
[inaudible]
TWO NINE NINE EIGHT NOTES I AS I
REMEMBER WALDRON A SIMILAR TO
NINE NINE EIGHT NOTES I MISTER
FRAZIER S. B. NINE FIVE SEVEN I
TO NOT VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER SAMPLE
NINE FIVE SEVEN AYE TONIGHT
VOTING [inaudible]
DOCTOR WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD.
AT AB SIX TWENTY SIX ITEM NOT
VOTING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD A SUNNY
WILL SIX TWENTY SIX I TO NOT
VOTING.
MISTER BIGELOW APARTMENT MISTER
LACKEY.
LACKEY SENATE BILL [inaudible]
EIGHT FORTY SIX NOTE I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LACKEY SENATE BILL EIGHT
FORTY SIX NOTES I AND LACKEY AB
TWO NINE NINE EIGHT NOTE I
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY S. ONLY
WILL TWO NINE NINE EIGHT NOTES I
VOTE CHANGE CORRECTION AS I
REMEMBER BIGELOW.
AS I'M WILL.
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE I IT'S NOT
VOTING [inaudible]
THIS MELENDEZ --
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN
I TO NOT VOTING MULLIN.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELENDEZ ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN EIGHTEEN FIGHTS
NOT VOTING
.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL [inaudible]
THIS IS.
WHILE ADAM.
THREE FORTY SEVEN S. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN THE CORPORAL POSTS.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHICH TO THE
YOUR GALLAGHER MISTER SPEAKER A
MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MOTION TO ADJOURN IS NOT IN
ORDER WHEN A BILL IS ON CALL
.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE
WELL CLOSER ALL TALLIED ABOUT.
ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS [inaudible]
THIRTY FIVE MEASURE PASSES.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE [inaudible]
ATTAIN [inaudible]
ALL MOTIONS.
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS.
I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
TO ADJOURN.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOUR MOTION TO
ADJOURN IS IN ORDER.
SECONDED BY MISTER COOLEY.
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY AUGUST THIRTIETH.
AT TEN A. M. IN THE QUORUM CALL
IS LIFTED